this course from Harvard University
picks up where cs50x leaves off diving
more deeply into the design and
implementation of web apps with python
JavaScript and SQL using Frameworks like
Django react and bootstrap Brian you
will teach you topics such as database
design scalability security and user
experience you learn to write and use
apis create interactive uis and leverage
cloud services like GitHub and Heroku
[Music]
hello world this is cs50 and this is web
programming with python and JavaScript
with cs50 Zone Brian you this course
picks up where cs50 itself leaves off
diving more deeply into the design and
implementation of web apps with python
JavaScript and SQL using Frameworks like
Django react and bootstrap we'll start
by taking a closer look at HTML and CSS
languages that we can use to describe
the structure and the style of web pages
after that we'll introduce git a Version
Control tool that we can use to keep
track of changes we make to our code and
also to allow multiple people to
collaborate on the same project at the
same time after that we'll dive more
deeply into python exploring some more
advanced features of the programming
language and in particular how we can
use it in order to create Dynamic web
applications using a web framework known
as Django we'll leverage Django and in
particular its ability to deal with data
working with SQL models and migrations
to create web applications that use a
database in order to create interactive
user experiences after that we'll dive
more deeply into another programming
language JavaScript exploring how we can
use JavaScript to create Dynamic and
interactive user interfaces writing code
that responds to events and also
manipulates a web page in response to
some kind of user interaction
after that we'll explore some best
practices in Industry including testing
to make sure that our code works as
expected and also continuous integration
and continuous delivery to allow us to
rapidly make changes and deploy those
changes to our code whenever we're able
to make those updates and then finally
we'll consider concerns around
scalability and security as we take our
applications and move them from our own
computers to the web where anyone can
access them we'll talk about how we make
sure that these applications are able to
scale and how we're able to make sure
that these applications are secure along
the way you'll have an opportunity to
put all of this into practice by
building web applications of your vario
this is cs50
[Music]
thank you
all right welcome everyone to web
programming with python and JavaScript
my name is Brian Yu and in this course
we'll dive into the design and
implementation of web applications in
lectures we'll have an opportunity to
discuss and explore many of the ideas
and tools and languages that are Central
to Modern web programming and through
Hands-On projects you'll have an
opportunity to take those ideas and put
them into practice designing multiple
web applications of your own culminating
in a final project of your own choosing
throughout the term we'll cover a number
of topics in this world of web
programming beginning with HTML5 and
css3 two of the languages that are
Central to the understanding of web
pages HTML is a language we'll use to
describe the structure of a web page and
CSS is a language we'll use to describe
the style of a web page the colors and
the fonts and the layouts and the
spacing that make the web page look
exactly the way we want it to look
after that we'll turn our attention to
git a tool not specific to web
programming per se but that we can use
in order to Version Control our programs
to keep track of the different changes
we make to our web programs and to allow
us to be able to work on various
different parts of the web application
at the same time before merging those
pieces back together
after that we'll take a look at python
one of the first main languages that
we're going to be exploring in the
course which is a language that we're
going to use in order to build our web
applications specifically we'll use
Python using a framework called Django
Django is a web programming framework
written in the Python programming
language that we're going to use to make
it easy to design and develop our web
applications Django in particular makes
it easy to design web applications that
interact with data so after that we'll
turn our attention to SQL a language
that we can use to interact with
databases in particular looking at how
Django allows us to use models and
migrations to interact with data and
allow users to interact with data all
the more easily
next we'll turn our attention to the
second of the main programming languages
that we'll be exploring in this class
JavaScript and looking at how we can use
JavaScript to run in users web browsers
to make web pages just a little bit more
interactive in particular we'll use
JavaScript in the context of user
interfaces looking at modern user
interfaces and exploring how it is that
those interfaces work and how we can
develop those user interfaces with a
combination of python and JavaScript
next we'll turn our attention to testing
and CI CD or continuous integration and
continuous delivery which are tools that
we can use in software best practices to
make sure that we're able to design and
develop code more efficiently and
testing in particular makes sure that as
we make changes to our code we're not
breaking existing parts of our web
application by making sure that we have
a whole Suite of tests that we can use
to ensure that our web application is
always behaving as it should
and finally we'll turn our attention to
scalability and security on the internet
thinking about what happens as our web
application grows larger as more and
more different users start to use our
web application how do we load balance
between those people and what do we need
to change about our database to make
sure lots of users are able to connect
to our web application at the same time
moreover we'll look at the security
implications behind designing our web
applications what might an adversary do
if we're not careful and how should we
proactively be designing our web
application to make sure that it's
secure
but today we begin our conversation with
HTML and CSS two of the languages that
are foundational to understanding web
pages and how web browsers are able to
display those web pages and we'll start
with HTML or hypertext markup language
which is a language that we can use to
describe the structure of the web page
all of the buttons and the text and the
forums and other parts of the web page
that the user ultimately sees and
interacts with
our very first HTML page is going to
look a little something like this it's
going to be text-based code that we
write that a web browser like Safari or
Chrome or Firefox is then able to look
at parse understand and display to the
user so let's take a look at this page
one line at a time and get an
understanding for how it works even if
you don't quite understand all the
nuances of the syntax there are probably
a couple of things that stand out to you
you might notice the word title which
probably reflects the title of the web
page for example which in this case
appears to be the word hello and then
down further below we see that we have
the body of the web page that seems to
contain the words of hello world so what
is this webpage actually going to look
like well let's take a look at it
we'll go ahead and open up a text editor
you can use any text editor you want but
for this course I'm going to use
Microsoft's Visual Studio code and I'm
going to open up a new file that I'm
just going to call hello.html
inside of hello.html I'm going to write
the same HTML that we just saw a moment
ago and we'll explain each of these
lines in due time
but recall that we had
a title of the page that says something
like hello
and then a body of the page where we
said something like hello world for
example
so this is our very first HTML page and
if I go ahead and open that HTML page as
by opening hello.html for example inside
of a web browser what I'll see is
something like this in the body of the
page I see the words hello world
and if you notice up here at the top of
my web browser I see the title bar where
I have the title for this page which in
this case is just the word hello
so this is our very first web program
that we've been able to develop just
using HTML and now let's explore in more
detail how exactly this program works
so here again was the web page that we
were just looking at and this very first
line here doctype HTML is what we might
call a doctype declaration it's a way of
telling the web browser what version of
HTML we're using in this particular web
page because depending on the version of
HTML the web browser might want to
display different information or I might
need to parse the page a little bit
differently each version of HTML has had
a slightly different way of indicating
that version but this line here doctype
HTML is our way of saying that this HTML
page is written using HTML5 the latest
version of HTML
after that our HTML page is structured
as a series of nested HTML elements
where an HTML element describes
something on the page and we might have
elements that are inside of other
elements each of those elements is
indicated by what we're going to call an
HTML tag enclosed using those angled
brackets and right here we'll see the
beginning of the HTML tag which means
this is the beginning of the HTML
content of our page
down below this slash HTML means that
this is the end of the HTML content of
the page and in between is the actual
HTML content of the page which might
include other HTML elements
you might also notice that in this HTML
tag we've specified what we're going to
call an HTML attribute some additional
information that we're giving about this
tag in particular we're giving it a lang
or language attribute which is equal to
e n or English this just tells the web
browser or anyone looking at the HTML of
this page that this page is written in a
language and the language it's written
in is English and this is helpful for
search engines for example when they're
looking through many different web pages
trying to figure out what language each
web page is in we can just tell the
search engine or anyone else who's
looking at the page that this page is
written in English
now inside of the HTML body of the page
we have a number of different elements
that are going to describe what we want
on this page starting with the head
section of the web page which describes
stuff not in the main body of the web
page the part of the web page the user
sees it but other information about the
web page that's going to be helpful or
useful for web browsers to know about
for example one important thing that the
web browser needs to know is what is the
title of the web page and here we see a
title tag again indicated by the word
title in those angled brackets followed
by the end of the title tag indicated by
a slash before the title and in between
the two title tags is the word hello
which means the title of this page
should be the word hello
and that's all the information we'll
have in the head of the page we'll add
more information there later but for now
all the web page needs to know is that
it has a title and the title is the word
hello
next up comes the body of the page again
indicated by a body tag and that ends
with the tag with Slash body meaning
this is the end of the body of the page
and the body of the page again is just
the visible part of the page that the
user can see and what do we want inside
the body of the page for now we just
want the text hello world and that's the
information that's going to be displayed
when someone visits this webpage
and so that's all there really is to
this HTML page we specified in the
header that there's a title of the page
called hello and inside the body we're
saying the page should say the words
hello world and if you want to visually
think about the way that all these HTML
elements are structured it can sometimes
be helpful to think about an HTML page
in terms of a tree like structure that
we call the document object model or Dom
and so here for example is what the Dom
for this webpage might actually look
like here on the left is the HTML
content that we just saw a moment ago
and over here on the right is the Dom
the document object model the tree-like
structure that describes how all of
these HTML elements are related to each
other so we start up here with the HTML
element and this parent element so to
speak has two child elements within it
head element and a body element as we
can see here we're inside of HTML we
have a head section and a body section
and the indentation here that we're
including in the HTML text it's not
strictly necessary the web browser
doesn't care what the indentation is but
it can be helpful for someone who's
reading the page just to see the
indentation to understand visually that
the head is inside of the HTML element
and the body is inside of the HTML
element too
so inside of the head element we have a
title element and inside of the title
element is just the text the word hello
and likewise inside of the body element
we also have some text the text hello
world
so thinking about HTML and HTML
documents in terms of this structure can
be helpful for understanding which HTML
elements are inside of which other HTML
elements and that's going to make it
easier for us to reason about these
Pages later on and especially as we
later transition into the world of
JavaScript JavaScript is going to make
it all the more powerful and give us the
ability to actually modify parts of this
Dom as well but we'll certainly get to
that in due time
so now let's take a look at some of the
other common HTML tags and HTML elements
that we might be interacting with in our
web page and we'll start by thinking
about HTML headings so big Banners at
the top of a page for example some
headline that describes what a page is
about
so I'll go ahead into my text editor and
create a new file that I'll call
headings.html and the structure of this
page is going to be pretty similar to
the pages that we've seen before already
so I'm going to start by just using the
hello.html text and paste it in here
I'll change the title of the page
instead of hello we'll go ahead and call
it headings
but inside the body of this page now I
want something a little bit different
I'm going to inside the body of the page
use an H1 element and say this is a
heading for example
so H1 is a tag that I can use to create
a large heading at the top of my page
like for the title of a page for example
so if I open up headings.html
I might see something that looks like
this a big heading at the top of my page
that says this is a heading H1 where the
H stands for heading and the one stands
for the largest possible heading and in
fact HTML gives us a number of different
tags that we can use in order to create
headings of various sizes so for example
I could also say
H2 inside of which I say this is a
smaller heading if H1 is the largest
heading H2 is the second largest heading
so if I load this page for example I now
see the H1 at the very top this is the
big heading and then beneath that I see
this is a smaller heading the H2 and it
turns out there's also H3 H4 H5 all the
way down to H6 which is the smallest
heading
such that if I load this page now I have
a big heading a smaller one and then
here's the smallest so we can often use
these H1 H2 H3 tags just for visually
organizing text inside of a page if I
want the title of the page
but also I want titles for each of the
various different sections and
subsections that might be contained
within that page as well
so those are headings and now let's also
take a look at some other elements that
we might want to add on web pages we see
not just titles and not just text but we
might also see lists for example like if
you've ever used a to-do list program on
a web page for example you might see a
list of things that you need to do or
other web pages might display lists of
information and it turns out that HTML
has two basic types of lists we have
ordered lists for things that are in a
particular order like item number one
item number two item number three and we
have unordered lists for lists that
don't have any particular order so just
bullet point bullet point bullet point
for example and both are quite easy to
use
I'll go ahead and create a new file and
we'll call this lists.html
and again in list.html I'll copy the
same structure from hello.html We're
again going to have doctype HTML just to
indicate the version of HTML most of the
heading is the same I'm just going to
change the title from Hello to lists and
then we're going to replace the body of
this page to show some different
information here
so let me first show what an ordered
list might look like something that has
numbers one two three and ordered list
as an HTML tag is just o l o l for
ordered list so I can add a tag that
says ol
and now inside of my ol element my
ordered list element I need a new
element for every list item list item
we're going to abbreviate to just Li so
the l i tag in HTML is what we're going
to use to designate an item inside of an
HTML list so here for example I could
say Li and then first item and then I
could do the same thing Li second item
and then again Li third item
so what I have here are some elements
and then elements nested within other
elements I have an ordered list element
inside of which are three other HTML
elements three list items that are each
indicating each of the individual items
that are inside of my HTML list
I can now open this up by opening
lists.html
and this is what I see I see an ordered
list where I have item number one first
item second item third item note that I
didn't actually need to in the HTML
anywhere specify the number one the
number two and the number three when the
web browser reads this should be an
ordered list my web browser Chrome in
this case just adds those numbers in for
me because it knows what an ordered list
means and it knows how to take the HTML
that I've written and display it in the
way that I intend to to the user
now in addition to ordered lists that
all have numbers one two three we also
have unordered lists that are just
bullet points bullet points of
information so I could up above add some
more content to this HTML page I can say
here is an unordered list
and just as an ordered list we
represented using the ol tag in HTML ol
standing for ordered list likewise we
can use the UL tag in HTML to create an
unordered list U for unordered
so here we're going to add a UL tag and
again my text editor here is
automatically adding the closing tag
here this slash UL meaning the end of
the unordered list and many text editors
will do this now just so you the
programmer don't forget to add that
and now inside of this unordered list
we're again going to have some list
items also using the LI tag here is one
item and here is another item and here
is yet another item
if I go ahead and refresh the page now
I'm still on list.html I now see that on
top of my ordered list I have an
unordered list where each item instead
of being numbered one two three is
instead labeled with just bullet point
bullet point bullet point where each of
these bullet points and each of these
numbered items is a list item element or
An Li
so hopefully now we can see that as we
start to explore these various different
HTML tags and nesting HTML tags inside
of one another we're able to create more
and more interesting web pages as a
result
so let's explore now what other types of
web pages we can create using other
types of HTML elements in addition to
lists one thing you might imagine is
that one of the important things on the
web is not just displaying text but also
displaying other types of media like
images for example so how might we go
about doing that
well I can for example let's go back
into my text editor let me create a new
file that I'm going to call
image.html which is going to contain
some code for displaying some images
I'll go ahead and go into hello.html and
copy this text into the page again
change the title to image and now inside
of the body I'm going to add a new tag
called image
and the image tag has a couple of
required attributes remember that
attributes are what we saw before things
like adding a lang equals en to the top
of my page to indicate that this web
page is written in English for example
and the image tag has a couple of
required attributes that I need to add
in particular when I display an image on
the page I need to specify what image I
actually want displayed for example so I
might specify image SRC short for Source
if is going to be equal to what image do
I actually want to display on this page
and it just so happens that inside of my
folder where I have image.html I have an
image called cat.jpg so I'm just going
to specify cat.jpg as the file name of
the image that I want to display
and it turns out that images also have a
second required attribute in addition to
the file name or the link to whatever
image I want to display I also need to
provide some alternative text a text
based representation of what you're
going to see on the image because in
some cases some web browser might not be
able to render the image correctly you
might imagine if there's some error
rendering the image or if someone's on a
slow internet connection or if someone's
using a screen reader and therefore
can't actually see the image we want
some text-based representation of that
image as well and so I'll provide some
alt text some alternative text that can
be used to substitute the image in case
for some reason we can't display the
image and the alt text that I'll use in
this case
is just going to be the word cap for
example
and that's all I need now notice in
particular that something a little bit
different about this image tag compared
to other tags that we've seen before in
the sense that it doesn't have a closing
tag in the sense that the body had a
beginning of the body and an end of the
body our ordered list had a beginning of
the ordered list and the end of the
ordered list with list items in between
it doesn't really make sense for for an
image for example to have the beginning
of the image and the end of the image
and some content in between because the
image is just a single HTML element that
can't really have anything inside of it
so in that sense we don't actually need
a closing image tag the image tag is
self-clothing it is its own beginning
and end so we can just say we want an
image to be here that is cat.jpega with
an alternative text of just the word cat
for example
so now if I open up image.html
we'll see that what gets loaded is quite
large a picture of a cat and I can
scroll around and see this entire image
of course this picture of a cat is
probably larger than I wanted it to be I
probably when my user visits this
webpage I don't want them to have to
scroll all the way to the right in order
to see the entire cat so I can actually
add additional HTML attributes in order
to modify the size of the image that I'm
displaying and later we'll see we can
use CSS to do a similar thing as well
but for now what I can add is an
additional attribute
and say that let me give cat.jpeg this
image tag another attribute that in this
case I'll just call width and I'll say
that width is going to be equal to 300
because I would like for this image to
be 300 pixels wide for example
so now if I refresh this page I now see
that the same cat image appears except
now it appears at 300 pixels wide
exactly so I'm able to add additional
attributes additional information to
control how an HTML element is going to
appear in this case I want to control
its width and it automatically scales
down the height to make sure that the
image is proportional as well
now on the internet in addition to just
displaying information on a single page
it's also common for a page to link to
other pages in fact that's one of the
main important values of the internet is
the ability to go from one page to
another via these links and so one thing
we might reasonably want to do is add
some links to our page where if you
click on something you're taken to
another page altogether
so let's take a look at an example of
that
I'll create a new file based on
hello.html and I'll add laying equals
English for good measure and I'll call
this new file
link.html where here we're going to
practice with building some links into
our HTML page
I'll copy the content of hello.html
again
call this link
in order to create a link I'm going to
use a tag called the a tag short for the
anchor tag
and the a tag takes one important
attribute which is called href for
hyperlink reference which is going to
specify what page I would like to link
to
so if for example I wanted when a user
clicks on this link to go to google.com
then I'd set the href attribute of this
tag equal to https colon slash
google.com for example
then inside of the a tag I would specify
what text I want to display what text
should the user see such that when the
user clicks on that text they're taken
to the web page in this case I'm just
going to say something like click here
for instance
now if I open up link.html
this is what the user sees they see a
blue link that says click here
and when the user does click on that
link
they're taken to https colon slash
google.com
and it turns out that we can use this
href attribute not only to link to
different websites altogether but we can
link to different pages on the same
website so for example if I wanted to
link to that cap page that I designed a
moment ago instead of linking to
google.com I could instead just link to
image.html
and now if I save that and refresh or if
I open up link.html again
now I see a click here link where when I
click on click here now I'm taken to
that page cat image.html that happened
to have that picture of a cat from
before
so using these anchor tags and href
attributes we're able to link together
multiple pages so that if we have a
website that has many different web
pages we can connect them all together
by using a combination of these various
different links
so now that we've seen images and links
and lists what other HTML elements might
we add to our web page well one thing we
might want to add are things like tables
just other ways of displaying
information so let's go ahead and create
a table and look at what HTML elements
we can use in order to do so
so I'll go back here to my text editor
create a new file called table.html
using the same starting HTML
we'll call this page title or table
and inside the body of this page now
there are a number of different HTML
elements that we'll need in order to
create a table because as you might
imagine a table is really composed of
multiple parts we have our big table but
each table is really just a sequence of
individual table rows and each of those
rows is really just a sequence of
individual cells of data within that
table
and so that structure that we're
imagining a table that consists of
individual rows where each row consists
of individual cells is exactly how we're
going to represent this table in HTML
we're going to start with just a table
tag that's going to represent the
entirety of this table
but inside of the table we might have
different parts we might have the
heading of the table we would have the
body of the table so in order to
represent that I'll add T head that's
going to stand for the heading of the
table the stuff at the top of the table
that might indicate what each column of
the table means for example and let's
see what columns do I want well let's go
ahead and add some table headings which
I can represent using the th tag H for
heading
and maybe I want in this webpage to
display information about various
different oceans for example so maybe I
have one column for the ocean and
another column another table heading for
the average depth of that ocean and
another table heading for the maximum
depth of that ocean
and that'll be the very first row of
that table The Heading of the table but
in addition to The Heading of the table
we also have the body of the table so
underneath the T head I'll go ahead and
include T body body for the main part of
the table where all my data is going to
be and that body is going to consist of
individual rows of a table so I might
have a TR which here stands for table
row
and inside of this table row we'll go
ahead and add some individual data
points inside of the table so inside of
my table row I'm going to have one table
data point or TD for table data that
says Pacific Ocean for example
then another table data that says 4280
meters and then another one for the
maximum depth of the Pacific Ocean which
is ten thousand nine hundred and eleven
meters and in fact this these three
table heads as well at the top of the
page the ocean the average depth and the
maximum depth those should actually
probably be in a row of their own as
well because the very first part of the
table that is also a row so I'll go
ahead and add a TR short for table row
and inside of that TR
put these headings
I'll go ahead and add one more row just
so we can see what this looks like and
then we'll take a look at the page and
then go back to this code I'll add the
Atlantic Ocean to
which has an average depth of
3646 meters as well as a maximum depth
of 8486 meters as well
so when I open up table.html now here's
what I'm going to see I'm going to see a
table like representation of the data
it's not just one thing after another
after another anymore it's structured in
a table now granted there aren't any
borders and I can probably add some
colors and spacing to make this look a
little bit nicer but I see three columns
ocean average depth and maximum depth
where this very first row is what we
might call the table header the very top
of the table that's defining what all of
the columns mean inside of that table
header is a single table row that has
three table data cells ocean average
depth and maximum depth then beneath
this table header represented in bold is
the table's body or the T body element
inside of which we add two rows one for
representing the Pacific Ocean one for
representing the Atlantic Ocean and then
we had data cells in each one of those
rows for representing each of the
individual cells that's located within
this table
so this is what that page ultimately
looks like and let's take one more look
at the HTML just to get an understanding
for how all of these tags interact with
one another and no need to memorize all
these tags right now slowly as you begin
to design HTML Pages you'll start to get
more familiar with what HTML tags are
available to you and certainly all of
these HTML tags are things that are easy
to reference if you need to look them up
it's very helpful to be able to look up
something like how do I create a table
in HTML and then you'll be able to see
what the various different tags you'll
need to add are in order to generate the
table that you're looking for
but again just to recap here we have a
table element inside of which are two
child elements TI head and T body inside
of each of those are one or more table
rows representing using TR inside of
each of those are three table data cells
representing using TD and so using these
nested tags elements inside of elements
inside of other elements we've been able
to build something far more complex than
just a bulleted list we've been able to
build an entire table that has
information as well
But ultimately our web pages should be
web pages that don't just display
information but that also let users
interact with that information in some
way for example you might imagine that
on Google's homepage for example it's
not just unchanging there's a field
where I can type something in and
anytime users can provide input to a web
page we generally call that a four or
someplace where a user can fill out a
form in order to provide information to
the web page and so now let's take a
look at how we can use HTML in order to
create a form that's going to display
some information
so I'll go ahead and create a new page
called form.html
again using that same HTML as before
call the page form
and inside of the body of this page now
let's say that I want to create a form
that gives the user an opportunity to
provide their full name for example how
do I do that well the first thing I need
is a form element some way of saying
here is going to be a form
and now inside of that form what are the
various different parts of the form well
there's really two parts that you might
imagine to this form one is a place for
the user to actually type in their name
and they probably also need some way to
submit the form some button that just
says submit such that they can click on
that button in order to submit the form
so how would we do that well in order to
create an input field we're going to use
an input tag
whose type in this case is going to be
text there are a number of different
ways the users might provide input to a
forum they might type in text they might
choose from a drop down menu they might
choose from a radio button option or
they might provide input as by clicking
on a button for example in this case
we're specifically using the type
attribute to say that when the user is
providing input in this way the type of
input that they're providing is going to
be some kind of text
then we might provide a placeholder
some default text that's going to be
inside of that input field the first
time the user looks at the page so for
example the placeholder might be full
name that way the user knows that what
they should type into this place into
this placeholder is their own full name
and then finally we're going to go ahead
and give a name to this input field now
this isn't going to be something that
the user sees when they visit the page
but anytime you submit a form when we
receive that form in our web application
something we'll explore later on we need
some way of knowing which input field
corresponded to which value and so we're
going to name each of the input Fields
just so that later on we'll be able to
reference them and for now since the
user is typing their full name here we
could just name this full name or we
could more succinctly just say name as
the name of this input field
after that we have an input field where
the user can type in their name and now
we need some way for the user to be able
to submit this form so we might say
something like input type equals submit
to say here is a way for the user to
submit the form type equal submit means
this is how they're going to submit the
form when they're done completing it
now if I open up form.html
this is the page that we're ultimately
going to see when we load this HTML this
entire page just contains a single HTML
form but that HTML form contains two
parts the first part was this input
element here that allowed an opportunity
for the user to type in their full name
they type in their full name into this
input field and when they're done they
can click the submit button to indicate
that they would like to now submit this
form
of course right now this form isn't
going to do anything when we type in our
name and click submit because we haven't
added any logic in order to handle this
form but later on as we transition into
the world of building web applications
using python we'll see how we can design
a form such that after the user submits
it we save information to a database or
display some sort of results back to the
user all by using the power of building
these web applications and connecting
them to these sorts of HTML forms and
HTML forms can actually get quite a bit
more complex we'll take a look at
another example for instance let me open
up forms 1
form1.html which is a form that I built
in advance
which shows a number of other ways that
users can provide information as input
to an HTML form
here we see an input whose type is text
meaning we want the user to type in
their name as text but you might also
imagine that if a user is logging into a
website for example they might in
addition to typing in a text-based name
or username or email also provide a
password and generally if you've been on
a website and you've typed in a password
the password characters don't all show
up as the actual characters for security
reasons they generally show up as just
little dots on the screen hiding the
actual characters that they're
representing and in HTML we can do that
very easily
by just saying that the type of this
input is password if they're typing in a
password our web browser will know not
to actually display those individual
characters
in addition to just text based input we
also have radio button input as I
alluded to a moment ago so here we have
a number of different radio inputs where
the user might be able to select from a
number of options choosing their
favorite color for example from a number
of these options and finally just to
take it one look at one other additional
feature of HTML5 in fact a new feature
of HTML5 is something we might call a
data list where we might have the user
choose in a drop down from a number of
different options but we want to very
quickly filter down or autocomplete
based on those options so if the user
needs to select what country they're
from for example we might have an input
field
and specify that it's going to be
associated with a list called countries
then immediately below that I have a
data list element whose ideas countries
where here I'm going to specify these
are all of the options for what country
we could have each one is inside of an
option element whose value is whatever
country they could select and we have
all of the countries of the world listed
in these option elements
so this input here is going to allow me
to select one option from a list of all
of these possible options
so now if I open up form1.html
here's what that form ultimately looks
like I can hear inside of the name field
again that word name shows up because
it's the placeholder I can type in my
name here
and inside of the password field
anything I type is going to show up as
just little dots instead of the actual
characters because the type of that
input field was password instead of the
type being text
in favorite color I now have the ability
to choose between various different
favorite color options in a radio button
format I choose from one of a number of
options and finally inside this country
drop down I have the ability now when I
click on it to see all of the countries
but as I start to type letters like u n
i t it filters down to only the options
that I actually care about so here if I
type in enough letters eventually I see
United States and I can click on that
option as well
so HTML5 builds in these additional
features to make it easy to implement
something like a text field where it
will auto-complete based on the text
that you provide you can just specify
that it is inside of this data list and
then provide a list of all the possible
values and then HTML and your web
browser in turn will take care of the
process of rendering that information in
the way that you expect it to be
displayed
so those are just some of the possible
HTML elements that we can ultimately
create by using these various different
elements that we Nest within each other
and there are definitely other HTML
elements that exist as well you can
begin to explore but all of them follow
a very similar pattern that we're going
to have some tag that might require some
attributes additional information about
the HTML to give context to the web
browser for how that element should be
displayed maybe that element needs to
have a particular source for an image
maybe it needs a link in order to link
to somewhere or other information as
well and then inside of that element you
might Nest other elements so that your
table has rows and inside of those rows
we have other cells and you might
imagine nesting elements inside of other
elements inside of other elements
but right now so far all of our web
pages have been rather simple they've
just been we've described the structure
of the page and we've described we want
to list here we want to form there what
we might really like is some way of
specifying that we want to style our web
page in some way we want to add color we
want to add spacing we want to add some
sort of other layout to our page as well
and in order to do that we're going to
use a second language that we're going
to call CSS short for cascading style
sheets in particular we'll use the
latest version of CSS css3 which gives
us the ability to take an HTML page and
tell the web browser how we would like
it to be styled instead of just black
text in the same font on a white
background we can begin to specify
particular CSS properties of how we
would like this page to look to make
sure that the page looks the way we want
it to
so let's take a look at a simple example
now of CSS to take a look at how we can
add some CSS code to our page
so I'll go ahead and create a new file
that I'll call style.html
just to demonstrate some basic ideas of
adding some style to our page and we'll
go ahead and copy the same hello.html
from before
and maybe in addition to hello world I
display an H1 some big heading at the
top that says like welcome to my web
page for example
so now if I open up style.html
this is what I see I see a big heading
at the top that says welcome to my
webpage beneath which is just a text
hello world
and now imagine that I want to add some
style to this heading at the top of the
page maybe instead of being left aligned
I want it to be centered maybe instead
of just being black texted like to
change the color
in order to do that
just as we've used attributes in the
past to add additional information to
this particular HTML page we can do a
very similar thing with CSS
we can specify that we're going to give
this H1 element a style attribute
and that is going to be equal to and
then in quotation marks we're going to
provide all of the CSS properties that
we would like to add to this particular
element so the way that CSS styling
works is that we can give elements
individual CSS properties where a
property is something like the color of
the element or the alignment of the
element and each of those properties has
a default value but we can change its
value to something else so if for
example I wanted to change the color of
this heading so that instead of a black
heading it displayed as a blue heading I
could say for this H1 I would like to
give it a color property and then to
give the color property a value I say
color colon and then the value that I
would like to give to it so color colon
blue for example followed by a semicolon
will change the color of this H1 element
to Blue and my text editor is
automatically showing me a little square
that shows me what this color blue is
actually going to look like this isn't
part of the text it's just my text
editor being helpful so that I can see
in advance as I'm writing this code what
the color is actually going to look like
so now if I open up style dot HTML
here's what I see instead of a black
heading at the top we've changed the
color to Blue and there are many other
built-in colors that exist within HTML
that we can use in order to change the
color to whatever we want if instead of
blue I said I want the color to be red
for instance I can refresh the page and
now the heading is red and there are
many other colors I can change the color
to like spring green for instance and
that's going to be a particular shade of
green that displays just like this
and so now we have the ability to add
various different style properties to
individual elements I can say take this
heading and change its style so that the
color instead of being black is going to
show up as blue instead
and if I want to add multiple CSS
properties to the same HTML element I
can do that as well
here in the style attribute I can say
that in addition to saying that the
color is blue I'd like to give a second
CSS property to this element I'd like to
say that the text align property should
be Center for example
the text align property controls as you
might imagine how a particular HTML
element has its text aligned is it all
the way on the left all the way on the
right or centered and if I change the
text align property to have a value of
Center
well then now when I refresh this page
I see that welcome to my web page is now
both blue and it's centered I've changed
the color and I've changed the alignment
of this particular element
and HTML elements don't need to just be
styled directly they can also get their
style information from parent elements
so if you recall again that Dom
structure where we have an HTML element
inside of which is this body element
and inside of the body element is this
H1 element and this text you can imagine
if we wanted this styling to apply not
just to this heading but also to the
hello world text I could move the
styling information move this style
attribute change it from the H1 and
escalating it to this body and if I move
the style to the body then everything
inside of the body is going to be styled
in that way so let's now take a look at
an example of that to see how that works
if I take this style information and I
move it so that instead of associating
it with the H1
i instead associate it with the body
then now when I refresh the page I see
that both parts of the body both the big
heading at the top that says welcome to
my web page as well as the text hello
world both have those CSS properties
applied I've changed their color to Blue
and I've also changed their text
alignment to be centered instead of just
left aligned
but if I do want it to just be that
heading then I can move it out and say
that I just want to apply the style to
that one individual heading
now one thing that we might imagine
might become a problem over time is that
imagine if I had multiple headings that
I wanted to style in the same way for
example let's say I have a second
heading that this is a second heading
that I also want to be styled as blue
and centered as well
I can refresh this page and see that
right now that is not the case and I
don't want to make the entire page blue
and centered I only want these two
headings to be blue and centered so what
I could do is I could just take this
style code from the H1 and apply it to
this H1 as well so that both of my H1
elements now have the exact same style
code and I'll go ahead and refresh this
and now we see this is the intended
Behavior I have two headings both of
which are centered and both of which are
blue
but what we want to start to think about
as we start to build web applications
and especially as our web applications
start to get a little bit more
sophisticated is to think about the
design of how we're building our web
pages and how we're building our web
applications and in particular anytime
we find ourselves copying a lot of the
same information from one place to
another that's probably not the best
design and you should start to think
about how might you design this a little
bit better it's not great design one
just because there's some redundancy
that probably doesn't need to be there
but also because it makes the page a
little bit more difficult to change and
a little more difficult to update if I
instead want to change both of these
headings to be red instead of blue then
all of a sudden I need to change my code
in two places I need to change the style
attribute on this first heading up here
and I also need to change the style
attribute on the second heading down
there
what I'd like to do is to somehow just
be able to write the style code once and
then have it applied to both of these
headings and in fact there is a way to
do that what we can do is instead of
doing what we might call inline styling
where we take the CSS code and place it
directly as an attribute of an HTML
element we can move our style code to an
entirely different part of the web page
recall again that at the top of our HTML
page we have this head section that just
includes information that's useful to
know about the web page but isn't
actually part of the body of the web
page the content that the user sees this
head section is a great place where we
can begin to put some style information
information about how we would like for
this web page to be styled
so what I can do here is instead of
putting these style attributes inside in
line with these HTML elements
I can inside of the head section of my
web page add a style element
where in between these the opening style
tag in the closing style tag I can add
any of the style information that I want
and here's the way that syntax is going
to look I first need to specify what
types of elements am I going to style
and in this case I want to style all of
the H1s so I can just say H1
and then
all of the style code is going to go
inside of a pair of curly braces where I
can say I would like the color to be
blue and I would like the text align
property to be centered
so now here's what I've done I've taken
the CSS code that used to be down here
inside the body of the page actually as
an attribute of these H1 elements and
I've moved the style related code to a
different part of my page altogether now
the style information is inside the
header of my page inside of the style
element where I've said for every H1
element here's how you should style it
The Styling is in between the opening
and curly closing braces here and I've
said that every H1 should have a color
of blue and every H1 should have a text
align property of Center
and that is then going to apply to all
of the H1 elements that my web page
happens to find inside the body of my
web page so there's a couple of
advantages here Advantage number one is
what we talked about a moment ago I
don't need to duplicate the same code in
both of these H1 elements I can write it
once and say apply this styling to all
of the H1s that show up in the page an
advantage number two is we've been able
to factor out the style code to
somewhere else just to make it a little
bit cleaner so that instead of having a
really long line you might imagine if we
had not just two but maybe five or six
or seven different CSS properties that
would have taken up a lot of space on
one line
I can instead in a more readable more
organized way move that style related
code to the style element at the
beginning of the page just to make it
easier to read easier to visually
understand and just to clean up the body
of the web page as well and that's going
to be another of the key themes that's
going to come up again and again in this
class this idea of separating things out
so that every piece can sort of be
independent of one another our structure
of the web page inside the body is
separate from the style and we'll see
the same sort of idea appear again and
again as we begin to try to design web
applications well
so now if I take this exact same page
and go ahead and refresh style.html
we'll see that we see the exact same
thing both of the headings still show up
as centered both of them still show up
as blue but now we have the advantage of
having only written the style code once
instead of needing to write the exact
same style code multiple times in the
same way
but it turns out that we can even do a
little bit better than this because one
thing you might imagine is that if I
have a web application or a website that
has multiple different web pages it's
probably going to be likely that each of
those web pages might need to be styled
in similar ways if I have a big banner
at the top of one web page then in other
Pages related to that page I might want
the same Banner styled in the same way
using similar style information and
right now our CSS code is specific to
one particular page and it's not going
to be easy to then take that same
styling and apply it to another page if
I wanted to I'd need to copy the exact
same CSS code put it inside of another
page but then we run into the same
problem of duplication where I've now
had to repeat myself across multiple
different pages putting the exact same
CSS code across all those different
pages so there is an improvement we can
make and the Improvement we can make
is to take that CSS code and just move
it to an entirely different file
so instead of putting this style code
inside of a style element inside of this
HTML page I'll just create a new file
that I'll call styles.css inside of
which is going to be all of the CSS that
I care about I want to take every H1 I
want to change its color to Blue and now
I want to change its text align property
to Center
and now inside of my HTML page I no
longer need to include any CSS at all
instead of this style element altogether
I can just link my CSS code in that CSS
file called styles.css to this
particular HTML page and how do I link
the styles.css file well I can do so
again in the head section of my web page
using a link tag where I can say I'd
like this link to be the relationship is
it's going to be a style sheet meaning
what I'm about to link is going to be a
style sheet for this page it's going to
describe how I want for the elements on
this page to be styled
and then just as in the case of a link
to another page I used href to specify a
hyperlink reference what I want to link
to I'm now going to specify using an
href attribute what CSS file I would
like to Now link and in this case the
CSS file that I'm going to link is
styles.css that is the file that just so
happens to contain all of the CSS that I
would like to apply to this particular
file
now if I refresh the page
I see again nothing has changed in the
last two revisions the pages stayed
exactly the same as far as the user is
concerned they still see two headings
both of them are centered both of them
are blue but now the advantage is that
here is my HTML it's shorter than it was
before and in particular there's no CSS
that's baked in to this HTML file at all
I factored it all out into the separate
styles.css file and now if I have
multiple HTML files that are all using
the same styling I can just link them
all to the same styles.css file
such that they're all using the same
style information I don't need to repeat
myself and If Ever I need to make a
change across all of those pages I just
change the styling once I change the
styles.css file and then all of the web
pages that are linked to that style
sheet will update as well in order to
reflect those changes so again we've
been able to factor out some of this
style information to a separate file
just to make our lives a little bit
easier
all right so so far we've now seen how
we can use CSS in a number of different
ways to add some basic style store Page
we've seen that we can take an element
and change its color we've seen how we
can take an element and change its
alignment move it from left to line to
right align to Centered for example as
it turns out there are a lot of
different CSS properties that we can add
to our HTML elements in order to style
them in various different ways more than
we'll have time to talk about in this
lecture but now let's just take a look
at a couple of the most popular most
common CSS properties that we can add in
order to make our web pages look the way
we want it to and one of the most
powerful tools for CSS is controlling
the size of various different elements
by default HTML just used a default size
for everything on the page but if I want
to more precisely control how big any
particular element is I can use CSS in
order to do so
so let me now create a new file that I
will call size.html
we'll start with the same HTML code and
call the page size
and now inside the body of my page let
me just have a vertical section of my
page just some section of my page that's
going to have some content and I'm going
to put this inside of a div tag now this
is the first time that we've seen a div
in HTML you can think of a div as just a
division of the page some section of the
page that's going to have some content
inside of it and we use div because it
makes it easy to reference a particular
div or a nest information inside of
other pieces of information or just to
divide and break up our page into
multiple different sections here inside
of the body I'm just going to have a
single div that is going to say
something like Hello World
and now I'm going to add some style to
this page in order to control the size
of this div to control the size of this
section of my web page I could use
inline styling I could Factor things out
into another file but since I'm only
dealing with one file for now I'm just
going to add a style section to the top
of my web page just so you can more
clearly see how the style of this page
is going to map on to the way that we're
modifying these HTML elements
and I would like to style this David in
a couple of ways one thing I can do is
give the div a background color let me
change its background color to Blue for
example
and then I can say all right I'd like to
give this div a width and a height some
size information I can say go ahead and
give this div a width of 100 pixels and
maybe a height of 400 pixels
so now when I go ahead and open up
size.html
this is what I see I see in a 100 by 400
pixel wide vertical or rectangular
section of my page I see the words hello
world and so you might imagine if you
have multiple different elements on your
page as your web pages start to get a
little bit more complex you probably
want to have some more precise control
over how wide or how tall any particular
element is and these width and height
attributes can be very helpful because I
can very easily change the width to say
like 500 pixels for example and now when
I refresh the page now I see that the
width of this page of this div this
section of the page has actually now
gotten a lot wider
and so we have the ability to control
size using CSS go ahead and close some
of these pages that I no longer need and
now take a look at some other things
that we can do in addition to
controlling the size and let me change
this color to something a little bit
lighter something like orange such that
now if I open up size it looks like this
I'll make this a little bit smaller
let's try 200 by 200 pixels
it looks now like this you might imagine
there are some other changes that I
might like to make like this hello world
for example is very close to the edge of
this particular div it's right up
against the upper left corner of that
div I might want to change that by
adding what we might call some padding
to this particular HTML element some
space just so that the content of the
element isn't so close to the border of
the element itself
so for example one thing I can do is
inside this div add some padding say
maybe I want 20 pixels worth of padding
on the inside of the element such that
now when I refresh the page
we see that we have some padding along
the outside of the element so that hello
world now shows up not right up against
the edge of the element but inside a
little bit as well
and if we have a particular HTML element
that maybe is too close to the edge of
the screen maybe it's too close to the
top of the screen we can also add space
around outside of the element by adding
what we call margin to the element as
well so I can say let's give it 20
pixels of margin inside of this div and
then refresh and now we see that whereas
before this div was very close to the
upper left edge of the screen now we've
moved it 20 pixels away from everything
so it's got some space on all four sides
of it
so that's how we can now use margin and
padding just to make the page look a
little bit nicer to the user so objects
are not too close together or too far
apart ing again is on the inside of the
border of the element I can add 20
pixels of padding for example to make
sure that the content inside of the
element in this case the words hello
world just have a little bit of space
from the border and that's padding on
the inside of the element margin
meanwhile is on the outside of the
element we add some margin along the
outside of the border to space the
element out from other elements that
might be nearby to make sure that
there's enough space between the border
of the element from the top of the
screen and also from the left and also
the bottom and the right though there's
no objects there that we're currently
creating space from
so by combining width and height and
margin and padding we now have the
ability using CSS to make sure that
we're able to lay out our page the way
we want to lay out the page so that
elements have the right amount of
spacing from each other and are the
correct size
so now let's take a look at some other
features that CSS is going to give us in
addition to just changing where
particular elements are like centering
text or adding size and margin and
padding we can also use CSS to change
how elements actually look we've seen it
to change the color of text changing it
from one color like black to another
color like blue but we can also use CSS
to be able to change something like the
font that we use in order to display
text modern web pages don't show
everything in the exact same font
usually some designer is choosing what
font they want for any particular web
page
so let's experiment with those
possibilities I'll now create a new file
that I'll call font dot HTML
inside of which will be an HTML page
called font
and inside the body I'll again just have
a div that says hello world same as
before
but now inside of the style tag here up
in the head section of my web page I
would like to add some font information
to this div and in particular there are
a number of different font related CSS
properties that I can add to control the
font of any particular HTML element
one thing I can specify is the font
family specifying what font would I like
to use in order to display this text and
maybe I want to display it in Arial for
example which is a common font used on
the internet
such that now if I open up font.html
I now see in aerial the words hello
world different from the text that I was
using before
you can also specify multiple different
fonts not all Computers support all
fonts so I could specify that just in
case Ariel isn't supported fall back to
any Sans serif font any of the fonts
that don't have the little glyphs at the
edge of each of the characters so now if
I refresh the page because my web
browser supports Ariel I don't notice
anything different but you might imagine
if you're using more complex fonts that
not all web browsers have or support you
might add some backups just in case the
font you want isn't actually available
in addition to a font family I might
also specify a font size how big I want
the font to be inside of this div so I
can specify that I'd like the font size
of this div to be you know 28 pixels for
example such that now I refresh it and
now this div appears using larger text
and I can also adjust as like text
editors let you specify whether you want
it to be normal text or bold text I can
specify a font weight for this div and
say that in addition to being in font
aerial and size 28 I would also like for
the font to be bold such that now I
refresh it and now the font shows up as
bold
and using these CSS style sheets we're
able to selectively apply The Styling to
only particular parts of the web page if
I have another underneath this div
some more text down here for example
that additional text that's outside of
the div isn't going to be affected by
the CSS styling such that now if I
refresh this page some more text shows
up in that same standard default font
provided by my web browser and not the
custom font that I have specified to
apply to only this particular part of
the HTML page
so that now is the ability to add fonts
to our page too
another thing that we might want to do
is to be able to add some sort of border
around our HTML elements so maybe I want
a line to be able to separate this
entire part of the page from another
part of the page so I could add a border
by going to this div and saying let me
give this div a border and maybe I want
the border to be like a 3 pixel solid
black border for instance I can specify
how big I want the border to be I can
specify whether I want the border to be
a solid line or a dashed or dotted line
and I can specify what color I would
like that border to be as well
so now when I refresh this I now see I
have a border around this entire section
around this entire div inside of my web
page and you can imagine these borders
being helpful for styling various
different parts of my page so for
example if we go back to that table that
we were looking at a moment ago when we
were dealing with Oceans Where I had
ocean and Pacific Ocean and Atlantic
Ocean this is structured in the format
of a table we have rows and columns but
it doesn't look great right now I might
like to add some styling in order to
improve the way that this table looks
for example so let's give that a try
I'll go ahead and go back into
table.html that HTML file I was using
before where I had this table
and let me now add some style
information to this table
I might say that for this table I would
like to give it a border that is maybe a
one pixel solid Glock border
such that now when I refresh the page I
have a 1 pixel solid Blackboard room
around the entirety of the table
all right that's great but I also really
wanted to border in between the rows and
the columns as well in particular every
table data item I might like to have
some additional
CSS applied to those two
so I might say for every table data cell
again TD stood for table data and those
were the individual cells within my
table
I might specify that I would like those
to also have a border that is one pixel
solid black
such that now I refresh the page and now
each of my table data cells also has a
border around it
now this applied to the table data cells
in the body of my page but it didn't yet
apply to these cells up in the heading
and that's because those
were th elements table headers
and so here we have a couple of options
I could specify once more table headers
I would like to give a border of one
pixel solid black
but when I do so you'll see that it does
create a border around those table
headers but again one thing that should
be crossing your mind now is that
there's a fair amount of redundancy here
some repeated style code that shows up
in multiple different places table data
cells in the body of my page I really
want to be styled in a very similar way
to table header cells and so it would be
nice if I could somehow consolidate
these two different CSS selectors these
ways of me saying style table data style
table headers I'd like to combine them
into one and you can in fact do this in
CSS there are a number of different CSS
selectors ways of choosing elements and
one of them is just called the multiple
element selector that if I want to
select both table data cells and table
headers then I can do so by saying TD
comma th
and delete these three lines down there
what these three lines are now saying
are that I would like to style all table
data cells and table headers in the same
way and I could even combine table if I
wanted to for good measure but I'd like
to give all of them a border of one
pixel solid black
such that now I refresh it and now I see
that they all have this border around
them
now most tables you see on the internet
don't have both a table or a border
around everything in the table and also
a border around each of the individual
cells usually those are collapsed just
into a single line and it turns out that
CSS has an easy way for you to do this
as well I can add a CSS property to the
table called border collapse and just
say I would like to collapse all of the
borders in the table just going to show
you there are many many different CSS
properties far more than we'll be
looking at today but they're easy things
to reference so you can easily look up
how to collapse borders in a table and
then find a CSS property like this that
you can then use and apply to your web
page
so now I refresh that and now I see that
I have a border just a single border
around all of the cells in this
particular page
next what I might like to do so though
is like add some space around here like
it seems like these these text is very
tight against the border of this table
so in order to do so I want to add some
spacing and recall again do I want
margin or padding margin is facing
around outside of the border of a
particular HTML element whereas padding
is inside of the border so if I want
some space inside of the Border just to
space out the text from the border
itself then what I want is padding
inside of all of my table cells so I can
say let me add five pixels worth of
padding inside of all of my table data
cells and table header cells
refresh the page and now here's what the
resulting table looks like just by
adding a little bit of CSS specifying
what border I want around the edge of
the page specifying a little bit of
padding inside of each of the cellism my
table now looks a whole lot nicer than
it did just a few lines of code to go
when I just had the HTML structure of
the page and not the CSS to describe how
I actually want that page to be styled
and notice again that in doing so we
were able to use one of these CSS
selectors I was able to say that I
wanted to use the multiple element
selector which is just this comma here
to specify that I would like to apply
this styling not just to TDs but also to
THS as well we'll take a look at some
additional examples of CSS selectors in
just a moment
but next let's turn our attention to
some more tricky instances where we
might want to apply styling to multiple
elements at the same time let's imagine
and let's go back to style.html where we
had some style code where I had one
heading
I'll call this
heading one
and let's give myself two other headings
heading two and heading 3.
all of these now are H1 elements that
are going to show up the same way such
that now if I Style
and say I would like all H1s to show up
with a color of blue
then when I open this page where I have
three H1 tags Each of which has a color
of blue
when I open up style.html
what I'm going to see is something like
this three headings Each of which
happens to have a color of blue
but what would happen now if I wanted to
style only the first edit I want heading
1 to be blue but I don't want to style
heading 2 and heading 3.
how do I do that
well one thing we could do is go back to
the inline styling we did a moment ago
where inside of H1 I said style color is
blue and that would say for just this
very first heading I would like that to
be blue but not the other elements at
all but this again we decided was not
the best design this inline styling
co-mingling of HTML and CSS just gets a
little bit messy and it would be nice to
be able to factor all of our style code
to a separate part of the page
altogether
so how do we do this well we need some
way to uniquely reference this
particular HTML element and in order to
do so we can give an HTML element an ID
in ID is just some unique name we give
to an HTML element so that we can
reference it more easily later on let me
just go ahead and give this an ID of Foo
it could be any idea you want but Foo is
just a generic name here and now we've
given this heading a name such that in
other parts of our page or in other code
we can reference and find this
particular HTML element
and in particular now in the style
section of my web page instead of
styling all H1 elements I only want to
style the element that has an ID of Foo
IDs are by definition unique there can
only be one element in this page that
has an idea Foo otherwise it's not valid
HTML
and so in order to do so we're going to
use hashtag Foo
the hash mark symbol is just css's way
of selecting just something with a
particular ID so instead of just H1 for
selecting all of the H1 tags if I want
to select something by its ID I say hash
Foo to say only style the element that
has an ID of Foo and give it a color of
blue for example
so this style code now will find
something with a particular ID and give
it a style to correspond with it
such that now if I reload this page only
heading 1 is styled heading 2 and
heading 3 are not I've been able to name
heading 1 give it a name of Foo an idea
Foo and then in my style code just style
that particular part of my HTML page
of course what if I wanted to style
multiple but not all of the headings
like maybe I want to style both heading
1 and heading 2. now I could use a
second ID maybe give this an ID of bar
for example and then Style Both the
element with ID Foo and the element with
ID bar but now we're starting to add IDs
unnecessarily I have too many different
names things could start to get messy
especially as my web pages start to get
bigger so while IDs are a way of giving
a name to an HTML element that is unique
sometimes I want to give a name to an
HTML element that is not unique some
name that can apply to multiple
different HTML elements and when we do
that we call that a class an ID is a way
of giving a unique name to an HTML
element while a class is a way of giving
a name to an HTML element that might not
be unique it might apply to zero or one
or two or more different HTML elements
so here's what that might look like
instead of giving each of these H1s an
ID that's different I can give each one
a class we'll give this a class of baz
again just another arbitrary name that
we've chosen
and I'll give this H1 a class of baz as
well
they both belong to the same class
called baz in this case
and now inside of my style code I would
like to say just style the elements that
are of class baz
and just as we had a special symbol the
hashtag for styling only something with
a particular ID
you to style everything with a
particular class I can use a DOT so dot
baz in this case is going to style only
the elements that have a class of baths
so here I can now say take all of the
elements with a class of baz and go
ahead and give those a color of blue
so now I have two H1s that belong to
class baz each the other H1 does not and
I've styled only the things that are of
cloth spaz such that now when I go back
to the page and refresh the page my
first two headings those do get styled
as blue but the third heading does not
because I've applied a class to these
two elements that does not get applied
to this third element there
so oftentimes it can be very helpful if
you have to start to design larger web
pages where you have multiple different
elements some of which might be styled
in some ways and other elements that
might be styled similarly to one another
you can add IDs and classes to your HTML
elements just to clean up the way that
you write your CSS to be able to very
specifically pinpoint one element that
you want to apply style to or to apply
styling to entire class of elements as
well
now one tricky thing you might imagine
now is that now we have multiple ways of
referencing the exact same element so
for example if you imagine that I just
had a single H1 which had an ID of Foo
for example that I've named Foo what
would happen if for instance I said all
of the H1s I would like those to be
colored red
and all of the elements with an ID of
Foo or the only element with an idea Foo
I would like that to be colored blue
what might happen then these would seem
to be conflicting where now suddenly we
have an H1 style tag that is saying I
should style each ones in this way but I
should style element Foo in another way
so what happens if I have an H1 whose ID
is Foo how do I choose to style that and
in order to deal with that we have to
start to deal with the CSS problem of
specificity of what happens when I have
multiple different CSS selectors that
could apply to the exact same HTML
element and
this often happens when we start to add
IDs and classes to our elements as well
so when we deal with specificity
specificity goes in a particular order
there's an order of Precedence that we
can follow for determining what style
should ultimately be applied to any
particular element the first most
powerful most specific way of
referencing an element is inline styling
literally adding a style equals
attribute towards the HTML elements the
way we did way at the beginning when we
were first taking a look at CSS if we
associate inline styling with an HTML
element that's going to take precedence
over any styling that's inside the style
section of our head of the web page or
inside of a separate.css file because
the reasoning goes if you are
literally putting the style code
attached to the element itself then we
probably want to apply it to that
element
after that specificity goes in order of
how precisely we are identifying an
element an ID is a unique way to
identify an element there's only one
element with that particular ID so if
I've added style to a particular ID that
is going to be pretty highly valued in
terms of how specific it is
next we look at classes so if there's no
ID selector we look for did we reference
the element by its class and if so then
that takes next precedence
and otherwise then we fall back to what
type of HTML element it is is it an H1
is it an ordered list is it a table so
in short the type is the least specific
class is slightly more specific ID is
more than that and the most specificity
we can provide is by literally putting
the CSS in line with the HTML element
itself
so let's take a look at an example of
this let's look at this code for example
where for instance I have a div whose ID
is Foo inside of which I'm just saying
the word hello and the CSS code that
I've included here is I've said for all
divs I would like to give those a color
of blue obviously in that case there's
nothing conflicting what we're going to
see is we're going to see the word hello
and we're going to see the word hello in
blue
but what happens now if we add anything
with ID Foo should be colored red well
because ID has higher specificity than
just an individual tag well then next
what we're going to say is that this
hello is going to show up as red the ID
is more specific and so this element is
going to show up red instead and it
doesn't matter
what are these are in it's not that the
later one takes precedence if I were to
flip these around where idfu color red
div color blue is in that order it's
still going to show up as red because
this ID selector is more specific than
just the name div which is the name of
the HTML element that happens to be
there
and so as you start to develop more
sophisticated style sheets you might
find that some of your CSS code is going
to conflict with each other and that's
where it's important to bear in mind how
these specificity rules work to know as
you add style to your elements how are
they actually going to end up showing up
now we've seen a couple of CSS selectors
now in terms of selecting a single
element selecting an ID selecting a
class selecting multiple elements as
well it turns out there are a number of
other CSS selectors that we can use too
so we saw for example the multiple
element selector like TD comma th for
selecting table data but also table
headers but there's a number of other
selectors here's just a sampling of ones
you can specify like descendants or
children so if I only want to style divs
that are inside of tables or I only want
to style lists that are inside of
certain classes I can use these
descendant and child selectors to add
styling in those particular ways and
there are a number of other CSS
selectors we can add as well and we'll
go ahead and explore a couple of these
just to give you a sample of how some of
these CSS selectors can actually work
and we'll start by taking a look at the
descendant selector which is used to
select all the elements that are
descendants of some other element for
example
so let's go ahead and create a new file
that I'll call descendant
.html
that again
we'll start with the same code
and inside the body of this page I want
an ordered list that maybe has a list
item one
and maybe list item two
and it turns out with lists in HTML you
can Nest lists inside of other lists
maybe you've seen bullet points where
there's like nested bullets inside of
other bullet points I can do that here I
can add an unordered list and create a
sub list like sublist item one
and sublist item two and maybe down here
here's another list item
such that now I have a couple of items
but some that are inside of an unordered
sub list
let's go ahead and open up
descendant.html and see what that looks
like
so here's what we have we have list item
one list item two another list item that
is probably actually
list item three
so we have three items but inside of
list item two I have an unordered list
let's imagine for example that I wanted
to only style these sub list items as a
particular color like maybe I want those
to be blue for example
if in the style section of my web page I
say that I would like for all list items
to be styled blue
well then not styled colored blue rather
then what I'm going to see when I
refresh the page is that all of the
items are going to be blue instead of
just the two sub-list items
but I could instead say that you know
what I only want list items that are
children of unordered lists and I can do
direct children using this greater than
symbol to say that only if there is a UL
that immediately contains an Li within
it then I would like for that to be
colored blue
and now if I refresh that now you'll see
that the ordered items listed in one two
three those do not get colored but only
the list items that are inside of the
unordered list that are directly
children of that unordered list actually
get the CSS styling applied this greater
than symbol here is specifying immediate
children I could get rid of it ulli like
this and this would also work
you still see sublist item one and two
but this is a more General selector
called The Descendant selector that
selects all descendant elements so they
might not be the children element so
that might be grandchildren elements so
to speak if those children elements have
other children that are attached to them
as well again for all of this it's
helpful to begin to think about things
in terms of that document object model
that Dom structure that tree that
represented how all of our various
different HTML elements are related to
one another
so next up we can begin to take a look
at some of the other selectors that we
have access to so one of those selectors
might be something like modifying and
only on a specific attribute of a
particular HTML element so we can use
the attribute selector for that I'll
create a new file called attribute.html
where here let's go ahead and create a
unordered list
that's going to have a number of
different links to various different
websites so here's a list item that is
going to be a link to Google
so I'll link to google.com and say
Google
and I'll go ahead and add a link to
facebook.com
call that Facebook
and I'll go ahead and add a link to
amazon.com and call that Amazon
and let's imagine for a moment that I
only wanted to style the Facebook link
like I want to really highlight the
Facebook link tell people to click on
that one as by coloring it in entirely
different color
well to cut to style links normally I
would say something like links should be
colored you know blue for example
they're color blue by default but I
could be explicit about it and say links
should be color blue like that such that
now when I open up attribute.html all of
the links are colored blue
but I could also say I would like links
that have an href attribute of
facebook.com
I would like those links
to be colored red instead
so this square bracket notation I can
use to specify a particular attribute of
an HTML element only anchor tags a tags
whose ahref is equal to facebook.com
those should be the only ones colored
red so now when I refresh this I now see
that Facebook is a link that is now
colored red instead of colored blue
because I've been very specific about
picking an attribute that I would like
to use in order to reference that
particular HTML element
and we can use CSS selectors in more
powerful ways too maybe not just to
style a particular element always but to
style an element only under certain
conditions or only when an element is in
a particular State and this is very
often done for something like when you
hover over something when you hover over
some a button and something pops out or
you hover over something and it changes
color slightly we can begin to do this
by adding what we call a pseudo class to
a CSS selector so let's take a look at
an example of that to see how we can
modify an element when a user hovers
their cursor over that element for
example
so I'll go ahead and open up a new file
hover.html
we're here I'll go ahead and inside the
body of the page just give myself a
button
this button is going to say
click me
and let's add some style to the button
by default buttons show up as fairly
simple buttons it just looks something
like this I might like to add a little
bit more to this button and say you know
what let's add some style to the button
and give it a width of 200 pixels a
height of 50 pixels a font size of 24
pixels and maybe a background color
of green for example
so I specified some size information how
big I'd like the font to be and also a
background color for the button such
that now here's what that button looks
like shrink it down a little bit it says
click me but many buttons especially
nowadays are a little bit of they give
you a little bit of feedback you hover
over them and they change their color
slightly how do they do that well often
it's using a CSS pseudo class where I
can say button colon hover meaning when
I am hovering over a button
then I'd like you to change the
background color
to Orange for example some other color
so now I specified that by default
normally for a button your background
color should be green but when the
button is being hovered over instead now
change the background color to Orange
such that now when I open up this page
and go to click me if I hover over the
button
the color of the button changes normally
green changes to Orange and so that is a
very powerful feature that we have
access to as well
all right so now we've seen how we can
use various different CSS selectors to
very precisely Define how we want our
web pages to be styled but one other
thing we can use CSS for that's quite
powerful is responsive design and
responsive design is all about making
sure that our web pages look good no
matter how you're looking at the web
page nowadays people aren't always
looking at web pages on their computers
but they're looking at web pages on
their mobile phones or on their tablets
as well and it's important as we begin
to design web pages that we design our
web pages in a responsive way so we'll
look at a number of different ways we
can Implement responsive design in our
web pages starting with the discussion
of the viewport
and what the viewport is is the viewport
is the visual part of the screen that
the user can actually see so the
viewport is this entire area of the web
page that displays content to the user
so one question you might ask is what's
going to happen when you take this page
and translate it onto a Mobile screen
well one thing that many mobile devices
do by default is treat their viewport as
though it is the same width as a
computer screen because not all web
pages are optimized for mobile device
mobile devices you want to make sure
that on a mobile device you can see
everything and so many phones will take
a web page like this and just shrink it
down to fit onto a Mobile screen that
looks a little something like that
now of course that's probably not really
what we want it to look like ideally we
want our page to adapt to different size
screens maybe we want the heading and
the image and the text if that's what
these are to grow a little bit to fill
that entire screen and so one simple
thing we can do is just to add a little
line of code to our HTML inside the head
section of our page that controls the
viewport this line of code here is
providing some metadata to our HTML page
and saying I would like you to change
the viewport to be specifically the
width of the device by default many
phones will use a viewport that's
actually wider than the with the device
treat it as if they're loading a page on
a computer and then shrinking it down to
the size of a mobile device if you and
your web page specify though that you
want the viewport to be just the device
with oftentimes a page is going to look
a whole lot better on a mobile device
but in addition to just adding a line
like this there are other actual changes
we can make to our page to make it look
a little better on different screens and
one of those has to do with media
queries and media queries are all about
controlling how our page is going to
look depending on how we render that
particular page or what size screen
we're rendering that page on so let's
take a look at an example of how we
might go about do using media queries in
order to control what a page actually
looks like depending on what type of
page or what type of browser we're using
to view it
so I'll go ahead and open a new file
that I'll call
responsive.html because we're going to
try and build a responsive web page now
and now I'll go ahead and inside the
body of my page just include a big
heading that says welcome to my web page
for example
and just to demonstrate what you can do
now with responsive design is I could
say something like let me add a style
tag here
where I want to say that if the size of
the screen is a certain width then I
want to style the page in one way and if
the size of the page is a different
width then I might want to style the
page in a different way you might
imagine that as you shrink the screen
you want to move elements around in
order to rearrange them to make the page
just look a little bit nicer on a mobile
screen so we'll do a very simple example
of just changing the color depending on
the size of the screen
so let me specify now in a media query
in the Syntax for media query looks like
this I'm going to use the at symbol and
say media and then specify for what type
of media I would like to apply this
query I can say something like if the
minimum width of the page is 600 pixels
in other words if the width of the page
is 600 pixels or anything larger than
600 pixels
well then go ahead and take the body and
give it a background color of red
but then I could also add another media
query and say you know what for this
media query let me give it a Max width
of 599 pixels meaning if the size of the
screen is 599 pixels or fewer then maybe
I'd like to take the body and give it a
background color of blue for example
so now let's take a look at what happens
when I take this page and actually open
it and see what's going on I'll open up
responsive.html
and here's what I see normally I see a
red web page because my screen is longer
than 600 pixels wide but notice what
happens is I shrink this web page if I
go ahead and shrink it
looking at it on the smaller screen
eventually it turns to Blue if it's
above 600 pixels wide it's going to be
red if it's below 600 pixels wide the
color changes to Blue so we're able to
now use these media queries to really
fine-tune the control how our page is
going to look on various different types
of devices if it's on a big screen maybe
you want the elements to look a certain
way if it's a smaller screen maybe they
look differently and you don't just need
to control a background color you can
control any CSS property you want just
by using these media queries you can say
on a big screen you want certain amounts
of spacing or padding you can even hide
elements on smaller screens if you want
to by using a particular CSS property
called the display property that
controls whether or not an element is
even visible
and ultimately put together this can
help to make your pages a little bit
more responsive and there are a number
of different media queries that we can
apply to our page as well we can check
to see whether a mobile device is
vertical or landscape we can check to
see whether the user is viewing the page
on their computer screen or if they've
tried to print out the contents of the
page as well so there are a number of
different options that we have to really
control how a page is going to look
there are some other tools we have in
our toolbox as well though for dealing
with mobile responsiveness and one of
the tools built into the latest version
of CSS is something called flexbox and
flexbox is quite helpful if we have
multiple elements that we're all trying
to display on the same page at the same
time that might overflow if we're not
careful about how we do responsive
design if we're really not careful let's
imagine I have six elements that show up
on my computer's monitor when you
translate that to a Mobile screen you
can imagine they may all shrink down so
that they're barely visible something
like this this is probably not what we
want if we're trying to design a mobile
responsive page for example so you might
imagine how can we do a little bit
better
well another thing we could do is take
these elements and go ahead and keep
them the same size but make you have to
scroll through them this isn't a
slightly better the elements are at
least still visible and they're large
enough on the screen but it'd be nice
not to have to scroll through them what
would be really nice is given that we
have all this extra space I would like
to be able to wrap around elements if I
don't have enough space for them such
that if I'm translating these six
elements to a Mobile screen they
translate but I get them in like two
rows for example three on the top and
three below and flexbox is an easy way
to be able to implement something like
this inside of our web pages
so let's take a look at what that might
actually look like to add flexbox to our
page
so I'll go ahead and create a new file
called flexbox.html
we'll start with the same HTML code and
now
inside of the body I'm going to create
first a div that is going to be called
the container
and we're creating a container because
we're going to specifically say that
everything inside the container I would
like to add flexbox to to be able to
wrap it around so that things can go on
to multiple lines if I ever need to and
now let me just add some sample text so
this is some sample text inside of a div
to demo flexbox
and I'll go ahead and repeat this maybe
like 12 times and I'll number each one
here's one two three four and I'll
number all the rest
this is just to give a demonstration of
what these elements could actually look
like
ideally these would be different pieces
of content though
so now inside of my style tag here's
what I'm going to say just to
demonstrate I'll say take the ID
container again the hashtag specifies
get me something with a particular ID
and I want to display it using flexbox
and in particular I would like to use
the flex wrap property to say if there's
not enough room at the end of a line for
all of the elements go ahead and wrap
around those elements onto the next line
instead
and now I can specify some additional
CSS properties for the divs inside of
the container so I can say for the
container all of the divs inside of that
container again using this child
selector to get all of the divs that are
inside of the container I can add some
CSS to that too I can say let's give
these a background color of like a shade
of green I can give them a particular
font maybe 20 pixel font give them some
margin and padding just to add some
space and maybe each one is going to be
200 pixels wide
so just adding some spacing to those
individual divs the important part is
this right here where I've said that
this whole container is going to be a
flexbox container and I'd like to wrap
around elements if you ever reach the
end
so now I'll open up flexbox.html
and so here I now see 12 elements that
are on multiple lines but notice what
happens as I shrink the page if there
isn't room for all of them elements move
onto other lines now there's only three
elements in any particular row now
there's only two elements on any
particular row and so I can use flexbox
to very well adapt myself to different
size screens and no matter whether
you're looking at this on a big screen
or a small screen the content is still
going to look good because I'm able to
adapt responsively to whatever might be
happening
so this is one layout Paradigm that
exists within CSS this flexbox layout
there are other layouts that exist as
well one common one is the grid layout
for any time you want to arrange things
in a particular Grid or maybe certain
columns need to be certain widths but
others could maybe be a little bit more
flexible show us I'll show one example
of that too just to give you a
demonstration of what that grid layout
might look like
so here's grid.html
where I'll go ahead and inside the body
of this page give myself a div whose
I'll give it an ID of grid
and then let me just add div class
equals grid item again a class because
there might be multiple items
but I'll go ahead and just create a
whole bunch of grid items and number
each one so two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so I have a whole bunch of grid items
inside of a div whose ID is grid
and now I'd like to add
some style here
I'll say for the grid
let's give it a background color maybe
maybe a background color should be green
a display is going to be grid I want
this to show up as a grid and now there
are a couple of attributes I'm going to
or properties that I'm going to specify
here maybe I want some padding around
the grid first but the important grid
properties are grid
column Gap how much space goes between
each of the columns maybe I'll say like
20 pixels likewise there's also a grid
row Gap how much space goes between each
of the rows of the grid maybe I'll say
10 pixels here
and then finally grid template columns
is a way for me to specify how many
columns there are going to be and how
wide should each of those columns be so
if I want maybe three columns I can
specify that the First Column should be
200 pixels
the second column should also be 200
pixels and the third column can be
automatically sized just grow or Shrink
to fill the screen
so we'll say Auto so First Column 200
pixels second column 200 pixels third
column just do it automatically
and now for all of the grid items
well those I can add some styling to to
as well I'll give them a background
color of white just to distinguish them
and also give them some font size and
some padding and maybe Center them as
well so just adding some additional CSS
properties in order to make it display
the way I want to but the important ones
to care about here are display as grid
and then I'm specifying here's how the
grid should be laid out how much space
between columns how much space between
rows and how wide are each of those rows
going to be
now if I open up
grid.html here's what that grid looks
like I now have a First Column 200
pixels wide a second column also 200
pixels wide and a third column that's
going to resize dynamically based on how
wide or how narrow my screen happens to
be so as I shrink the screen the third
column shrinks with it as I grow the
screen it also grows alongside with how
big this window happens to be
and so flexbox and grid are some very
powerful tools that we can use just to
make it easier for us to be able to use
mobile responsive design to be able to
make sure that our Pages look good no
matter what kind of browser or what kind
of device the user is using in order to
look at our page but it turns out there
exists a lot of libraries out there that
do a lot of this for us some people that
have already written CSS code to make
our text look good to make our buttons
look good in order to make sure that
things are mobile responsive and one of
those is called bootstrap bootstrap is a
very popular CSS library that we can use
in order to use some styling that they
have written such that we don't need to
write all the styling from scratch so
this is what bootstrap's website looks
like I'll go ahead and show it to you
now just to give you a sampling for
what's available inside of a library
like bootstrap
if I go to getbootstrap.com
here's bootstrap's website and if I go
to their documentation on this first
link here I can look at all of the
bootstrap components that I'm given
access to these are things like alerts
for example that here's an alert that's
styled in a very particular way it's in
a specific font it's gotten a certain
amount of padding in certain colors and
if I want to just copy this alert once
I've used bootstraps code I can just
apply certain classes to a div and
bootstrap will handle the process of
applying the right styles for me I don't
need to write all of these styles by
myself from scratch bootstrap's written
a lot of The Styling already
so how do you actually go about using
bootstrap well to get started with
bootstrap all you need to do is copy the
CSS link that bootstrap gives you to the
top of your file so if I take the CSS
link and then go back to something like
hello.html which you'll recall
originally looked something like
this just hello world
I can add some bootstrap to it to say
all right I would like to take this HTML
file and apply bootstrap styling to it
to make it look a little bit nicer so I
refresh the page and now you'll notice
bootstraps chosen a custom font for me
just to make things look a little nicer
in bootstrap's own eyes and now if I
want to add bootstrap elements I can say
all right let me go to their components
and I want to add an alert I can just
copy their alert code
here's their alert code for a primary
alert an alert that looks blue
and I can just inside the body of my
page go ahead and add an alert and maybe
change the text to here is my alert for
example
now when I reload hello.html I now see
an alert that shows up styled according
to bootstrap styling
and again I can change that styling just
by changing these classes
so a primary alert shows up as blue a
success alert shows up as green a danger
alert is red so if I want to give a
danger alert the user is doing something
wrong on the web page for example I can
change alert primary here inside my HTML
to something like alert danger instead
and now when I refresh this page I now
see the alert shows up as red instead of
blue
so bootstrap gives us access to a lot of
these various different types of
components different ways of adding
breadcrumbs and alerts and carousels and
other elements to our page just to make
it easy to make our page look good very
very quickly without having to worry too
much about writing our own CSS because
bootstrap's written a lot of that for us
bootstrap even includes a way to make
sure that web pages are mobile
responsive using something called
bootstrap's column model
so I'll show you an example of that now
bootstrap divides its page into 12
distinct columns so one thing I can do
is I've pulled this up in an example I
have an advance called column 0.html
notice that inside of the body of my
page now I have a div whose classes
container and then a div whose classes
row and bootstrap divides every row into
a 12 unit column
so here for example I have a whole bunch
of divs that are each three unit columns
so if I have four three unit columns
that will take up a total amount of
space equal to 12 meaning filling up the
entirety of the screen
so if I now open up Source column zero
dot HTML here's what that looks like I
have four columns Each of which is of
width three and as a result as I shrink
it those columns will automatically
resize to make sure that they're always
the appropriate size now as long as they
add up to 12 they don't all need to be
the same size so for example if I only
wanted three columns instead of four I
could get rid of the fourth column by
deleting those rows
and maybe change the second column
instead of to being a column of size
three let's make it a column of size six
so that's a length six column instead
and now if I refresh the page now
suddenly I see three columns where the
middle one is twice as large as the ones
on either end and as I shrink this down
I can see that it shrinks down as well
and one of the advantages of using
bootstrap columns is that they too can
be mobile responsive they too can wrap
around other lines if they ever need to
so for example let me pull up
columns1.html
here for example I have a row and let's
take a look at what's going on in here
recall that every Row in bootstrap is
divided up into 12 column units but
bootstrap in addition to letting me
specify how many units a column should
take up also lets me specify how many
units that column should take up
depending on the size of the screen so
if I'm on a large screen as indicated by
LG this is saying that on a large screen
this div should take up three units of
space and this div should also take up
three units of space and for each of
these four divs on a large screen each
will take up three of the total 12 units
of space so they'll all show up on one
row
what happens on a small screen though
well here call SM for column on a small
screen I've said on a small screen each
column should only take up should take
up six units of Space six or half of the
total 12 that I have in the row and so I
use up six here six here for a total of
12 and one row which means the next two
also a size 6 need to go on to a second
row and bootstrap is smart enough to do
this math for me and figure out how
exactly these elements should ultimately
be laid out
so now if I open up columns1.html
and see what's there on a large screen I
see four columns all in the same row but
as I shrink down to a smaller screen
eventually
we'll see that things change I now see
the third and four sections move down
onto the second row because on a smaller
screen now when the when the window is
smaller now I only have the ability to
show two elements in any particular row
so I get two on the first row and then
two on the row underneath that
so all in all there are a lot of
different ways to know that we can use
CSS in order to make sure our pages are
mobile responsive we can use bootstrap's
column model to make sure the columns
move around whenever a size of the
window shrinks or grows we can also use
things like flexbox and the grid model
writing our own CSS to make sure that
our page is responsive depending on the
size of the screen that the user happens
to be using in order to visit our web
page so these are some of the very
powerful features that we get using just
CSS
but one thing you might imagine is that
as we begin to write more and more CSS
there's going to be more and more
repetition things that appear again and
again and again and we've already seen
some ways that we can minimize
redundancy in CSS we've seen how we can
move CSS into the style section of our
web page we've even seen how we can move
CSS to an entirely different file
however what we haven't yet seen is how
to deal with other types of redundancy
and so let's take a look at an example
of that now let's imagine for example
that I want to style multiple different
elements uh in different ways but using
some common properties so for example
let me create a new file that all in
this case call variables.html
and you'll see why in a moment
I'll go ahead and copy hello.html but
I'll get rid of all this bootstrap
inside of it
let's imagine that here I have in maybe
two lists an ordered list and an
unordered list
where my unordered list has unordered
item
maybe three unordered items
and my ordered list also has three
ordered items
again just for sake of demonstration I'm
showing that we have these two lists now
and I'll open up
variables.html just to give you a sense
for what that could look like we have
three unordered items in an unordered
list three ordered items in an ordered
list
let's imagine I wanted to style these a
little bit differently
maybe inside the style section of my
page I want to style the unordered list
to have a font size of 14 pixels and
maybe a color of red
and my ordered list I would like that to
have a font size of maybe larger 18
pixels but also a color of red I want to
keep the same color for all the text but
I want the font sizes to be different
now if I refresh this page here's what I
see they are indeed of different sizes
the ordered list items are larger than
the unordered list items and they're all
red but there was some redundancy some
repetition that was introduced when I
was writing my CSS code in particular
when I was writing my CSS code
I've repeated this usage of the color
red if I ever want to change the color
from red to blue for example I'm going
to have to change my code in two
different places ultimately I just like
for my CSS to be a little bit more
powerful and so that brings us to our
last topic today which is a language
called SAS and SAS is a language that is
essentially an extension to CSS it adds
additional features to what CSS has to
offer just to make it a little bit more
powerful for us to be able to use and
manipulate CSS in a way that's going to
be faster and remove some of the
repetition that we might have had in CSS
previously and one of the key features
of SAS is the ability to have variables
so let's take a look at an example of
the snow
I'm going to create a new file normally
when we created our CSS files we call
them like
variables.css something.css to stand for
a CSS file SAS is a different language
though so it's going to require a
different extension we're going to
conventionally use dot scss to stand for
this is a SAS file
so here's now variables.scss
and now what I can do in SAS is I can
actually create variables in the same
way that we could create variables in a
programming language like python which
we'll soon see CSS normally doesn't
support variables but SAS is going to
give us that power in SAS all variables
begin with a dollar sign so I can create
a variable dollar sign color to create a
variable called color
and I can say the variable called color
is going to be equal to red
so this line here line one is my way of
telling SAS I'd like to create a
variable called color and I'd like for
its value to be red
and now I can add the same styling I had
before I can just use normal CSS and say
for an unordered list I'd like the font
size to be 14 pixels but the color
instead of saying red here I can use the
name of a variable I can say dollar sign
color
to mean go ahead and use the value of
the variable color as the color for this
unordered list
then for an ordered list I'll also say
font size 18 pixels and say color should
also be this variable called color
by using a variable I've removed the
repetition rather than having the word
red show up in multiple places in my
code where I would need to change it
twice if I ever needed to change it now
I have defined the variable once and I
only ever need to change it in one place
if I ever need to make modifications to
this particular file
so now let's try and Link this file
instead of we'll go back to
variables.html
instead of putting the style code here
I'll go ahead and Link
a style sheet
and say the href should be
variables.scss because that's the file
where my styling exists
so now let me try and open up
variables.html after I've linked the CSS
and all right something seems not quite
right I specified font sizes I specified
that everything should be read but it's
not showing up everything is showing up
black and I don't see any of the
differences in sizing and the reason for
this is while the web browser things
like Chrome and Safari and Firefox can
understand CSS they can't by default
understand scss or SAS SAS is an
extension to CSS that web browsers don't
understand out of the box
so in order to solve this problem once
we've written our SAS file we need to
compile it convert it translate it so to
speak from SAS into plain old CSS so
that our browser is able to understand
it and so you'll need in order to do
this you'll need to install a program
called SAS onto your computer you can
install it on Mac or PC or Linux and now
in the terminal in order to do this
compilation I'm going to say SAS
variables.scss the file I'd like to
compile colon variables.css
so variables.scss is the file that I
would like to compile and the file I'd
like to generate is variables.css I'd
like to turn my SAS file into a plain
old CSS file
I'll go ahead and press return and to
write that compilation process is now
done
and so now inside of variables.html
instead of represent referencing the
scss file I'm going to reference the CSS
file as the style sheet because my web
browser only understands CSS it doesn't
understand SAS
now when I load the page now I see the
result I expect everything shows up as
red and the font sizes are different so
ultimately this was a two-step process I
first needed to take my SAS code compile
it into CSS and then I could link the
CSS to this particular page
but the advantage now is that if ever I
want to make some sort of change I want
to change the color rather than change
it in two places or you might imagine in
a more complex page like tens or dozens
of places I just go to the scss file
and I change the color from red to blue
now if I refresh the page
all right everything is still red and
it's because I forgot a step I changed
the SAS file but that doesn't
automatically change the CSS file I need
to now recompile the CSS file
by saying SAS variables.scss
variables.css to compile the file again
using the updated SAS file and now I see
the updated changes
and if you're curious as what the
updated file looks like I'm gonna
actually look at variables.css to see
what code happens to be there and though
it's styled a little bit strangely you
can see that I have a UL with a font
size of 14 and a color of blue so
they've substituted the word blue for
this variable and they've done the same
thing for ordered lists as well
now in practice it's going to be pretty
annoying if I'm building a web page
building using SAS if I constantly need
to go back and recompile my SAS into CSS
every single time what I'd like to do is
just automate that process and SAS makes
it easy to do this I can just say SAS
dash dash watch
variables.scss variables.css
and what that's going to do is now you
see SAS is watching for changes SAS is
going to monitor the
variables.css file and if ever I change
my SAS file SAS is going to know about
it and it's automatically going to
recompile the corresponding CSS file and
you can do this now just with single
files but entire directories as well if
you have multiple different SAS files so
now what I can do
is if in the variables.scss file I
change the color instead of blue I now
want it to be green for example I now
save the variables.scss file and now
without doing anything take a look at my
terminal
SAS detected a change to variables.scss
so it gave me a new version of my
original CSS file
if I go back to my web browser now
refresh the page now all of the text is
green as I would expect it to be
so that's one of the very powerful
features that SAS gives us it gives us
the ability to add variables to our CSS
code just to factor out commonalities if
there are common fonts common colors
common borders common styling that I
want to apply to a lot of different
things it becomes much easier just to
use SAS in order to do so
and finally we'll take a look at a
couple of other features that SAS gives
us the ability to do one of them is the
ability to Nest CSS selectors inside of
other CSS selectors
so one thing you've seen so far for
example is that in CSS if I wanted to
style all of the unordered lists that
are inside of divs for example I could
say like div Arrow unordered list in
order to style unordered lists that are
inside of divs
what CSS what SAS will do is it'll give
us a bit of a nicer Syntax for doing
this type of thing in particular by
allowing us to Nest CSS inside of other
pieces of CSS
so just as an example of this I'll go
ahead and open up a file I already
brought called nesting.html
and so here's what we might see inside
of nesting.html here's the body of the
page inside the body of the page I have
a div
inside of which is a paragraph inside
the div and also a list in unordered
list or UL that's inside of this div as
well
and then we also have a paragraph that's
outside of the div and a list that's
outside of the div in addition to that
so A number of different elements some
of which are located inside of other
elements and what I'd like to do is be
very precise about how I style these
pages
what SAS is going to allow us to do is
it lets us write a SAS file that looks a
little something like this let's take a
look at what it's doing it's saying for
the entire div I would like to give that
div a font size of 18 pixels
and then what CSS normally doesn't allow
us to do but we can do now using the
power of SAS is say for any paragraphs
that are inside of that div go ahead and
give those paragraphs a color of blue
and for any unordered lists that are
inside of the div give those unordered
lists a color of green by nesting these
CSS selectors inside of others we've
been able to get across the idea that I
only want to style the paragraph if it
is inside of a div and this is just a
little bit of a nicer cleaner syntax for
doing some of these more complex styling
tasks that might come up
so what does this actually look like if
I like take this scss file and turn it
into normal CSS what is the result going
to be well let's take a look we can try
it out by let me go into my nesting
folder where all these files are located
and if I run SAS nesting.s CSS turn it
into nesting.css
now let's open up nesting.css and see
what it looks like
here it's turned into take all of the
divs give them a font size of 18 pixels
and then we're using the same descendant
selector notation that we saw before
where all the paragraphs inside of divs
should be color blue all the unordered
lists inside of a div should be colored
green and this certainly works and we
could have just written this CSS from
the beginning but it can be a little bit
cleaner a little bit easier to read to
use SAS in order to really say uh
paragraphs inside of divs should be
structured this way unordered lists are
styled in some other way and using this
nesting approach just makes it often
easier to take a look at this scss page
and really understand how all of the
different style code interacts with each
other
so after all of this now if I open up
nesting.html
we might see something that looks a
little something like this the paragraph
inside the div and the list inside of
the div those both get changes to the
way that they've been styled but unlike
them these paragraphs outside of the div
and the list that is also outside of the
div those get styled a little bit
differently
so two features now we've seen inside of
SAS we've first seen the ability to have
variables to make sure we're not
repeating ourselves in many places
throughout the code and now we've seen
the ability to Nest CSS selectors inside
of each other by taking advantage of SAS
finally we'll take a look at one last
feature that SAS is going to give us and
that is something called inheritance if
we have certain CSS selectors that are
related to other CSS selectors but that
are maybe adding some additional
information and in this case I'm
actually going to show you the finished
product first so let's go into
inheritance and let me open up
inheritance.html
and here you see I've tried to almost
Implement bootstrap style alert messages
in HTML I have a success message up at
the top a warning message and then an
error message and each of these messages
you'll notice are styled differently in
particular they're each a different
color but despite that they share a lot
in common they share a common border
they share a common font they share a
common size and many other properties
are all shared between these elements
there are just some things that are a
little bit different about them I could
have written three different CSS
selectors to deal with all of these
cases but there might be some repetition
there so here's what I can do by taking
advantage of the features that SAS gives
me
let me go ahead and look at inheritance
dot scss to look at the code for doing
this
and
it looks a little bit cryptic at first
but here's what I've defined I've here
defined using a percent sign that this
is what a generic message is going to be
something that I can extend later to add
additional information to all of the
messages whether they be success
messages or danger messages or warning
messages they're all going to have the
same font they're all going to have the
same border they're all going to have
the same padding and margin spacing
around and outside of it but each of the
specific messages are going to be
slightly different
how are they different well let's take a
look down here
anything with a class of success I'm
going to say extends this message and by
extends this message what I mean is that
anything with a class of success is
going to inherit all of these CSS
properties the font the border the
padding and the margin
but it's going to add additional
information to it in particular we're
going to add a color we're going to say
that for Success messages the background
color is going to be green I have
extended the basics of what a message is
but said that this message in particular
has some additional style that we're
going to assign to it as well and the
other two messages behave in very
similar ways my warning message extends
the message but instead says the
background color should be orange and
finally the error message also extends
the message but this time gives us a
background color of red instead
so now when you compile this all
together into inheritance.css which are
compiled in advance
uh this is what this is ultimately going
to look like it translates what I've
written into saying all right success
and warning and errors should have all
of these properties but success should
also have this background color warning
should have this background color error
should have this background color so you
again we could have written this CSS
there's nothing that SAS does that we
couldn't have written ourselves using
CSS SAS will just make it a little bit
easier to do many of the same things so
we can write things in a little bit of a
nicer syntax by saying the success
message inherits from the message but
adds a background color and likewise the
warning and error messages do the same
thing but in a simpler syntax and a bit
of a nicer syntax such that later we can
let the computer take the SAS code and
compile it into CSS instead
and so those now are some of the
fundamentals of what we've seen in
building web programs using HTML and CSS
we've seen how we can use HTML to
describe the structure of our web page
deciding what's going to show up where
on the page and then we looked at CSS
and how CSS can then be used to style
our web page in various different ways
adding custom styling like colors and
layouts but also thinking about things
like responsive design like what happens
on a mobile screen or on a tablet and
making sure that our web pages look good
on those screens too and then finally we
took a look at SAS in extension to CSS
that adds a number of additional
features features like variables and
nesting and inheritance that make it
even easier for us to be able to write
style that we can apply to our web pages
from there we're going to be
transitioning now to looking at how we
can use HTML and CSS in larger web
applications as we begin to incorporate
other tools tools like Python and
JavaScript and other languages and
Frameworks altogether so this is web
programming with python and JavaScript
we'll see you next time
thank you
[Music]
all right welcome back everyone to web
programming with python and JavaScript
so last time we took a look at two
languages HTML and CSS both of which can
be used to design web pages HTML we used
in order to describe the structure of
web pages to decide what content we want
in the layout of the page and then CSS
we use to describe the style of the page
what color we wanted things how much
space we wanted to run things as well
today we're going to turn our attention
to a tool that we can use as we begin to
develop these web applications and in
particular we're going to be looking at
a tool called git and what git is is it
is a Version Control tool not specific
to web programs necessarily but that
we're going to use as we begin to
develop bigger and more sophisticated
web applications over the course of this
term so what is git going to enable us
to do well it's going to do a couple of
things first and foremost what git is it
is a command line tool that's going to
allow us to First keep track of changes
that we make to code so once upon a time
the first time I was starting to develop
web applications I remember working on a
file and then when I wanted to make
changes I might have wanted to save the
old version so I would duplicate the
file and then just make changes to the
duplicate but this quickly gets messy
especially if you have lots of different
versions of your code in various
different stages keeping track of them
just starts to become a nightmare so
what git is going to enable us to do is
to keep track of changes that we make to
our code so we might create a file
initially save that version of it but
over time as we make changes add to it
remove things from it we can save
snapshots so to speak of various
different parts of our code at different
points in time such that we can quickly
and easily reference all of those
changes that we've made to that code
additionally git is going to make it
easy for us to synchronize code between
different people in larger scale web
applications it's rarely just one person
who's working on the entire application
usually you're working with a co-worker
or multiple co-workers all in the same
application and all at the same time and
one definitely tricky part of this
process is figuring out how to
synchronize your work between different
people if I make a change on my part of
the web application I want to make sure
that my colleagues are also able to see
those changes and get access to the
latest changes that I've made and then I
want to be able to get access to the
latest changes that the people I'm
working with have made too so we need
some way to keep everything in sync and
git is going to enable us to do that
what we're going to effectively have is
one version of the code stored in what
we're going to call a repository
somewhere online and both I and someone
I'm working with a partner for example
might both be able to get access to that
exact same repository those same files
in the same state and If Ever I and the
other person make changes to those files
we can each make changes to those files
and then say synchronize them back up
pushing them back up to the server so to
speak so that the server will have the
most recent most up-to-date version of
this code then after that after we've
both pushed our changes up to the server
then we can both pull changes from the
server so to speak in order to get
access to the latest version of the code
so that no matter what so long as I've
been working on the same project that my
partner has we can use git to
synchronize our work so that I have
access to my colleagues most recent
changes and vice versa
git also enables us to do a number of
other things for example git allows us
to test changes to our code without
removing access to the original so for
example you might imagine that as I'm
working on writing a program I might
want to try making some changes but I'm
not sure if they're quite going to work
so I want to test those changes but I
don't want to lose access to my original
working version of the program just in
case something goes wrong so what git
enables us to do is it lets us make
changes to code on a separate Branch so
to speak such that later once we're
happy and satisfied with the changes we
can merge those changes back into the
original version of our code being able
to test those changes before we're
really sure that they're the ones that
we want to make and finally one powerful
feature that git gives us access to is
the ability to revert back to old
versions of our code so you might
imagine in a situation where I've been
working on some code and I realized that
actually what I'm doing right now isn't
what I want git enables us to say you
know what this most recent change isn't
something that I wanted I would like to
revert back to a previous version of the
code instead and git makes it very easy
to go back to those previous versions
so the goal for today is going to be to
learn how to use this tool to learn the
various different git commands that will
be quite popular and quite common as you
go about working on web applications or
really any other code related project
because Version Control really allows a
number of useful features that are
practical as you begin to work on larger
and larger projects But ultimately as we
begin working on these git projects they
need to be stored somewhere online such
that we're able to download them from
anywhere such that me and a partner can
both be working on the same files in the
same code and so in order to do that we
need to host our git code somewhere and
there are a number of different websites
that can do this but one of the most
popular is a website known as GitHub
GitHub is a website that stores git
repositories where all a repository is
is you can think of it as a folder that
holds a whole bunch of code and files
related to our code so we're going to
host this code online on a website
called GitHub and then on our computer
we'll be able to access these GitHub
repositories and manipulate those
repositories by changing the files that
are within them so let's go ahead and
take a look at GitHub and see how we can
go ahead and create our very first
GitHub repository
if you don't already have a GitHub
account you can create one by going to
github.com and signing up for an account
for free and I'll now go to github.com
new github.com new is the page I go to
if I want to create a new GitHub
repository and so let's take a look at
what I need to do in order to create a
repository the first thing I need to do
is give my repository a name so in this
case I'm just going to call the
repository hello we can give it any name
you want so long as that name doesn't
collide with other repository names that
you already have
GitHub optionally lets me provide a
description for this repository I'll
just say web programming with python and
JavaScript
and then GitHub gives me the choice do I
want this to be a public repository such
that anyone can see the repository not
everyone can necessarily make changes to
it but it's publicly available if anyone
wants to download my code and try it out
public means that anyone can access it
or private meaning by default only I can
see this repository but I can choose if
I would like other people to be able to
see it as well and I can select which
individuals for now I'll go ahead and
make this repository public and I'll go
down here and click on the green create
repository button in order to make this
new Repository
so I click the create repository button
and here it is this is the github's
repository page and right now you'll
notice that there's a lot of
instructions here but there are no files
because right now when I first created
my first git repository I got an empty
repository with nothing in it so what
I'd like to do now is somehow download
this repository onto my own computer
such that I can add say an HTML file
that contains some HTML that I want to
keep track of using git so how am I
going to do that well in order to do
that we're going to take a look at the
very first git command that's going to
be involved with Git which is known as
git clone git clone is a command that we
can run in order to take a repository
from the internet and download it onto
our own computer so you'll need to have
git installed onto your computer you can
install it on any Mac or PC or Linux
machine and once you do what you're
going to do is on your computer in the
terminal you'll run git clone followed
by the URL of the git repository that
you're trying to download so you might
imagine that here's your computer over
here and up here is some server where a
git repository is located GitHub for
example is one such server but there are
others as well and up there is the
repository that potentially has files or
maybe other folders with other files
that contain the contents of the
repository that you care about
downloading
so if I run git clone followed by the
URL the repository I want the effect of
that is that the repository and all of
its contents get downloaded onto my
computer such that I on my computer now
have a copy of everything that was
originally inside of that git Repository
so now now that we know how to clone a
repository let's actually try it we've
just created a repository using GitHub
and now let me go into my terminal and
actually try to clone this repository so
that I have a copy of it on my computer
and I can begin to make some changes to
it
so I'll go into my terminal now and I'll
go into my lecture one directory and the
first thing that I'm going to need is
I'm going to need the URL of the git
repository so if I go back into GitHub
what you'll notice is that it gives me
an https Link in order to download my
git repository so there are a couple of
different ways that I can use to clone
my repository of ways to authenticate
myself one is using https which will
eventually involve like a username and
password that I'll have to type in in
order to prove to get that these are my
GitHub credentials alternatively
familiar with SSH this is another method
of authentication you can give GitHub
your public SSH key in order to
authenticate as well but no need to
worry about that if you're not as
familiar with that technology and the
key here is that this URL is the GitHub
URL that corresponds to my repository so
I'm going to copy that URL
and then inside of my terminal I'll type
git clone and then I'll just paste in
the URL that I would like to clone that
contains that repository I'll go ahead
and press return it says I'm cloning
into a directory called hello and then
it's saying you appear to have cloned an
empty repository it's saying that's a
warning but that's okay because I know
that I've cloned an empty repository
because the repository is brand new
and now I can type the command LS in my
terminal the ls command in the terminal
stands for list and effectively what
it's going to do is list all of the
files that are currently inside of this
directory all the files and folders that
are inside of my lecture one directory
where directory is just a fancy name for
folder so I'll type LS and I see that
all right I now have a folder called
hello inside of my lecture one directory
which I didn't have before I'll go ahead
and move into this hello directory in
order to change into a directory or
folder you can use the CD command CD
stands for change directory and so if I
type CD hello I will now move myself
into the hello directory and if I type
LS you'll see that there's nothing
inside of this hello directory right now
because again this repository was empty
I cloned it and there was nothing in it
so now I'd like to actually put
something in this repository the
repository is only useful if I'm keeping
track of my code and keeping track of
the changes that I make to that code so
I'll go ahead and actually try now to
add some code to the repository the
first thing I'll do is create a new file
and we could create a new file just by
opening up a text editor but on the
terminal there's actually a command for
creating a new file called touch so in
the terminal I can type touch hello.html
and what that's going to do is create a
new file called hello.html and if I type
LS I can see that indeed I do have a
file called hello.html now inside of my
hello directory
Let Me Now open up this directory in the
hello.html file inside of a text editor
again I'm using vs code and let me now
add just some text to hello.html on the
status simple HTML page
same thing we've seen before where I
give it a header a title will be hello
and inside the body of the page will be
hello world same HTML page we've seen a
number of times now and now just now
inside of this Repository
of course I haven't yet made any saving
to this repository I haven't said that I
want to save these changes to the
repository and the repository isn't
keeping track of every single character
I write I need to tell git that this is
a state of my current files that I would
like to keep track of something that I
would like to save and in the world of
git we call those save points commits
when I say I am making a commit I mean I
would like to save the current state of
all of the files and folders and other
assets that exist inside of the
repository and basically take a snapshot
of their current position such that
later I might be able to refer back to
that but in order to do that there are
actually a couple of steps
so the first step we need to follow is
an additional command so we saw that git
clone was the command we could use in
order to clone a repository take a
repository and download it onto our own
computer the next command we'll take a
look at is a command called git add and
what git add is going to do is it's
going to let us tell git that I would
like to add a file as one to track the
next time I save the next time I make a
commit to say that I would like to take
a snapshot of all these files such that
I'm able to refer back to them later in
order to do that I need to tell git what
files to keep track of so if for example
I'm keep working on this file and I'd
like to tell git that I'd like to track
it I can run a command like git add
followed by the name of the file like
foo.pi or HTML or whatever file it
happens to be and then git will display
a message saying that all right now we
have added food.pi this is now a file
that will be saved the next time I make
a commit so why are these two separate
steps well one reason you might imagine
is that if I'm working on a lot of
different files say I'm working on 10
different files and there are only three
that I'm happy with three that I want to
save I don't want to just say save and
have everything be saved in a commit I
might want to say that you know what
these are the only three files that I
actually want to save right now and the
other ones I'm still working on so git
gives us that ability to have the
separation to say let me explicitly say
that I want to track this file the next
time I save the next time I make a
commit and not all of the files for
example so there are shortcuts we can
use if we do want to add all of the
files and we'll see those in a moment as
well so let's go ahead and try that
we'll go back to our repository where
I've created this hello.html file and
now what I'd like to do is say that I
would like to add the hello.html file to
my git repository so inside of my
terminal
I'll now say again I have a hello.html
file here I'll say git add
followed by hello.html
and you'll notice that so far nothing
seems to have happened because so far I
haven't yet saved anything I've just
said that I would like to add hello.html
as a file that the next time I say save
the next time I commit my repository it
is going to keep track of the changes I
have now made to hello.html so how do I
actually make a commit how do I actually
say save the state of these files well
that's going to be one more git command
which is known as git commit when I say
git commit I am going to tell my git
repository that I would like to save a
snapshot of the current state of the
repository keeping track of any of the
changes that have been made to files
that I've added using git add and the
way we run it is by running git commit
followed by Dash M and then in quotation
marks a message and this message is
known as a commit message and what it is
is it a description in English or
whatever your language is of what
changes you've made in this most recent
commit because over time as you work on
a big project you're probably going to
make lots of commits as you make lots of
changes to your program you'll commit
and commit again after each new addition
you make to the project and you might
want to refer back to a previous commit
but it's only valuable to do so if you
can identify in which commit you made a
particular change for example so by
providing some English message just some
note to yourself such that later you can
refer back to all your commit messages
and know that all right at this point in
time in this Commit This is the change
that I made that can just make it easier
to keep track of all the changes that
you've made to a particular git
Repository
so when you type git commit followed by
Dash M you might include a message
something like I added a new line for
example and when you do git is going to
save a new snapshot of a version of your
code right now keeping track of the old
version or old versions that used to
exist there inside of the Repository
so let's try and actually make a commit
now and see how that's actually going to
work so we've already added the file as
by running git add to say add the
hello.html file as one to keep track of
but now when we're happy with it and we
could make additional changes to the
file if we want to
I can go back into the terminal and now
say git commit and then Dash m
and then I can specify the commit
message some English description of what
it is that I did in this most recent
commit and what I did was I
um added the
hello.html file so I'm just going to say
I added the hello edited HTML file that
was the change I made in this most
recent commit I'll go ahead and press
return
and here's what it's telling me it's
telling me one file has been changed
with nine insertions so git keeps track
of changes in terms of how many lines
have been added or inserted and how many
lines have been deleted or removed and
in this case it's telling me there have
been nine insertions to one file because
previously the file didn't exist and now
a file that has nine lines does exist
and now I have saved hello.html to this
git Repository
so now you might imagine if I go back to
my git repository on github's website
and refresh it that maybe I'll see that
hello.html file better refresh and all
right nothing happened nothing changed I
don't see my hello.html file and that's
because there's one final step here I'm
missing before my changes are going to
be reflected online recall that when I
ran the get clone step in order to clone
the repository from GitHub GitHub had a
version of the repository and Iran git
clone to download a copy of that
repository onto my own computer and when
I ran git add to add the hello.html file
or I ran git commit to say I would like
to save these changes I was always
making those changes only to my local
version of the repository I was never
affecting anything that was already on
GitHub the changes I was making were
only happening on my own computer if I
want to push those changes up to GitHub
then I'm going to need some additional
commands and in fact we can see what's
currently going on inside of my
repository using a command called git
status and what git status will do is
it'll tell us what's currently happening
inside of my repository so for example
if I were to in this current state run
the command get status then git is going
to report back to me and tell me that I
am currently on Branch Master more on
branches later but then I'm saying my
branch is ahead of origin Master by one
commit so this is a long-winded way of
saying that my local version of the
repository the version of the repository
on my computer is ahead of the origin
version of the repository the version of
the repository that's up on GitHub by
one commit that I have one commit that
the origin GitHub does not have and it's
helpfully telling me I can use the
command git push to publish your local
commits get push is a command that I can
use in order to say I would like to take
my changes and actually push them up to
the server push them up to GitHub so
that they're reflected there so after
we've checked our current status with
Git status we can use the command git
push to say that now whatever changes
that I've made when I run git push those
changes
get pushed up to GitHub so GitHub has
access to all of the commits that I have
now made
so let's try those two commands now get
status to see what's currently going on
inside of my repository and then get
push to say I would like to now push
those changes to GitHub so that the
online version of the repository has the
same contents as the local version on my
own computer
all right so in my terminal now I can
run git status and I see that I'm on
Branch Master same as before and it's a
slightly different message because
there's nothing currently inside the
repository but the key here is that now
I can run the command git push to say
take all of the changes that I have made
to my repository and go ahead and push
them up to GitHub so I'll type git push
and what's going to happen is it's going
to compress all the information and it's
going to push it up to GitHub to this
URL and now if I go back to github's
website github.com my repository and
refresh the page
I'll see that I do actually now see
something different and so this is what
github's user interface actually looks
like it gives me a few pieces of
information it's telling me for example
that there's one commit currently made
to the repository that's the one I just
made that is on one branch so far I've
only created one branch the default one
but we'll see how to create more
branches later and in particular down
below you'll see the files that
currently exist inside of this
repository that right now I have this
hello.html file which is the one that I
pushed and in particular next to it is
the commit message the message from the
most recent time that I touched this
file which is in particular telling me
that I added the hello.html file in the
most recent commit that affected
hello.html
and if it were not I didn't out a click
on hello.html to actually see what's
inside of it I would see
the same content that I wrote in that
file before I see doctype HTML and then
the hello world page that we've seen a
couple of times now so I made the change
on my own computer and I've now pushed
them up to GitHub so they're now inside
of this repository that's now public
such that anyone else if they wanted to
collaborate on this project could take
this URL clone it to their own computer
and make their own changes locally as
well
and so now we can explore how we might
be able to make additional changes to
this web page as well so if for example
I wanted to add a heading to this
webpage for instance I might at the top
of the body say something like in an H1
tag uh welcome
to my website
and now if I you know just for good
measure open up hello.html see what it
looks like this is what my web page now
looks like
and now I've made changes to my
hello.html file changes that have not
yet been saved and I can tell that if I
run git status git status is your go-to
for telling you what's currently going
on inside of your repository so here we
see changes not staged for commit which
is a fancy way of saying files that have
been changed but I haven't said I would
like to keep track of them in the next
commit it's telling me that I've
modified hello.html but it's not
something that git is currently going to
keep track of the next time I make a
save so if I want to save hello.html
when I commit for the next time then
I'll first need to run gitad
hello.html and then I could run git
commit but there's actually a bit of a
shorthand here if you want to add all of
the files that have been changed and
commit at the same time the shorthand is
git commit Dash am remember before we
just use Dash M to say specify a message
Dash am means git commit all of the
files that have been changed a for all
and also provide a message so you can
combine the get add step and get commit
step into just a single step by saying
I'd like to commit all of the files that
I've changed and then I'll provide a
message what exactly did I change I
added a headache
I'll go ahead and press return it's kept
track of the fact that I've now changed
one file with one insertion all I did
was add one new line to that file
and now if I run git status it's going
to tell me I'm on Branch master and I am
ahead of origin Master origin Master
being the version on GitHub by one
commit that I have this add a heading
commit but right now on GitHub if I
refresh this page
it's still showing the old version of
that page
in order to take my changes that I've
made on my computer and make sure
they're updated on GitHub I can just run
git push to say push those changes up to
GitHub and once that's done I can now
refresh the page on GitHub and I'll now
see that GitHub now has the latest
version of my program as well it now has
this H1 it says welcome to my website
so that's git push now the ability for
me to say I would like to make the take
the changes that I have made to the my
repository and push them up to some
remote server the remote server on
GitHub for example but we can also go in
the opposite way you might imagine that
maybe the version that's up on GitHub is
more recent than the version that I have
on my computer and in that case I would
like to download the latest version of
the repository that currently exists on
GitHub and in order to do that we can
use a command called git pull how does
that work well when I run gitpo what's
going to happen is the opposite of what
get pushed it well git push took my
changes on my computer and pushed them
up to GitHub git pull will say take the
changes that currently exist on GitHub
and go ahead and pull the most recent
changes down so that I and my local
version of the repository have access to
the latest version of all of the code
that is currently on GitHub
and we can demonstrate this for example
if I go back and take a look at github's
website itself because on GitHub I
actually have the ability to edit files
using github's interface
so I'm going to simulate like someone
else working on this project for example
maybe someone else added a second
heading so they add an H2 that says
hello for example
and then they can provide a commit
message this is sort of a graphical
equivalent to the dash M and then a
message that we provided before they can
say added H2
and then commit
so this is another way to edit a git
repository is by literally adding it in
editing it inside of github's interface
so GitHub allows you to just edit a file
and then add or modify any of the lines
there
so now the version on GitHub is actually
different from the version that we have
on our computer that if we look at
hello.html here I only see the H1 and I
don't see the H2 that was just added
because it's a more recent commit that I
don't yet have access to
but if I want to download that commit
then what I can say
is inside my terminal I can say git pull
in order to download it
and all right it's updated one file it's
made some changes and so now if I go
back to the file you'll notice that
automatically I now have the latest
version of the file I now have this H2
that says hello because I've pulled the
latest version of the file down from
GitHub so via a combination of git push
and git pull I can make changes to my
code push them up to GitHub and also get
access to the latest version of code
that already is on GitHub
but as we do this you might imagine that
we could run into some sort of problem
in particular we might run into a
problem if I've been making changes to
my code and some someone else working on
my same project has also been making
changes to the code what happens if we
both make changes to the same part of
the code and then try to sync up our
work together what's going to happen
well we're going to run into some sort
of conflict because I've made changes to
the same line that my colleague has been
making changes to and that type of
conflict is called a merge conflict that
when trying to merge my changes with the
changes that someone else has made we
run into a situation where suddenly git
doesn't know what to do there are two
different sets of changes and we need to
figure out how to resolve them and what
to do when we run into this sort of
conflict
so here's what's going to happen if ever
we run into this sort of merge conflict
it's generally going to happen if I try
and pull in or merge in some changes
from elsewhere so let's say I run git
pull but there's some conflicting commit
something that is online that conflicts
with my current version of the
repository what I'll get is a message
like this some conflict saying merge
conflicts in some file have failed you
need to fix the conflicts and then
commit the results
so what might those conflicts look like
well generally the file is going to look
a little something like this git is
automatically going to add some metadata
to the file to describe the things that
it can't quite figure out and it's a lot
of cryptic looking information but we
can distill it down into a couple of Key
Parts
everything in between these arrows at
the top and the equal signs here are
your changes the changes I have made on
my version of the repository that are
somehow conflicting with some other
changes
everything between these equal signs and
these arrows down here are the remote
changes the changes from GitHub that I'm
trying to pull in that somehow are
conflicting with what I've currently
been working on and then this sequence
of numbers and characters here is the
hash of the conflicting commit so every
commit gets a hash just some sequence of
numbers and characters that is likely to
be unique that helps to identify any
particular commit and git will
automatically generate a hash every time
you make a commit and we'll see in a
moment how you can look at all of those
possible commits but here git is just
helpfully telling us this is the commit
that is causing the conflict just for
our own reference in order to address
this merge conflict the way we do it is
we first need to remove all of these
merge conflict markers that exist in the
text file and decide what we want what
we want as the resolution of the
conflict so maybe I want to keep my
version of the changes maybe I want to
keep the remote version of the changes
the changes that were already on GitHub
for example or maybe I want to combine
them in some intelligent way I the
programmer get to make that decision I
get to look at my version and the
conflicting version and decide how I
want to resolve that conflict I'll
remove any of the blank lines and then
commit the changes to say this is what I
want the merged version of this program
to look like
so let's now take a look at an example
of emerge conflict in action to see how
one might arise and how we might
actually go going about dealing with a
merge conflict should it happen
so I on my computer now
I'm going to make a change to this page
I'm going to say add a second
exclamation point one exclamation point
wasn't enough I'll add in a second
exclamation point to this H1 and I'll go
ahead and commit those changes I'll say
git commit Dash am ADD
exclamation point
and I'll go ahead and commit those
changes I saved this new version of the
program but I'm not going to push the
code yet instead what I'm going to do is
simulating someone else working on the
same file maybe someone else on GitHub
has decided you know what
for this H1 what we'd really like to do
is add some style to it with some inline
Style by saying let's give it a color of
blue for example
so they've added some CSS
we'll go ahead and write a commit
message what did they do they added some
style and we'll commit those changes
and now what we've created is what is
going to be a merge conflict that
someone else on GitHub has made a change
to this line changing the color to Blue
of this particular H1 tag for example
and I meanwhile have also made a change
the same line adding an exclamation
point and git entirely operates in terms
of like adding lines and removing lines
given that we both made changes to the
same line git is going to have a very
hard time figuring out what to do in
this scenario
so here in my terminal I'll go ahead and
run git pull because I want to pull in
those latest changes and when I do I'll
see that all right I get this message
conflict there was a merge conflict in
hello.html the automatic merge failed
because normally git will try to merge
files automatically if it can but
sometimes it can't so now
I need to fix the conflicts and then
commit the results
so let's go ahead and look at what's
inside of hello.html and what you'll
notice is a whole bunch of these markers
and my text editor just so happens to
highlight them for me so that I can see
them a little more clearly but this is
just highlighting provided by the text
editor it's not actually part of the
text itself but you'll notice all of
these arrows and then all of these equal
signs and in between here's my version
of this line of code the line of code
with the extra exclamation point at the
end of it
down below here is the remote
conflicting version of the same code the
version that was modified on GitHub that
I am now trying to pull in this is the
version that says we want style color
blue inside of the inline style for this
particular H1 element and now what I
need to do is somehow figure out how to
merge these two together how do I want
to resolve this conflict well in this
particular case I might like to resolve
this conflict by just taking the Best of
Both Worlds if the person on GitHub
wanted to add a style attribute to this
H1 element and I wanted the extra
exclamation point I can do both I can go
ahead
and just add an extra exclamation point
and then get rid of my version
and then also get rid of these commit
markers so go ahead and remove those
I basically modify the file until I'm
satisfied with it until I think that all
right this is the way I wanted to
resolve the conflict one person added
color one person added punctuation the
way to resolve it in this case is just
use both of them but here's where some
human intuition comes in the human
programmer does need to look at this
file and figure out how exactly do we
want to resolve this conflict how do we
want to figure out how to take these
different changes and merge them all
together
but once we're satisfied with it we can
go ahead and commit the results I can
say git commit Dash am fix merge
conflict and all right we fix the merge
conflict and now if I push those results
back up to GitHub
when that is done and I refresh the page
I now see the updated line of code on
GitHub with the H1 that has both the
inline styling and the extra punctuation
because I've resolved the merge conflict
and then I've pushed that information
back up to GitHub as well
there are a couple of other git commands
that are just useful to know about I
mean there are many but we'll talk about
a couple right now the first of which is
git log git log is useful if you ever
need to keep track of all of the changes
that you've made to your code you want
to keep track of all of the commits that
have been made in this particular
repository all you need to do is run the
command git log and git will spit out a
bunch of messages that look like this
describing each of your commits for each
commit it'll tell you what the commit
hash is such that you can reference it
more easily it'll tell you who made the
commit it will tell you the date on
which that commit was made and it will
also tell you the commit message so if
you need to very quickly look back and
see you know on what day was this
feature added or who added this part to
the web page you can just look through
the git log find the commit in question
and then you'll know which commit it
happened to be
also helpful is if you realize that
you've made a change that you didn't
mean to and you want to go back to a
previous commit then in that case you
can use a command called get reset which
has a number of different possible ways
to use it but get reset in effect we'll
take the current state of the repository
and revert it back to an older state of
the repository for example so a couple
of ways you can use it are like this you
can do get reset dash dash hard meaning
hard reset reset everything back to and
then you can plug in a commit hash so
git log as you might recall from before
gave you the commit hashments for each
of the various different commits if I
want to go back to one particular commit
I can say get reset dash dash hard and
then the commit message I want or the
commit hash that I want to go back to
and I'll go back to that commit
alternatively I could say something like
gitreset dash dash hard origin master
and recall that origin Master is the
version of my repository that's
currently on GitHub so if I want to take
my current version of the repository and
reset it back to whatever's on GitHub
then I can use a command like this in
order to do so you run git reset
followed by a commit hash and that will
reset the current state of your
repository back to whatever state it was
in previously and there are a number of
other git commands as well that can be
quite helpful as you begin working with
larger and larger project projects but
these are some of the most helpful and
some of the ones you'll use the most
often are just adding files that you
want to keep track of git commit to say
I would like to make a save I would like
to save the current state of all of
these files push and pull to be able to
upload changes and download changes that
have made to been made to your
repository and then some helpful
commands like reset and log and status
just to give you information about your
repository and get you back to an older
state of the repository if you need to
but as we begin to work on more and more
projects and especially as we begin to
work on more sophisticated projects you
may find that just keeping track of one
change after another isn't nearly as
powerful as you might like it to be and
so we can explore what might happen in a
hypothetical situation where you begin
making some changes till we get
repository for example so let's imagine
you make your first commit you're making
some changes you make some additional
changes and maybe you realize you want
to start working on a new feature to
this web application that you've been
working on so you start working on a new
feature then you continue working on
that new feature but then you realize
suddenly you know what there was a bug
in the original code that I made way
back here and you want to go back and
fix that bug but now we're sort of in a
tricky spot that we want to fix the bug
but we're in the middle of working on a
new feature so what do we do we could go
back to this and try and fix the bug but
then what happens to the new feature the
problem is that this structure just
change after change after change is very
linear it only goes one after another
after another and oftentimes when you're
working on a project it's not going to
operate in a very linear fashion you're
not always working on one thing that
immediately follows the thing before it
you might be fixing multiple bugs while
working on multiple new features and you
want some way of being able to work on
all of those things simultaneously and
to easily be able to switch between them
and so that is where branching comes
into handy branches are git's way of
working on different parts of the
repository at the same time and so you
might imagine a situation unfolding more
along these lines you make your first
commit you start to make changes you
make more changes and when you decide
that you'd like to start working on a
new feature for example
rather than keep making changes in one
after another after another on this same
Branch so to speak I can create a new
Branch I can Branch off and say you know
what let's create a new branch and start
working on a new feature there and then
keep working on that new feature there
and if I realize later on down the road
that you know what there was a bug way
back at this commit then I can go back
to this commit and create a new Branch
where I go ahead and fix that bug and
now I have two different branches Each
of which might have different code on it
one of which I've been fixing a bug one
of which I've been working on a new
feature on for example
generally each of those branches is
going to have a name so the master
branch is your default branch which is
generally going to contain the
up-to-date stable version of your code
and as you're working on newer things
newer additional features you might have
some feature Branch where you're working
on some other feature for example and at
any given time though your focus is only
on one of these two branches and where
your focus is what the current state of
your repository is is designated by
something we call the head
so if head is pointing to master that
means your repository right now is
working on this Branch where you fix the
bug but you can change the head you can
switch what brands you want to look at
and you can check out the feature branch
and say let's look at that branch and
begin working on that as well and you
can begin working on these different
branches by switching where your head is
switching from one branch to another and
then back again and only when you're
satisfied that you know what this bug is
fixed and this feature is in a
satisfactory place then after all of
that we can merge those changes back
together so that everything comes back
onto this unified Master branch that now
has all of the latest code
and that's the real power of git
branching this ability to say that I
would like to be working on multiple
things simultaneously and be working on
a feature without disrupting the master
version of the code
so let's now take a look at an example
of how we might go about doing that
so here in my hello.html file I've been
adding some style to this H1 I added a
color of blue and let's say that I would
like to make some changes I would like
to move the styling outside of inline
styling and I'd instead like to move it
up into the head section on my web page
because we decided earlier that with
slightly better design for a web page
like this
I could make those changes immediately
but I can instead it if I expect I might
be working on multiple changes I could
move on to a different branch and Branch
off into something else in order to work
on these new changes and so here are
some of the key commands to know about
this if I type git branch that will tell
me what branch I'm currently on and what
branches exist in my repository so here
for example I type git branch and I see
that I just have a single branch called
master and the star on the left hand
side tells me that this is the branch
that I am currently on the only branch
that there is
if I want to check out a new Branch I
can type git checkout and if it's a new
Branch I'll type git checkout Dash B
and then the name of the new branch and
I'll call the new Branch style because
I'm going to be making some style
changes to the web page for example
so I typed git checkout Dash b style and
git gives me a message I have switched
to a new branch called Style
and now if I type git Branch again
you'll see that now I have two branches
I have the master branch which is the
branch I was originally on and now I
have the style branch which is this new
branch which I am on now as indicated by
the star on the left hand side
so now that I'm on this new Branch I can
feel free to make any changes that I
want and nothing I do is going to mess
up what is on the master Branch so long
as I stay on this Branch so I can say
all right let's experiment with removing
the style
and let's add a style tag to the top
where I can say that I would like my H1
to have a color of blue for example so
I've made a whole bunch of changes and I
would like to now commit those changes
I'll say git commit move style
properties
that's the change that I've made but
I've only made those changes to the
style Branch again if I run git Branch
you'll see that I'm currently on the
style Branch where I've moved the style
information up here to the top of my
page
but I can switch branches by using git
checkout git checkout allows me to
switch between branches we used git
checkout B to create a new Branch but if
you're switching to a branch that
already exists I can just say git
checkout Master for example to switch my
current Branch from the style Branch to
the master Branch so I run git checkout
Master now I'm on the master branch
and now you'll see if I go back to the
file now I'm back to the inline styling
without the styling up here in the head
section of the page if I check out the
style Branch again then the file
immediately goes back now I have the
style code up here in the style section
of the page and not inline so these
changes have only been made to one part
of the page
so now I'll check out Master again
and maybe I want to make some other
changes on my master Branch maybe I
realize that I want to remove this extra
punctuation you know what two
exclamation points was too many we'll
remove now we just have one
and now I'll commit these changes I'll
say git commit
and remove punctuation
and now I've removed the punctuation
only from the master branch
so this master Branch now has just a
single exclamation point here but it
still does have the inline styling
so now what I'd like to do is merge in
those changes that I made from the other
Branch I'd like to take what I was
working on in the style branch and merge
it into this current version of the
repository on my master branch and in
order to do that the command we'll use
is called git merge so git merge notice
that I'm currently on the master Branch
but if I run git merge and then Style
that is going to take whatever's on the
style branch and attempt to merge it
into my current branch and what we'll
find is we're able to get most of the
way there but there's a merge conflict
now this won't happen all the time when
you merge sometimes git will be smart
enough to know that if one change has
been made to one part of a file and one
change has been made to another part of
a file when you merge those changes back
together git will resolve those merge
conflicts automatically but in this case
that wasn't the case because both my
style branch and my master Branch made
changes to the same line of code and
we'll see why if I go back here
you'll notice that in the merged version
we do see this style tag at the head of
the page no problems no conflict there
because that was just lines that have
been added to this page so there was no
conflict the conflict comes up here
which is where in my version on the
master Branch I remove this punctuation
mark whereas in the version on the style
branch which we can see here by the word
style we removed the inline styling so
we need to resolve these somehow and
what I'll ultimately do
is just get rid of these style markers
or the conflict markers
and say you know what I would like for
the updated version not to have either
not to have the inline styling and not
to have the additional punctuation so I
have now made those changes I have
resolved the merge conflict and now I
can commit
I fixed the merge conflicts
and that's the general workflow now of
how branching in git ultimately works
when you're working on something new
you might Branch off in order to say you
would like to work on a different part
of this web application
you'll make changes make commits add
changes to that new branch and when
you're satisfied with those changes when
they're in the state that you want them
to be you can then say merge them back
in to the original version of the
repository sometimes you'll have to deal
with merge conflicts though certainly
not always and if you're careful about
where you make changes and trying to be
careful not to make modifications to the
same line of code in two different
places you can reduce the likelihood of
actually getting emerge conflict because
git ultimately is quite smart about how
it tries to deal with these sorts of
issues
and finally we'll take a look at a
couple of features of GitHub
specifically that can be quite helpful
if you begin to work on larger projects
that have many different moving pieces
the first of which is forking a GitHub
repository so let's go to a GitHub
repository and look at the GitHub
repository for bootstrap for example so
bootstrap which is the CSS library that
we took a look at
last time is a library that gives us the
easy access to a whole bunch of
different CSS features and the entire
thing is open source meaning all of the
code for bootstrap is publicly available
for anyone to look at and more
importantly for anyone to contribute to
that it's not just one person that's
been working on all of bootstrap but
it's a Community Driven repository that
many people can be working on adding new
features and making fixes to bootstraps
code and collaborating on them by taking
advantage of the features of git and
so if you find a git repository that you
would like to contribute to or if you
want other people to be able to
contribute to your repository one thing
you can do is Fork that repository and
by forking we mean making your own copy
of the original repository and so up
here in the upper right hand corner of
github's page is a button called fork
and we can see that right now about 68
000 people have already forked
bootstraps repository made a copy of the
repository into their own GitHub account
and so we could Fork it ourselves just
by clicking on this button called Fork
and then getting our own version of the
repository that we can then clone and
push and pull from as well the reason we
might do that is that bootstraps
repository while it is public doesn't
allow anyone to just push to it that
would be probably unsafe if anyone in
the world could just update bootstrap's
master code but what you can do is copy
the code make a fork of it make changes
to it on your own push and pull to it
and then when you feel like you've made
a contribution that you would like to
send back to bootstrap you can open
What's called a pull request that you
are requesting that your code be pulled
in to bootstraps code and we can look
for example at bootstrap's pull request
tab
it looks like right now there are 71
open pull requests there are 71 people
that have made some fixes or made some
changes to bootstraps code and you can
submit a pull request to say that you
would like to take those changes and
merge them back in with bootstrap's
actual code and the people that maintain
bootstraps code in this particular
repository can review those pull
requests provide feedback ask for
additional changes and then when
everyone's satisfied they can merge
those changes into bootstrap's actual
code and this is one of the key benefits
of Open Source software the ability for
multiple people to be working on the
same piece of code and for a community
to be able to collaborate on finding
bugs on figuring out what changes to
make on figuring out how to improve upon
an existing repository and make it
better moving forward
and one final thing worth noting about
GitHub is an additional feature known as
GitHub Pages GitHub pages is a free way
that GitHub provides to be able to
quickly take a website with HTML and CSS
and maybe even a little bit of
JavaScript and deploy it to the internet
for anyone to look at and anyone with a
GitHub account is allowed to create a
GitHub Pages website for free and in
order to do so we can demonstrate it now
all you need to do
in GitHub is let's create a new
Repository
that we'll call it should generally be
your
username.github dot IO is the
conventional name for your GitHub Pages
site though it can have other names
you'll just have to manually turn on
GitHub pages
and we'll go ahead and create this
repository now if you create a GitHub
repository called your
username.github.io it will automatically
be supporting GitHub pages and what that
means is that I can take
this URL and I can clone it so I can say
git clone
followed by this URL
I've cloned an empty repository but I
can go into this Repository
and add some files to it I can say let's
add
by default it's called an index.html
file
and I'll create an HTML file
that is my site and the body of it will
just say
this is my GitHub pages
website
so something like this something simple
but it can certainly be more complex if
you want it to be
inside my terminal I will git add this
index.html file and I'll make a commit
and often a first commit you'll just in
the commit message right first commit so
that we know it was the first commit
and then I'll push those changes to
GitHub now
so if you push your changes to a
repository called your
username.github.io
then if you take a look at the settings
and scroll down
you'll see that GitHub pages is by
default uh ready to be published
and now if I click on this URL my
username.github.io you'll see deployed
to the internet such that anyone can go
to this URL and see it they'll see a big
heading that says this is my GitHub
Pages website because this is the way
the browser is rendering the HTML that I
pushed to my GitHub Pages repository and
the advantage of doing this is that it's
very easy now to be able to quickly
update my website all I need to do is if
I make a new change I can commit that
change push that change to GitHub and
when GitHub detects that I've made a
push to my GitHub Pages repository then
it will update my website that anyone in
the world can access by going to
myusername.github.io and this allows you
to leverage all of these features of git
the ability to Branch the ability to
work on different features of your web
page at different times and revert back
to different versions of the code as
well
so all in all git has given us a number
of very powerful tools it's given us the
ability now to be able to very quickly
and very easily keep track of any
changes we make to code keep track of
when a piece of code is updated and to
quickly revert back and look at old
versions of that code if need beam and
in particular it's given us the ability
to take our code and work together with
other people on it such that we can be
working on multiple parts of the same
project and someone else working on the
same project can also be working on
multiple parts of the same project on
different branches and is very easy then
to sync up our changes in order to work
together and so git is a very popular
tool used not only in the world of web
programming but especially whenever
dealing with any kind of larger project
where multiple people might be working
on the same thing simultaneously git
will enable us to more easily develop
our web applications over the course of
this term next time we'll take a look at
python which is one of the first
programming languages that we'll use as
we continue on our journey towards
building more sophisticated web
applications I'll see you then
[Music]
thank you
all right welcome back everyone to web
programming with python and JavaScript
and today we take a look at one of the
two main languages we're going to be
looking at in this course in particular
we're going to be looking at python pi
very powerful language that makes it
very easy to build applications quickly
because there are a lot of features that
are built into the language that just
make it convenient for quick and
productive development so one of the
goals of today is to introduce you to
the Python programming language if you
haven't seen it before and even if you
have seen it before to give you a taste
for what the language has to offer
exploring some of the more advanced
features and some of the techniques we
can use using python to be able to
develop applications all the more
effectively so we begin with our very
first Python program just a program that
says hello world we're going to be
writing it in a text file and the
program just looks like a single line
just like this and if you've used other
programming languages before like C or
Java or other languages this probably
looks pretty familiar syntax wise but
just to break it down we have a function
called print built into the Python
programming language for us and like
many other programming languages
functions in Python take their arguments
inside of parentheses so inside of these
parentheses are the argument or the
input to the print function which in
this case is just the words hello world
followed by an exclamation point
so here's how we can actually take this
program and run it I'm going to go into
my text editor and create a new file
that I'll call
hello.py.py or dot Pi is the
conventional extension for python
programs so I'll create a file called
hello.pi inside of which will just be
the python code that we just saw a
moment ago we'll call the print function
and as an argument or the input to the
print function I'll say hello world
exclamation point
now in order to run this program we're
going to use a program in our terminal
that also just so happens to be called
python
python is what you might call an
interpreted language meaning we're going
to run a program called python which is
an interpreter that is going to read our
DOT Pi file line by line executing each
line and interpreting what it is that it
means in a way that the computer can
actually understand so we'll run python
followed by the name of the program that
we'd like to interpret in this case
hello.pi and when we run this program we
see that the words hello world are
printed to the terminal and that's it
that's the end of the program and that's
the very first program that we've
written using the Python programming
language
so now already we've seen a couple of
features of python the ability to
interpret python there's no need to
compile it into a binary first in order
to run a Python program we've seen
functions and we've also seen strings
just text that we can provide in
quotation marks that we can provide as
input to other functions or manipulate
in other ways and we'll see some
examples of string manipulation a little
bit later
like many other programming languages
python also supports variables and in
order to assign a new value to a
variable the syntax looks a little
something like this if I have a line
like a equals 28 what that's going to
mean is take the value 28 and assign it
store it inside of this variable called
a now unlike other languages like C or
Java which you might be familiar with
where you have to specify the type of
every variable you create I have to say
like int a to mean a is an integer
python doesn't require you to tell you
what the types of each of these
variables actually are so we can just
say a equals 28 and python knows that
because this number is an INT that it's
going to represent the variable a as an
INT and it knows it's able to infer what
the types of any of these values happen
to be so all the values do indeed have
types you just don't explicitly need to
State them so for example this here the
number 28 is of type int it's an integer
a number like 1.5 has a decimal in it
it's a floating Point number so that in
Python is what we might call a float
type any type of text something like the
word hello wrapped in either double
quotation marks or single quotation
marks python supports both is what we
would call the stir type short for
string we also have a type for Boolean
values things that can be either true or
false in Python those are represented
using a capital T true and a capital
false those are of type Bool and also we
have a special type in Python called the
none type which only has one possible
value this capital N none and none as a
value we'll use whenever we want to
represent the lack of a value somewhere
so if we have a function that is not
returning anything it is really
returning none effectively and so you
might imagine that none can be useful if
ever you want a variable to represent
the absence of something for example so
lots of different possible types and
there are more types than just this but
here's a sampling of the possible
variables and types that might exist
inside of this language
so now let's try and actually use a
variable in order to do something a
little bit more interesting inside of
our program and we'll write a program
that's able to take input from the user
in order to say hello to them for
example so I'll create a new file
we'll call it name dot pi
and to start I'd like to prompt the user
for input I'd like to prompt the user to
for example type in their name
so how might we do that well just as
there is a print function that is built
into python that just prints out
whatever the argument happens to be
python also has a built-in function
called input that prompts the user for
input and asks them to just type in some
input so let's provide some input and
ask the user to type in their name for
example
and then we can save the result the
output of that function inside of a
variable and in this case I'll save it
inside of a variable that in this case
also just happens to be called name
now we can run the program I can run the
program by going into my terminal and
typing python name.pi
I'll press return and we'll see the
program prompts me to type in my name I
see Name colon space which is that
string I provided as the argument to the
input function and this now prompts me
to type in my name so I will
and after that nothing seems to happen
so far so now I'd like to do something
with that input I typed in my name I'd
like to say like hello for example to
myself
so I'll go back into this program and
now what I can do is I can say print
hello comma and then I can say plus name
this plus operator in Python does a
number of different things if I have two
numbers it'll add those two numbers
together but with two strings plus can
actually concatenate or combine two
strings together so I can combine hello
comma space with whatever the value of
name happens to be
so now I'll rerun this program
python name dot pi
type in my name
and now we see Hello Brian as the output
of the program
so this is one way that you can
manipulate strings in Python
another way that's quite popular in
later versions of Python 3 is a method
known as using F strings short for
formatted strings and in order to use f
strings in Python it's going to be a
similar but slightly different syntax
instead of just having a string in
double quotation marks we'll put the
letter F before the string
and inside of the string I can now say
hello comma and then if in a formatted
string if I want to plug in the value of
a variable I can do so by specifying it
in curly braces so what I'll say here is
inside of curly braces name
and so what's going on here is I am
telling this formatted string to
substitute right here the value of a
variable so I prompted the user for
input to type in their name we took
their name saved it inside of this
variable called name and now here in
this print statement on line two I'm
printing out a formatted string that is
hello comma and then in curly braces
here I'm saying Plug In the value of the
variable name and so that is going to
have the effect of taking whatever name
was provided as input and printing it
out and this is a slightly more
efficient way of being able to quickly
create strings as by plugging in values
into those strings so now I'll see the
exact same behavior if I run python name
dot pi then prompted to type in my name
something like Brian and then I see the
result hello Brian for example
and so those are a couple of ways that
we can deal with strings manipulating
strings and combining strings using this
technique
so in addition to variables python also
supports all the same other features
that are core to many procedural
programming languages such as conditions
for example so let's take a look at an
example now of seeing whether a number
is positive or negative or zero for
example so I'll create a new file then
I'll call conditions.pi
and inside of conditions.pi I'll first
prompt the user to type in some input
I'll say input
number to mean you know type in a number
and we'll save that input inside of a
variable that I'm just going to call n
and now I can ask questions I can say
something like if n is greater than zero
then print and
is positive
and so what's going on here is I have a
python condition and the way a python
condition works is it begins with this
keyword a keyword like if
followed by a Boolean expression some
expression that's going to evaluate to
true or false or something kind of like
true or false we can be a little bit
loose about that as we may see later and
then a colon means all right here is the
beginning of the body of the if
statement and in Python the way we know
that we're inside the body of an if
statement or inside the body of any
other block of code is via indentation
so in some languages like C or in
languages like HTML which we saw a
couple of lectures ago the indentation
isn't strictly required by the computer
to be able to parse and understand
what's inside the program in Python it's
different the indentation is required
because the indentation is how the
program knows what code is inside of the
if statement and what code is outside of
the if statement
so we have if n is greater than zero
colon and then everything indented
underneath the f is all of the body of
the if statement it is the lines of code
that we'll execute if this condition
this Boolean expression n greater than
zero happens to be true so if n is
greater than zero we'll print out n is
positive
and then we can add an additional
condition I can say something like well
I could say something like else print n
is not positive
but I can be a little bit more specific
than that here is sort of two branches
one if n is greater than zero and one
else case to handle all of the other
possible scenarios but really what I'd
like to do is perform a second check in
other languages this might be called an
else if like if this condition is not
true but this other condition is true
python abbreviates this to just L if
e-l-i-f just short for else if
so I can say l if n is less than zero
then let's go ahead and print out n is
negative
and else
print n is zero
so the idea here now is that if n is
greater than zero we perform some task L
if in other words if it's not greater
than zero then we check to see if it is
less than zero in which case we print
out that n is negative else if neither
of those two conditions are true it's
not positive and it's not negative the
only remaining possibility is that n is
0 so we can print out that n is zero and
so we might like for this program to
work but watch what happens if I now try
and run conditions.pi even though
logically in our heads and looking at it
now it probably seems pretty logical
if I run
pythonconditions.pi and type in a number
I'll type in the number five for example
we'll just see what happens all right
something weird just happened and this
is our very first python exception an
error that happens because something
didn't quite go right inside of our
Python program and over time you'll
begin to learn how to parse this
exception and understand what it means
and where to begin to debug but learning
how to read these exceptions and figure
out how to deal with them is definitely
a very valuable skill on your way to
becoming a python developer and so let's
see if we can figure out what this
exception is saying oftentimes I start
by looking at the bottom I see that
there is a type error that is the type
of the exception that has happened there
are a lot of exceptions that can go
wrong in Python things that we can do
that cause errors in this case it's a
type error which generally means that
there's some mismatch of types that
python expected something to be of one
type but it turned out to be a different
type so let's try and understand what
this might be where it says greater than
sign not supported between instances of
stir short for string and int
so what does that mean well I guess it
means that the greater than symbol that
checks if one thing is greater than
another doesn't work if you're comparing
a string to an integer and that's
probably pretty reasonable it doesn't
really make sense to say a string is
greater than or less than an integer
when we're talking about greater than or
less than usually we're talking about
numbers so they should both be integers
for example so why do we think that
greater than is comparing a string and
an integer well now we can look a little
bit further up at the traceback which
will show which parts of the code are
really causing this problem and in this
case the traceback is pretty short it's
just pointing me to a single line of a
single file it's saying in the file
conditions.pi on line three
here is the line that triggered the
exception if n is greater than zero so
what's the exception here well zero is
obviously an integer because that just
is an integer and so if greater than
thinks that it's comparing a string with
an integer then n somehow must be a
string even though I typed in the number
five it must still think N is a string
so why might that be let's take a look
at the code again and see if we can
figure out what's going on
well it seems that this input function
doesn't care what you type in it's
always going to give you back a string n
somehow is ending up as a string which
is pretty reasonable because the input
function has no idea whether I typed in
a number or whether I typed in a letter
or I typed in other characters
altogether so input doesn't know to give
back its data in the form of an INT or
in the form of a float or in any other
form so by default it's just going to
return a string what characters did the
user type in as their input
so what I'd like to do now in order to
make this program work the way I wanted
to is take this and convert it into an
integer
cast it into an integer so to speak
and the way that I can do that is by
using a function in Python called int
that takes anything and turns it into an
integer so here I can say int and then
as the argument to the int function the
input to the end function I'm just going
to include this whole expression input
number
so I'm going to ask the user to input a
number they type in some text the input
function gives me back a string and that
string is going to serve as the input to
the int function which then gets saved
inside of this variable called n
so now that we know that n is indeed an
integer let's try and run this program
again I'll go back into the terminal run
python conditions.pi I'm asked to type
in a number I type in a number like five
and
all right that still doesn't seem to
have worked and it didn't work because I
didn't save the file so I'll go ahead
and save the file try it again type in a
number and now we see that indeed n is
positive we get no more exception we
were able to run the code successfully
and see that the value of n is positive
and I could try this again to test the
other conditional branches type in
negative one for example to see that n
is negative
and otherwise if it isn't either
positive or negative then we know that n
is zero and so here was our first
exposure to conditions in Python the
ability to have multiple different
branches and do different code depending
on some expression that we're going to
evaluate to either be a true expression
or a false expression
all right so let's take a look at some
of the other features that are going to
be present inside the Python language
and one of the most powerful features of
python are its various different types
of sequences data types that store
values in some sort of sequence or some
collection of values altogether so I'll
go ahead and create a new file that
we'll call sequences.pi
and there are a number of different
types of sequences that all obey similar
properties
um but one of the types of sequences is
a type we've already seen which is just
a string for example so if I have a name
and the name is something like Harry for
instance and this sequence allows me to
access individual elements inside of the
sequence and in order to do so it's much
like an array in other languages if
you've experienced them before
but I can print out name
square bracket zero
this square bracket notation takes a
sequence some ordered sequence of
elements and gets me access to one
particular element inside of that
sequence and so if I have a string like
name and I say name square bracket zero
the effect of that is going to be take
this long sequence and get me the zeroth
element in many programming languages
and in programming more generally we
often start counting things at zero so
the very first item in the sequence is
item zero the second item is item one so
it's easy to get slight off by one
errors there but just know that item
zero of the name should be the first
character in the name and I can see that
for sure if I run python I'll save this
file run python sequences dot pi and
what I get is just the first character
of Harry's name which in this case is
the letter H
if I instead asked to print out
character one which will be the second
character in the name if I rerun the
program now I get the letter A
and this type of indexing works for many
different types of sequences not just a
string which so happens to be a sequence
of characters but other types as well
python for example has a type for lists
of data so if I have a sequence of any
type of data that I want to store I can
store that information inside of a list
in Python so maybe instead of storing
one name I have multiple names that I
want to store so I want to store names
like Harry and Ron and Hermione for
example so now I have three names all
stored in a sequence inside of a python
list
and I can you know I can print out all
of the names for example just to print
out all of the names to see what the
value of the variable names is equal to
and we'll see that when I do that I get
a printout of the contents of that list
Harry Ron Hermione in that particular
order but you could also much as you
could index into a string index into a
list to say get me just the very first
item inside of this names list which in
this case when I run the program
is going to just be hairy so there are a
number of different sequence types you
can use in order to represent data
another one just so happens to be called
a tuple and a tuple is often used if you
have a couple of values that aren't
going to change but you need to store a
pair of values like two values together
or three values together or something
like it you might imagine that if you're
writing a program to deal with graphing
in two dimensions for example you might
want to represent a point as an x value
and a y value and you could create two
variables for it I could say you know
let me just say a coordinate X is going
to be equal to 10.0 and coordinate Y is
equal to 20.0 but now I'm creating two
variables for what's really one unit
that just so happens to have two parts
and so to represent this we can use a
tuple in Python and just say something
like coordinate
equals 10.0 comma 20.0 so whereas in
lists we use square brackets to denote
where the list begins and where the list
ends in a tuple we just use parentheses
to say we're grouping a number of values
together we're grouping one value 10.0
with a second value 20.0 and now we can
pass around these two values as a single
unit just by referencing them using a
single name which in this case is
coordinate so there are a number of
different types of these various
different sequences and some of those
sequences we'll take a look at
are these data structures here so list
for example is a sequence of mutable
values which we took a look at and
mutable just meaning we can change the
elements in the list if I have a list I
can add something to the end of the list
I can delete something from the list I
can modify the values inside the list a
tuple on the other hand is a sequence of
immutable values those values can't
change you can't add another element to
the existing Tuple you'd have to create
a new Tuple in order to do so and there
are other data structures that exist as
well a couple that we'll take a look at
in a moment include sets which are a
collection of unique values so if you're
familiar with sets from the world of
mathematics it's a very similar idea
that whereas a list in a tuple keeps
things in a particular order
a set does not keep things in any
particular order it's just a collection
and in particular all of the values need
to be unique in a list or inner Tuple
you might have the same value appearing
multiple times in a set every value
appears exactly once and there are some
advantages to set some ways that you can
make your programs more efficient by
using sets if you know that you just
need a collection if you don't care
about the order if something is only
going to show up exactly once at most
then you can use a set to potentially
make your programs a little more
efficient and a little more elegantly
designed
and finally one other data structure
that's quite powerful and it's going to
come up a number of times during this
course is a dictionary in Python
shortened to just addict which is the
collection of what we're going to call
key value Pairs and the way I like to
think of this is with an actual physical
dictionary that you might find at a
library that Maps words to their
definitions in a physical dictionary you
open up the dictionary and you look up a
word and you get the definition an
addict in Python is going to be very
similar it's going to be a data
structure where I can look something up
by one keyword or one value and get some
other value as a result we call the
thing that I'm looking up the key and we
call what I get when I do the looking up
the value so we keep pairs of keys and
values in the case of an actual
dictionary in the real world the key is
the word that we want to look up and the
value is its definition but we can use
this more generally in Python any time
we want to map something to some other
value such that we can very easily look
up that value inside of this data
structure
so we'll see examples of dictionaries as
well
so let's now explore the first of these
data structures these lists to explore
what we can do by taking advantage of
the features that are given to us by a
python list for example
so we'll go ahead and create a new
program
that I'll call
lists.pi
and here I'm just going to create a list
of names so names equals Harry Ron
Hermione and Jenny for example
and as I start to write multiple lines
of code especially as my python programs
start getting longer it can be a good
idea to document what it is that I'm
doing so I can say let me add a comment
to this particular line of code just so
I know what it is that I've done in this
line of code and in Python there are a
couple of different ways to create a
comment but the simplest way
is just to use the pound sign or the
hashtag as soon as you include that
everything after that for the remainder
of the line is a comment The Interpreter
is going to ignore that comment if you
can say whatever you want it's more for
you the programmer and for someone who's
reading your program to be able to look
at the program understand what it's
saying and figure out what they need to
do about it so I can just say Define a
list of names for example just to make
it clear to me what it is that I have
done inside of this line of code
so I can print out that list of names as
we've done before
and we'll see that when I print out that
list of names what I get is oh let me
run
list up I what I get is this list Harry
Ron Hermione and Jenny but I could also
print out as we've seen before just the
first of those names say you know print
out just name square bracket zero in
which case I'm going to get just Harry
for example
but now recall that a list is mutable I
can modify the elements that happen to
exist inside of this list so I could say
names dot append
a new name something like Draco for
example and so lists have a number of
built-in methods or functions which are
functions that I can run on an existing
list to access particular elements of
the list or to modify the list in
particular ways and in the case of a
list the append method is a method or
function that I can run that just adds a
value to the end of an existing list so
I've added Draco to the list
and there are a number of other methods
that I can use on lists one of which is
for example sorting a list no need to
write your own sorting algorithm in
order to sort a sequence of objects in
Python there is a built-in sort method
that works on lists where I can just say
names dot sort that will automatically
sort everything in the list and now if I
print out all of those names
go ahead and print them out and get rid
of this old print statement
now we see that we get five names that
are printed out because I had four
elements originally in this list but
then I added a fifth one and notice now
that they are actually in alphabetical
order starting with Draco ending with
Ron because I was able to sort the list
by modifying the order in which those
elements actually show up and so lists
can definitely be quite powerful anytime
you need to store elements in order a
list is definitely a useful tool that
python gives to you
if you don't care about the order of the
elements though and if you know that all
the elements are going to be unique then
you can use a set which is another
python data structure that works in
similar ways the syntax is slightly
different
so let's do an example with those I'll
create a new file call it sets dot pi
and let me first create an empty set
and we can do that by just saying s
equals s is going to be the variable
that will store my set and I'll say set
and then parentheses that will just
create an empty set that just so happens
to have nothing inside of it
now we'll add some elements to the set
so I can say s dot add let's add the
number one to the set let's add the
number two let's add the number three
and let's add the number four
and then we can print out the set to see
what happens to be inside the set right
now
now when I run this program
uh python sets dot pi we see that inside
the set are four values one two three
and four they happen to be in order but
sets are not naturally ordered they're
not going to always keep track of what
the order is going to be but I could add
for example if I add 3 again to the set
now I've added 3 to the set twice I
added one two three four and then three
again
when I print out the contents of the set
it still just contains the elements one
two three four no element ever appears
twice in the set following with the
mathematical definition of a set where
no element ever appears more than once
inside of a set
you can also remove elements from sets
as well so if I wanted to remove the
number two from the set for example I
could say s dot remove two and then
print out s to say print out whatever
happens to be inside of that set now
and now when I rerun this program I only
get one three and four because I removed
two from the set so sets allow you to
add to them remove from them and also
all sequences whether they Be Strings or
lists or sets allow you to get how many
elements are in the set by taking
advantage of a function built into
python called Len so Len will give you
the length of a sequence so the number
of items inside of a list or the number
of characters inside of a string or the
number of elements inside of a set
and so if I wanted to print out how many
elements are in the set I might do
something like this in a formatted
string say the set has
some number of elements
and how do I know how many elements well
again inside of these curly braces I can
include any expression in Python that I
would like to substitute into this
string so how many elements are in the
set I can get that by calculating Len of
s
so what I've done here is I've said with
lenovs I would like to calculate the
length of the set s in other words how
many elements are actually inside of
that set and then using this curly brace
notation I'm saying take that number and
plug it into this string so we can see
the set has some number of elements for
example
so now if I run this program
pythoncepts.pi I see that I get these
three elements that happen to be inside
of the set right now which is one and
then three and then four and then it
tells me that the set has three elements
inside of it which is the number of
elements that are in the set right now
so now we've seen a number of different
language features inside of python we've
seen variables we've seen conditions so
that we can conditionally do things if
something is true if something else is
true and we've seen some of the data
structures that are core to the way
python Works lists and sets and tuples
and other data structures can be helpful
too and now let's take a look at another
feature of the Python programming
language common to many programming
languages the idea of looping if I want
to be able to do something multiple
times
I'll go ahead and create a new file
called Loops dot pi and let's just
create a simple Loop the simplest Loop
we could create in Python is just one
that's going to count a bunch of numbers
so in order to do that what I could say
is something like this
for I in one two three four five
or maybe I want to count zero one two
three four five just to start counting
at zero
print I
and so here is the basic Syntax for a
python Loop and here's what seems to be
going on over here on the very first
line I have a python list as denoted by
those square brackets that contains six
numbers zero one two three four five and
now I have a for Loop for I in this list
and the way python interprets this is to
say go through this list one element at
a time and for each element call that
element I we could have called it
anything but in this case I is just a
conventional choice for a number that
keeps incrementing and we're going to
print out now the value of I for each
iteration of this Loop
so we can try this out now and run
python loops.pi we see one zero one two
three four five great it printed out all
of the numbers from zero to five one at
a time in practice though if we wanted
to count all the way up to five or for
print six numbers for example this is
fine for now but if we wanted to print
like 100 numbers or a thousand numbers
this is going to start to get tedious
so python has a built-in function called
range
where I can say for I in range 6 to
achieve exactly the same thing range six
means get me a range of six numbers so
if we start at zero it's going to go
from zero all the way up to five and
then we can print out each one of the
elements inside of that sequence so if I
rerun python loops.pi we get 0 1 2 3 4
5. so Loops enable us to Loop over any
type of sequence so if the sequence is a
list I can say something like if I have
a list of names like Harry and Ron and
Hermione
and this is my list of names I can have
a loop that says that for each name in
my list of names let's print out that
name for example so we have a list the
list is called names We're looping over
it one element at a time and printing it
out now if I run the program I see three
names printed one on each line and you
can do this for other sequences as well
maybe I have just a single name that is
called Harry
and now I could have a line that says
you know for every character in that
name print the character
if the name is is the sequence is a
sequence of individual characters
because it's a string then when I Loop
over that string I'll be looping over
each individual character in that string
so I can run the program and see one on
each line each of the letters that just
so happens to be inside of Harry's name
so now we've seen conditions we've seen
loops and we've seen a number of
different data structures we've seen
lists and sets as well as tuples the
last important data structure that we're
going to be taking a look at are python
dictionaries which as you'll recall are
some mapping of keys to values if I want
to be able to look something up I can
use a python dictionary just as a data
structure to be able to store these
sorts of values
so I'll create a new file called
dictionarys.pi
and maybe I want to create a dictionary
that is going to keep track of say what
house each of the students at Hogwarts
happen to be in so I might have a
dictionary called houses
and the way we specify a dictionary is
by specifying a key colon of value when
we're defining a dictionary for the
first time so I might say Harry
colon Gryffindor
and then Draco colon
Slytherin for example
and so what this line of code is doing
is it is creating a new dictionary this
dictionary is called houses and inside
this dictionary I have two keys two
things that I can look up I can look up
Harry or I can look up Draco and when I
look up those keys I get the value that
follows their colon so after Harry if I
look up Harry I get Gryffindor if I look
up Draco I get Slytherin for example
so now if I wanted to print out what
house Harry is in I can print out houses
square brackets Harry
so I can here say I would like to print
out take the houses dictionary and the
square bracket notation is how I look
something up inside of a dictionary it's
similar to how we use square brackets to
look up a specific element inside of a
list to say like get me element 0 or
element one
in this case we're using a python
dictionary to say take the houses
dictionary and look up Harry's value
which hopefully should be Gryffindor and
we'll see that if we look up run python
dictionaries.pi we do get Gryffindor as
the value of Harry's house
we can add things to this dictionary as
well using the same syntax in the same
way that I use square brackets to access
the value inside of a dictionary if I
want to change the value in a dictionary
or add something new to it
I could say houses and Hermione and say
that Hermione is also in Gryffindor for
example
and so this line of code here says take
the House's dictionary and look up
Hermione in houses dictionary and when
you do that should be set equal to this
value here Gryffindor so we took that
value and we are going to assign it to
Hermione inside of the dictionary such
that now if we wanted to we could print
out Hermione's house as well
run the program and see that Hermione is
also in Gryffindor so anytime we want to
be able to map some value to some other
value whether we're mapping people to
what house they happen to be in or we're
mapping users to some information about
those users inside of our web
application dictionaries are going to be
very very powerful tools for us to be
able to do that
the next Python language feature we'll
take a look at are functions in Python
that are going to be some way for us to
write our own functions that take an
input and produce some output we've
already seen a number of different
functions that already exist in Python
we've seen the input function that takes
an input from the user we've seen the
print function that takes some text or
some other information and prints it to
the screen but if we want to Define our
own functions we can do so as well
so here I'll go ahead and write a new
program called functions.pi
and let's write a function that takes a
number and squares it so the square of
10 is 10 times 10 or 100 I would like a
function that very easily takes a number
and returns its Square
the way I Define a function in Python is
using the def keyword def short for
Define and here I can say let me Define
a function called Square
and then in parentheses what inputs it
takes in this case Square just takes a
single input then I'm going to call X
but if there were multiple inputs I
could separate them with commas like XYZ
for a function that took three inputs
for example but in this case there's
just a single input X
and the square function could have any
logic in it indented underneath the
square function but ultimately this
function is fairly simple all it's going
to do is return x times x x multiplied
by itself
and now if I want to print out a whole
bunch of squares of numbers I can do so
I can say for I in range let's say 10.
let's print out
that the square of I is
Square I
so let's try and parse out what's going
on here line four says for I in range 10
do some Loop 10 times looping from 0 all
the way up to nine and for each time we
loop we're going to print something out
we're going to print out the square of
plug in the value of I here is plug in
the value of calling our Square function
using I as input
so that is going to have the result of
running this Loop 10 times and printing
out this line 10 different times each
with a different value of I
so I can run pythonfunctions.pi and
here's what I see the square of zero is
zero square of one is one two is four so
on and so forth all the way up to the
square of 9 is 81. so we've now written
a function and been able to use it but
ideally when we write functions we'd
like to not just be able to use them in
the same file but for others to be able
to use them as well
and so how can we do that well in order
to do that you can import functions from
other python modules or files so to
speak so let me create a new file
called squares.pi for example
so that instead of running this Loop
here let's instead run this Loop in
squares dot Pi again separating out
different parts of my code I have one
file that defines the square function
inside of functions.pi and then another
file called squares.pi where I'm
actually calling the square function
now if I try to run python squares.pi
you'll notice I'll run into an error
here's another error you'll see quite
frequently it's a name error another
type of exception which here says the
name square is not defined meaning I'm
trying to use a variable or a function
name or something else that doesn't
actually have a definition I've never
said what square is and that's because
by default python files don't know about
each other if I want to use a function
that was defined inside of another file
I need to import it from that file and I
can do so like so I can say from
functions import Square
functions was the name of this file
functions.pi and I'm saying from that
python module I would like to import the
square function as a function that I
would like to use
now I can run python
squares.pi and we get the output that we
expect no more exception
I've now been able to import something
from another module
and access it this way
so this is one way to import to
literally say from functions import a
square function import a particular name
that is defined inside a functions.pi
another way I could have done this is
just to say import functions just import
that whole module but then I would need
to say instead of just Square I would
need to say
functions.square to mean go inside the
functions module and get the square
function and run that function and this
would operate in exactly the same way
so a couple of different options I
either import the entire module in which
case I use this dot notation to say
access a particular part of that module
or I say from functions and import
Square to just import the name square
into this file entirely so that I can
just use the word square whenever I want
to and this works not just for modules
that we have written but also python
comes with a number of built-in modules
if you want to write programs that
interact with CSV files which are a
spreadsheet file format I can import
Python's built-in CSV module to get
access to a whole bunch of CSV related
features there are a whole bunch of math
related features you can get by
importing the math module so on and so
forth and there are additional python
modules and packages that you can
install that other people have written
and then you just import them when the
time comes and next time as we take a
look at Django this is one of the
techniques that we're going to be
looking at is using functions that have
been written by people that are not
ourselves
so that now is modules and how we can
use modules to be able to import
functions in order to allow for certain
behavior and this is one way that we can
program using the Python programming
language but another key technique that
python supports that are supported by a
number of other programming languages as
well is an idea of object-oriented
programming a special type of
programming or a programming Paradigm so
to speak which is a way of thinking
about the way that we write programs and
an object oriented programming we think
about the world in terms of objects
where objects might store information
store some data inside of them and also
support the ability to perform types of
operations some sort of actions or
methods or functions as we might call
them that can operate on those objects
so now we're going to take a look at
some of the object-oriented capacities
that the Python programming language is
going to give us the ability to have so
python comes with a number of built-in
types it has types for lists such as
types for sets and so on and so forth
let's imagine though that we want to
create a new type in Python some way of
representing other types of data for
example
two-dimensional points things we've
talked about before something that has
an x value and a y value now as we've
already discussed you could do this
using a tuple just using one number
comma another number but we could create
an entire class of objects to be able to
represent this data structure as well
and so that's what we'll take a look at
now is how to create a class in Python
so I'll create a new file called classes
dot pi
and all a class is is you can think of a
class as a template for a type of object
we are going to define a new class
called point and then after we've
defined what a point is we will be able
to create other points we'll be able to
create points to store X and Y values
for example
and so what do we need in order to
create a class
well we need some way to say that when I
create a point what should happen and in
Python this is defined using a what's
called a magic method called underscore
underscore init and underscore
underscore init is a method or function
that is going to automatically be called
every time that I try to create a new
point
and this function takes a couple of
arguments
all functions that operate on objects
themselves otherwise known as methods
are going to take the first argument
called self and this argument self
represents the object in question and
this is going to be important because we
don't just want a single variable called
X to store the points x coordinate or a
single variable called y to store the y
coordinate because two different points
might have different X and different y
values and we want to be able to store
those separately and we're going to
store them inside of the object itself
so this variable self references the
object that we are currently dealing
with and it might change depending on
which point we happen to be interacting
with at any given time
what other inputs does a point need well
a point also needs an x value and a y
value so when we create a point we're
going to provide to that point in x
value and a y value
now what do we need to do in order to
store all this data inside of the point
well recalled itself is representing the
point itself and so if we want to store
data inside of that point allow the
point to store its own X and Y values
then we just we need to store that data
inside of the self so to speak and in
order to do that we can use this dot
notation to say self dot X is equal to
whatever this input X happens to be and
self dot Y is equal to whatever this
argument y happens to be and these
values X and Y they could be called
anything they could just be called like
input 1 and input 2 for example and then
you would just reflect them here the
important thing is that these two input
values are being stored inside of the
point itself in properties that we're
going to call X and Y
all right so that was a little bit
abstract but now let's see how we could
actually use this if I want to create a
new Point called P I can say p equals
point
and then the self-argument is going to
be provided automatically I don't need
to worry about that but I do need to
provide input 1 and input 2 the x value
and the Y value so I'll go ahead and
provide an x value of 2 and a y value of
8 for example so now I've created this
point and now that I have a point I can
print out information about the point I
can print out the x value of the point
and I can print out the Y value of the
point again I'm using this dot notation
to say go into the point and access data
that is stored inside of that point
access its x value and excess its y
value
so now when I run this program
pythonclasses.pi what I get is 2 on the
first line that is the x value and then
8 on the SEC or eight on the second line
that is the Y value
so what we have here is a function
called init that creates a point by
storing the two inputs inside of the
object inside of a property called X and
a property called y such that later I
can create a point which calls this init
function implicitly and after we've
created the point I can access the data
inside of it I can say print out
whatever P dot X is equal to print out
whatever P dot Y is equal to as well
so that was a fairly simple example of
creating a class just creating a class
for representing a point in X and A Y
value let's look at a more interesting
example let's imagine that we're trying
to write a program for an airline where
the airline needs to keep track of
booking passengers on a flight and
making sure that no flight gets
overbooked we don't want more passengers
on the flight then there is capacity on
that flight
so let's define a new class that we're
going to call flight and this time the
init method is just going to take a
single argument other than the self
which is the capacity every flight needs
some sort of capacity to know how many
people can fit on the plane and so I'll
store that inside of a value called
self.capacity Equals capacity
and what other information do we need to
soar about a flight well a flight has a
capacity and it also has all of the
passengers on the flight and so we could
represent this in a number of ways but
we know that lists can be used in order
to store a sequence of values so we'll
go ahead and just create a list that
will store in self.passengers
that is going to be equal to the empty
list so we start out with an empty list
of passengers
so now if I want to create a flight I
can say flight equals and then capital F
flight that's the name of the class and
then provide a capacity I can say
capacity of three to mean three people
can go in this flight but no more than
three that is the capacity because that
is the argument that's specified inside
of this init function and when I do so
I'm automatically going to get this
empty list of passengers
so now let's think about what methods or
what functions we might care about
performing when it comes to a flight
so one reasonable function to add would
be a function that says all right let's
add a passenger to the flight if I want
someone new to go on this slide
so how might I go about doing that
well let's define a new method also
known as a function to this flight class
called add passenger this method can be
called whatever we want
because this is a method that's going to
work on an individual object we need
some way of referencing that object
itself so we'll use the keyword self
again
and when we add a passenger we need to
add a passenger by their name so I need
to specify
their name as well
such that now here I want to add that
name to the passengers list
how do I get access to the passengers
list will I have access to the self the
object itself and I stored the
passengers inside of Self in self dot
passenger in attribute of this object
and self.passengers is a list that
initially starts out as an empty list
but if I want to add something to the
end of a list we've already seen that in
order to do that I can say
self.passengers dot append
name
so that adds that someone new to the end
of this passengers list
now what could potentially go wrong here
well every time we call this add
passenger function what's going to
happen is we are going to append to the
end of this passengers list this name
but we haven't taken into consideration
the capacity of the flight ideally our
ad passengers function shouldn't let
someone be added to a flight if the
flight is already at capacity
so there are a number of things we could
do here we could just check it inside of
this function but just for good measure
let's create a new function
let's add a new function called
open seats that is going to return the
number of open seats that are on the
plane
other than self there are no other
inputs that we need to calculate how
many open seats there are the only thing
we need to know in order to calculate
open seats is we need to know the
capacity
minus
however many passengers there are
remember self.passengers is our list of
all the passengers and anytime we have a
sequence to get the length of that
sequence I can say Len or length of that
sequence to say get me the number of
passengers that there are
so now we have this function called open
seats which will return capacity minus
the number of passengers and tell us how
many open seats there are
and now in this add passenger function I
can add some additional logic I can say
if
not
self dot open seats
so this is equivalent to me saying in
this case like if self dot open seats
equals equals zero meaning there are no
open seats a more pythonic way so to
speak of expressing this idea is just
saying if not self dot open seats in
other words if there aren't any more
open seats then what should we do we
should return and maybe you might
imagine this ad passenger function
returns true if it was able to
successfully add a passenger and false
otherwise so in this case I can return
false to say you know what there aren't
enough open seats let me return false
from this function to indicate that
there was some sort of error
but otherwise if there are open seats we
can add the passenger and return true to
mean that everything was okay we were
able to add the passenger successfully
so now we have these three functions in
it that creates a new flight add
passenger that adds a new passenger to
that flight and open seats which tells
us how many open seats there are and now
let's use those functions to actually
add some passengers to the Slate let me
get a list of people we'll say Harry
Ron Hermione and Jenny
and now let me Loop over all of those
people for every person in that list of
people
let's try to
flight dot add passenger
person
and we can save the result in a variable
called success for example
and then I can say if success well then
let's print out that we added the person
to flight
successfully
but else otherwise let's print out no
available seats for
that person
so what's going on here we have a list
of people four people and for each of
those people we're going to try and add
the passenger to the flight calling
flight dot add passenger calling this
method passing as input the person's
name and save the result true or false
in this variable called success
if success is true we print out we've
added them successfully otherwise we
print out there are no available seats
for that person
so now we can try running this program
I'll run
pythonclasses.pi and now we see we've
added Harry Ron and Hermione to the
flight successfully but the flight had a
capacity of three which means there are
no available seats for Ginny which we
get as the error message on the fourth
line
and if you're really trying to optimize
you might notice that you don't really
need this variable I could just take
this entire expression
flight.adpassenger person and put it in
the condition itself I can say try and
add a passenger add passenger will
return true or false and if it returns
true that means it was a success and
then I can print out that we've added
the person to the flight successfully
so that is a brief look at object
oriented programming this technique
within Python and other programming
languages to represent objects like this
particular flight and then to manipulate
those objects using methods like the add
passenger method that takes a flight and
adds people to it at least as long as
there is available capacity on that
flight so one of the many powerful
features of python that we'll be
definitely taking a look at later in the
term and using as we go about building
these web applications
now there are a couple of final examples
that are just worth taking a look at
just to give you some exposure to some
of the other features that are available
in Python one thing that will be coming
up soon is the idea of decorators and
just as we can take a value in Python
like a number and modify the value
decorators are away in Python of taking
a function and modifying that function
adding some additional Behavior to that
function so I'll create a new file
called decorators.pi
just to demonstrate what we can do with
decorators and the idea of a decorator
is a decorator is going to be a function
that takes a function of input and
returns a modified version of that
function as output so unlike other
programming languages where functions
just exist on their own and they can't
be passed in as input or output to other
functions in Python a function is just a
value like any other you can pass it as
input to another function you can get it
as the output of another function and
this is known as a functional
programming Paradigm where functions are
themselves values
so let's create a function that modifies
another function by announcing that the
function is about to run and that the
function has completed running just to
demonstrate so this announce function
will take us input a function f and it's
going to return a new function and
usually this function wraps up this
function f with some additional behavior
and for that the reason it's often
called a wrapper function so we may call
this wrapper
to say that all right what is my wrapper
function going to do it's first going to
print
about to run the function just to
announce that we're about to run the
function that's what I want my announced
decorator to do
then let's actually run the function f
and then let's print done with the
function
so what my announce decorator is doing
is it's taking the function f and it's
creating a new function that just
announces via a print statement before
and after the function is done running
and then at the end we'll return this
new function which is the wrapper
function
so this right here is what we might call
a decorator a function that takes a
function modifies it by adding some
additional capabilities to it and then
gives us back some output
and so now here I can define a function
called hello that just prints hello
world for example
and then to add a decorator I use the
add symbol I can say at announce to say
add the announced decorator to this
function
and then I'll just run the function
hello and we'll see what happens
I'll run Python
decorators.pi and I see about to run the
function then hello world then done with
the function so again why did that work
it's because our hello function that
just printed hello world is wrapped
inside of this announced decorator where
what the announce decorator does is it
takes our hello function of input and
gets us a new function that first prints
an alert warning that we're about to run
the function actually runs the function
and then prints another message so a bit
of a simple example here but there's a
lot of power in decorators for being
able to very quickly take a function and
add capability to it you might imagine
in a web application if you only want
certain functions to be able to run if a
user is logged in you can imagine
writing a decorator that checks to make
sure that a user is logged in and then
just using that decorator on all of the
functions that you want to make sure
only work when a user so happens to be
logged in so decorators are a very
powerful tool that web application
Frameworks like Django can make use of
just to make the web application
development process a little bit easier
as well
let's take a look at a couple other
techniques that exist within python one
is how we might be able to more
efficiently represent functions so let's
imagine that I now have I'm going to
call this lambda.pi for a reason you'll
see in a moment
let's imagine that I have a list of
names or people for example and inside
of this list of people each person
instead of being just a string is going
to be a dictionary that has both a name
like Harry and a house like Gryffindor
and let me add another name like Cho and
a house like Ravenclaw
and then
another name like Draco and a house
like Slytherin
so here we have a list where each of the
elements inside of that list is a
dictionary a mapping of keys and values
and that's totally okay in Python we
have the ability to Nest data structures
within one another we can have lists
inside of other lists or lists inside of
dictionaries or in this case
dictionaries inside of a list and in
fact this nesting of data structures is
one of the reasons why it's very easy in
Python to be able to represent
structured data like a list of people
where every person has various different
properties
what I might like to do now is something
like sort all of these people and then
print them all out so I might want to
say people.sort
and then print all the people
but if I try to run this I'll get an
exception
I get an exception
type error less than not supported
between dict and dit which is sort of
weird because I'm not using any less
than symbol at all
anywhere in my program but in the
traceback you'll see that the line of
code that it's catching on is
people.sort somehow people.sort is
causing a type error because it's trying
to use less than to compare two
dictionaries
and what this appears to mean is that
python doesn't know how to sort these
dictionaries it doesn't know does Harry
belong before or after Cho because it
doesn't know how to compare these two
elements and so if I want to do
something like this then I need to tell
the sort function how to sort these
people
and so in order to do that one way I
could do this is by defining a function
that tells the sort function how to do
the Sorting what to look at when sorting
so if I want to sort by people's name
let me Define a function then I'll just
call F that takes a person as input and
returns that person's name by looking up
the name field inside of that dictionary
and now I can sort people by their name
by saying sort key equals f
what this means is sort all the people
and the way to sort them the way you
know how to compare them is by running
this function where this function takes
a person and gives us back their name
and this will sort Everyone by name now
if I run pythonlab.pi
you'll see that I first get show then
Draco then Harry in alphabetical order
by name whereas if instead I had tried
to sort people by their house
by changing my function that I'm using
to sort
and then rerun this now I see that it's
first Harry who's in Gryffindor then
Ravenclaw then Slytherin for example so
we get the houses in alphabetical order
instead
but the reason I show this is because
this function is so simple and is only
used in one place python actually gives
us an easier way to represent a very
short one-line function using something
called a Lambda expression and this is a
way of including the function just as a
single value on a single line I can say
instead of defining a function called f
i can get rid of all of this and just
say sort by this key a Lambda which is a
function that takes a person and Returns
the person's name
so we say person is the input colon
person name as the output this is a
condensed way of saying the same thing
we saw a moment ago of defining a
function giving it a name and then
passing in the name here this right here
is a complete function that takes a
person and as input and returns their
name so python lambda.pi that will
actually sort the people by their name
Cho then Draco then Harry whereas if I
have left off this key altogether
and then tried to sort well then we get
this type error because we can't compare
these two dictionaries
so we've seen a lot of different
exceptions now throughout python so the
very last example we'll take a look at
is an example of how to deal with these
exceptions like what to do when things
might go wrong if we want our program to
be able to handle those possible
exceptional cases situations where
things might in fact go wrong
so let's try an example I'll create a
new file that I'm going to call
exceptions.pi
and what exceptions that Pi is going to
do is it's going to get some input it's
going to say let's get an integer input
called X
and let's get an integer input called y
and then let's go ahead and print out
the result of x divided by y so result
equals x divided by Y and then let's
print out
something like x divided by y equals
result and we can literally print out
the values of X and Y
so this is a simple program that's just
performing some division get a value of
x get a value of y divide the two and
print out the result
we can try running this by running
python exceptions.pi if I type in like 5
and then 10 5 divided by 10 is 0.5
exactly what might I might expect
but what could go wrong now if you
remember from math in division what
could go wrong is if I type in 5 and
then 0 and try and do five divided by
zero what's going to happen well when I
do that I get an exception I get a zero
division error which is an error that
happens whenever you try to divide by
zero what I'd like to happen though in
this case is not for my program to
display kind of a messy error and a
trace back like this but to handle the
exception gracefully so to speak to be
able to
catch when the user does something wrong
and report a nicer looking message
instead
and so how might I go about doing that
well one thing I can do here
is instead of just saying result equals
x over y I can say try to do this
try to set result equal to x divided by
Y and then say except if a zero division
error happens
then let's do something else let's print
error
cannot divide by zero and then exit the
program
how do you exit the program it turns out
there's a module in Python called sys
and if I import the sys module
I can say CIS dot exit one to mean exit
the program with a status code of one
where a status code of one generally
means something went wrong in this
program
so now I'm trying to divide x divided by
y except I have an exception Handler
this is a try accept expression I'm
saying try to do this except if this
exception happens rather than have the
program crash just print out this error
message can't divide by zero and then
exit the program
so now let's try it python exceptions.pi
again 5 and 10 Works totally normally
gets me a value of 0.5 but now if I try
5 and 0 press return I get an error
cannot divide by zero no long exception
that's going to look complicated to the
user it's no longer messy I've been able
to handle the exception gracefully
now one other exception that might come
up is what if instead of X is 5 I type
in a word like hello something that's
not a number now I get another type of
exception a value error which is
happening when I try and convert
something to an INT because hello cannot
be converted into a base 10 integer you
can't take text that is not a number and
turn it into an integer so instead I'm
getting this value error here
how can I deal with that well I can deal
with it in much the same way when I'm
getting this input X and Y I can say
rather than just get the input just try
to get the input
except if a value error happens which is
the error that we got a moment ago this
value error
then print error invalid input
and go ahead and sys.exit one
so now I've been able to handle that
error as well I can say
pythonexceptions.pi I can say hello and
I just get error invalid input I can
divide by zero I get error cannot divide
by zero but if I do type a valid X and A
Y value then I get the result of
dividing one number by the other and so
exception handling is often a helpful
tool for if you expect that some lines
of code you might be running might run
into some sort of problem be they a
value error or a zero division error or
some other error altogether to be able
to handle those errors gracefully and
that's probably what you want if you're
going about building a web application
using python is the ability to say that
if something goes wrong we want to
handle the error nicely display a nice
error message to the user telling them
what was wrong instead of having the
program entirely crash so those are some
of the key features now this Python
programming language this language that
gives us the ability to Define these
functions and loops and conditions in
very convenient ways to create classes
where we can begin to build objects that
are able to perform various different
types of tasks and next time time using
python we'll be able to design web
applications such that users are able to
make requests to our web applications
and get some sort of response back so we
will see you next time
[Music]
okay welcome back everyone to web
programming with python and JavaScript
so thus far in the course we've taken a
look at a couple of different
Technologies we took a look at HTML and
CSS which are languages we can use to
describe the structure of a web page and
then style it appropriately and then we
also took a look at python a programming
language that we could use to get
programming features features like loops
and conditions and variables and
functions and more and what we're going
to do today is introduce Django which is
going to combine these two Django is a
python web framework which is going to
allow us to write python code that is
able to dynamically generate HTML and
CSS ultimately allowing us to build a
dynamic web application so what is this
now going to enable us to do that we
weren't able to previously do using just
HTML and CSS well using HTML and CSS the
web pages that we created were static
web pages they were the same and every
time you visited the web page the page
you were looking at was identical But
ultimately if you think about websites
you interact with on a day-to-day basis
say like the New York Times for example
it's not the case that every time you go
to the New York Times homepage you're
seeing the exact same HTML it changes
the next day you might see the new date
you might see the next day's articles
whenever someone comments on an article
you can see those comments and you can
see how many people have commented on an
article for example and it's probably
not the case that someone is sitting
there updating the HTML of the New York
Times website every time something
changes but rather more likely there is
some program maybe written in Python
maybe written in some other language
that is dynamically generating that HTML
and CSS and allowing the web application
to respond based on how users are
interacting with it and this is
ultimately what we're going to be trying
to create using this Django web
framework we're going to be creating
software that's going to run on a web
server such that clients running in
their web browser can make requests to
our web server and our server is going
to respond back with some sort of
response and so how does this process
actually happen well ultimately it boils
down to this protocol http otherwise
known as the hypertext transfer protocol
which is the protocol for how messages
are going to be sent back and forth over
the internet in this case you can think
about this as a computer some user which
we might call the client and then our
server which is going to be the server
that is going to contain our web
application we are going to write a
Django web application that is going to
run on this server and clients are going
to make requests to that server the
server is going to process that request
and then return some sort of response
that request might look a little
something like this underneath the hood
it might start with the word get get is
just an example of a request method a
way that you might try to get a page so
get just means I would like to get a
particular page in this case the page
I'm trying to get is the slash page just
denoting the root of the website usually
the default page for the website HTTP
1-1 is just the version of HTTP that
we're using and the host is what URL
we're trying to access the web page for
so example.com or some other website for
example that I might be trying to make a
request to
so this request ultimately gets sent by
my web browser when I type in a URL and
press return for example the server
processes that request and then gives
back some sort of response and the
response will generally look a little
something like this beginning with the
HTTP version 1.1 or in some cases 2
version 2 now and then some sort of
Response Code 200 is a response code
that just means okay everything was okay
the page was returned successfully for
example and here on the second line we
see content type text HTML which just
means the format of the data that's
coming back in this response is HTML
data it's HTML data that the user's web
browser on the client should then render
as HTML for example and there are other
content types as well and other
information that comes back in that
response but the key idea is just
thinking about the web in terms of
requests and responses one user makes a
request to get a particular web page and
what they get back is a response like
this that hopefully includes status code
200 which means okay but there are a
number of other status codes well some
of the more popular 200 means okay
you've probably seen 404 the status code
that means not found if you try to
request a web page that doesn't exist
for example others you might see are 301
moved permanently that often happens if
you're redirected from one website to
another for example we'll take a look at
an example of that shortly
403 generally means forbidden you're
trying to access a page you're not
supposed to have access to and 500
usually refers to some sort of internal
server error usually meaning that
whoever was writing the server maybe our
Django web application has something
that's buggy in it and we might need to
go back and figure out where that bug is
in order to fix it and again there are
other status codes as well but these are
some of the most common that we're going
to be seeing and interacting with as we
go about building web applications using
Django so Django is a web framework it's
a set of tools that is already built for
us that's just going to make it easy to
get started by writing python code in
order to design a fully fledged web
application by taking care of some of
the stuff that most web pages all have
to do such that we can focus on the
interesting logic of building our own
web applications so the first step
you'll need to do in order to use Django
is to install it if you're using python
you may be familiar with Pip the python
package manager which makes it easy to
be able to install new packages and the
first thing we'll probably want to do is
install Django and here we're going to
be using python3 so you might need to
specify pip 3 install Django to install
Django on your system and after you do
we can run a command to be able to
create a Django project and that command
looks something like this Django Dash
admin start project followed by the name
of the project that we would like to
create when we run this command Django
is automatically going to create some
starter files for us just to get started
with the process of building a web
application
so let's try creating a project now I'll
go ahead and go into my terminal window
and what I'm going to do is type that
command I'm going to type Django admin
and then start project and then I need
to give this project a name and I'm just
going to give this project a name of
lecture three for example you can name
the project whatever you'd like
and when that happens if I type LS what
I see is that a lecture 3 directory or
folder has been created for me by Django
and if I go ahead and open this up
inside of my text editor
we can take a look at what files are
inside of this lecture 3 directory so
actually I'll go ahead and CD into
lecture three and open it up
and what we see inside of lecture three
are a couple of files that we're given
just to get started so there are a
couple files not all of them are really
interesting to us right now but first
and foremost manage.pi is a file that
Django is going to create for us we'll
generally not need to touch that file
but we're going to use the manage.pi
file to be able to execute commands on
this Django project and we'll see a
couple of examples of that now and a
couple of examples of that in future
lectures as well and then the other
important one that we'll be looking at
is settings.pi which just contains
important configuration settings for our
Django application settings.pi comes
pre-loaded with a couple of default
settings but we might want to change
those settings to be able to add
features to our application as well or
make some modifications to how the
application behaves and then the other
important file that's pre-created for us
now here is urls.pi and you can think of
urls.pi as a sort of table of contents
for our web application that On Any
Given web application on a website there
are a number of different URLs or routes
that you can visit on Google for example
you can visit slash search or slash
images and urls.pi is just going to be a
table of contents of all of the URLs on
my web application that I can ultimately
visit
and so if I'd like to try running this
web application just to see what it
looks like the way to do it in Django is
in the terminal
I'll run python manage.pi followed by a
command and the command is called run
server and so this is generally how
we'll use manage.pi we'll run manage.pi
followed by an argument specifying what
command we would like to run and python
manage.pi run server means go ahead and
actually run this web server
if I do this I'm now running this web
server locally and I see a bunch of
debugging output but the interesting
point to me is that it says down here
starting development server at HTTP
colon slash
127001 colon 8000. and so this is where
my web application is currently running
127001 is an IP address an address on
the internet that just refers to my
local computer the computer I'm looking
at right now so only I can access this
not anyone else on the internet and 8000
is what we would call a port number it
just refers to what type of service is
being run and you might have multiple
different internet services running on
different ports in this case our Django
application is running on Port 8000.
so if I copy this URL and just go ahead
and go into my web browser and paste
that URL in what I see is just jenga's
default page to say our installation of
Django works and this now is the default
page that Django is going to give to us
to say the Django has been loaded for
this web application and we can now
actually start to begin building this
web application by adding the features
we want to it and so what we've created
here is what we call a Django project
and in terms of the way a Django project
is structured is that every Django
project generally consists of one or
more Django applications so one project
may have multiple applications within it
and the reason for this division is if
you think about big websites oftentimes
a big website a big project has multiple
different apps that are sort of separate
services that operate within it Google
for example has Google search but also
Google images and Google news and Google
Maps where you can think of each of
those Individual Services as a separate
app all under one larger project like
Google for example or Amazon's website
for instance might be one big project
that has a couple of different apps
within it one app for shopping maybe and
one application for Amazon's video
servers for example and so Django comes
pre-loaded with this ability to take a
project and divide it into multiple
distinct apps maybe for simpler apps
we're only going to have a project that
has one app inside of it instead of
multiple but it has the ability to allow
us to create these separate apps that
have have different capacities
so if we want to get started with Django
the first thing we'll need to do after
we create a project is create a Django
app and so the way to do that if you go
back to the terminal I'll go ahead and
exit out of this server by pressing Ctrl
C to say I would like to exit stop
running the server so now if I go back
to that URL and refresh it it won't work
because the Jango server is no longer
running
but I'll run the command python
manage.pi start app and then the name of
the app that I would like to create and
for our very first app I'll just call
this app hello for example
so I've now created one Django project
called lecture three and inside of which
I've created the very first app that
I've now called hello
and so if we take a look at our files
now you'll see that in addition to a
lecture 3 directory which existed before
we also now have a Hello directory that
Django created for us that is going to
contain the information needed for the
Hello app to work and there are a number
of files again that are generated by
default we're not going to look at all
of them today we're going to focus
primarily on views.pi we'll see why in a
moment which is going to be the file
that lets us describe what it is the
user sees when they visit a particular
route for example where we can decide
what gets rendered to the user and the
other files we'll take a look at over
the course of this term taking a look at
what additional features Django has to
offer
so we've now created this Hello app that
we would like to install into this
project and in order to install it we
need to go into the settings for this
particular Django project so if I go
into the lecture 3 directory and open up
settings.pi
what I'll see here is a big file all
created for me by Django I didn't write
any of this code but this is all just
the default configuration for a Django
project and if you scroll down somewhere
there you'll see a variable called
installed apps which is where Django
configures what apps are installed on
this project and there are a whole bunch
of individual apps that are installed by
default that are just created by Django
one for example manages sessions which
we'll take a look at a little bit later
but if I want to add my new app that
I've just created called hello to these
installed apps I'll go ahead and just
add to this list of strings this
installed apps variable I'll just add
hello and so now hello is going to be an
installed app on this particular Django
project
so now what I'd like to do is actually
make this app this Hello app do
something and display something when I
try and visit a particular route for
example so how can I go about doing that
well let's go ahead and go into the
hello directory and let's take a look at
views.pi inside of my Hello app
so here's the default file I get for
views.pi I see a comment that's given to
me by default that says create your
views here and you can think of each
view as something the user might want to
see so let's go ahead and just create a
default view and in order to create a
view in Django we're going to define a
function to this function I'll just call
index
this function by convention takes this
argument a request argument and this is
going to be an argument that's going to
represent the HTTP request that the user
made in order to access our web server
so if we want information about that
request we can look inside of this
request object to get access to some
other data and we'll take a look at that
momentarily too
but now what would I like for this
request to do well what I want to do for
now is let's just do something simple
and return an HTTP response of hello
world for example
now HTTP response is a special class
created by Django and so if I want to
use it I'll generally need to import it
and so Django is going to give us a lot
of features that we might want to use in
our web applications but if we want to
use them we generally have to import
them first and it just so happens and I
only know this from Reading Django's
documentation that I can include a line
like this from django.http import HTTP
response to say I would like to import
the ability to give an HTTP response and
now what I have is a function
representing my view this function is
called index and what the index function
does is it just returns an HTTP response
of hello world
and so this is the response but now we
need to tell the app like when should
you actually return this response what
URL is the user going to visit and this
is where we now begin to create some URL
configuration some sort of setting to
tell Django when a particular URL is
visited then this function should be run
in order to return that particular HTTP
response so how to do that well in order
to do that we're going to need to create
a urls.pi file for this particular app
so Django has one urls.pi file that
works for the entire project but
oftentimes We'll have each app contain
its own urls.pi file just for the sake
of separating things out into different
places such that if we have multiple
different apps Each of which is doing
something independent we can have each
of those individual apps have its own
urls.pi file to control what URLs are
available for that particular app
so I'll go ahead and go into the hello
directory and I'll create a new file
inside of the hello directory called
urls.pi
and What urls.pi needs is it needs to
Define a variable called URL patterns
which will be a list of all of the
allowable URLs that can be accessed for
this particular app
and the way you create a URL is by first
importing from django.url's import path
and let's create our first URL I'll say
path and then the first argument here
I'm going to give the empty string to
mean no additional argument and we'll
see what that means in just a moment
meaning nothing at the end of the route
and then the second argument to path is
what view should be rendered when this
URL is visited and so if I want to
render my index view recall that in
views.pi over here I have this index
function then what I want to render when
someone visits this URL the empty URL is
going to be views dot index views is
representative views.pi that file where
I've defined All of My Views an index
just so happens to be the name of the
function that I want to call when
someone visits this URL for example
and then you can optionally provide a
path with a string name to represent
this URL I'm going to give this a name
of index we'll see why this can be
useful later on but the idea is giving a
name to a particular URL pattern makes
it easy to reference it from other parts
of the application so later when we
might want to link to things or have
forms that are submitting to different
parts of the web application giving a
name to a path can be a useful tool in
order to use views last line I need to
add to urls.pi is to say from dot in
other words from the current directory
go ahead and import views
anytime I'm using a variable name like
views I'm using that name I need to
import it from somewhere and it just so
happens that views.pi and urls.pi are
located in the same directory so I can
just say from dot import views to import
all of that into
this particular file
so this now is the urls.pi file for this
application
but the last step in order to get all
this working for the very first time is
to go back into the lecture 3 directory
and open up urls.pi here
this is the urls.pi file for the entire
project for all of the apps that might
be contained within this project and it
just so happens that there's one path
already given to us by default called
admin which runs a default Django
application called the admin application
we'll see more about that in the next
lecture but for now I'd like to add my
own route here to say that I would like
for a particular path to lead to not the
admin app but the Hello app that I have
just now created
so I'll go ahead and give this a path of
hello
and what I'd like to do is say that
after you've included the path hello go
ahead and include all of the URLs from
the urls.pi of my hello application I
basically like to link these two URL
configuration files together and so the
command to do that is include
Hello dot URLs inside of the hello
module get at the URLs URLs file there
and that is now what I would like to add
as a URL pattern and in order to do this
I also need to import include since I'm
using include inside of URL patterns
so that was a lot of steps just to get
things started but just to get a high
level overview of how this is all
working I have a Django project called
lecture three and inside of lecture
three there's a URLs file that decides
what URLs I can access I can access
slash admin which takes me to the admin
application which is created by Django
where you don't have to worry about that
just yet but now I've just added you can
go to slash hello to go to the hello
application and when you do that I'm
telling Django to look at the urls.pi
inside of the hello directory to figure
out what additional URLs I can get to
from there so this is one master urls.pi
file that might connect to multiple
different other URL configurations that
exist as well
then inside of the urls.pi for my app
for the Hello app I've said that when
someone visits just the default route on
this particular application go ahead and
just run the index function that is one
of my views
so all that's to say that now that that
is done I should be able to go back into
my terminal and run python manage.pi run
server to actually start up this web
server
and now I can go back to this URL but
instead of just going to that default
URL I'll go ahead and go to that URL
slash hello
and when I go to slash hello what I see
is hello world so what was happening
there is that I typed in a URL that URL
went to Django and Django looked at that
URL and looked at my urls.pi file and
said you know anytime something starts
with Slash hello that belongs to the
Hello app and inside of our hello
configuration we said that when we go to
the default route we should run the
index function and the index function
returns this hello world response
and now we can begin to change that
response we can begin to adjust what it
is that views.pi is actually doing right
now it says hello world but if I want to
change it to just say like hello for
example I can just edit it now say the
index function just returns an HTTP
response of hello for example
and so now if I refresh this page now it
just says hello so I can edit my files
when I do Django notices that a change
has been made and it will re-update the
server with my latest code such that now
I can visit slash hello and I can see
that an HTTP response of hello is what
ultimately comes back to me
so now let's take a look at the idea
that in addition to just having one view
inside of us.pi I can have as many views
as I want I can create additional
functions that each return different
responses maybe I'd like a route that
says hello to me for example so let me
Define a new function then I'll call
Brian
that accepts the request argument and
this function is just going to return
HTTP response
hello
Brian for example
and now I need to associate this new
view that I've created with the URL so
I'll go ahead and go back to urls.pi
inside of my hello directory and so I
have a default route represented by the
empty string that loads the index
function but I can add to this just add
to this list add a new path
where if I type Brian into the URL
instead that will load the Brian
function and I'll go ahead and give that
a name as well
[Music]
so now if I refresh the page I'm still
on just the slash hello route and that
just displays hello for example but if I
go to slash Brian for example now I see
Hello Brian I have two different URLs
one that is just slash hello with
nothing after it which was that empty
string and one which was Slash hello
with Brian following it that loads a
different view function that returns a
different HTTP response and so we could
imagine continuing to do this I might
want a web application that has a number
of different URLs that I can visit so I
could go ahead and add like a David
function for example
that returns an HTTP response
of hello David
and then again inside of my URL
configuration I would say go ahead and
give me another route call David that
loads the David function
each time I'm giving it a URL so what
comes after the slash hello I'm giving
it a function to run the David function
inside of views.pi and giving it a name
just to make it easier to reference a
little bit later
so now I have slash hello Brian and now
I have slash hello David Each of which
displays a different hdb response so you
can imagine starting to use this feature
to begin to build a web application that
has a number of different routes it has
different routes to do different things
and many web applications are
parameterized by what it is that's
actually in the URL so for example on
Twitter you can go to twitter.com
someone's username to see all of that
user's tweets for example or GitHub a
service we've taken a look at now you
can go to github.com your GitHub
username to be able to see all of the
repositories for a particular user for
example
so if you think about how that might be
implemented if either of these Services
were using Django they might have a
urls.pi file or something like it that
is just defining a whole bunch of URLs
and saying what route should be
associated with them
when someone visits that page
but you can imagine ultimately that this
is probably going to start to get
tedious that if I want to say hello to
anyone if I want to not only support
slash hello Brian and slash David but I
also want to support arbitrary names
like slash Harry or slash Ron or slash
Hermione well then it would seem that I
need to create a whole bunch of
different functions Each of which says
hello to a different person and then
create a whole bunch of different URLs
to be able to do that as well
but it turns out that what I can do is
create URL patterns that have
placeholders in effect things that allow
me to parameterize the path via certain
path converters so to speak so what does
that actually mean
well let's instead of creating functions
that just say hello Brian and hello
David let me create a new function
that's just called greet for example
that also takes a request but takes an
additional parameter takes a parameter
like someone's name for example
and this greet function is going to
return an HTTP response
of hello comma and then I'll go ahead
and plug in the name here and I'll need
to add an F to the beginning of the
string to indicate that it's a formatted
string this is just python syntax to say
that I would like to say hello not just
to anyone but to whatever the value of
the name variable happens to be I'd like
to substitute the name variable into
that greet function
and then what I can do
is inside of urls.pi I'll go ahead and
add another path
but instead of saying a name like Brian
or David or Harry for example here I'm
going to say in angled brackets stir
colon name
and when someone visits that route let's
go to the views.greatfunction and the
name for this route will be greet
and so what's going on here is we have a
fundamentally different kind of path
rather than prescribing exactly what the
URL should look like like nothing after
the end of the route or Brian at the end
of the route or David at the end of the
route this route here on line seven is
saying this route could be any string
that we're going to give a variable name
of name to but you could replace a name
with something else entirely and this
could be any string so it could be Brian
or David or could be any other name and
when that happens we'll call the Greet
function and when that function is
called it will pass in this argument
this name as a parameter to that
function
so now be able to create a custom route
that allows me to specify any string and
figure out how to deal with that
appropriately
so now if I visit slash hello Harry for
example not a route that I explicitly
created but that is a string Harry is a
string I press return it says hello
Harry I can go to slash hello Ron and
say hello Ron and slash Hermione to see
Hello Hermione as well and you know what
maybe just for good measure I'd like to
capitalize this name like Hermione for
example
well the way to do that is that I can
add arbitrary python logic it turns out
that with any python string there is a
function or method on that string called
capitalize that I can say is just dot
capitalize
and if I can do it in Python then Django
allows me to incorporate it into the
response that I'm giving back so I'm now
using python to take the name capitalize
it and use that in the response that
gets sent back to the user so now slash
reminding returns hello Hermione with a
capital H likewise for hello Ron
likewise for hello Harry I've now been
able to add a route
that takes an HTTP request as well as a
parameter that name whatever was in the
URL and return an HTTP response that
just says hello to that person
so these HTTP responses can be any HTML
content right now we're just using text
but you can imagine adding lists or
tables to this as well but you might
imagine that if I have to include an
entire HTML page just inside these
double quotes that that's going to get
unwieldy very quickly very quickly we're
going to find that there's a lot of HTML
to just go in a single string inside of
a Python program and if we think back to
the principles and the ideas that we've
been looking at in this course so far
we've generally tried to separate out
different parts of our application
wherever possible and there's a lot of
value in that one in just keeping things
clean two and making sure that people
are able to collaborate if you want one
person working on the python logic and
one person working on the HTML you'd
rather they not step on each other's
toes as they're working and so what we
can do in Django as well is separate the
response the HTML from the actual python
code here as well and so the way we can
do that is instead of returning an HTTP
response I can instead let's say for
this default route instead of returning
an HTTP responsive hello let me go ahead
and render
and when I render something I need to
pass in the HTTP request but I'll also
pass it pass in the name of a template
and I'll go ahead and call this template
hello slash index.html
so if I don't want to render just a
string but I want to render an entire
HTML file I can call this render
function pass in the request but then
also pass in the name of a template and
now all I need to do is create that
template so let me go ahead and inside
of the hello directory I'll create a new
folder called templates
inside of that template I'll create a
folder called hello because the template
name here is hello slash index.html so I
need to create a folder called hello
inside of which is a file called
index.html I could have just called it
index.html without the hello but the
reason we often want to prefix our
templates with the directory name is to
so-called namespace them to make sure
that if we have multiple different
index.html files in multiple different
apps to make sure they don't conflict
with each other so Django best practice
is to use hello
index.html or whatever your app name is
and inside of that hello directory I'll
then create a file called index.html
and this index.html can contain any HTML
content same as we've seen before so I
could add that doctype the HTML tag a
title of hello and maybe inside the body
I'll have an H1 that says
hello world for example so I can have an
entire HTML page just like this
and now when I visit the default route
of my web application by going back into
my web browser and just going to slash
hello for example now I see that HTML
that I've defined inside of Hell of
index.html it's a big H1 that just says
hello world
and it turns out that these HTML Pages
these templates that I can render using
Django are parameterizable as well right
maybe I want to implement hello Hermione
as some sort of HTML page an HTML page
that says hello comma Hermione and using
HTML out of the box you can't really do
stuff like this HTML is a markup
language not so much a programming
language which means it doesn't by
default have support for things like a
variable to represent someone's name but
using Django's ability to take an HTML
page and treat it like a template that
we can render Django has added its own
templating language so to speak on top
of the existing HTML and I can take
advantage of that to be able to render
an HTML page that actually has a
variable inside of it or a condition
inside of it or a loop inside of it as
we'll see in just a moment as well
so let's go ahead and go back to
views.pi and the function that I would
like to change is this greet function
here that right now is just returning an
HTTP response but I'd like to render an
entire page for example so what might I
render well let's render
a template called hello slash greet dot
HTML
and then this render function can take
an optional third argument which is
called the context
and the context is all of the
information that I would like to provide
to the template all the variables for
example that I want the template to have
access to
and so one thing I might want my
template to have access to for instance
is something like a name
and so this is a python dictionary just
a sequence of key value Pairs and this
name might be associated with what
values of name is the key the value I
want to be name dot capitalize
and so what's going on here is that now
when I render this template this
template hello slash greet.html I'm
providing that template with some
additional context some additional
information as represented by this
dictionary here where I'm providing
information with a key of name I'm
effectively giving this template access
to a variable called name and its value
is whatever name dot capitalize is equal
to where this name here is the argument
to the function greet
so now I can return this template and
inside of greek.html I can use this
variable called name
so how do I go about doing that
well let's first create that greet.html
file so inside of the template hello
directory I already have index.html I'll
go ahead and create a new file called
greet.html
and inside of greek.html I'll go ahead
and write some HTML
and inside the body of the HTML whereas
before I might have said something like
hello comma world
I don't want to say hello to world I
just want to say hello to whoever the
name is whatever is contained inside of
that variable called name
so how might I go about doing that well
what I can do is use these double curly
braces and double curly braces are part
of the Django templating language that
allows me to say I would like to plug in
the value of a variable into this
particular position inside of my
template
and so if I include the word name here
then what I'm saying here is that when
you render this greet.html template
inside the body of the page I would like
for there to be an H1 a big heading that
just says hello comma and then inside
these double curly braces I'm saying
Plug In the value of the variable name
there his name is Hermione it's going to
be hello Hermione if it's Harry it's
going to be hello Harry if it's David
it's going to be hello David
so let's go ahead and give this a try
now
when I go to slash hello Harry for
example I now see a big H1 tag that says
hello Harry if I go to slash hello Ron I
see a big H1 that says hello comma Ron
and the reason why all this is happening
the way we're getting to that final
position is because URLs says that when
I have a URL that just is a string like
someone's name we'll call the Greet
function
the Greet function inside of views.pi
it's taking the name as an argument
rendering the greek.html template and
passing in that name as part of the
context part of what the template has
access to
and inside of greet.html here is the
actual HTML file here is where we then
plug in the value of name
so it's a lot happening across a lot of
different files but the reason for all
these various different files is to help
keep things separate to have one file
that is just responsible for URLs and
directing people to where what should
happen when those URLs are clicked then
we have one file views.pi that is
entirely responsible for deciding on
this particular view what template
should be rendered what information
should be passed in this context and
then I separately have a file for each
of my HTML templates that are saying
what does the page actually look like
and so if you start to begin to think
about the separation of components
inside of a web application it can help
to make the structure of a Django
application a little bit clearer
so we've now been able to use the Django
templating language to put variables
inside of our HTML templates to be able
to create an infinite number of
different routes where I can visit slash
hello some name in order to display
hello to that person's name but the
Django templating language is even more
powerful than just that there are a lot
of additional features that the
templating language is going to give us
access to
and we'll take a look at a couple of
those now and to start I'm going to
introduce you to a website you may be
familiar with I consider it to be one of
the simplest websites on the Internet
it's a real website called is
itchristmas.com and if I visit is it
christmas.com and press return here's
what the website says the website says
no it is not Christmas and you just have
to take my word for it if you visit this
website on Christmas day you go to is
itchristmas.com it will instead say yes
and so this website is very simple you
might imagine that it's really just an
HTML page that probably contains a big
heading that in this case just says the
word no but on Christmas day just says
the word yes now how might a page like
this be implemented well one way you
could imagine is that on Christmas Day
whoever maintains the website goes into
the HTML and changes no to yes and then
afterwards changes the yes back to a no
but we can be a little bit cleverer
about this if we realize now that we
have the ability to use Python logic to
be able to use logic like a condition to
be able to decide how a web page is
ultimately going to be rendered for
instance the condition might be
something simple like if today's date is
Christmas then render yes else render no
and so we're going to use Django and
take a look at some of the features of
Django's templating syntax to be able to
create a website like this we're not
going to create is it Christmas we're
going to create is it New Year's the
checks if the current date is January
1st or not
this is going to be a separate app it's
sort of distinct from our Hello app the
Hello app just says hello to people the
new year app for example is just going
to see whether or not it happens to be
New Year's for example
so I will now go ahead and create a new
app and I can do that by writing python
manage.pi start app and I'll call the
app New Year for example I'd like to
create a new app called New Year
I've now created that new app if I type
LS you'll see that not only do I have a
Hello directory that represents the
Hello app I now have this New Year
directory that represents the fact that
this is a new app called New Year
as with before I'll need to go into
settings.pi inside of my project
directory
and add new year as an installed app
this is now a new app that exists in my
web application
so it too now needs to be a new
installed app what else do we need to do
for new apps well I need to go into
urls.pi for uh lecture three
and just as before I had a path saying
when I go to slash hello then you should
go to all the URLs for the Hello app let
me add a new path that says that if I go
to my application slash New Year
well then you should go to all of the
URLs for the new year file go to new
years.urls representing the urls.pi file
inside of the New Year's app now that
file isn't given to us by default so we
need to create it I need to go into
my new year folder
and create a new file called urls.pi and
inside of that file I'll do from
django.urls import path from dot import
views and then Define some URL patterns
same as before where I'll just have a
single path that loads the index
function inside of views.pi and it has a
name of index
so again just mirroring the type of
structure that we've already seen before
in the Hello app this app is just going
to have a single route the empty route
that loads the index function
now all it's left to do is to actually
create that index function so I go into
views.pi and here now I'll Define an
index function that takes an HTTP
request as an argument and now inside of
this index function I would like to add
some logic that checks whether or not
it's January 1st and so how might I go
about doing that in Python well it turns
out that there is a date time module in
Python you can learn about this just by
reading up about its documentation to
figure out how it works and the date
time module gives me access to things
about the date and time for instance and
I can play around with the date time
module outside of Django just to get a
feel for how it works if I just type
python Into The Interpreter
into my command line rather what I get
is the python interpreter that lets me
just write python code just to
experiment and test and see what the
result of running this python code would
be so I can try like import date time
for example
and let me create a new variable called
now which is
dateetime.date time.now it just so
happens that inside of the date time
module is a function called datetime.now
that gets the current date and time for
example
and so inside of now I have access to
variables like now dot year for an
example which tells me the year
now.month now dot day that gives me
information about the year the month and
the day of the current timestamp based
on getting whatever the current time is
right now
and given that I have this information
you can imagine us constructing a
Boolean condition to check whether or
not today is in fact
the New Year and that condition might
look like now dot month equals one
and now dot day equals one I can press
return and see that okay the result of
this condition is false it is not true
that both the month and the day are true
or are one rather and so using that sort
of condition I can now take that and
adapt it into my Django view that I'm
using to try and render whether or not
it's the new year or not
so how might I go about doing that well
what I'd like for my index function to
do is return render a template the
template will be called New Year slash
index.html
and then what context would I would like
to provide to this template what
information what variables do I want for
this template to have access to well I
wanted to have access to a variable
that'll just be called New Year
[Music]
and in order to access that I need
access to the current date consider do
that I'll at the top of my file I'll go
ahead and import date time
and inside of my index function let me
give myself a variable called now which
is equal to date time.datetime.now
and this New Year variable that I'm
passing in to my template will be equal
to now dot month
equals one and now dot day equals one
so if it is the case that after I get
the current date and time by running
datetime.datetime.now saving the result
inside of this variable called now
if both the month and the day are equal
to one then the value of this New Year
variable is going to be true when the
template gets access to it otherwise as
it is the case today and on most days
the value of that variable is going to
be false
Now All That Remains for us to do is to
actually create this template New Year
slash index.html and have that template
somehow use this new year variable in
some interesting or meaningful way
so how do we do that well if you recall
what we did with the hello application
when we want a template then inside of
our application this new year app will
need a new folder
that we'll call templates
inside of which I'll create a new folder
called New Year
and inside of that I'll create a new
file that will be called index.html
here will be the index.html file for
this new year application
the structure will be very similar I'll
give it a title of is it New Year's
and inside the body now here's where the
interesting logic is sometimes I might
want a big H1 that says yes
other times I might want a big H1 that
says no and what I need to do is
conditionally decide when to say yes and
when to say no
and inside Django's templating language
and again you'd only know this by
reading Django's documentation just as
we used double curly braces to say plug
in the value of a variable here the
Syntax for logic inside of a Django
template like conditions is curly brace
percent sign
so we use curly brace percent sign some
logical statement and then percent sign
curly brace to include any kind of logic
and the logic in this case is an if
statement and this is very python-like
we'll say if
New Year
New Year is the name of that variable
that I passed into this template and if
it is the new year then I want to
display an H1 that just says yes
and then else
also inside of curly braces and percent
signs I want a big H1 that just says no
so if it's the new year then yes else no
and then Django also requires me to give
an end if tag to say this is the end of
the if statement unlike python itself
that uses indentation to denote when the
if statement is beginning and ending in
Django the indentation is optional
inside of the template but in order to
distinguish when the if statement is
happening from when the if statement is
over we need this end if tag at the very
end
so this here is a condition inside of
our Django template we're saying if a
particular variable is true then render
this in the HTML and else render
something else if it's the New Year say
yes it's the new year otherwise say no
it is not the new year
so we can try this out right now we're
on the route hello Ron if I instead not
go to slash hello but go to slash New
Year for example
the site can't be reached okay so why
did that happen
127.001 refused to connect so what must
be happening is for some reason my web
server isn't running and it turns out
that in order to create the new
application I had stopped my web server
and so if ever that happens to start it
up again we can just rerun python
manage.pi run server to say I would like
to now start up this web application
again
and all right it looks like now I have
another error there's some sort of
syntax error and the syntax error is in
New Year slash views of dot Pi so let me
go ahead and go back into views.pi and
see if I can spot where the syntax error
is and all right it looks like render is
a function function arguments need to be
enclosed in parentheses and while I have
a starting parenthesis here I'd
forgotten a closing parenthesis so I'll
go ahead and add that and now that will
complete the render function
and now I should be able to load slash
New Year and indeed what I see is that
no it is not the new year and so what
happened is we ran some python logic
calculated the current date and time
checked to see is the current month one
is the current day one and if that's not
true then we're here displaying no
if we look at the actual HTML of this
page like what HTML is actually making
up this particular page which I can do
by right clicking and control clicking
and just clicking view page Source this
will show me the HTML of this page this
is the HTML that came back from the web
server that my web browser Chrome in
this case is rendering and what you can
see is it looks very similar to the
index.html template we wrote before but
it only contains no it doesn't contain
any of that if logic it doesn't contain
the yes it just contains the HTML
content that we wanted to respond with
back to the user
and so you might imagine based on this
that what Django is really doing is
taking the index.html template and then
manipulating it based on the input we
get based on whether or not it's the new
year or not to say that if it's not the
new year then all we should do inside
the body is display an H1 that says no
and the user when they get it they don't
see the conditions they don't see there
was another branch that could have been
taken they only see the final result of
rendering the template with whatever
variables and logic and conditions
happen to be inside of that rendering
process so when the user sees it all
they see is the word no
and if we were to run this program on
New Year's Day it would indeed say yes
and we can test it just to see what it
would be like if that were the case by
cheating a little bit instead of now dot
month equals one and now to day equals
one let me just go ahead and replace
this condition with new year is equal to
true just to test it let's try passing
in the value true as the value of New
Year and see what happens instead and
now when I run this page now it does say
yes as we might expect it to on New
Year's and so that can be a nice way of
just testing what would happen if you
were to replace a particular variable
with a particular value we can
substitute inside the context just for
development purposes what value we would
like that variable to take on
[Music]
now we've rendered HTML but we haven't
really added any styling to this website
just yet the real is it christmas.com
has the text centered a little bit it's
in Sans serif font instead of having the
little serifs or the glyphs at the edge
of each of the characters so maybe I'd
like to add some custom CSS to this file
as well and we could do this
conventionally the way we've seen it
done before by just including a CSS file
and that is what we're still going to do
but Django has a special build system
for dealing with what are called Static
files files that aren't going to change
the HTML of this page that's not a
static file because it changes depending
on whether it's New Year's or not if I
visited on New Year's it says yes if I
visit it when it's not New Year's it
says no and so this is a dynamic page
but static files files that don't change
like our CSS the CSS doesn't change
whether it's New Year's or not and
because that's files unchanging Django
calls it a static file and it means that
Django can be a little bit cleverer
about it if you start to think about
projects at scale you might store your
static files somewhere separate just in
some place that makes it easy to access
where they're cached for faster reads
later on we'll talk about that a little
more later in the course as we start to
delve into topics like scalability as
you begin to build larger web
applications on the internet but long
story short Django contains a lot of
features that make it easy for us to
deal with static files files that don't
change like CSS files
and generally the way that we'll add
static files is inside of the New Year
folder in addition to having a template
slash New Year slash index.html we'll
also create a new folder called Static
that will contain all of the static
files that we would like to include
inside of this application as well
inside a static I'll create a new folder
called New Year
inside of which is a new file called
styles.css
and so inside of scales.css I can now
write all of the same CSS that I would
want to have written before so maybe I
want all my H1s to have a font family of
sans serif
a font size of 90 pixels maybe and I
want the text alignment to be centered
just a couple of CSS properties and
values same as we've already seen just
to say I would like to give H1 tags this
particular style
now what's left to do inside of
index.html is at the top of our page
I'll go ahead and add a command that
says load static to mean go ahead and
load static files for this particular
HTML page
and now I'll go ahead and Link
a style sheet you'll recall that
this type of command inside the head
section of my web page where I would
like to link some particular URL as a
style sheet is how I add CSS to a page
but what I'm going to include in here is
the link is I'm going to include rather
than hard coding a URL which I could do
Django best practice says that instead
let's just say it's going to be a static
file and the static file is called New
Year styles.css
so I'm not specifying exactly what the
URL is but I'm saying it is a static
file that is inside of a new year folder
called styles.css and Django is going to
figure out what that URL ought to be and
this is often better than hard coding a
specific URL because maybe you might
imagine in larger web applications where
your static files are might change you
might move your static files to a
different domain or to a different route
and so in order to deal with that this
static keyword just means Django will
figure out where your static files are
located and will replace this command
here in the curly braces and percent
signs with the actual URL for this
particular file so now that I've said
that I want to link this particular
static file styles.css into this webpage
what I might first need to do just to
let Django load static files is restart
the server so you might sometimes need
to control C and then go ahead and rerun
python manage.pi run server that will
rerun the server and now if I go back to
the slash New Year route inside my web
browser now I see the style look a
little more close to what I actually
wanted it to be centered sans-serif in a
larger font that here just says no and
if we look at the underlying HTML of
this page we see that Django is actually
for us filled in what the static URL is
for these particular static files and by
default Django just uses slash static
slash and then whatever the files happen
to be
and so anytime we're dealing with static
files files that don't change like CSS
files or JavaScript files we'll take a
look at later in the course that's
generally where they're going to go as
some sort of static file that we're
going to ultimately link to this
particular page
so now we've seen a couple of examples
of web applications we can make using
Django we've seen the Hello app in
Django that can parameterize URLs that
depending on the URL we visit can say
hello to Brian or hello to David or
Harry or Ron or Hermione and we've seen
the ability to using Django add some
conditions to be able to conditionally
say if something is true render this
page if something else is true render
another page let's now use these
features plus some additional features
to begin to build a more sophisticated
web application something like a to-do
list that maybe I want a web application
that gives me a list of tasks that lets
me add new tasks to my to-do list and
lets me view all of the tasks that are
currently on my list and I'd like to
build this up one step at a time
so where can I start with this well this
again is going to be a new app inside of
my lecture 3 project I have two apps so
far a Hello app and a app for the new
year and now what I'd like to do is
create a third app that I'm just going
to call tasks that is going to be my
task management app that's all under
this umbrella lecture 3 project
so I'll go ahead and run python
manage.pi start app tasks to say I'd
like to go ahead and create a new app
called tasks anytime I create a new app
a couple of steps I need to follow
recall that I need to go into
settings.pi
inside of lecture three
to say that in addition to installing
hello and New Year I'd also like to
install the tasks app for example
then I need to go into urls.pi inside of
lecture three to say that in addition to
hello and New Year I'd also like for us
to include the URLs for tasks this URLs
is again the table of contents for my
entire web application where my web
application if I visit slash hello then
we go to the URLs for the Hello app if I
go to slash tasks then I go to the URLs
for the tasks app so on and so forth it
tells me all of the different URLs that
I now have access to
and as with before the URLs file isn't
created for me inside of my application
so I will need to go into the tasks
directory
and inside of the task directory I'll go
ahead and create a new file that I will
call urls.pi and the format of this is
going to be very similar to what we've
already seen from django.urls import
path from dot import views and now I
Define my URL patterns where I would
like a path
that it's just the empty string the
empty path for now that loads the index
function whose name is index for example
[Music]
so now let's actually write this index
function inside of views.pi
what I'd like to do is Define a function
called index that accepts the request
and what I'd like to do is render a page
that displays a list of all of my tasks
so before we get to the idea of adding
tasks let's just see if we can get our
program to display a list of tasks for
example so all up at the top create a
global variable that I'll just call
tasks that the entire application is
going to have access to and I'll add
three tasks to it for now we'll just use
Foo bar and baz this sort of nonsense
names that are just useful strings for
testing purposes just placing those as
sample tasks that I might want to have
inside of my application
and now what I'd like to do is render a
template the template I'd like to render
will be called tasks slash index.html
and then I'll provide some context to it
some information that index.html needs
what information does index.html need
well index.html needs access to
all of my tasks and where are all of my
tasks while they're inside of this
variable that Joseph happens to also be
called tasks and this will be something
we see quite often as a paradigm in
Django where we see a key and a value
that look like they have the same name
the key distinction is whatever is here
on the right after the colon this is the
value the variable takes on this is a
python variable like this python
variable tasks here on the left this key
the string tasks that is the name of the
variable that the HTML template will
have access to when Django is rendering
it so Django has access to this variable
name on the left that has this value on
the right so if you see this Paradigm
that's ultimately what that's going to
mean
and now what I need to do is create this
index.html file and make it use this
tasks variable somehow
how might I go about doing that well I
can go back into my tasks directory
create a new folder for my templates
so I'll create a templates directory
inside of which is a tasks directory
because the template that I'm rendering
again is tasks slash index.html
and inside of tasks I'll create a new
file called index.html
inside of which we'll include some HTML
I'll include just a standard starting
HTML
title will be tasks and now we'll have
the body of the HTML page that I want to
display all the tasks inside of an
unordered list perhaps and if you recall
from HTML to create an unordered list it
looks a little something like this UL
starts the unordered list and each list
item is an Li tag like item one and then
item two and then item
three something like that gives me an
unordered list that has three elements
inside of it
but I don't want to do this now because
I don't want to hard code or exactly
specify what all of the tasks are going
to be what I really want to do is Loop
over this tasks variable here looping
over all of the tasks inside of it and
creating a list item for each one of
those tasks
and just as in before where we could use
if inside of curly braces and percent
signs to use a condition likewise we can
use four to say something like for task
in tasks
I would like to display a list item
and then using these double curly braces
I'm saying Plug In the task here in
between these list item tasks I would
like to plug in whatever the value of
the task variable is
and then I'll go ahead and end the for
Loop there
so what I've done here is rather than
add a condition into a template which
we've already seen I now have the
ability to add a loop into an HTML
template using Django to say that for
task in tasks I'd like to Loop over all
of the elements inside of this sequence
called tasks and for each one of those
individual tasks I would like to display
a list item in HTML that includes
whatever the value of the task happens
to be and N4 just like and if ended the
if statement N4 is going to end the for
Loop
so this syntax now rather than give me
exactly the same number of list items
every time with exactly the same content
will be dynamic whatever the value of
tasks is we will now see on this page
each one as a list item
and we can test this right now if I
actually run this application by going
to
pythonmanage.pi run server
I'll go ahead and go to this URL the
default URL has no page but if I go to
slash tasks
well then here's what I see I see an
unordered list that has Foo bar and bath
each one is a list item and if I view
the page source to see what the actual
HTML is here's what I see I only wrote
One Li tag inside of my template but
because I put it inside of a for Loop
that iterates over each of the tasks
what I ultimately get in the HTML that
comes back to the user is one list item
for each of the elements that was
originally inside of that list
so I now have the ability to Loop over a
list in order to generate that list of
tasks
of course there's still no way to like
modify any of these tasks what we have
here is just a fixed list of tasks that
just so happens to be rendering using a
loop what I'd maybe like is another page
that will allow me to add in new tasks a
form effectively that lets me type in a
new task and press add in order to add a
new task
so let's do that inside of views.pi I'll
Define a new function that I'm going to
call add
and what the add function is going to do
is render
tasks slash ad dot HTML
in order to know when to run the few I
need to give this view a URL so I'll go
into urls.pi and add a new path
when I go to the add route I want to go
to the views.add function
and I'll call this function add for
example
and so now
when I go to slash task slash ad it's
going to call the add function inside of
views and inside of views here it's
going to run this function that will
render add.html
so let's go ahead and now write ad.html
we'll go into templates I'll create a
new file called
add.html and you know what add.html
syntax is very similar to the syntax
from index.html in terms of what the
HTML content is so I'll go ahead and
just copy this whole page from
index.html paste it into ad.html the
only thing that's different is the body
of the page where instead of an
unordered list that displays all the
tasks I'd instead like a form
where that form has an input whose type
is text and maybe this input field has a
name called task such that I can access
that input data later and an input whose
type is submit for example and maybe
I'll give it a big heading at the top
that says like
add task for example
so now I have a new route that adds a
task so my default slash tasks route
just displays a bulleted list of all the
tasks and if I go to slash tasks slash
add here now is my form that gives me a
place where I can type in a task press
submit that right now does nothing but
that ultimately I hope will actually add
a new task
of course something I just did there
should strike us as not the best design
in particular the decision I made was
because the general structure of this
HTML page is so similar it's got the
HTML tag it's got a head the title of
the page is tasks
ultimately I just copied all of the
content of index.html and pasted it into
this new HTML page add.html and anytime
you find yourself copy pasting this
should be another area where you start
to think there's probably a better way
to do this and with just pure HTML there
kind of wasn't if we wanted multiple
different HTML pages that displayed
similar content we needed the same HTML
on all those different pages
but now in the world of Django we have
the ability to use something called
template inheritance what I'm now going
to do is Define an HTML file called the
layout just some file that the other
files add.html and index.html are going
to inherit from they're going to inherit
from my layout all of the structure of
the page that's the same on both of the
pages and all I then need to write is
what differs between the pages and as I
mentioned before the only thing that
differs between ad.html and index.html
is the content of the body of the page
over here
so what can I now do well I will create
a new file inside of my template tasks
directory called layout.html
and layout is going to have
the basic layout that is common to both
of these pages I have a title these
title is tasks I have the body of the
page and maybe there's more in common
with both of the pages as well that I
could add but right here this in between
the body tags this is the body of the
page that is going to change between
each of the different pages
so to denote this inside of a layout in
Django I'll again use the curly brace
and percent signs I'll call this a block
and then I'll give this block a name
I'll call it body just because it's the
body of the page but I could give it any
name and then I'll add an end block at
the bottom here
and so what I've now said inside of this
layout file is that this layout file has
a body inside of the structure of the
page and inside the body is this block
called body and what I'm saying here is
this block might change depending on
which file we're using add.html or
index.html the rest of the structure
won't change but the content of this
block this block called body might
change
and so now what I can do inside of
index.html and add.html
is instead of including all of this
logic I can get rid of everything other
than the key part of the page that's
going to be different about index.html
the only thing different about
index.html is this unordered list
and what I'll now include at the top of
index.html is I'll say that this HTML
page extends
tasks slash layout.html
so this is now this idea of template
inheritance I'm inheriting from the
layout.html template basically saying
use the layout.html template except
inside of block body
I would like to include
all of this content
and maybe I'll give it a H1 that just
says tasks just as a title as well
and so now what index.html is saying is
rather the need to include all of that
HTML all I need to say is this HTML file
is based on the layout.html file but the
difference is that inside the body of
the page it's going to be this
particular content here and for ad.html
I can do exactly the same thing I can
just add this line extends tasks slash
layout.html to the top of ad.html
and then I can get rid of all of this
boilerplate code so to speak
and just include the part of the page
that differs
inside
the body of the page
and so it seems like we've done a fair
bit more work for just these two pages
but if you imagine more complex websites
it might have dozens or hundreds of
different pages the ability to factor
out the HTML that Pages have in common
can definitely be very helpful just for
good design to be able to make sure
we're not repeating ourselves and if we
ever need to change the structure rather
than change it in dozens or hundreds of
different places we just change it in
one place inside of the layout file and
the result of that is that it's going to
change in each of the pages that inherit
from that page as well
and we can test this by just going back
to slash task slash add which looks fine
and back to tasks looks fine too both of
these Pages now are inheriting from that
basic layout
now it's a little Annoying that anytime
I want to switch between this page and
the ad page I have to go to the URL and
know that I need to go to slash tasks
slash ad in order to get back and forth
between them so I might like to add a
link that takes me from one page to the
other and vice versa and I can do that
if I go into index.html you might
imagine that I could just add a link
here a href to create a link let's go to
slash tasks slash add
and like add a new task it'll be the
name of that link
except the problem is or the reason why
this isn't necessarily good design is
the Django is designed to make it such
that it's very easy to change the
structure of the pages in terms of how
the URLs all relate to each other and I
have here hard coded that when you click
this link we go to slash tasks slash ad
and If Ever I wanted to change that URL
maybe instead of Slash ad I wanted Slash
new instead of Slash ad well then I need
to change it in two places I'd need to
go back to the urls.pi file to change
the actual URL to say instead of add it
should be called new but then I need to
find every place where I use that URL
and I'd need to change it there as well
so in order to deal with this Django has
an additional feature that basically
lets Django figure out what the URL
should be instead and we do that by
using the name that we gave to each of
those routes and so this is where that
name becomes relevant that I can hear
just say
link to a particular URL
link to the URL called add
so I just said link to URL called add
and how Django figures this out is based
on the contents of my urls.pi file that
inside my urls.pi file I defined a
number of different paths and I gave
each of those paths a name this one was
called Index this one was called add
and so when I did that I was able to say
if you link to a URL called add Django
will find a URL whose name is ADD and
Link me directly to that route and so if
ever I were to change the route to
something else Django would just figure
out what the new URL should be and I
wouldn't have to worry about it Django
would fix the problems for me
and so now if I go back to the task site
I can click the add a new task button
and that will take me to the add task
and maybe now I'd like to add a link
that goes back so I can go to add.html
and maybe add a link down to the bottom
ahref equals and what URL would I like
to link to well my default page was just
called index so I'll go ahead and
include the word index I'd like to link
to the URL index
and then
view tasks maybe as the name of the link
so now if I go to just the default tasks
page I see a link to go add a new task
and now I see a link that's going to
take me back to the ability to view
tasks and when I click on that link I
see no
and now that's probably not what I
wanted I wanted to go back to the index
page for my tasks application but it
seems that when I clicked on view tasks
I'm taken to no
and what's going on here well if you
look at the URL
the URL is Slash new year
somehow I was on the tasks app I clicked
a link and I'm back at the new year app
how did that happen well it turns out
this is an example of a namespace
collision where I have two things that
all have the same name and in this case
what's happening is that I have a
urls.pi file
for my tasks application where I have a
route called add and a route called
index
but it just so happens that inside of
the New Year folder if I go up to New
Year and I look at New Year's urls.pi
file the New Year's urls.pi file also
has a path whose name is index and so
what I said was create a link and I
would like that link to link to the
thing that has the URL with a name of
index and it turns out there were
multiple things that all had a name of
index and so Django didn't know which to
choose and it just chose the new year
one and you might imagine that linking
between apps is something you might
reasonably want to do you want to from
Amazon's shopping page for example be
able to click a link that takes you to
Amazon video or you want from Google
search to be able to click a button that
gets you to Google Maps but in this case
this isn't quite what I wanted there's a
namespace collision where two things
have the same name that I would now like
to be able to fix
and the easy way to fix this is inside
of urls.pi for my tasks application let
me just give each of these URLs an app
name called tasks
this just helps uniquely identify all of
the URLs because now inside of ad.html
rather than just link to a URL whose
name is index I'm going to instead link
to tasks colon index to mean from tasks
the tasks app get the index URL and
likewise inside of index.html I'll link
to tasks colon add to get that
particular route from this particular
application name
so now if I go back to the site
go back to my tasks page now the Links
work as expected I can get to the new
tasks and I can get back to the list of
all of my tasks as well
so this now works I now have these two
pages one that displays my list one that
displays my ability to add a new task
but the form to add a new task doesn't
really do anything right now I type in a
task I type in like Foo if I want to add
a task called Foo and I press submit and
like nothing happens nothing changes
meaningfully on this site so I'd like
for this form to do something and we've
seen that we can add an action to a
forum to be able to take that form and
submit it somewhere and that's what I'd
like to do
when I add a new task I'm going to add
an action to this form and when I submit
the form what URL would I'd like to
submit it to well I'll go ahead and
submit it back to
the URL
for tasks colon add I'll send it back to
that ad URL when I submit the form
and I'm going to give this form a
specific request method its method is
going to be post
and so we've already seen a request
method of get anytime you type in a URL
or click on a link to go to another page
the request method implicitly associated
with that request is called get which
just means I would like to get a
particular page
anytime you're submitting data that has
the potential to change some State
inside the application like changing the
state of the list of tasks that is
stored inside the application then we'll
generally use a different request method
called post post was generally used for
submitting form data it doesn't include
parameters inside the URL the way a get
request does as we saw with Google for
example but this post ability is going
to give us the ability now to send data
via a different request method to my ad
route
and so let's now give this a try
now I'm going to go to task add I see
the ability to add a task and maybe I'll
add a task like check email or something
and press submit
and all right I get an error forbidden
this 403 in parentheses means that is
the response code that came back this is
an error that Django has generated for
me so this 403 as we saw before means
forbidden I don't have permission to do
this for some reason now why don't I
have permission to submit this form it
says csrf verification failed so csrf
stands for cross-site request forgery
and what that means it is a security
vulnerability that is inherent in some
forms if they're not designed in a
secure way meaning that someone could
Forge a request to a particular website
using some form on their own separate
website for example you might imagine
that someone on a different website
might trick the user into submitting a
form that submits its data to R add task
function that adds a new task to their
task list and maybe that's not a big
deal for tasks but you might imagine in
more secure contexts more sensitive
contexts like a bank for example they
might have a form on their website for
transferring money from one user to
another and if they're vulnerable to
this sort of attack cross-site request
forgery someone else on a different
website could trick the user into
submitting a form where it submits form
data and it goes to the bank's website
to say I would like to transfer money
from this one user to another user so we
would like to be able to design forms
that are not vulnerable
to that particular security
vulnerability that don't allow for
requests to be forged by another website
so how can we go about doing this well
one strategy that can be used in order
to deal with these sorts of attacks is
to add into our Forum a hidden
cross-site request forgery token or csrf
token which will just be some unique
token that's generated for every session
so every time a different user visits
this particular form they see a
different csrf token and then when the
user submits the form they're submitting
that token with the form and our web
application is going to check to make
sure that that token is indeed valid and
if it is valid then they'll allow the
form submission to go through but this
means that an adversary wouldn't be able
to fake a request to our website because
that adversary doesn't know specifically
what the generated token is so they
would fail the check for csrf validation
and it just so happens that Django has
csrf validation turned on by default and
it's done so via specific add-on known
as a Django middleware middleware refers
to the ability in Django to be able to
sort of intervene in the request
response processing of a Django request
and if I look at the settings.pi file if
you're curious for this particular web
application
[Music]
inside of settings.pi if we scroll down
we see there's a whole bunch of
middleware that's installed by default
inside of a Django application in terms
of making sure that we have various
different features hooked into this
request response processing and one of
those is the CRS csrf view middleware
this feature of Django that allows it to
make sure that our requests whenever
we're submitting data via post something
that has the potential to change the
state of the application in some way
that we need to have csrf validation we
need to add some sort of token to our
Forum to make sure that Django is able
to authenticate the validity of this
form to make sure they know the form
actually came from the web application
itself
and it's quite easy to be able to add
this token into our HTML page Django has
a built-in inside the curly brace and
percent sign we can just say I would
like to add into this page the csrf
token for example to go ahead and fill
in the csrf token right there
if I now go back to the page and refresh
the page
now I see add task but if we're curious
I can now actually go and view the page
Source I can look inside this page and
here now is the form and this is the
form same as we saw before but you'll
notice that Django has inserted this
additional input field this input whose
type is hidden meaning we won't be able
to see it normally whose name is csrf
middleware token and here is its value
some long string of characters that
Django has generated for me such that
when I submit this form it's going to
check to make sure this token is valid
and if it doesn't find this token it is
not going to accept my form submission
and if someone else goes to this website
they're going to see a different token
presented to them as well and that helps
to make sure that nobody can forge these
sorts of requests
so now if I type in a task that I'd like
to add something like check email and
press submit now the Forum does submit
without errors of course it doesn't do
anything if I go back to my task list
it's still empty but at least I've now
been able to submit that form
it's worth noting that inside of ad.html
we created this form sort of from
scratch I created an input field whose
type is text and whose name is Task but
creating forms is something that happens
so often in the world of web programming
oftentimes with many different fields
that you might want to change over time
the djangos added a number of ways to
make it easier to create forums to
validate the data inside of those forms
just to make our lives a little bit
easier when it comes to dealing with and
interacting with forums and so now we'll
explore an alternative way of doing the
same thing what we did here just works
we can create a forum just using raw
HTML as we've seen before
but Django also has the ability to
create forms for us so in order to do
this I'll go into views.pi and at the
top add from Django import forms
[Music]
and now I'm going to create a new class
to represent this form I'll create a
python class that'll just call new task
form since I'll use it to create a new
task it will inherit from forms.form
and now inside of this class I need to
Define all of the fields I would like
for this forum to have all the inputs
that I would like the user to provide
and so I want them to provide the name
of a task which will be a character
field or a Char field meaning I want the
user to type in characters
and I can give this a label call it new
task for example
and now what I can do is when I render
add.html I can add some context and say
give this template access to a variable
called form which will just be a new
task form I'm going to create a new task
form pass it into this ad.html template
and now inside of add.html instead of
writing the input whose type is text
name is Task and having to do that on my
own I can just use double curly braces
and say plug in the form here and that
will automatically take care of Django
will generate the necessary HTML to make
that form work
so if I refresh this page now I see that
here is the form the Django has created
for me it's created an input field
that's given it a label of new tasks so
I know that it's where a new task should
go but now rather than needing to edit
the HTML anytime I want to change the
form data that's involved inside of this
application I can just change this new
task form if maybe I want to eventually
make upgrades to my application where in
addition to specifying a text field
where I can type in the new task maybe I
also want to be able to specify a number
indicating the priority that tasks
should have I could additionally give
this form access to a priority variable
which is an integer field
whose label is priority and I can even
add constraints on this to be able to
ensure that it's valid data I can give
it a Min value of maybe one and a max
value of 10 for example in order to add
all of that and now without touching
anything in my HTML I just changed the
form itself inside of my python code now
if I refresh the page I see an
additional field I see an opportunity
for me to type in a new task and I see
an opportunity for me to specify some
priority and of course you could add CSS
in order to style this up a little bit
nicer but now
Django will automatically do client-side
validation where if I type in a new task
like check email but I don't specify a
priority and submit it it tells me to
fill it out if I type in a number that's
in an invalid range I only wanted
numbers from 0 to 10 it fills it out and
this is all what we would call again
client-side validation the server isn't
getting any of this data it's just the
web page has been encoded to know what
the valid values are and it's going to
constrain me to make sure that I'm
typing in something that matches those
values but in general when we're doing
form validation when we're making sure
that forms are valid data we want to
somehow make sure
to include not only client-side
validation but also server side
validation we also want to check on the
server to make sure that inputs are
value valid as well because there are
many reasons why this we might want to
be able to do this one is that it's very
easy to disable this sort of client-side
validation or just submit a request
without doing any of the client-side
validation and maybe if the user is
looking at an old version of the page
the validation we're doing on the server
is more up to date than this client-side
validation as well and Django's forums
will make it very easy for us to do both
of these things both the client-side
validation and the server side
validation as well
so how does this work how do we do that
well inside of the add function
this add function now gets called in two
different ways depending upon the
request method if I try to get the ad
page and by just clicking on the link
for add a new task or going to the URL
of Slash add then I want to just render
a new blank form
but if I post data to this page by using
the post request method instead of get
that means I'm submitting the form and I
now want to submit a new task to be
added to my list of tasks
so I'd like to add a check for that I'm
going to add a condition here that says
if request dot method equals post
well then here what I'd like to do is
process the result of that request and
the way you do that in a Django form is
by creating a new variable called form
which will be a new task form and if I
just use new task form with two
parentheses like I did before that
creates a blank form but you can also
populate that form with some data
and if I populate it with request dot
post what that is going to do is
request.post contains all of the data
that the User submitted when they
submitted the form
and so what I'm doing now is I'm
creating a form variable by taking all
of that data and filling it into this
new task form which will contain now all
of the data the User submitted and you
can imagine checking this manually but I
can just call if form
dot is valid
and inside this if statement use some
logic using the clean data as a result
of using this form
and so inside of a variable called form
dot clean data that will give me access
to all of the data the User submitted
and so if I want to get like what task
they submitted because I had a variable
here called task inside of a new task
form
well I'll just go to form.clean data and
then task
and I'll go ahead and save this inside
of a variable called tasks
and now what I might like to do is add
this task to my list of tasks go
tasks.append
this new task
so that's what we do if the form is
valid if the form is valid we take the
data from the form get the task save it
inside this variable called tasks and
add it to my growing list
but else if the form is not valid
what should we do instead well then I
should return
the ad.html file again but instead of
providing the form back to them the a
new form back to them I'm going to send
back the existing form data back to them
so we can display information about any
errors that might have come up as well
so what does this now look like let's
Show an example and then I'll go back to
the codes you can see in better detail
how it works
here's task add recall that if I type in
a task like check email and a priority
that's not valid out of range like 11
and press submit it says value must be
less than or equal to 10. but let's now
imagine a situation where the client and
server are validating different things
that maybe I've now decided you know
what priority instead of being from 1 to
10 can only be from one to five that's
now the valid range for priorities
but this client which is still an older
version of the page doesn't know this
so it thinks that a priority of eight is
still valid and it's going to pass
client-side validation
but now I press submit and the server is
going to process it and because it's
invalid it gives me back the form and
gives me an error ensure this valid
value is less than or equal to 5. and so
this now is why we generally want both
client and server side validation to
make sure that the data we ultimately
get
is going to be accurate and it's going
to be clean matching whatever
specification we sent out when we were
creating that form for the first time
and so for the purposes of now we're not
going to really worry about priority too
much because we just really care about
what the task is but just know that if
you wanted a form that had multiple
Fields you could add additional fields
to this form input as well
so now we've added some application
logic to our route that checks to make
sure that the form is valid or not if we
take a look at what the add function is
really doing we're checking if the
request method is post meaning if the
User submitted some form data then we
figure out all the data they submitted
and save it inside this form variable we
check to see if the form is valid did
they actually provide a task are they
making providing all the necessary data
in the right format if so then we get
the task and add it to the list of tasks
otherwise if the form is not valid then
we go ahead and render that same ad.html
file back to them but we pass in the
form that they submitted so that they
can see all of the errors they made they
can make modifications to their own form
submission if they'd like to
and then otherwise meaning if the
request method wasn't post at all if the
user just tried to get the page rather
than submit data to it then we're just
going to render to them an empty form
and this sort of Paradigm is actually
quite common when we're dealing with
requests and responses that oftentimes
pages that have forms will want you to
First be able to get that form via the
get method to just get the page in order
to display the contents but those routes
will also often support a post method
where you can post data to those routes
in order to say I would like to now
submit data to a particular route in
order to get some sort of result some
sort of addition to a list of tasks
transferring money in a bank from one
account to another for example or
something else entirely
but watch what happens if I now try
inside of tasks ad to add a new task
that's valid something like check email
for example I press submit and all right
nothing quite seems to happen because I
just get back this new task form
but if I go back to view tasks now I see
that check email has been added to my
list of tasks the original list of tasks
just had Fue barbaz and now we've added
check email to it but this wasn't quite
the behavior that I might have expected
maybe I wanted that after I submitted
the task Forum to add a new task I would
like to be redirected back to this page
as well and it turns out Django makes it
easy for us to be able to redirect users
from one page to another
in order to do that
after we add a new task to my list of
tasks I'm going to return an HTTP
response redirect
and redirect the user to a particular
route I could redirect them to just like
slash tasks for example but again we
generally try not to hard code URLs into
our application so better design would
be to say let me give you the name of
the route and go ahead and reverse
engineer what the route actually is from
that and so in order to do that we can
use the function called reverse built
into Django
and say tasks colon index to say figure
out what the URL of the index URL for
the tasks app is and use that URL as the
one that we ultimately redirect to when
we return this HTTP response redirect in
order to use these we need to import
both of them so from the top I'll say
from django.http import HTTP response
redirect and
from django.urls I'll go ahead and
import reverse so I've imported both of
these and now the effect of this is that
after I submit a new task
and add it to my list of tasks I'm going
to be redirected back to the index page
of my tasks application and for good
measure I'll go ahead and start us off
with an empty list to get rid of the
fubarb as we saw there originally so
tasks start out as the empty list
now refresh the page I see no tasks in
here by default but if I add a new task
I type in something like check email
press submit I now see that added to the
task list and I get redirected back to
the task page I can add a new task
something like do laundry press submit
and that gets added to my tasks list as
well too so by maintaining this Global
variable called tasks and updating it
anytime I submit the form I've been able
to dynamically grow this list of tasks
inside of my application and display all
of those tasks here inside of my HTML
page
however there's still one big problem
with the application that I've built and
it goes back to the idea that I've
stored these tasks inside of a global
variable this variable is something the
entire application has access to which
means that anyone who visits my website
is going to be able to see the same
exact list of tasks and we can simulate
this by imagining someone else visiting
this URL which I can simulate in Google
Chrome by opening an incognito window to
simulate a different session a different
person interacting with the page and
going to the same URL
what they see when any incognito window
they go to the same URL is they see the
exact same list of tasks both me and
another person see the same list because
there's just one tasks variable across
the entire application that is shared
among all of the requests that come in
to that particular application and
that's probably not what I want when I'm
dealing with something like a list of
tasks I probably want it to be per user
such that if a different user visits the
page they have their own list of tasks
as well and so in order to do this we'll
introduce the concept of sessions in
Django or in the web more generally
where sessions are away for one Django
to be able to remember who you are such
that on subsequent visits it remembers
who you are and knows who you are but
more importantly
it's able to then store data about your
particular session it's able to store
your user ID or information about you or
in this case it's able to store all of
your tasks
and so in order to take advantage of
sessions
instead of having a global variable
called tasks we're going to go ahead and
delete this and instead store tasks
inside of the user's session
so inside the index route I'll include a
line like this
I'll check to see if tasks is not in
request.session
meaning if I look inside the session you
can think of the session as like a big
dictionary representing all the data we
have on file inside the session about
the user
and if tasks is not in that session well
let me add to request.sessions
or session tasks and set that equal to
the empty list
and so what I've done here is I'm
looking inside of the session I'm
looking inside the session to see is
there already a list of tasks in that
session and if there isn't if there
isn't already a list of tasks in the
session well then I'd like to create it
then I'd like to set request.session
square bracket tasks equal to the empty
list if the user doesn't already have a
list of tasks go ahead and give them an
empty list of tasks
and now here in tasks instead of
rendering the variable tasks which no
longer exists I'll render request dot
session
tasks to pass in that list of tasks to
this particular template
and now in index.html we're still
looping over to that list of tasks and
now we'll see if I go back to tasks I
see no such table Django underscore
session
so this is a bit of a strange error
what's going on here no such table
Django underscore session well it turns
out as we'll see in the future Django
tends to store data inside of tables and
we haven't yet gotten to what that
ultimately means or how to manipulate or
interact with data stored inside of
tables but Django stores data about
sessions as it would happen inside of a
table by default now you can change this
to have Django stored data about
sessions elsewhere but ultimately Django
is keeping data about who you are and
what your tasks are and that data needs
to be stored somewhere and by default
Django wants to store it inside of a
table
and right now that table doesn't exist
so we need to create it and the way to
give Django access to that table that it
wants to create that has been waiting to
create but it hasn't yet is to run this
command inside the terminal python
manage.pi migrate
and we'll learn more about what that
means in terms of what a migration is
and what it means to migrate data into a
database but for now just to know that
python managed.pi migrate will allow us
to create all of the default tables
inside of Django's database next time
we'll take a look at actually creating
databases of our own adding tables of
our own that store our own custom data
but Django has some initial default
tables that it wants to create and
running python managed on Pi migrate
allows for those tables to be created
now that those exist I first need to run
the server it's a python manage.pi
run server
I load the page and here now is my list
of tasks there's nothing here so when I
Loop over all the list items it's sort
of empty which maybe isn't the best user
experience or user design so what I
might want to do is add an additional
condition it turns out inside of
index.html whenever I have a for Loop
inside of a Django template
I can also add an empty condition to say
if I run the for Loop but it doesn't run
at all because the sequence is empty
well then let me just say like no tasks
for example and this is just a nice to
have feature of the Django language that
just makes it easy for us to be able to
deal with situations where we're
iterating over a list and there's
nothing in that list
so now I refresh the page no tasks
exactly what I would expect to see
and now this index route seems to be
working fine what now needs to change
when it comes to adding a new task
well rather than append the task to my
list of tasks let me go ahead and say
request.session tasks
because that is my list of tasks and let
me add to request.session tasks this new
task I'm adding to it a new sort of
adding a list to the end of it that just
contains the one new task that I got
from the form
so when the form is submitted we check
to make sure the form is valid we get
the task the User submitted and we
append that to the list of tasks that's
already stored inside of the session
before redirecting the user back to the
index page
so let's give it a try we'll go back to
this URL back to tasks I see I have no
tasks initially
and now I can go ahead and add a new
task
type in something like check
email
press submit
and all right now that's added add a new
task someone like do laundry submit and
now both of those tasks are there but
now importantly if you imagine someone
in ink in an incognito window or on a
different computer visiting my same
website going back to this page what
they see is an entirely different list
of tasks because they have a different
session the sessions are determined by
cookies these little hand stamps that
help the browser to be able to give some
information to Django's web server to
say here is who I am so Django knows
what data to show you and in this case
my original case Django knows who I am
knows to show me these tasks and in this
case it's a different user in incognito
window in this case and so what they see
is a list that has no tasks inside it at
all
so now we've really just scratched the
surface of what Django has to offer but
we see now the ability it has to be able
to create Dynamic web applications
instead of just displaying HTML and CSS
that's the same every time using Django
we now have the ability to be able to
generate programmatically custom HTML
and CSS either saying hello to a
person's name based on what name is
provided inside of a URL or the ability
to say to check the current date and
conditionally display something if the
date is one thing versus another and the
ability to store data on a session basis
to be able to store information about a
user's to-do list for example such that
on subsequent visits they can see their
list of things they need to do with a
different list for each of these
possible users and here really is just
the beginning of what Django has to
offer where Django gets very powerful is
when it comes towards storing data
inside of databases and manipulating
that data and interacting with that data
in various different ways and that's
ultimately where a lot of the power of a
web framework like this ultimately comes
in we'll explore more of that next time
but for now that was just a look at
Django and how we can use use it to be
able to build these sorts of web
applications this was web programming
with python and JavaScript we'll see you
next time
[Music]
all right welcome back everyone to web
programming with python and JavaScript
so last time we took a look at a brand
new web framework written in Python
called Django and what Django allowed us
to do was to build Dynamic web
applications applications where we now
had the ability to not just display the
same HTML and CSS to the user every
single time but to dynamically generate
HTML in order to allow users to interact
with a page that was a little bit more
Dynamic doing things like rendering
things on the page only if a certain
condition was true or looping over a
list of values and displaying one HTML
element for each of those possible
values but where Django gets especially
powerful and where web applications
certainly get much more interesting is
as we start to delve into the world of
data and trying to have web applications
that store data inside of a database and
to do that we're going to introduce a
couple of topics today in particular
we're going to introduce the idea of SQL
models and migrations SQL is a database
language that we can use to interact
with databases and Django is going to
allow us to have an abstraction layer on
top of SQL to interact not by writing
direct SQL queries but by interacting
with python classes and objects that
we're going to refer to as models and
migrations are going to be a technique
that are going to allow us to update our
database in response to changes that we
make to our underlying models so before
we get into things that are more Django
specific let's begin with the discussion
of SQL more generally and more broadly
just the discussion of data and the
types of data that we're going to want
to store and now there are a number of
ways that we could try to store data
inside of a computer system but
oftentimes in databases in particular in
a type of database known as a relational
database we're going to store data
inside of a table where each table is
going to have rows and columns and so
for the take of today we're going to
imagine starting to construct a database
and a web application that an airline
might use for example for keeping track
of various different flights on that
Airline and keeping track of which
passengers are on those flights and so
what we have here is a sample table for
example of how you might represent a
whole bunch of flight related data here
I have three columns for three pieces of
information that I might want to keep
track of for any particular flight for
any given flight I might want to know
that flight's origin what city it's
leaving from its destination what city
it's arriving at and its duration some
value in minutes of how long it's going
to take the flight to get from the
origin to the destination so each of
those columns represents one field that
I might want to keep track of about my
data and each row meanwhile is going to
represent an individual flight so here
for example is one row representing one
flight from New York to London and that
flight just so happens to take
415 minutes and so what SQL is going to
allow us to do is it is going to be a
database language that is designed to
interact with relational database
Management Systems databases that
organize data into tables where every
table has rows and columns and it turns
out there are a number of different
database management systems that
Implement parts of the SQL standard of
this type of language some of the more
popular are MySQL postgres SQL and
sqlite but there are definitely others
as well and each of these has various
different features and different use
cases where some might be more
appropriate MySQL and postgresql
otherwise known as just postgres are
more heavier database management system
so to speak they're generally running on
servers elsewhere where a lot of big
companies will use servers like this in
order to store data and represent their
data in sort of a separate database
where the idea of that is that you might
want your web application running on one
server but you might want your database
running as an entirely separate process
such that they can behave independently
you can debug and test them
independently and one is not if one goes
down the other doesn't go down as well
sqlite is a bit of a simpler lighter
weight implementation of the SQL
standard and what sqlite is going to do
is rather than be an entire server that
is going to be listening for requests
and making responses sqlite is just
going to store all of its data as a
single file so we're going to store SQL
data inside of a sqlite file and that's
going to make it a little bit easier for
us as we're just getting started to
begin to write queries and add things to
our database and retrieve things from
our database but know that many of the
same types of SQL syntax that we'll see
with SQL Lite which is Django's default
can also be applied to other languages
as well in other database Management
Systems too
so as we begin to store data inside of a
SQL database ultimately each of those
pieces of data has a type in the same
way that in Python we have types for
various different types of data we have
integers and we have strings and we have
lists and tuples and so forth SQL 2 has
types that represent various different
categories of information that you might
want to store inside of a database and
each database management system has its
own different set of types sqlite for
example has a fairly short list of basic
types that it supports it supports text
for just like strings of text for
example something like a city name for
instance might be stored as text we have
support for integers which are just 0 1
2 3 4 plus the negative numbers negative
one negative two negative three and so
forth we have support for real numbers
where real numbers don't have to just be
integers they can have something after
the decimal point something like 2.8 or
something else that might have a decimal
in it and then numeric is another
category for data that's just more
generally some sort of number that might
number like data so something like a
Boolean value or something like a date
for example might be stored using this
numeric type where it's not really an
integer or a real number though you
could represent it as such it's other
numeric type of data and then finally
blob which stands for binary large
object is any type of other binary data
just zeros and ones that you might want
to store inside of your database so for
example if you're storing files maybe
they're audio files or images or other
types of files that you want to keep
track of inside of your database you can
store just pure binary data inside of a
SQL database as well
so these now are the basic types of
sqlite supports but other database
Management Systems have other types that
they support as well MySQL for example
has a much longer list of other types
that it supports in addition to just
supporting a text type for arbitrary
length text MySQL also has a type called
Char that takes an argument of size for
saying I want like size characters worth
of data that we're going to store inside
the database and you might imagine that
this can be advantageous in situations
where you know that your data is going
to be within a certain number of
characters so if you're storing a zip
code for example in the United States a
zip code in the United States might just
be five characters and so you can
allocate a character length of five
characters worth of space for storing
every single zip code inside of your
database table so for efficiency's sake
if you know the maximum length and you
can fix that length inside your database
that can be an efficient choice varchar
of a size is similar and this is a
variable length character if something
isn't going to be exactly a certain
number of characters but maybe up to a
certain number of characters you can use
varchar to say you know maybe sometimes
it's going to be fewer characters but it
could be up to size number of characters
and there are trade-offs there too
then there are various different types
of integers there's not just a single
integer type but small int and int and
bigint Each of which uses a different
number of bytes in order to store an
integer data so if you want to be able
to store much larger or much smaller
numbers you might need a bigger type
like an INT or a big end but if your
numbers are going to be pretty small
maybe you're okay with just a small end
and likewise there are similar types of
trade-offs for floating Point numbers
where much as in programming languages
like C if you're familiar have both a
float and a double type where a double
uses more bytes of memory in order to
store information here too we have float
and double which allow us to store
floating Point numbers numbers that
might be real numbered values where a
double just allows us to express a
number to a little bit more Precision
than a floating Point number might be
able to and there are many other types
as well but the general idea is that
here even in SQL much as in a language
like python we have types for each of
these various different kinds of data so
now that we understand that each type of
data has types what we'd like to do is
to be able to inside of a database
actually create a table and there are
various different SQL commands that we
can run on our database in order to
perform various different operations and
the first we might want to execute is a
command that is just going to create a
table for example so how might we go
about doing that well it turns out the
syntax for creating a table is going to
look a little something like this this
here is the syntax we would use to
create a table in sqlite for
representing flights for example
so we begin with the keyword create
table to say I would like to create a
new table inside of this database next I
give the name of the table every table
has a name just for ease of reference
and here the name of the table is just
the word flights then what follows in
parentheses are a comma separated list
of all of the columns that should be
present in the table I'm not yet adding
any data to the table the create table
query is just going to decide the
structure of the table what are the
columns and what are the columns types
and so here we see that in the beginning
of each of these pair of these Clauses
that are separated by commas we have the
name of the column so we have an ID
column because though we didn't see this
before often in SQL it's going to be
helpful to be able to have some way of
uniquely referencing a particular
element inside of the table and you know
maybe there are multiple flights that
are going from New York to London for
example and I want some way of
distinguishing between them and one easy
way is to give every single entry inside
of a table a unique identifier or a
unique ID represented here by this ID
column and that's going to be of weight
making sure that we can always access a
particular flight uniquely
so we have an ID column An Origin column
a destination column and a duration
column and each of those columns has a
type
so the types here ID is an integer it's
just going to be some number
representing the flight counting one two
three four so on and so forth origin and
destination we'll label here as text
though you'll see that if we were using
MySQL for example I might make these a
variable length character that could be
up to a certain number of characters if
I know you know there's probably not
going to be a city that's longer than a
certain number of characters for
instance and then I have a duration
which here then is an integer some
number of minutes that is going to be
how long it takes for this flight to go
from the origin to the destination
after the types for each of the columns
I have additional constraints that I
might add to the columns as well so
integer primary key the primary key here
means that the ID is going to be the
primary Way by which I uniquely identify
a flight and there's going to be some
optimizations here to make it very quick
to be able to look up a flight by its ID
and not know as a constraint that I can
place on columns to be able to say I
don't want to allow for this particular
column to ever be empty I don't want
there to ever be a flight that doesn't
have an origin or doesn't have a
destination or a duration so I can add
constraints to a particular column to
say you know what for the origin
destination duration columns those
should not be allowed to be null I want
to always have an origin and a
destination and a duration
and then finally this Auto increment
after the primary key is a queue into
SQL to automatically update the ID every
time I add a new row into the table so
if I add a new flight I can give the
flight An Origin destination and
duration but I don't have to worry about
giving it an ID SQL is going to handle
that for me automatically automatically
giving that new table the next or the
new row in that table the next available
ID number so here then is the way we
create a table by giving the name of the
table each of the columns the types for
each of those columns and then any
constraints we would want to place on
those columns and it turns out there are
a number of different types of
constraints that I can add to a
particular column not null is one we've
seen before you can add a default which
just adds a default value to a
particular column primary key we've seen
unique guarantees that every value is
going to be unique so if you don't want
to allow for the same value to appear
twice for a particular column you can
add a unique constraint to a particular
column to enforce that as well and then
check can be use to make sure that a
value obeys a certain condition like a
number Falls within a certain range for
example if you have like movie ratings
for example and you're storing movie
ratings inside of a database you might
care to make sure that those ratings are
within the one to five range or the one
to ten range or whatever range you deem
valid for the database and so via
constraints you can begin to ensure that
as you add data to the table that data
is going to be valid in some way that it
needs to obey certain constraints
otherwise if you try to add it to the
table it's not going to be accepted at
all
and so that leads into the natural next
question which is I now have all of
these various different tables that I
can create using these create table
commands but how do I actually add data
into those tables and the way we're
going to do that is via an insert
command where we're going to insert data
into a SQL table
and so what might that command look like
the command is generally going to look
like this where we're going to say
insert into to say I would like to add a
new row to a table
following that we provide the name of
the table something like flights to say
I would like to add a new row to the
flights table and following the name of
the table we need to provide in
parentheses a comma separated list of
all of the column names for which we are
going to provide values so here I've
said I want to provide values for the
origin destination and duration of this
flight note that I'm leaving out the ID
column I don't have to worry about
adding a value for the ID because I said
the ID should Auto increment so it's
going to automatically give the next
available ID
and what values am I going to provide
well after the word values I provide
again in parentheses a comma separated
list of all of the values that are to be
associated with those columns in the
same order so origin was the first one
here so origin will correspond to New
York destination will correspond to
London duration will correspond to 415.
so this query then lets me take the
flights table that I've already created
and add some data into that table as
well
so you can use these insert queries so
once you have a table to be able to add
new rows of data to that table every
time a new flight comes up for an
airline the airline might behind the
scenes be running an insert into flights
command that takes data about that
flight and adds it to the table but of
course once we've added data to a table
we'd ideally like some way to get data
out of that table as well that once
we've stored data inside of our database
we want to retrieve that data too and to
do that we're going to use a particular
type of query
called a select query and what select is
going to do is it's going to take a
table that already exists and allow us
to get data out of that table
it's not going to modify the data that's
there it's just going to retrieve data
that might be inside of a particular
table so what do those queries look like
well the simplest query might look a
little something like this select star
from flights select from flights means I
want to select data from the flights
table and this star is a wild card that
here just means that select all of the
possible columns that you can and so if
this is my table my table of flights
where each flight has an ID An Origin a
destination and a duration then select
star from flights we'll select all of
that data all of the rows and all of the
columns are going to come back to me
when I run a query like this
now it's possible that when I'm running
these queries when I'm accessing data
that I don't actually care about all of
these columns especially if I have a
table with many more columns than just
this maybe I only care about particular
columns and it would be wasteful to
query the database asking it to return
to mean a whole lot more data than I
actually need so instead I could run a
query like this
select instead of star I'm saying select
origin comma destination from flights so
I'm again selecting from the flights
table selecting all of the rows of still
but the difference is that instead of
Select star which means select all of
the columns that are present in the
table select origin comma destination
means I'm only going to select these two
columns the origin column and the
destination column so highlighted in
blue here is the data that would be
returned if someone were to run this
particular SQL query
now especially as tables begin to get
larger and begin to have more and more
rows here I just have six rows but you
might imagine a table with thousands or
even millions of rows within it you
probably don't want to be returning
every single row every single time so
just as you can constrain which columns
come back to you likewise you too can
constrain which rows come back to you
when you perform a query too so I could
say something like select star from
flight where ID equals three again this
reads it's very english-like I'm saying
select all of the columns from the
flights table but not all of the rows I
only want to select the rows where this
is a SQL keyword where ID equals three
ID is the name of a column three is the
value and it's going to look through to
this table only find me the flights
where the ID is equal to three and I'll
just get back that one row as a result
it finds the row with an ID of three and
it gives that back to me
If instead I said select star from
flights where origin equals New York I
can see that I don't just need to filter
on the primary key the ID I can also
filter on any other column I can say
give me all the flights where New York
is the origin so all the flights leaving
from New York and you might imagine that
in New York's airport for example they
likely want some sort of query that's
going to find all the flights leaving
from New York such that they can display
on a screen of some sort all of the
departures from that particular airport
so you could run a query like this and
get back only the rows in this database
inside of this table that happen to have
an origin of New York for example
so let's go ahead and take a look at how
we might actually run some of these
queries inside of a SQL database so in
order to create a SQL Lite database
which is really just a file I can start
just by creating the file and it turns
out that in the terminal there's a
command called touch that will create a
brand new file for me so I'm going to
create a file called
flights.sql it's going to be a sqlite
database file that by default has
nothing in it but then assuming you have
sqlite installed I can run sqlite 3
followed by flights.sql
and now I'm inside of the sqlite prompt
I can now begin to write commands that
will be executed on the SQL database
so one thing I might do is create a
table
called Flights
this table I want to have in ID column
which is an integer it should be the
primary key the main wave which I
identify a flight and I would like to
Auto increment it
I would also like for the flights table
to have an origin which will be a text
field that is not null
I'll add a destination field also a text
and then finally I'll add a duration
field which is an integer that also
shouldn't be null I'll end with an end
parenthesis and a semicolon press return
and that executes that command on my
database I have now created a table
called Flights and to verify this in
sqlite in the prompt I can type dot
tables and that will show me all of the
tables that currently exist in my
database and it just so happens that I
have a table called Flights
of course there's nothing inside this
table which I can verify by running
select star from flights meaning get all
the data from the flights table if I
press return all right nothing happens I
don't see anything there's no data that
happens to be here but now I could say
something like insert into flights
then I'll provide in parentheses the
names of the columns and on the slide a
moment ago I showed this on multiple
lines that was just for visual sake this
command can be entirely on one line if
we would like it to so I can say origin
destination and duration and then
provide values I can say let's add New
York
to London
and I'd like for this flight to B
duration of 415 minutes
so I press type in that command press
return that adds a new row to my flights
table and I can verify this by running
select star
from flights
and I see that now I have this table
whose ID is one that's the ID column
from New York to London with a duration
of 415 minutes and I could do this again
and again and I in advance prepared a
couple of insert queries just to give us
a little bit more data each of this is
just a different insert query
that's going to add one new flight into
our database so I'll go ahead and copy
those and then into the database I'll go
ahead and paste in all these insert
commands to insert a whole bunch of
flights into this database
and now if I run select star from
flights what I get is all of the flights
and this is not formatted particularly
nicely sqlite has some additional tricks
if you'd like to format it a little
nicer so I can say go ahead and put this
into columns mode and give me some
headers yes so header dot headers
yes and now if I select star from
flights the data is organized a little
more nicely where things are really into
columns and their headers for each of
the rows where I can see that all right
I kind of have a text based
representation of what I was displaying
graphically a moment ago that inside of
my flights table I have four columns an
ID column origin destination and
duration each flight is just one of the
rows that's inside of this table
and now I can begin to run additional
select queries if I want to do something
like select star from flights
where origin equals New York
well then instead of getting back all of
the flights I'm only going to get back
the flights where the origin is New York
so I can very quickly filter down on
this data only getting the information
that I actually care about taking a look
at and there are other ways of
interacting with sqlite as well but this
sqlite prompt is a very direct way of
just being able to write a query very
quickly and see the results of that
query
so it turns out there are other types of
queries we can run as well so we'll take
a look at some others we don't just need
to say where something equals something
else other types of Boolean expressions
are allowed as well so I could say
something like select star from flights
where duration is greater than 500 where
the idea here is all right let's look at
the duration column it's an integer so
we can do arithmetic Expressions on
these values I can take a value and see
is it greater than 500 or not and when I
do that what I get back is all of the
rows that have a duration that's greater
than 500 so I can begin to query not
just on whether one value equals another
value but also other types of
comparisons as well and much as in
Python is when we had Boolean
expressions in Python I could join
multiple Boolean Expressions together
using words like and and or SQL has the
same type of thing in its own query
syntax too I could say something like
select star from flights where duration
is greater than 500 and destination
equals Paris and as you might logically
Intuit this means this means get me all
flights that are going to Paris and that
take longer than 500 minutes and it
turns out there's only one such row
inside this table that satisfies both of
those constraints of course instead of
using and I could have also used or to
get a different query where now I'm
looking for all of the flights longer
than 15 minutes or longer than 500
minutes or the destination in Paris is
Paris so as long as either of those
conditions are met I'm going to get
results back and so when I get back are
some of the rows where the destination
is Paris some roads where the
destination isn't Paris but the duration
is more than 500 minutes and of course
any row that satisfies both of these
constraints in particular flight ID
number two that gets come to get this
resulted as well when I run this
particular query on this table
and there are other types of queries I
can perform in addition to that so I can
say something like select star from
flights where origin is in and then in
parentheses New York comma Lima to say
check if the origin is in this sequence
of possible values the sequence of New
York and Lima as long as it is one of
those two then I want for the results to
come back and so then you'll get back
rows that have an origin of New York
rows that have an origin of Lima as well
so you can begin to construct more
sophisticated queries that are able to
check for whether an origin is in a list
of possible values or even if it matches
a particular pattern that maybe you know
that one of the columns looks a certain
way or is formatted according to a
particular structure but you don't know
exactly what the value is I could run a
query like select star from flights
where origin not equals but where origin
is like and then in quotation marks I
have a bit of a strange expression
percent a percent
this percent again stands for a wild
card and this time the wild card is
looking at the values of a particular
column in this case the value of the
origin column meaning the percent stands
for zero or more characters no matter
what those characters are we're looking
for some number of characters maybe zero
maybe more followed by an a followed by
some other number of characters maybe
zero many more maybe maybe more and
ultimately what this query is going to
do is look inside of the flights table
and get back to me all of the results
where there is an A in the origin as
long as there is an A in the origin
column it doesn't matter if there are
characters before it or characters after
it all of the rows that come back are
going to be the rows that just so happen
to have an A in it so lots of ways we
can begin to run select queries and
there are even additional functions you
can add to your select queries as well
where if instead of just selecting the
values of columns I want to compute the
average duration of a particular
category of flights or I want to count
how many flights that are coming out of
New York or I want to find the longest
flight that goes to London or the
shortest flight that goes to London or I
want to add up all of the durations for
a whole bunch of flights maybe they're
flights that are connected to each other
and I want to add up the total travel
time that my take SQL has a number of
built-in functions that allow us to
perform these sorts of calculations as
well
so a couple of different SQL commands
we've now taken a look at we've taken a
look at create table that allows us to
create a new table insert that lets us
add data to a table and then select
which lets us take data inside of the
table and retrieve it but of course
often when we're dealing with databases
the data doesn't just get added the data
changes in some way so we also need some
way of being able to update data after
it's already inside of our database and
to do that there's another query for
that which is an update command that we
can execute on our database and that
command looks something like this again
displayed on multiple lines but you
could put this entirely just on one line
SQL doesn't really care if you add line
breaks it just knows that when it sees a
semicolon at the end of the command that
is the end of this particular command
but here what I've said is use the
update keyword to say I would like to
update a table what table would I like
to update I'd like to update the flights
table
and then what would I like to do well
I'd like to set the duration equal to
430.
so whatever the value of duration
happens to be right now change it to 430
but of course I don't want to change it
to 430 for every single flight just as
in a select Clause I could say where
something equals something or where and
then some other Clause to specify where
I want the rows to be selected from
likewise to an update I can say set
duration equal to 430 where a particular
condition is true so here I'm going to
look through the flights table find
myself all of the flights where the
origin is New York and the destination
is London and for those rows I'm going
to update the value of the duration
column setting the duration column equal
to 430. so using that syntax I can take
data and update it changing one value to
another value by pinpointing which row
or rows I would like to change if I only
want to change one row I might do like
update flights set duration equal to
something where ID equals a particular
ID to be able to pinpoint one ID and
then take that row and make some
modification to it
and in addition to inserting data
selecting data and updating data the
last main command will concern ourselves
with is the ability to delete data the
ability to take a row and say I'd like
to get rid of it or take multiple rows
and get rid of them and so a command
like delete from flights where
destination equals Tokyo as you might
imagine deletes from the flights table
all of the rows satisfy this condition
where the destination is equal to Tokyo
so a number of different operations now
that we have the ability to do the
ability to delete from a particular
table where a condition is true the
ability to update a table based on
particular conditions the ability to
select data from a table and insert data
into a table as well and there are a
couple other Clauses that can be used to
add to SQL queries as well just to add
additional functionality if I don't want
all of the rows to come back from a
particular SQL query I can limit the
results that come back so normally
select star from flights would get me
all of the flights inside of the table
but I could say select star from flights
limit five to just say you know what I
only want Five results to come back from
the staple
order by allows me to decide how the
results are ordered inside the results
that come back so I could say select
star from flights order by destination
or order by duration to get all of the
flights in order by how long they are
Group by allows me to group a whole
bunch of rows together so if I wanted to
group all of the flights by their origin
so they can get all of the flights
leaving New York and all the flights
leaving London and so forth I could do
something like select star from flights
Group by origin to group flights by
their origin as well and having as a
constraint I can place on Group by to
say that I would like to select all of
the flights from the grouping them by
their origin but they need to have a
count of at least three meaning there
need to be at least three flights that
are leaving from that particular City
and for all of these particular Clauses
these are helpful to know if you're
going to be directly writing SQL we
won't worry about them too much here in
particular because fairly shortly we're
not going to be writing SQL ourselves
we're going to just be writing python
code and Django is going to under the
hood be manipulating the database and
creating the SQL commands that it is
going to run on the underlying database
and so we will see how we don't actually
need to worry about writing the specific
syntax but Django is going to handle
much of that for us
so here now we have a flights table a
table that keeps track of all the
flights that we have organizing them by
their ID and their origin and their
destination and their duration but
oftentimes when we're dealing with data
especially in a larger database we don't
just have one table of data we have
multiple tables of data and those
multiple tables might relate to each
other in some way and let's take a look
at an example of how that might come
about we're going to introduce a concept
that we'll call foreign keys and we'll
see what that means in just a moment
so here again is our flights table the
flights table has four columns an ID
origin destination and duration
but of course in New York there are
multiple airports in New York for
instance and so it might not make sense
for me to just label each origin or each
destination just by the name of the city
maybe I also want to give the three
letter airport code that corresponds to
the airport to which I'm referring in
this case and so how would I encode into
this table not only the origin but also
that City's airport code and not only
for the destination the name of the city
but also the airport code for that
airport as well well I could just add
more columns I could say something like
all right now we have this table that
has an ID
and origin in origin code a destination
a destination code and a duration but
here now the table is starting to get
fairly wide there are a lot of columns
here and in particular there's some
duplicate data that I've repeated my
mention of Paris is associated with this
particular three letter code and the
same thing for New York and other
airports as well there's some messiness
in the structure of this data and so
often what we'll want to do is we begin
to deal with data in larger and larger
sets with more and more columns is we'll
want to normalize this data separating
things out into multiple different
tables that just reference one another
in some way and so instead of just
having a single flights table what we
might consider doing is saying that
flights are one type of object but
another type of object that I care about
is like an airport and so I might just
have a separate table just for airports
where this table has three columns a
column for the ID of the airport just
some unique number that can identify a
particular airport one column for the
three letter code for that airport and
one letter for the city or one column
for the city where that airport is in
and now this is a much more
straightforward simpler representation
of all of the airports and the question
becomes what happens to my flights table
that my flights table that here had an
ID origin destination and duration
where the type of origin and destination
where in this case just text text-based
Data representing the name of the city
from which the flight is departing or to
which the flight is arriving well now
that I have this separate airports table
where every Row in the airports table
has its own unique ID then what I can do
in this case is instead of storing An
Origin and a destination as text
I can store what we'll call a foreign
key a reference to a key in another
table and rename these columns to origin
ID and destination ID that instead of
storing text are going to store a number
origin ID 1 means the origin of flight 1
is
whatever airport number one happens to
be and I could go to the airport stable
look up which airport has an ID of one
and that would tell me the origin of
this flight and if I went to the
airport's table and looked up which
airport had an idea for that would tell
me the destination of the slide as well
so by combining now two different tables
one table for representing airports and
one table for representing flights I'm
able to connect these two different
tables together by way of a foreign key
some columns inside of my flights table
namely the origin ID column and the
destination ID column that together
allow me to reference information stored
inside of another table as well and as
you imagine this sort of Airlines
database growing and storing more
different kinds of data the ability to
relate tables to each other is going to
become incredibly powerful so one thing
you might imagine is that in addition to
storing airports and storing flights an
airline probably also needs to store
information about its passengers like
who's on which flight
and so you could imagine constructing a
passengers table that has an ID column
to uniquely identify every passenger a
first name column that stores every
passenger's first name a last name
column for storing their last name and a
flight ID column for storing what flight
that passenger happens to be on so in
this case I could say that all right
Harry Potter is on flight number one I
could look that up in the flights table
to find out all right inside the flights
table here is where the flight is
leaving from where it's going to and
what its duration happens to be
now as we begin to design these tables
we have to think about what the
implications of that design happen to be
and in the case of this passengers table
it does seem that there is a limitation
on the table design that I have created
and namely if you think about it you'll
see the limitation of this table design
is that any particular row can only have
one flight ID associated with it that
Harry Potter has a single flight ID
column that can only have one value
stored inside of it and this would seem
to make it impossible to allow for us to
be able to represent a person that could
be on multiple different flights and so
this starts to get at the idea of
different types of relationships that
rows in a table can have to one another
one type of relationship is a many to
one relationship or a one-to-many
relationship where I can express the
idea that one flight can be associated
with many different passengers for
instance but what we might also want is
a many-to-many relationship where many
different passengers can associated with
many different flights a passenger might
have more than one flight a flight might
have more than one passenger and to do
that we're going to need a slightly
different structure for this particular
type of table
and one way we can approach it is by
creating a separate table for storing
people that I could have a people table
where every person has an ID has a first
name and has a last name same as before
but I'm no longer storing flight
information inside of the table I've
cleaned my setup up I'm only storing
people in this table and nothing about
their flight information and then I'll
have a separate table for dealing with
passengers on the flight and mapping
people to their flights and we can think
about what does that table need to look
like well I need some sort of table that
is going to relate people to what
flights they happen to be on so odds are
we're going to need one column that is a
foreign key that references this people
table and we'll need another column that
is a foreign key that references the
flights table such that I can relate
those two tables together and so that
table could look like this
this now is the simplified passengers
table that only has two columns it has a
person ID column and a flight ID column
and the ID of this table now is it's
known as an association table or a join
table that just Associates one value
from one table with another value from
another table that this row here one and
one means the person with an ID of 1 is
on flight number one and I could look up
that person inside of the perp people
table look up that flight inside of the
flights table and figure out who the
person is and what flight they're on and
down here two and four means whoever the
person with an ID of 2 is is on
whichever flight happens to have an ID
of four
and so this now has allowed us to be
able to represent the types of
relationships we want we have a table
for airports and a table for flights and
any flight is going to map to two
different airports one destination one
origin and any airport might appear on
multiple different flights it's sort of
a one-to-many relationship and then over
here when it comes to passengers we've
stored people inside of a separate table
and then had a many-to-many mapping
between people and flights so that any
person could be on multiple different
flights like here for example person
number two is on both flights one and
four and likewise a flight could have
multiple people so in this case flight
number six has passengers five and six
that are on that flight as well so we've
been able to represent those
relationships
of course a byproduct of doing this is
that now our tables are a little bit
Messier to look at and messy in the
sense that it's not immediately obvious
to me when I look at this table like
what data I'm looking at I see these
numbers but I don't know what these
numbers mean I've separated all these
tables into different places and now
it's a little harder for me to figure
out who's on which flight I have to look
at this data look up people in the
people table look up flights in the
flights table and somehow associate all
of that information back together in
order to draw any sort of conclusion but
luckily SQL makes it pretty easy for us
to be able to take data across multiple
different tables and join them all back
together and we can do this using a join
query that takes multiple tables and
joins them together so the Syntax for a
join query might look something like
this and here we'll go back to just a
two table setup where I have flights and
passengers where every passenger is
associated with one flight that you
could extend this and join multiple
tables to deal with our more complex
example as well but here I'd like to
select select every person's first name
and their origin and their destination
and I'm going to select that from the
flights table but I need to join it with
the passengers table and then I say on
to indicate how it is these two tables
are related to one another and in this
case I'm saying the way these two tables
are related to one another is that the
flight ID column of the passengers table
is associated with the ID column of the
flights table the flights table has an
ID that uniquely identifies every flight
and the passengers table has a flight ID
column that uniquely identifies the
flight that we're referring to for this
particular passenger and so the road
result I might get is a table that looks
like this that gives me everyone's first
name but also their origin and their
destination or origin and destination
are going to be drawn from that table of
flights and the first name is going to
be drawn from the table of passengers
but by using a join query I've been able
to take data from two separate tables
and join them both back together and
there are a number of different types of
drawing queries that I can run what we
saw here was just the default join which
is otherwise known as an inner join
where effectively an inner join will
take the two tables it will cross
compare them based on the condition that
I've specified and only return back to
me the results where there's a match on
both sides where we match a passenger's
flight ID with an ID in the flights
Table and there are various different
kinds of outer joins if I want to be
okay with the idea that maybe something
on the left table that I'm joining
doesn't match with anything on the right
or so maybe something on the right table
doesn't match with something on the left
but just know there are other types of
join queries that I can run as well
other strategies that can be helpful
when dealing with SQL tables are
optimizations we can make to make
queries more efficient and so one thing
we can do with our tables is to create
an index on a particular table and you
can think of an index as kind of like
the index in the back of a book for
example where if you wanted to be able
to search for a topic in a textbook you
could open the textbook and just Page by
Page look for every topic and just try
and find the topic you're looking for
but often what you'll be able to do if
the table has an index is go to the
index of the book find the topic you're
looking for and that will quickly give
you a reference for how to get to the
right page in question in an index on a
table operates in much the same way it
is an additional data structure that can
be constructed and it does take time and
memory to be able to construct this data
structure and to maintain it anytime you
update the data inside the table but
once it exists it makes querying on a
particular column much more efficient
that you can very quickly look something
up in the index and find the
corresponding rows that go along with it
and so here we could have a command like
create an index that we're going to call
name index on the passengers table and
in particular on the last name column to
say something like I expect that as I
query this table I'm pretty frequently
going to be looking up passengers by
their last name so I would like to
create an index on that table to be able
to more efficiently search for a
passenger based on their last name as
well
and so that's just a general overview of
what SQL syntax is all about a syntax
that we can use to be able to create
data tables inside of which restoring
rows of data where every row consists of
some number of columns and every column
has a type you have the ability to
create tables add data to them update
delete and get data out of those tables
as well but as we begin to introduce
these new technologies there are always
risks and potential threats that are
associated with those Technologies as
well and in SQL the key one to be aware
of is what's known as a SQL injection
attack a security vulnerability that can
happen if you're not careful about how
it is you actually execute your SQL
commands and so where might this come
about you might imagine for instance
that if a database has some number of
users you might be storing those users
inside of a database for instance in a
user's table where there's a username
column and a password column though in
practice you probably wouldn't want to
store passwords in clear text let's
imagine here for example that you are
storing usernames and passwords inside
of a table
and we have a login form for a website
that looks like this where you get to
type in your username and your password
and so someone types in their username
and password what might happen is that
the web application might look select
star from users where username equals
this particular username highlighted
here we're just going to substitute the
username right there and password equals
and we'll substitute the password over
there so someone tries to log into our
site like Harry logs in with a password
of one two three four five what we might
do is run the select query and say
select star from users where username is
Harry
and where the password is one two three
four five and our logic might be if we
get results back then that means there
is a user whose username is Harry and
password is one two three four five
and we can go ahead and sign that user
in
but imagine now what might happen if
instead the user who typed in a username
of hacker quotation mark dash dash seems
like a bit of a strange username to type
in and it doesn't matter what they put
in their password here now the result
might be that what they plug into the
username is where username equals hacker
and then the dash dash it turns out Dash
Dash and SQL stands for a comment in SQL
it just means ignore everything that
comes after it in the same way that in
Python you can use the hashtag symbol to
mean the rest of this line is a comment
and the compiler whoever's running the
program should just ignore it so
everything after the dash dash kind of
gets ignored and we've effectively been
able to bypass the password check that
someone could bypass a password check
and log into an account even if they
were unauthorized to do so so here the
vulnerability within the SQL syntax if
we're not careful about when we're
running SQL syntax we could be running
untrusted SQL commands that some hacker
some adversary has been able to plug in
to our program
so how do we solve this sort of problem
one strategy is to escape these
characters escaping just meaning add
some backslashes and just make sure that
SQL knows to treat these as a literal
quotation mark and a literal Dash and
not as like special SQL syntax of any
sort another strategy is to use an
abstraction layer on top of SQL so that
we don't have to write the SQL queries
at all and that's in fact what we're
about to do as we transition to the
world of Django to take a look at how
when we begin to use a web framework
like Django we now have the ability to
not worry about the nuances of the
syntax of SQL and just deal a little
more high level with what our models are
what are the types of objects that we're
dealing with and interacting with inside
of this application
one other concern worth noting about
with regards to SQL is the possibility
of race conditions and a race condition
is something that might happen anytime
you have multiple events that are
happening in parallel threads so to
speak that you have one thing happening
and another thing happening
simultaneously you might imagine that in
the case of social media sites where you
can like a post like an image on
Instagram or a tweet on Twitter for
example what would happen if two people
tried to like the same post at the same
time if we're not careful about how we
run those particular SQL queries there's
a potential for us to be able to get a
race condition problems where we end up
like trying to query for the number of
likes that a post has and then another
person tries to do the same thing and
there are conflicts when we try and
update it where the result might not be
what we would expect it to be and there
are a number of unexpected results that
can happen when we deal with problems
related to race conditions where
multiple things are happening
simultaneously how do we solve those
problems well one strategy is to sort of
place a lock on the database to say all
right well I'm working on this database
nobody else can touch this data let me
finish this transaction so to speak
finish working on this particular
transaction and making all the changes I
need to make to the database and only
after I'm done I can sort of release the
lock let someone else go ahead and
modify the database as well
the number of concerns to be aware of as
we begin dealing in this world of SQL
and trying to work with databases
so now that we've taken a look at the
syntax of SQL understanding how these
tables work how they're structured and
what it is that we can add to those
tables let's go ahead and turn our
attention in particular to Django models
which are a way of representing data
inside of a Django application because
where Django is really going to get
powerful in designing our web
applications is the ability to represent
data in terms of these models and so
we're going to go ahead and try and
create a web application that is going
to represent like what an airline might
want to store inside of its own web
application as well all right so the
first thing I want to do is create a
Django project so I'll go ahead and type
Django admin start project and the name
of my project will just be called
Airline I'm creating a project for an
airline's website for example I'll go
ahead and go into the airline directory
open that up in my code editor but
before I actually begin editing any code
remember that every Django project needs
to have one or more apps within it so
the first app that I'll create for this
Airline is I'll start an app for keeping
track of flights so keeping track of
flight related information like Origins
and destinations and durations and what
passengers are on those flights
when I create a new app first thing I'll
need to do is go into settings.pi inside
of Airline and go ahead and add this app
as an installed app right so flights is
now an app that I've installed
and then what I'll want to do is say go
ahead and go into urls.pi
which is again that table of contents
for all the URLs I can get to for this
particular web application I'll import
include because I want to do is when
someone visits the path of flights
something I'll want to take them to
flights.urls mapping them to the urls.pi
file that will be inside of my flights
application
of course now I need a urls.pi file
inside of my flights application so I go
into flights and create a new file that
I'll call urls.pi
and we can do
from.jango.urls import path from dot
import views and then my URL patterns
are going to go inside of this list
right here but before I begin dealing
with actual URLs the first thing I'm
going to want to do is create some
models models are going to be a way of
creating a python class that is going to
represent data that I want Django to
store inside of a database and so when I
create a model Django is going to figure
out what SQL syntax it needs to use to a
create that table but then B manipulate
that table selecting and updating and
inserting anytime I make changes to
those models and so here what I can do
is inside of every app that gets created
in this case called flights there's a
models.pi file one that we haven't
looked at before but this is going to be
the place where we get to Define what
models are going to exist for our
application every model is going to be a
python class and you can think of this
as having one model for each of the main
tables we care about storing information
about so let me Define a new class
called flight that is going to inherit
from models.model so I'm creating a new
class called flight that is going to be
a model
and then I need to provide inside of
this class all of the parameters that a
flight has what properties does a flight
have that I might want to keep track of
well a flight has an origin and the
origin is going to be a models.shar
field and this is all documented on
Django's website in terms of the various
different types of fields that exist
then I can include inside of a Django
model where here I'm saying all right
here is a character field whose max
length is going to be let's say 64. I'll
assume that most city names are not
going to go longer than 64 characters
that seems like a reasonable maximum
length for the origin of the flight for
example
every flight will also have a
destination which will be a character
field whose Mac length is also 64. and
every flight will have a duration which
will just be an integer field
so now this is my very first Django
model it is a class called flight where
I've defined all of the properties that
a flight has and then using Django
syntax to find what type they should
have as well every flight has an origin
has a destination and has a duration
but of course nothing here has actually
modified the database that Django is
using in order to store information
about my web application and we can see
if we in fact go back to Airline and I
type LS what you see here is that there
isn't yet a database that exists I just
have an airline directory a flights
directory and a manage.pi file
so what I'd like to do is somehow tell
Django that you should update the
database to include information about
the models that I have just created and
this is a process that we refer to in
Django and more generally as migrations
I create a migration to say here are
some changes that I would like to apply
to the database and then I migrate them
to tell Django all right take those
changes and actually apply them to the
database so it's a two-step process one
is creating the migration the
instructions for how to actually go
about manipulating the database and then
one to take that migration step of
saying now take those instructions and
actually apply them to the underlying
database
we can make the migrations via command
again we'll use the manage.pi script
that has a number of different commands
that allow us to control various parts
of the application I'll use
pythonmanage.pi and then make migrations
and now what we see is we've created a
migration inside of zero zero zero one
underscore initial.pi where in this
migration it's created a model called
flight and so if I go ahead and look at
the migrations directory I see this file
has been created for me I didn't have to
create it myself and what this file is
is it is instructions to Django for how
to manipulate the database to reflect
the changes I have made to the model
that here is an instruction to Django to
create a new model called flight that
has these particular Fields inside of it
and it's basing this off of the changes
that I made to models.pi the model that
I added is now reflected in this
migration
and now if I want to apply the migration
actually apply it to Django's database I
can run python manage.pi migrate to go
ahead and apply these migrations there
are a bunch of default migrations that
get applied as well but notice that one
of the migrations that gets applied is
this one here applying
flight.0001 underscore initial to say
let's go ahead and apply that migration
create that table that is going to
represent flights and if I type LS now
you'll see that now I have a db.sqlite3
file a sqlite database that is going to
contain a table that is going to store
all of my flights
and so how can I actually begin to
manipulate this data how can I interact
with these with these sorts of models I
could use direct SQL syntax by opening
up this database file and running
commands but Django provides some nice
abstraction layers on top of it so that
I don't actually need to execute those
commands myself I can begin to work more
generally with python classes and
variables and things that I'm used to
inside the Python language
so I can enter Django's shell where I
can just run python commands by running
python manage.pi shell
and what this does is open up a shell or
a console where I can begin to write
python commands that get executed on
this web application and the first thing
I'd like to do is from flights.models
let me just import flight
so flights is the name of my app models
is the name of that file I'm importing
the flight class from that models file
that I've just created and now what I
can do is I can create a new flight I
can say something like f equals a flight
whose origin is New York and whose
destination is London
in his duration equals 415 minutes and
then I can say F dot save to save that
new flight that I have created and this
syntax now and I'll go ahead and make it
a little bit bigger so we can see it a
little easier is my way
of inserting data into this table I
don't need to use an insert query in SQL
I just have to write a python command
and Django knows that when I create a
new flight and save it that it should
run an insert command on the underlying
SQL tables where here I've created a new
flight with this particular origin and
destination and duration and I've gone
ahead and saved that flight as well and
if I want to query that flight get
information about that flight I can say
something like
flight.objects.all is the equivalent of
like a select all get me all of the
flights that exist inside of my database
and here I see I get back a query set
which is just a set of results and here
I have one flight that came back flight
object one so a flight has been created
for me with id1 now flight object one
probably not all that helpful of a name
it'd be nicer if this model had a
cleaner way of seeing the name of a
particular of a particular flight for
example and it turns out we can do that
that any model I'll go back to the code
inside of models.pi
any model can Implement double
underscore stir function which returns a
string representation of that particular
object and this applies not just a
Django models but to python classes more
generally than if this function returns
a string representation of the object
let's go ahead and return a formatted
string that is self.id I'll say
self.origin to self.destination
so here what I've said is that the
string representation of any flight is
going to be a string that gives its ID
and then says all right origin to
destination just a nice clean name that
is going to represent this particular
flight
so now if I go back
to the Shell by running python manage.pi
shell I can say from flights.models
import flight
I can say all right let's let a variable
called Flights be equal to
flight.objects.all
and now flight is going to be this
flight flight 1 New York to London it
now has a much nicer string
representation of the name which just
makes it a little bit easier to interact
with if I wanted to get just that one
flight I can say flight equals flights
DOT first
slice is a query set first gets me that
first flight
and so now I have this flight from New
York to London
and just as in any python object I can
begin to access properties of that
object I can say all right flight what
is your ID flight what is your origin
flight what is your destination flight
what is your duration and I can access
as values all of the properties of this
flight that I ultimately care about and
if I want to delete the flight I can say
something like flight dot delete
now ultimately though this is not the
model that I actually want to represent
my flight because here again I'm using a
character field a Char field for things
like origin and destination when in
reality I probably like to use something
like another table for representing
airports and then some relationship
between every flight and an airport so
let's go ahead and try and Implement
that idea now that I can go back into
models.pi and create a new class
I'll create a class called Airport
that is also a model
and I'd like for this airport class to
have a code
which is a character field with a max
length of three for the airport's code
as well as a city which would be a
character field with a max length of 64.
and let's also give this airport a
string representation we'll say that the
string representation of an airport will
just be the city of the airport and then
in parentheses the code of the airport
so it'll be something like New York and
then in parentheses JFK to represent a
particular Airport
and now our flight model needs to change
a little bit no longer will origin and
destination be character fields that are
just throwing text but instead origin is
going to be a foreign key a foreign key
that references another table like the
airport table
and then I can provide some additional
arguments so this alone would be enough
but I can add some additional arguments
like on delete equals models dot Cascade
so what does this mean well when I have
tables that are related to each other
SQL needs some way of knowing what
should happen if you ever delete
something if I have a flight from JFK to
London and I later in the later in time
decide to delete JFK Airport from my
database what should happen to that
flight like what happens to flights when
the thing that it is referencing gets
deleted what models.cascade means is if
I were to ever delete an airport from
the airports table it's going to also
delete any of the corresponding flights
and there are other on delete parameters
you can set for saying like don't even
let me delete an airport if there are
flights that are leaving from or going
to that airport that's called
models.protect but there are other ways
of implementing similar types of
constraints
and the other argument that I'm going to
provide is what's called a related name
and a related name as we'll see in just
a moment is going to be a way of me
accessing a relationship in the reverse
order that from a flight I can take a
flight and say dot origin to get the
flight's origin in airport but the other
question I might want to ask is in the
reverse order if I have an airport how
do I get all of the flights that have
that airport as an origin and so here if
I give a related name to this foreign
key Django will automatically set up the
relationship going in that opposite
direction and so here well if we have an
airport and I want to know all of the
flights that have that airport as their
origin the reasonable name for a related
name here is something like departures
so if I have an airport I can access all
of the departures which gets me all of
the flights that are leaving from that
airport
and I'll likewise do the same thing here
for Destination instead of a character
field it's going to be a foreign key
it's going to reference airport when we
delete it we'll go ahead and Cascade it
and the related name will be arrivals
because if I have an airport I might
want to access all of the arrivals all
of the flights that correspond to
flights that are arriving at that
particular destination
and so now I've done two things I've
added a new class called airport and
I've modified my existing flight model
so this has changed in my python code
but it hasn't yet changed in my database
so in order to make the change in the
database again it's a two-step process
step one
pythonmanage.pi make migrations to say
look for any new changes that have been
made to models.pi
and go ahead and create a migration
instruction for how to make those
changes to the database
here we see that we've created
a new migration file and this migration
is going to create a model called
airport and it's also going to alter the
destination field and alter the origin
field on my flight model because as we
know we've changed destination and
origin to no longer be character Fields
but to instead be references to a
particular airport so that's something
that's going to need to change in the
database and to make that change I can
run something like python manage.pi
migrate to go ahead and apply those
changes we've now applied this migration
that we just created and our database is
now up to date
so what can we do well now I can go
ahead and go back into the shell
and I'll just go ahead and import from
flights.models import Star import
everything
and I can now create an airport I can
say something like JFK equals airport
whose code is JFK and whose city is New
York for example and then save that I
can create a London one so lhr is an
airport whose code is lhr and who city
is London and I can save that you know
you could create more I could say CDG
equals an airport whose code is CDG and
city is Paris and maybe we'll do one
more we'll say nrt is the airport whose
code is nrt and whose city is Tokyo for
example so I've created and saved four
airports that get added to my airport
table
and now I can add a flight f equals
flight whose origin equals JFK whose
destination equals London Heathrow and
whose duration equals 415 minutes and
I'll go ahead and save that
as well
so I've now created four airports I've
created a flight and saved it if I type
f just for my flight I see that all
right this is a flight from New York to
London but I can also say what is f dot
origin
and to write F dot origin that is now an
airport object it's JFK in particular
and I can do F dot origin dot City to
get the city of the origin which is New
York F dot origin dot code to get the
code of that airport which is JFK and if
I start with an origin something like
JFK or London Heathrow I can say lhr dot
arrivals to go ahead and Dot all to get
all of the arrivals all of the flights
arriving in London Heathrow and it looks
like there's just one of them which is
this flight that I've just created uh
from New York that is going to London as
well
and so this now gives us the ability to
manipulate SQL just by using these
python models and I now have python
classes that represent all of these
various different types of data and now
instead of running SQL queries like
select star from flights or from
airports I can just interact with these
classes and these properties on the
classes and Django takes care of the
process for me of figuring out what the
underlying SQL queries should be
executing those queries and just giving
those results back to me and we can
begin now to design a web application
around this idea that I can go into
urls.pi and let's add a URL pattern that
says you know the default route will go
ahead and load the index view give it a
name of index same as similar things
we've seen from last time
and now what should we do in the index
view well the index view let's go ahead
and say what I would like to do is just
display a list of all the flights so I
might from dot models import flight and
airport or maybe maybe I just need
flight I just want a list of all the
flights so I'm going to import flight
from all of my models and now what I'd
like to do is return let's go ahead and
render a template called flight
index.html
and give index.html access to a variable
called Flights and what is that variable
going to be equal to it's going to be
equal to
flight.objects.all to get me like all of
the flights that I would like to put
right here
all right so what can I do from now now
what I need to do is actually create
those individual templates so inside of
flights I'll create a new folder called
templates
inside of which I'll create a new folder
called Flights inside of which I'll go
ahead and create a layout.html much as
we've done before where that layout is
going to contain the basic structure of
our HTML page so a head section whose
title is flights
and a body section that is going to have
a block body
and the end of the block
much as before this is the default
layout for this particular page
and then I'll add a new template called
index.html that is going to extend
flight layout.html
and then inside the body of the page
I'm going to display an H1 that just
says flights and let's now create an
unordered list where I can now Loop over
for flight in flights
N4 to end the loop but inside the loop
let me create a list item where I just
print out like a flight maybe I'll print
the flight and then flight dot ID to
print out like flight one flight two
flight three and then I'll print
flight.origin to flight.destination
so what I've done here is create a
template that I'm going to give access
to a variable called Flights where
flights is going to be a variable that
represents all of the flights that I
query by running
flight.objects.org that is my way using
Django's API using the functions that it
has given me access to to say take the
flight and get all of the flights that
are stored inside of Django's database
then here in the template I'm looping
over each one of those flights for each
one printing on a list item where I can
access properties of that flight say
flight this ID from origin
to a particular destination
so now
I'll go ahead and go into my terminal
run python manage.pi run server which
again is how we run a Django web
application and now if I go to that URL
slash flights this time because that's
the URL what I see is exactly what I
would expect to see an unordered list
that just so happens to have flight 1
New York to London displayed there it is
taking data from my database and now
displaying it inside of this template
and if I were to add new flights it
would also update on this page as well
so if I go ahead and go back go into the
Shell pythonmanage.pi Shell I'll go from
flights.models import Star let's go
ahead and well all right let's add a
flight from Shanghai to Paris for
example well how do I get the airports
for Shanghai and Paris well it turns out
that if I want to get like Shanghai I
can say like Shanghai equals airport Dot
objects. and then I can say if I do
airport.objects.all
that gets me all of the airports for
example oh and it seems I don't actually
have a Shanghai one um but I can add one
if I wanted to but if I do
airport.objects.all that again gives me
all of them but if I want to filter my
Airport's list so not get all of the
airports but just get some of them I can
say airport Dot
objects.filter and I can say like get me
all the airports where
um the city is New York for example
and that is going to go ahead and give
me a query set that only contains the
results that I care about so again
airport.objects.filter lets me constrain
the results that come back not get me
all of the airports but only get me
airports whose city is New York for
example and it owns only giving back one
so I could say dot filter City equals
New York DOT first to say take that
query set and just get me the first and
only thing in that query set and that
gives me Airport New York a simplified
way of doing the same thing if you know
you're only going to get one result back
if I can say something like
airport.objects.get which will only get
one result if it knows that there's only
going to be one airport with the city of
New York that too will return to me New
York JFK Airport
but it will throw an error if ever
there's more than one or if there's none
for example so we'll go ahead and save
that inside of JFK and we'll go ahead
and create a flight that is going uh
from New York to Paris for example I can
do CDG equals
airport.objects.get City equals Paris
and now I have this variable CDG which
represents the airport Paris and if I
want to create a new flight that goes
from New York to Paris I can say f is
going to be a flight whose origin is JFK
whose destination equals CDG and whose
duration equals 435 and I can save that
flight as well and so I've added a new
flight
and so now if I run the server
pythonmanage.pi run server
refresh the page I now see that I have
two flights one flight that's going from
New York to London one flight that's
going from New York to Paris but of
course it's going to be pretty annoying
if every time I want to update the data
adding new data manipulating the data I
need to go into the shell in order to
run direct commands that are able to add
new flights add new airports so on and
so forth what I'd really like to be able
to do is just very simply to add it via
a web interface via the web be able to
say all right let me add a new flight
that goes from location one to location
two and it's possible using the
information we know now to build a web
page that does just this but Django is
built on this idea that it doesn't want
you the programmer to have to repeat
work that other people have already done
and this process of trying to Define
models and very quickly be able to
create and edit and manipulate models is
so common the Django has already built
for us an entire app that is just
designed for the manipulation of these
models and it's known as the Django
admin app and this is an app that we've
seen traces of already that if we
remember that urls.pi file
from inside of our application we saw
that we added a path for our own app but
there was already a path given to us by
default slash admin that takes us to the
admin app as well and so in order to use
the admin app we need to create an
administrative account inside of our
Django web application and the way to do
that is via the command line I can run
python manage.pi
create super user it's going to ask me
for my name I'll go ahead and type in my
username
my email address and it's also going to
ask for a password I can just make up a
password that I would like to use
retype it in just to confirm it and now
Django has created a super user account
for me in this web application so that I
using these credentials have the ability
to visit the web interface for the admin
app and actually manipulate some of
these underlying models
so in order to do this the first thing I
need to do is take my models and add
those models to the admin app so inside
of models.pi I have a class called
airport and a class called flight
and if we look at the files I have
there's another file we haven't really
looked at yet called admin.pi inside of
my app and inside of admin.pi I'll first
from my models import flight and Airport
and now I'm going to say
admin.site.register airport and
admin.site
dot register flight
and what this is going to do is it is
going to tell Django's admin app that I
would like to use the admin app to be
able to manipulate airports and to be
able to manipulate flights as well
and so let's take a look at this admin
app and see how it actually works I can
run python manage.pi run server
that will start up the web server I'll
now visit this URL instead of going to
slash flights I'll go to slash admin
and this opens up this Django
Administration app that's not written by
me Django has written this and it's
asking me to log in I'll go ahead and
log in using those credentials I used a
moment ago typing in my username and
password and what I get here is Django's
site Administration interface Built For
Me by Django where I didn't need to
design this at all but importantly if we
notice down here I now have the ability
to add and manipulate airports and
flights via this web interface this
Django administrative interface so now
using this interface I have the ability
to manipulate the underlying database to
manipulate my models to add and modify
data that already exists so if I click
on airports for example I see here here
all of the airports that I've already
added to my database Tokyo Paris London
and New York and I can add a new one I
can say let's go ahead and add PVG which
is Shanghai
and I can either save it save and
continue editing save and add another
I'm going to add a couple so I'll go
ahead and save and add another let's go
ahead and add Istanbul airport as well
let's add a Moscow that's an airport 2
and maybe one more we'll add Lima as
well and I'll just go ahead and click
save and now I've added a whole bunch of
airports all via this web interface
Django was originally created for like
news organizations that very quickly
wanted to be able to post articles and
post new posts on their website and it
made it very easy via an interface like
this to very quickly just say like here
add a new article and here's the content
of the article to be able to display in
a page and now we've been able to very
quickly add new airports to our website
as well and so if we want to add flights
well we can go ahead
and go back home
I'll click on flights I see that I
already have two flights inside of my
database I have New York to London and
New York to Paris I'll add a new one
it's letting me choose an origin
destination and duration and Django
knows that the origin must be an airport
so it's going to give me the opportunity
to just choose an airport where I can
say Okay Shanghai is the origin uh the
destination is going to be Paris and the
duration is going to be like 760 minutes
for example so now using Django's admin
interface I've been able to add a number
of different flights and a number of
different airports and if I go back not
to the admin app but to my flights app
the app that I wrote myself and go back
to flash flights now I actually see all
of the new flights that I have added to
my database via Django's admin interface
I added them to the admin interface and
now I see this flight from Shanghai to
Paris I see this flight from Paris to
New York as well
and so now what I might like to do is
begin to add some more pages to this web
application make this web application a
little more sophisticated by maybe
giving me the ability to like click on a
particular flight
to view details about that flight what
I'd like is for every flight to have its
own page not just slash flights for all
the fights but slash flight one for
flight id1 Flight 2 for id2 so on and so
forth what I can do in order to do that
is go back into urls.pi
and create a new path we'll create a
path where I'm going to specify a flight
ID which would be an integer when I do
let's go ahead and load the flight view
whose name will be flight
and now I need to just go to views.pi
and add a function called flight
so I'll go back go into views.pi in
addition to an index function we'll
Define a flight function that accepts as
an argument a flight ID
so now what is this flight function
going to do well the first thing I need
was actually need to do is actually get
that flight I can say flight equals
flight.objects.get me the flight whose
ID is equal to flight ID for example or
alternatively Django also lets you say
PK instead of ID is a more generic way
of referencing the primary key for
whatever the primary key happens to be
called the PK in this case is just the
ID but then what I can do is render
a template like flight flight.html
and pass as input to that the flight
so we're passing it this flight to
flight.html and now I can create a
template
create a new file called flight.html
which is going to also extend flight
layout.html using that same HTML layout
and inside the body of the page
let's just say something like
in big we'll say flight flight ID and
then maybe an unordered list where I can
say something like the origin is
flight.origin
the destination is flight.destination
and the duration is flight dot duration
so now I have a page that displays
flight information about any particular
flight and if I go ahead and load not
slash flights in my web browser but
flash flight one for example will now
have information about flight number one
and Flash Flight 2 gets me information
about flight number two querying for
that particular flight then printing out
its origin destination and duration now
there's some error checking that we
probably should do here if I try and
access a flight that doesn't exist
something like Flight 28 for example I'm
going to get some sort of error that it
does not exist there flight matching
query does not exist I might like to
control what happens in that situation A
little better so you might imagine
adding some additional error checking to
handle those cases as well but we'll
leave it at this just for now
but now let's go ahead and add the
ability not only to have flights that
have airports associated with them but
let's also add passengers to our flights
as well to be able to represent
passengers that might actually be on
these flights too
so I'll go ahead and go back into
models.pi
and in models.pi in addition to an
airport class and a flight class let me
create a new class called
passenger also going to be a model
and what properties does a passenger
have well passenger has a first name
which will go ahead and make a
models.char field
whose max length will put at 64.
and a last name
max length equals 64. and passengers
also as we described before they have a
many-to-many relationship with flights
that a flight could have multiple
passengers a passenger could be on
multiple flights and ultimately we need
an additional table to keep track of
this but we can think a little bit more
abstractly here in Django and just say
that every passenger has flights
associated with them which are a models
dot many too many field with flight so
every passenger could be associated with
many flights we'll say blank equals true
to allow the possibility that a
passenger has no flights maybe if
they're not registered for any flights
at all
and we'll also give this a related name
of passengers meaning if I have a
passenger I can use the flights
attribute to access all of their flights
and likewise if I have a flight I can
use this passengers related name to
access all of the passengers who are on
that flight and we'll see how that'll be
useful in a moment too
the string representation of a passenger
we'll just go ahead and be their first
name space their last name which feels
like a reasonable way of representing a
particular passenger and now I need to
apply these changes I need to say python
manage.pi make migrations because I've
made new changes to my model I've
created a model passenger in particular
and now if I do python manage.pi migrate
now I've applied those changes to my
actual database
and if I go into admin.pi so we'll go
into admin.pi and register not only
flight and airport but passenger
admin.site.registerpassenger
then now via the admin interface I can
manipulate passengers as well I can say
python manage.pi run server to run my
web server
go to my web server's admin view by
going to slash admin
go down to passengers and let's go ahead
and add a passenger
where I can say all right first name
Harry last name Potter and we'll go
ahead and put him on flight one and
flight three maybe he's on two different
flights for example and you can hold
down command or control to be able to
select multiple flights and we'll go
ahead and save that Harry Potter has
been added successfully and let's add a
couple of other passengers We'll add Ron
Weasley and we'll add another We'll add
Hermione Granger and we'll add Ginny
Weasley as well so we've added a number
of different passengers that now all
exist in Django's admin interface and
now what I'd like to do is on the flight
page display information about which
passengers happen to be on any given
flight so the way I might do that
is by going into views.pi
and on the flight page in addition to
giving access to the flight let me also
give it access to passengers so
passengers this template is going to get
access to and we get passengers by
saying flight
dotpassengers dot all and the reason we
can do this is again because passengers
is that related name it is our way of
taking a flight and getting all of the
passengers that happen to be on that
flight
and so now
inside of
flight.html I can add something like
let's add an H2 called passengers
where here I'm going to Loop for
passenger in passengers
go ahead and display
that passenger just print out that
passenger inside of a list item and in
Django I can say if the list is empty
let's just have a list item that says no
passengers meaning nobody is currently
on this flight
so now my web server is still running I
can go back to slash flights here are
all the flights
and if I go to slash flight one I now
see that on flight one Harry Potter is a
passenger on that flight but if I go to
Flight 2 all right no passengers are on
that flight either and now it's been a
little Annoying that I've had to do
everything by using the URL here to be
able to go back and forth between pages
I could link to those pages if I want to
and the way I might do that is let's on
the flight page add a link
that goes to the URL index
that says something like back to flight
list Maybe
so here's now a link that takes me to
the index View
and likewise I can go into index.html
and for each of these list items each of
these list items is really going to be a
link
that links to
it's a URL to a particular flight and
the flight route takes as a parameter of
flight ID and so inside this URL
substitution here I can specify use
flight.id as the ID of the flight that I
would like to use here
and so now I've put every single flight
inside of a link that takes me to the
flight route but because the flight
route requires as an argument the flight
ID I can specify the flight ID here
and so now if I go back to flash flights
I now see a list of flights where every
flight is in fact a link that can take
me somewhere else
and so now I can click on any one of
those links like New York to Paris and
that takes me to the flight page I can
click back to flight list that takes me
back to the flight list click on another
flight and go to that flight as well so
I've now been able to come up with this
way of linking these pages together by
having links in each of the various
different pages that take me to some
other route as well
[Music]
and so now what I might like to do is in
addition to displaying all the
passengers on any particular flight also
give myself the ability to add
passengers to a flight as well which
feels like a reasonable thing that I
might want to do inside of this web
application and so how can I go about
doing that well in order to do that I'm
going to need some new route that lets
me book a flight for a particular
passenger and so I'll go ahead and go
back to urls.pi
and inside of urls.pi I'll add a new
path that will be int flight ID slash
book
an in-flight ID slash book is going to
let me book a flight for this particular
flight ID for flight one or Flight 2 or
flight 3 or so forth
when I do we'll go ahead and go to the
book View and we'll name that book
and so now I need to implement the book
View
so how is this view going to work I'm
going to define a function called book
that is going to take this argument not
only the request but also a flight ID
the first thing as with before is I want
to get the flight ID but remember from
before that there are multiple ways that
I can request a web page I can request a
web page via the get request method
which means I would just like to get
this page or I can request a method via
post meaning I would like to send data
to the page and generally speaking
anytime you want to manipulate the state
of something especially manipulating our
database that should be inside of a post
request I'm submitting some form some
data and in response to that post
submission you should manipulate what's
going on inside of the database
so we're going to check when this book
route is called upon if request method
is post then we want to perform some
sort of action
flight in question is just going to be
flight.objects.gettheflight whose
primary key is that flight ID
and then what I'd also like to do is
associated with the form when someone
submits this form to like book a new
passenger on the flight they should tell
me what the ID is of the passenger like
what passenger should I book on this
flight because those are the two pieces
of information you need to know in order
to actually book a flight you need the
flight and the passenger information so
let's assume for now that the
information is going to be in request
dot post
and then in square brackets passenger
what this means is that the data about
which passenger ID we want to register
on this flight is going to be passed in
by a form with an input field whose name
is passenger the name on any particular
input field dictates what name we get
receipt what is received when a route
like this book route is able to process
the request from the user so we'll go
ahead and take that information and
because by default this might be a
string let's go ahead and convert it
into an integer just to make sure we're
dealing with an integer and let me say
that the passenger in question is going
to be passenger.objects.get
PK equals
this whole thing
so now what I've done is if the request
method is post meaning someone submitted
this form via the post request method
I'm first saying flights.objects.get to
get a particular flight get me the
flight with that flight ID
and then I'm getting a passenger which
passenger am I getting the one who's PK
their primary key otherwise known as ID
is equal to whatever was submitted via
this post form with a name of Passenger
and we haven't yet created that form but
we'll do so in just a moment now
ultimately we'll want to add some more
error checking to this as well like what
if someone requests a passenger that
doesn't exist or a flight that doesn't
exist either so there's definitely some
error checking that we probably should
be doing here but for Simplicity let's
just assume for now that we're able to
get a flight and get a passenger
well how do we access the passengers
flights I can just say passenger dot
flights and in order in order to add a
new item to Sunset like flights I can
just say passenger.flights.add
flight
and this will do the equivalent of
adding a new row into a table of keeping
track that the passenger is on that
flight but the nice thing about Django's
abstractions is that I don't have to
worry about those underlying details I
don't have to worry about what the
structures of the tables are I can think
at a much higher level and just say
take this passenger take their set of
flights and go ahead and add a new
flight to that set of flights
and when all that's said and done what I
probably want to do is return some sort
of redirect that redirects the user back
to the flight page so we'll go ahead and
return an HTTP response redirect
what URL would I like to take them to
well I'd like to take them to the flight
route and reverse again takes the name
of a particular View and gets me what
the URL is and we saw that last time
and the flight route takes an argument
so I need to pass as an argument the
flights ID
so I need to provide it to the flight
route what the flight's ID is structured
as a tuple and that is going to redirect
me back to the flight route so that I
can see that flight page again
and what I need to add up at the top
here is from django.http import HTTP
response redirect
in addition to from Django dot URLs
import
reverse
and so those I'll need to add as well so
that I can redirect the user back to the
flight page after they're done
submitting the form and reverse takes
the name of a particular view as defined
in urls.pi something like index or
flight or book and gets me what the
actual URL path should be and as we
talked about last time that's helpful so
that I don't have to hard code URLs into
my Django web application I can just
reference URLs by their name and If Ever
I need to change a URL I can just change
it in one place in urls.pi and that
change is going to reflect everywhere
else as well
so now the next thing I need to do is
actually create this form that what I
have so far is just a function called
book that is waiting for a post request
to be made to it and when a post request
is made to it then we're going to go
ahead and submit this form and go ahead
and add the flight for this particular
passenger but what I'd like to do now is
actually add that form
so I'll go back into templates go into
flight.html
and what I'd like to add here is a form
I'll go ahead and label it with an H2
called add passenger
and we'll create a form
whose action is going to be URL of book
so we're going to go to the book route
and again if we recall the book route in
urls.pi the the route with name book
this View
requires as a parameter some flight ID
so I need to provide the flight ID as an
argument for what flight I'm booking the
passenger on and it just happens to be
flight.id because this template has
access to a variable called flight
the method of this submission is again
going to be post
and recall from before that whenever I
have a form in Django I need to give it
the csrf token just for security to make
sure that Django knows it's really this
application that is submitting this form
we'll go ahead and add a drop down list
which you can create in HTML using a
select field the name of this select
field is going to be passenger
and the reason for that is inside of
views.pi when I get the passenger I'm
looking for inside the post data inside
of request.post for a field whose name
is passenger and so that is what I would
like the name of this drop down to be
and inside of a select drop down we have
a whole bunch of options options that we
can choose from and there's going to be
one option for everyone who isn't a
passenger on this flight
and so how do I get everyone who isn't a
passenger on the flight well it seems
that right now the flight page only has
access to actual passengers and doesn't
yet have access to people that are not
passengers on the flight
so it sounds like I need to add some
additional context to this template
additional information that we want
access to so I'll go ahead and give the
slight access to additional information
that we'll call like non-passengers for
people that are not on the flight
and how do I get non-passengers well
just as I could say
passenger.objects.filter to only get
passengers that match a particular query
there's also a way in Django to say
passenger.objects.exclude to say exclude
passengers that satisfy a particular
query so I want to exclude passengers
who among their flights have this as one
of their flights
and so what does this actually mean well
it means that when I render flight.html
there's a couple pieces of information
that it should have it needs to know
what flight is being rendered it needs
to know who is on the flight who are the
passengers but if I want a drop down
where I can choose from all the people
who aren't already on the flight like I
would like to register you for this
flight well I also need all of the
non-passengers passengers accept
excluding the ones who are already on
the flight and get me all of them is
what that dot all is ultimately saying
and so using that I now have access to
this variable called non-passengers that
I can use as I'm constructing this page
so back on flight.html I can say for
every passenger in non-passengers
let me create a option that I can choose
from
and the options value is going to be the
passenger's ID because ultimately when I
submit the form what I care about
getting is what is the ID of this
passenger that I've chosen from this
drop down but of course the user who's
looking at this page they don't want to
see people's IDs they want to see
people's names so inside of the option
tag we'll go ahead and just print out
the passenger's name
and we'll see in a moment what all of
this actually looks like in terms of
HTML so now that I've created this form
I'll also need at the bottom to add an
input whose type is submit to let myself
submit this form to
let's now try running this application
it looks like there's a slight error
where I said view.book instead of
views.book views is the name of the
module since it's in a file called
views.pi and now looks like my server is
running okay I can go back to slash
flights let me get one of the flights
like New York to London flight number
one
and all right name error name passenger
is not defined this is how Django
renders to me errors that are occurring
in IPython code looks like it just means
inside of views.pi I'm referencing
passenger but I never imported it so up
at the top I'll go ahead and import
passenger as well
now it seems that my web application is
working okay so now hopefully I refresh
this page I see flight information I see
passengers and I also down at the bottom
now see an add passenger section with a
drop down list where I can click on it
and see all right here are the three
people that are not already on this
flight and so if I want to add like
Ginny Weasley to this flight I can click
Jenny Weasley click submit and that
submits the form and I'm redirected back
to the same flight page now Harry and
Jenny are both on the flight and then
the add passenger list I see Ron and
Hermione that's the options for me there
and so using Django's models I've been
able to very quickly build up a
reasonably sophisticated application an
application that has models that
displays that information to me and lets
me manipulate that data and that data is
ultimately stored inside of a SQL
database and one of the big powers of
Django that it really gives to me is
this admin interface that I ordinarily
might have had to spend a lot of time
designing a web interface that just lets
me do things like take some person and
go ahead and update like what is their
name what flights are they on and the
ability to very quickly add and delete
and edit the models is something that in
a web application could take quite a lot
of time to be able to build from scratch
but Django very fortunately
gives all of that right to me and this
admin interface even though it is
designed by Django it's very
customizable in terms of things that I
can do on this admin interface if I want
to manipulate it in certain ways in
order to add additional features to it
as well so we'll see a couple brief
examples of this if I go into admin.pi
here is my configuration for Django's
admin interface and I can say I would
like to configure the admin interface in
a particular way that in a flight for
example by default all I saw was like
the flight's origin and destination if I
want to be able to see more information
about a flight I can say go ahead and
give me a class called flight admin
which is going to be a subclass of model
admin where I can specify any particular
settings that I want to apply to how the
flight admin page is displayed so I can
and all this is documented on Django's
website and you just have to read it to
be able to know what configuration
options are available to you but I can
say in the list display when you list
all the flights and display them all to
me what Fields should I have access to
we'll go ahead and show me something
like the origin and the destination and
the duration and maybe also show me the
ID for example so I want to see all of
this information when you load a flight
and when I register the flight I'll say
register this flight but use the flight
admin settings when you do so so I can
specify I would like to use these
particular settings when you view the
admin interface
and so now if I go back and go ahead and
click on flights then now in this list
display whereas before I only saw IDs
and Origins and destinations now I can
configure it to show me all of the IDS
and Origins and destinations and
durations as well I've been able to
configure this display to work the way I
would like it to and there are other
configurations you can do as well one
that I quite like to use is if I want to
update my passenger admin so when I'm
editing a passenger you can have a
special way of manipulating many to many
relationships inside of an attribute
called filter horizontal
and if I use a horizontal filter on
flights this will just make it a little
bit nicer for manipulating the flights
that a passenger is on and again the
specific syntax of this not as important
as the idea that these are all just
configurable settings that Django has
documented that you can look at to see
how to configure the admin interface to
work exactly the way you want it to work
and so now if I go back home
and go to passengers and maybe click on
a passenger like Harry Potter
I now see this horizontal filter which
is a very nice way of being able to
manipulate flights that the person is on
I see on the left list of their
available flights that I could add them
to on the right a list of their chosen
flights flights that they're already on
and it becomes very easy for me to just
take a flight and double click on it to
Move It from an available flight to a
flight that they're on and vice versa
just very quickly being able to control
and manipulate these models and this is
all stuff that Django just gives to you
right out of the box
so Django now has given us a lot of
features the ability to represent models
very succinctly a migration method for
being able to very quickly apply those
changes to our database and the last
thing we'll take a look at is this idea
of authentication that on many websites
we want some method of authentication
some ability for users to be able to log
in and log out for Django to remember
who a particular user happens to be and
what we're going to do now is introduce
an application that lets us interact
with this authentication method because
Django has a whole bunch of
authentication features built right into
the framework that we can take advantage
of so that we don't need to rewrite all
the logic for how do you log someone in
and what does it mean to represent a
user Django has done a whole lot of that
for us so we'll go ahead and create an
application to do that now all right so
let's go back into my terminal now and
now I have this Airline project inside
of which is one app called Flights and
I'd like to now create another app
that's going to maintain users inside of
this application so I'll go ahead and
run python manage.pi start app users
which just be an app that's going to
allow me to represent users as of before
when I create a new
application I'll need to go into
settings.pi add users as one of the
installed apps inside of this project
and they'll go into urls.pi to say I'd
also like when I go to like users
we'll go ahead and include users.urls
so all the URLs that are associated with
my users application now I'll need to
actually create those URLs so I'll go
ahead and go down into my users
application create a new file called
urls.pi inside of which is the same as
what we've normally seen inside of these
URLs files I need to import path import
My Views and then Define some URL
patterns
where here what I'd like to do is Define
One path
that takes me to views.index
and we'll call this one index
then I'll create another path that takes
me to login
called the login View
and the name will be login
and we'll have another path called log
out
for a function called logout view that
will be associated with it so we'll
effectively have three different routes
one main index route that's just going
to display information about the
currently signed in user one route for
logging someone in a form that will
display the place where they can type in
a username and password to log in and
then one route to allow users to be able
to log out from this application as well
so let's go ahead now and actually write
these functions we need one function
called index one function called login
view one function called log out View
so I'll go into views.pi and we'll start
with index
and so what does the index function need
to do it's going to display information
about the currently signed in user that
I sign into this website and then I'm
presented with the index page
but as we think about this
programmatically we first need to think
about what should happen if someone
tries to access this page but they're
not authenticated how would we even find
that out and what do we do in that
situation well let's say if not
request.user DOT is authenticated the
request object that gets passed in as
part of the request to every user in
Django automatically has a user
attribute associated with it and that
user object has an is authenticated
attribute that tells us if the user is
signed in or not if they're not signed
in we'll go ahead and HTTP response
redirect them
to the login View
and in order to make this work I'm going
to need to from django.http import HTTP
response redirect and likewise from
django.urls let's go ahead and import
reverse as well so if the user is not
authenticated then we're going to
redirect them to the login view where
what is the login view going to do
well the login view for now let's just
go ahead and render
users
login.html some form where the user can
log themselves in
we'll need to create some templates I'll
create a templates folder inside of
which is a users folder inside of which
we'll just create a basic layout as
we've done multiple times now
this is again going to be the general
structure for pages in this app title
will be users and the body will just
have a block called body that I can
later fill in with other content
and now that I have this HTML layout I
can go ahead and create a new file
called login.html where login.html will
extend users
layout.html and inside the body block
I can just display an HTML form so I can
say something like I would like for
there to be a form whose action when I
submit the form let's go ahead and still
go to the login URL
but let's do so using the post request
method again I'm logging in I'm
submitting a form generally when you're
doing that you want to submit form data
via post especially in the case of
username and password because if you do
this sort of thing you don't want the
username and password to be passed in as
get parameters because those show up in
the URL
our form will have our csrf token for
security as before
an input whose type is text whose name
is username and just for user
friendliness let's give it a placeholder
also of username so the user knows to
type in their username here
we'll also have an input whose type is
password whose name is also password and
when an inputs type is password that
just means our HTML will know in the
browser that Chrome or Safari or whatnot
will know to show the password as dots
instead of as characters
and we'll give that a placeholder of
password
and then an input of type submit
whose value is log in so we now have the
ability to log in
so if we go ahead and run this program
python manage.pyrun server we should see
users.views has no attribute login view
all right it looks like I called this
function login request it should
actually be called login View and I'll
also need a function called log out view
but I haven't implemented that yet so
I'll just go ahead and say pass for now
but I'll come back to that later to
implement the logout View
all right so it looks like my web server
is running now and before I actually go
to the login page let me first go back
to the admin page and actually just
create some users I can go to users and
then add and let's add a user the
username will be like Harry for example
and we'll go ahead and give Harry a
password and we'll go ahead and save and
add another let's add maybe Ron as well
uh go ahead and add him we'll go ahead
and save that and these users they can
have additional information associated
with them I can give Ron a name like Ron
Weasley Ron Weasley example.com this is
email address there are a bunch of
default fields that Django gives you for
manipulating users and you can take
these users and go ahead and add to
those fields if I want to giving them a
first name last name email address and
whatnot
and you can also customize these fields
as well if you'd like to add custom
fields that you would like to keep track
of with regards to your individual users
and I will go ahead and log out from
Django admin now because I don't need it
anymore
but now if I go to slash users I'm not
authenticated so what I see is a login
form that just looks like this a place
for me to type in a username and a
password and of course now you can type
in like Harry's username and password
but I haven't yet implemented the
processing of that data yet so let's go
ahead and do that now
we'll go ahead and go back to views.pi
in the login view there are two ways the
login view function could be called one
is via the get request method meaning
just show me the login form and one is
via post submit data to the login form
as well so if the request method is post
well then let me first get the username
which will be inside of the post data in
a field called username and let me get
the password which will be in a field of
in the request.post
inside of password
and now what I'd like to do is try to
authenticate this user and how do I go
about doing that well it turns out there
are a couple of functions that Django
has given to me that I can import so
from
django.contrib.off auth for
authentication I'm going to import three
functions we're ultimately going to use
one is authenticate that checks if
username and password are correct one is
called login one is called log out
and I can now use those functions inside
of this login view here after I've
gotten the username and password I'd
like to authenticate the user check if
the username and password are correct so
I'll go ahead and say user is equal to
authenticate request username is the
username password equals password and so
authenticate as a function just takes
the request takes a username takes a
password and if the username and
password are valid they give me back who
the user actually is and as long as the
user is not none
that means the authentication was
successful and I can go ahead and log
the user in how do I log the user in I
use the login function that Django gives
me logging in with this request this
user
and now I can go ahead and redirect them
HTTP response redirect the user back to
the index route back to the original
route that the user started out as and
so that's if the user is not none if the
authentication was successful but
otherwise if the authentication failed
what should I do well let me go ahead
and render the same users login page
again but let me add some additional
context the context will be a message
that says invalid credentials
and now inside of login.html I can just
add some logic that says if there's a
message then go ahead and display that
message inside of a div
and then endif to end that so if there
is a message we'll see the message
printed otherwise we won't see it at all
so now if I go ahead and refresh the
login page nothing seems to have changed
but let's say I type in a username that
doesn't exist Hermione and some password
and I log in well then I get this error
message invalid credentials we were not
able to log the user in
so what happens if we do successfully
log in well then the user is going to be
taken to
this index route and it looks like now
we need to finish off this index route
what does the index route do well let's
go ahead and return render a template
called users slash user.html
and inside of user.html
we'll go ahead and display some
information about the user we'll still
extend user slash layout because we're
going to use the same basic layout
but in the body of this page the
information I want to show is I want to
say like welcome and then like Harry or
welcome Ron or whoever the user happens
to be
and it turns out inside of Django
templates I have access to the request
that was used to make this HTTP request
which means I also have access to
request.user who is the user associated
with that request and if the user has a
first name I can access
request.user.firstname
and in addition to that I can display
other information maybe like their
username is
request.user.username and maybe their
email address is
request.user.email and so I can show the
user information about them such that if
like Harry logs in for example I sign in
as Harry sign in with Harry's
credentials
click login
well then Harry sees a page that says
welcome Harry Harry is logged in they
are request.user and using that
information we can access first name
username and email as well just by
accessing properties of request.user
now last thing we need to add which
still doesn't yet exist is a way to
actually log the user out and it turns
out that just as Django has a login
function Django also has a logout
function that handles logout for us so
we don't need to implement it ourselves
so all our logout view needs to do is
make a call to this logout function and
then figure out where should the user go
after they've been logged out and you
know what let's go ahead and take them
back to the login page
with a message of logged up to indicate
that the user has now been logged out
then in user.html we'll go ahead and add
a link that will go to the logout route
that just says
log out for example
so now when Harry goes back to Harry's
page Harry sees a URL that says log out
if Harry clicks log out Harry gets
logged out is brought back to this page
because now
request.user.is authenticated is going
to be false there is no authenticated
user and so they now see just the
default login page and if now Ron were
to log in for example using Ron's
username and Ron's password
logging in then Ron nasi's information
associated with him as well so Django
gives us a lot out of the box gives us
the ability to represent these models
and admin interface to be able to
manipulate them a migration system that
allows us to very quickly make changes
to our models and apply them to our
database and also a built-in user
authentication system A system that
allows us to very quickly enable users
to be able to log in log out from our
web application as well so all of this
are features that just helps to make it
so that we can very quickly take
advantage of things like SQL and models
and migrations to build Dynamic
interesting web applications with data
to back them up this was web programming
with python and JavaScript we will see
you next time
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone to web programming
with python and JavaScript and today we
turn our attention to the second of the
main programming languages that we'll be
looking into this class in particular
JavaScript and to get an understanding
for why it is that JavaScript is
actually helpful let's go back and
revisit this diagram of what
communication over the internet will
generally look like oftentimes we'll
have a user otherwise known as the
client using their computer on their web
browser whether that's Chrome or Safari
or some other web browser that sends an
HTTP request a web request to some sort
of web server that server then processes
that request and then returns some sort
of response that comes back to the
client thus far all of the code that
we've written the python web application
code running in a Django web application
for example has all been code that runs
on some sort of server code that is
listening for requests doing some
computation in order to process that
request and then generating some sort of
response usually in the form of an HTML
template that we then send back to the
client what JavaScript is going to
enable us to do is to begin to write
client-side code JavaScript is going to
allow us to write code that actually
runs inside of the user's web browser on
the client and this can be useful for a
number of reasons one if there's
computation that we want to do but we
don't need to go out and reach out to a
server in order to do so we can do the
computation potentially faster just by
running the code exclusively on the
client and in addition to that we can
begin to make our web pages a whole lot
more interactive JavaScript is going to
give us the ability to directly
manipulate the Dom where again the Dom
is the document object model that
tree-like hierarchy that represents the
web page that the user happens to be
looking at so JavaScript will enable us
to write code that directly manipulates
the content on the web page and we'll
see how that can be quite powerful very
soon so how do we then use JavaScript
inside of a web page in order to add
some code add some programming logic to
a web page well so far we've already
seen HTML the language we use to
describe the structure of a web page
where an HT tml page just describes the
structure of a page in terms of nested
tags we had those head tags at the top
of the page the body tags that describe
the structure of the page and then
additional tags that could be nested
within those and in order to add
JavaScript to a web page it's as simple
as including some script tags that are
often located inside of the HTML page
itself when we use these script tags
we're telling the browser that anything
in between these script tags should be
interpreted in this case as JavaScript
code that the web browser is then going
to execute so our very first program for
example might just look like a line of
code inside of those script tags
something like this where alert for
example is the name of a function a
function that's going to produce an
alert and then just as it functions in
Python functions in JavaScript can take
arguments so in between these
parentheses we have an argument
something like the string hello world
the text that we would like to display
to the user so let's go ahead and give
this a try and see how we can actually
use this code to write JavaScript that
is going to run inside of the user's web
browser I'll go ahead and create a new
file that we'll call hello.html
and inside of it I'll include
the same basic HTML structure that we've
already seen before where I have a head
section that has a title and then a body
that maybe just says hello for example
and so now what I'd like to do is add a
little bit of JavaScript to this web
page so in the head section of my web
page I'm going to go ahead and add a
script tag we're in between these script
tags now I can write JavaScript code
code that is going to be written in
JavaScript that will run inside of the
web browser when the user actually opens
up this page and for now I'll just say
alert
and then hello world it turns out in
JavaScript you can use either single
quotation marks or double quotation
marks in order to represent strings I'll
generally use single quotation marks
here just by convention
so here I'm running a function called
alert that's going to display an alert
something like Hello World to the user
and that's going to be inside of the
script tags of this HTML page
so now if I want to actually open the
page up I can open hello.html or you can
just visit it inside of your web browser
whether it's Chrome or something else
and now at the top of the page what
you'll notice is that I get a little bit
of an alert some interaction where it
says this page says hello world and it
gives me an option to like press a
button for example like hello like the
OK button that'll say all right dismiss
the alert now and this is our very first
example of JavaScript we have a function
called alert built into JavaScript for
our web browser and our web browser
knows that when we call the alert
function the browser should display an
alert message that looks a little
something like that and if I click the
OK button to dismiss the alert then we
go ahead and get back the original page
that I had from the beginning
and so now we can begin to imagine that
using this ability to programmatically
display alerts that we can add
additional features to our applications
as well and one big area where
JavaScript can be quite powerful is with
event driven programming and what event
driven programming is all about is
thinking about things that happen on the
web in terms of events that happen what
are some examples of events events are
things like the user clicks on a button
or the user selects something from a
drop down list or the user Scrolls
through a list or submits a form
anything the user does can generally be
thought of as an event and what we can
do with JavaScript is add event
listeners or event handlers things that
say when an event happens go ahead and
run this particular block of code or
this function for example and using that
we can begin to allow our JavaScript
code to respond to how the user is
actually interacting with our web page
to say when the user clicks on a button
I would like to run this particular
JavaScript function for example
so let's go ahead and give that a try
I'll go ahead and now instead of just
saying alert hello world let me put this
alert inside of a function and to create
a function in JavaScript you just use
the keyword function followed by the
name of the function I'll call the
function hello for example and then in
parentheses any inputs that function
takes this hello function is not going
to take any input so I'll just use an
empty set of parentheses and then inside
of curly braces I include any of the
code that I want to run in this function
and so what I've done here now is create
a function called hello and then inside
of the curly braces I've defined the
body of the function what code should
run when I run the hello function and
what the hello function should do is it
should display an alert that in this
case says hello world
so now what I'd like to do is get this
function to run when something happens
on the page for example when a user
clicks on a button so to do that the
first thing I'll need to do is actually
create a button so add a button that
just says like click here for example
so now if I refresh this page
I now see that I have hello and I also
have this button that says click here
but when I click here like nothing
happens I'm clicking the click here
button but it's not changing anything
because I haven't yet said what should
happen when the user does click on this
button and so one way we could do this
is by adding an attribute to this HTML
element
called on click what this is going to do
is it's going to add an on click Handler
to this button it's going to say what
should happen when the user clicks on
this button and I'm going to set the on
click attribute equal to
running the function hello and in order
to run a function in JavaScript just as
you ran a function with python you use
the name of the function followed by a
set of parentheses to say go ahead and
actually run this function using those
parentheses calls the function another
word for running the function and the
fact that there's nothing in between the
parentheses means we're not providing
anything of input to the hello function
though if the hello function did take
inputs we could certainly add that in
between the parentheses
so now I've tied the two pieces of this
page together I have a button that says
click here and I've added an on click
Handler that says that when you click on
the button you should run the hello
function and then up above I've defined
the hello function to say what should
the hello function do well when the
function is called we're going to
display an alert then in this case says
hello world
so now we should be able to refresh the
page
we still see the same thing at least
initially where it just says hello and a
button that tells me to click here but
now if I go ahead and click the button
that says click here
well then I get the alert that says this
page says hello world I can press OK and
this event handler is always going to
work I click the button again and I get
the alert a second time because every
time I click the button it's going to
call the hello function again and when I
click the hello when the hello function
runs it is going to display this
particular alert
so this now appears to give us a fair
amount of power and much as in other
programming languages languages like
python or other languages you might have
worked with JavaScript has all these
same types of language features so far
we've seen data types things like a
string but we also have other data types
that we'll take a look at soon too we've
seen functions some functions that are
built into JavaScript like the alert
function and other functions that we can
write for ourselves functions like hello
but we also have the ability to include
things like variables inside of our
program as well so what might that look
like
I'll go ahead and create a new file the
we'll call counter.html
and counter is going to have some of the
similar code to hello so I'll just go
ahead and copy it for now but I'll clear
out the script section change the title
from Hello to counter
and now
inside of get rid of the button or
actually I'll keep the button but
instead of saying click here the button
is going to say count I'd like to create
a program that just counts for me from 0
to 1 to 2 3 4 so on and so forth
and now in order to do that in order to
have some way of counting repeatedly
zero one two three four five I'm going
to need to have some sort of variable
inside of my program something that is
keeping track of data like the number
that I'm currently have counted to so in
order to do that in JavaScript I can say
something like let counter equal zero
this is the way in JavaScript that I
Define a new variable I first say let
counter meaning let there be a new
variable called counter and I'm going to
initially set the value of counter equal
to the number zero
and now when I click on the button
instead of running the hello function
I'm going to go ahead and run the count
function
which doesn't exist yet but I'll now
write it I'll Define a function called
count
and what the count function is going to
do
is it is going to first increment the
value of counter and a number of ways I
could do that one is by saying counter
equals counter plus one to say go ahead
and reset the value of counter to
whatever counter is plus one and there
are a couple of shorthand notations for
this I could equivalently say counter
plus equals one to say add 1 to the
counter or in the case of adding one
JavaScript much like languages like C if
you've seen them before support notation
like this counter plus plus which just
means take the value of counter and
increment it add one to it so I'll add
one to the value of counter and then
I'll just display an alert
that has whatever the current value of
counter happens to be
and so I've incremented the value of
counter and then displayed an alert that
shows me what's contained inside of
counter
and so now
if I go ahead and not go to hello.html
but to counter.html instead I now see
that I still see a button that says
count and if I click on that button I
get an alert that this time says one
we've incremented the value of counter
from zero to one the alertness has one
and I can press ok
if I press count again the count now
goes to 2.
I press OK press count again it goes to
three and every time I click count it is
going to increment the value of the
variable counter inside of my JavaScript
web page and then it's going to display
an alert that is going to contain the
value of that variable so using alerts
now we're able to manipulate that we can
inside of functions manipulate the
values of variables and then display
alerts that show the contents of those
variables But ultimately when users are
interacting with the page it's going to
be fairly annoying if the only way that
we have to interact with the user is via
displaying these alerts the equivalent
of like printing something out except
instead of printing it to a terminal
we're printing it via an alert that
appears on the screen what would be more
interesting and more powerful and much
more useful in the context of a web page
is if we could programmatically update
the website change something about the
web page the user is actually seeing
changing the content that happens to be
on the page and turns out JavaScript is
going to enable us to do that as well
because JavaScript allows us to
manipulate the Dom the document object
model that represents all of the
elements that happen to be on that page
so to do that let's go ahead and return
to
hello.html this again was this webpage
that just said hello and gave me a
button where if I clicked on that button
it would display an alert that said
hello world now what I'd like to do is
instead of having the hello function
display an alert I'd like to have it
manipulate something on the page and
what might I want to manipulate well
inside the body of the page I here have
this heading this heading that just says
hello for example which is inside of an
H1 element and what I might like to do
is actually change that element
how can I do that well it turns out that
in JavaScript we have access to a
function called document
dot query selector and with
document.queryselector is going to do is
it is going to give us the ability to
look through an HTML page and extract an
element out of that page so that we can
manipulate that HTML element using
JavaScript code
and so if I want to select like an H1
element
I can say document.queryselector and
then as the argument the input to
document.queryselector I'll go ahead and
say each one meaning go through the page
find me an H1 element and query selector
is only going to return one element so
if they're multiple it's going to return
the first thing it finds but here we
only have one H1 element so it's okay
I'm going to say look through this
document try and find an H1 element
and when you do I'd like to manipulate
it and the way I'd like to manipulate It
Is by saying dot inner HTML equals let's
say goodbye for example
so all right what's going on here well
right now initially when we first load
the page we have an H1 a big heading at
the top that just says hello and now
when this hello function is called which
is called when this button is clicked on
because it has an on click attribute
that is equal to hello calling the hello
function what the hello function is
going to do is it's going to say
document.queryselector H1 find me the H1
element that will return this element
right here the JavaScript representation
of this HTML element that is just an H1
whose HTML inside of it says hello
and if I want to change that HTML I can
do that by modifying the inner HTML
property of the JavaScript element in
order to update a property of anything
in JavaScript we'll generally use this
dot notation where dot accesses a
property of some particular object and
so I have this element this H1 and
saying dot inner HTML means take that
element and access its inner HTML
property some property of that object
and I would like to update its inner
HTML to just in this case be the word
goodbye followed by an exclamation point
for example
so now what we'll see is that when we
run this page when we open this page up
as by opening up
hello.html I still see an H1 that says
hello I still see a button that says
click here but now when I actually click
on the button click here
you'll see that hello changes to goodbye
we've run JavaScript code that finds an
H1 element on the page and manipulates
it changing it to something else than it
was originally now every time I click
here nothing else happens because every
time I click here it's going to find the
same H1 and it's going to update its
HTML changing it from Hello to goodbye
so maybe what I'd really like then is
the ability to toggle back and forth to
toggle back and forth between hello and
goodbye rather than just change it from
one thing to something else every time I
click the button I'd like it to
alternate back and forth and there are a
number of ways you could imagine doing
this but one way is by taking advantage
of conditions so much in the same way
that a language like python has
conditions ifs and L ifs and else's
JavaScript 2 has if and else if and else
that allow us to describe it conditions
such that we can only run certain blocks
of code when a particular Boolean
expression is true for example so what
would that look like well let's go ahead
and say inside of this hello function
I can ask a question if
document dot query selector H1s inner
HTML is equal to
hello
well then
go ahead and set it to goodbye
and else
then go ahead and update the inner HTML
of this H1 element
go ahead and set it to hello instead
so what is this hello function doing
it's now a little bit more sophisticated
it now has a condition where I say if
the keyword if followed by in
parentheses the condition that I want to
check for the thing I want to see is
this true or not and what I'm checking
for is is let me run
document.queryselector H1 which again
looks through the page finds me the H1
tag and gets that element for me if I
look at that inner HTML if it is equal
to hello then I want to do something and
this triple equal sign here is
javascript's way of checking for strict
equality checking to make sure the two
values are equal and also that their
types are the same thing that if this is
a string this must also be a string it
turns out in JavaScript there's also a
weaker way to check free quality that
just uses two equal signs and that is
going to check that values are the same
but it's going to allow for a bit of
differences in type the two things might
have different types but so long as
they're basically the same value the
double equal sign might generally come
to be true
usually if you can you'll want to use
this triple equal sign the strict
equality to make sure that not only are
the types the same but the values are
the same too and the triple equal sign
will check both of those things so if I
go ahead and find the H1 element and its
inner HTML is the word hello well then
go ahead and find the H1 element and
update its inner HTML setting it equal
to goodbye for example
and else
go ahead and find that same H1 element
update it to Inner HTML set it equal to
hello
and again just as in functions where we
use these curly braces to enclose the
body of the function all of the lines of
code that are inside of the function
JavaScript does the same thing too that
inside of a condition when we want to
express that this is inside the body of
an if condition I can use curly braces
to say this line of code and that line
of code that's inside of the if
expression or that's inside of the else
expression for example
so let's go ahead and try this now I can
go ahead and open hello.html
refresh it currently says hello with a
button that says click here
and now
when I click here hello changes to
goodbye and when I click here again
goodbye changes back to hello and every
time I click the button it's going to
alternate between hello and goodbye
because we either get caught in the if
expression or we get caught in the else
expression
now there are a couple of places where
you might look at this and notice that
maybe this isn't as efficient as this
code could potentially be and recall
that every time we run
document.queryselector to say go ahead
and try and find a particular HTML
element for me it's going to look
through that page trying to find the H1
element and it turns out that right now
we have three separate calls to query
selector even though only two of them
will ever run on any given instance of
the function but we call document.query
selector then we call it again inside of
the if expression we can probably
improve the design of this page by
factoring that out by just looking for
the H1 element once and then
manipulating it and checking it using
that element that we have found and to
do that we can store an element inside
of a variable in the same way that a
variable can store a number like a
counter or a string like Hello World it
can also store other values like an HTML
element that we get back
from document.query selector so I could
say something
like
let heading where heading is just the
name of a variable be equal to
document.queryselector
H1 for instance find the H1 element save
it inside of a variable called heading
and now rather than
document.queryselector H1 all the time I
can just say if the headings inner HTML
is hello then set the headings in or
HTML to goodbye otherwise set the
headings inner HTML to hello so I've
improved the efficiency of the program
but also reduced the number of
characters of Code that I've had to
write my lines are now much shorter a
little bit easier to read this we would
consider to be an improvement in design
and it turns out there's one other
Improvement we can make here too that we
can define a variable like let something
equal something else but it turns out
that JavaScript gives us a couple of
ways to Define a variable and if we're
going to be creating a variable whose
value is never going to change we're
never going to reassign the variable
name to something else then instead of
let we can enforce that it's never going
to change by calling it a const variable
so const heading equals
document.queryselector H1 means I am
going to create a variable called
heading setting it equal to the result
of document.query selector H1 and never
again will I change what heading is
equal to I will never have another line
of code that says heading equals
something else because it is constant
and JavaScript will then enforce that
this variable should not change and If
Ever I do try to change it JavaScript
will give me an error and this can just
be helpful to prevent against possible
unintended behavior that if you know you
have a variable that is never going to
change it's often good design to label
it as a const variable so that you and
other people looking at your code know
that that is never going to have a value
that gets changed later on
so this then will behave the same way
where it says hello but I can toggle it
back and forth changing it to goodbye
and then changing it back to hello again
and so now using this ability this
ability to manipulate the Dom we can go
back to our counter program and actually
improve upon it that right now ever the
counter program uh I count and it
displays an alert that says one I count
and it displays an alert that says two I
can probably do a little bit better than
that by instead of displaying an alert
actually manipulating the Dom in some
way that I would like to have this H1
this big heading at the top instead of
starting up by saying hello let's have
it start out by saying
zero for example just some initial value
for the counter
and now when I increment the value of
counter rather than display an alert
that just tells me the value of the
counter in an alert I'm going to instead
say document.queryselector
H1
dot inner HTML equals
counter
where I'm saying find each one element
update its inner HTML set it equal to
whatever the value of the variable
counter happens to be
such that now if I refresh this page the
value of this H1 initially is zero
that's the initial value but every time
I click count we're going to update the
contents of that H1 element this time
setting it to 1 2 3 4 and so forth every
time I click the count button it's going
to increment the value of the variable
as well as manipulate the Dom actually
making changes in order to
produce the effect that I want to see on
this actual page
and we can begin to add additional logic
to this as well maybe I do occasionally
want an alert but I don't want to alert
every single time I could add a
condition I could say something like if
I only want to display an alert every
time I count to a multiple of 10 like 10
and 20 and 30 and 40 and 50 and so forth
I could add a condition that says that
if counter mod 10 and mod just gets me
remainder when you divide by 10. so if
you take the counter divide it by 10 if
the remainder is 0 when I divide by 10
well that means counter is a multiple of
10 and so I can now display an alert
where I can display an alert that says
like I want to say something like the
counter is now 10 or the counter is now
20. and in order to do that what I
really want to do is have some way of
plugging in a variable into a string
inside of JavaScript and in Python the
way we would have done this is by
appending F or prepending F in front of
the string to create a formatted string
and then I would have said something
like the count is now and then I'd use
curly braces to say go ahead and print
out the value of counter so this F for
formatted string followed by this string
would have been the way in Python that
we would have done this turns out
JavaScript does the same thing just with
slightly different syntax it doesn't use
f instead instead of using the regular
quotation marks whether the single or
double quotation marks JavaScript uses
these back ticks which are usually
located above the tab key on a standard
US keyboard
and this is going to create what
JavaScript calls a template literal
where I can then substitute the value of
a variable somewhere inside of this
template and then in order to actually
do the substitution well python uses
double curly braces to say plug in the
value of counter right here JavaScript
does something similar it also uses
double curly braces but there needs to
be a dollar sign in front of it the
dollar sign and then the dollar double
curly braces I mean go ahead and plug in
the value of a variable there
so this then is a template literal where
every time we get to a multiple of 10
we're going to display an alert that
says the count is now and then this
dollar sign curly brace means actually
plug in whatever the value of counter
happens to be right there
so now if I go ahead and refresh counter
it starts at zero I can count three four
five six seven eight nine but when I get
to 10 then I get an alert that says the
count is now 10 and then I see the
result update on the page
and so that template literal can allow
us to combine variables and strings in
order to generate new strings that are
able to represent data inside of them as
well
so now what improvements can we begin to
make here what changes can we make to
this to improve upon the design of it
well one thing especially as our
programs get a little bit more
sophisticated a little bit more
complicated is that we often don't want
to be intermingling our JavaScript code
with the contents of our HTML that down
here we have button on click equals
count that's the name of this function
and especially as our page starts to get
more complicated it's going to start to
get a little bit annoying if we're
constantly having to maintain a little
bit of JavaScript code like making a
call to a function inside of our HTML
we'll see a little bit later there are
other paradigms that actually encourage
this type of thing but right now it can
start to get a little poorly designed
we'd really like to separate all of our
JavaScript related code from all of the
HTML the general structure of our page
and so there are ways we can begin to do
that as well I can add an event listener
inside of JavaScript too that I can say
something like
document.queryselector
button
and then I can say dot on click
equals count
so what's going on here and I can do
this instead of this on click equals
count what I'm now saying is
document.queryselector button find me
the button on the page it turns out
there's only one button here so it's
fine though if there were more I might
have to be a little bit more specific
but once I get that button
then I'm going to access its on click
property and I'm going to set it equal
to count and what does count count is
the name of a function count is itself a
function and so what I'm here saying is
I would like to set the value of the on
click property of the button equal to
count the count is the function that
should run when the button is clicked on
and notice that I am not actually
calling the function it's not count and
then parentheses which would mean run
the count function and then get its
return value and use that as the value
for onclick I'm just setting on click
equal literally to the count function
itself without actually calling the
function and what this is going to do is
it is going to say when the button is
clicked on then and only then should you
actually run this count function and
we're not going to run the count
function until that button actually gets
clicked on and so in JavaScript
functions can be treated as values of
their own just as you can set a variable
equal to a string just as you can set a
variable equal to an integer just as you
can set a variable equal to like an HTML
element like the result of
document.queryselector you can also set
a variable equal to a function something
like count and pass that around as a
value just as you could with any other
value and this is a paradigm we
generally call functional programming
where we have functions as values of
their own things that we can reassign
things that we we can manipulate just as
we could any other value
so now I can try and run this program by
going ahead and refreshing the page I'll
refresh it it's zero I press count
and all right nothing seems to be
happening it's still zero I want it to
be counting but it doesn't seem to be
working so why not anytime you run into
problems in JavaScript where you're not
getting the behavior you want often it
can be helpful to look at the JavaScript
console or the JavaScript console is the
equivalent of like the terminal window
in when you're running your Django
application in Python that would display
any error messages the JavaScript
console will display any of the
JavaScript logging information and error
messages as well
in Chrome I can get to it if I first go
ahead and go to inspect
and then just open up the console tab
here
and all right we seem to have some sort
of error here it's an uncaught type
error that says we cannot set property
on click of null in counter.html line
18. so that will generally tell you
where the error is coming from it's
coming from counter.html on line 18 and
the problem seems to be that I'm trying
to access the on click property of null
and null is javascript's way of
expressing like nothing some object that
doesn't exist
so somehow I'm trying to set the on
click property of null well let's see
what's going on on line 18 and see if we
can figure out
what's happening there
well all right here is line 18 where I
say document.queryselector button
setting its on click property equal to
count
and now what seems to be the problem
here well the error message was that I
was trying to modify the on-click
property of no well here then is the on
click property so why would this
document.queryselector button be
returning or giving me an output of null
well it turns out the document.query
selector will return null if it's not
able to find something if I try and find
a button but it's not able to find a
button well this seems a little bit
strange because there's a button down
here on line 24 that I'd like for my
JavaScript code to be able to find when
it runs query selector and tries to find
the button as it turns out this is a bit
of The Quirk of the way the browser is
going to work but if the browser is
running our code from top to bottom just
reading it from line one on and on then
it's going to get to line 18 where I've
said document.queryselector button dot
on click equals count and it's going to
try and find a button on line 18 but the
button doesn't show up in my HTML page
until much further down in the page so
at this point when we get to this line
of JavaScript JavaScript is looking for
the button but the Dom the body of the
page hasn't finished loading yet the
content of the Dom has not yet loaded
and as a result we're not able to find
this button so how do we solve this
problem how do we get it so we actually
are able to like ask for the button and
actually get the button well it turns
out there are a couple of strategies we
could use one would be take the script
tag and go ahead and just move it to the
bottom section of the body so that after
we've already defined the button that
says count then we have the script tag
that then says all right go ahead and
now find the button and now we'll be
able to find it
turns out another way and perhaps a more
common way is to instead add yet another
event listener and we're going to add an
event listener not to the button but to
the entire document where document is a
variable built into this JavaScript that
we have access to on the web page that
just refers to this entire web document
where I've used document.queryselector
already to look through the whole web
document trying to find a button or
trying to find an H1 tag for example but
I can also add an event listener to the
document itself and in order to do that
I can say document dot add event
listener
and when I call out event listener and I
can do this on any HTML element not just
the document but I could run this
function on a button or on an H1 element
or any other HTML element ad event
listener will generally take two
arguments where the first is what event
I want to listen for the event could be
something like click when I click on the
document it could be something like when
I scroll through a page for example but
the event I'm going to listen for is a
particularly special event called Dom
content loaded
and the Dom content loaded event is an
event that is going to be fired or
triggered when the Dom the document
object model the structure of the page
is done loading when all of the elements
on the page are done loading the Dom
content has been loaded and then if I
attach an event listener to it it'll run
whatever code I want to run that should
only run after the Dom is fully loaded
after all of the content on the page has
then been loaded
and the second argument to add event
listener is what function should run
once the event actually happens when the
Dom content loaded does happen so I
could pass in the name of a function if
I had the name of a function that I
wanted to pass in but alternatively
JavaScript allows me to just directly
write a function here in the argument to
add event listener I can just say
function
and then a set of parentheses to mean
the function doesn't take any input and
then in curly braces I can include the
body of the function right here as the
second argument to add event listener
and this is a little bit of tricky
syntax to wrap your mind around if
you've never seen it before but the big
picture way to think of it is add event
listener takes two arguments one is the
event the second is the function so here
first is the event Dom content loaded
and the second argument is a function
and I would declare the function same as
before just using function I haven't
given the function a name because
strictly speaking it doesn't need a name
I'm never going to refer to the function
by name so it is what we might call an
anonymous function a function that has
no name but I'm still passing it into
the add event listener function as an
argument because I want to run the code
inside of the function once the Dom is
done loading and so inside of curly
braces then is the content of that
function the content of what code should
run when the Dom is done loading and
then at the end I again use just this
end parenthesis where that end
parenthesis lines up with this
parenthesis here this is in closing all
of the arguments to add event listener
where the first one is Dom content
loaded and the second one is this entire
function that might span multiple lines
so you'll see syntax like this quite a
bit in JavaScript
but now what I want to do is adding the
event listener to the button I can go
ahead and just replace and put it here
and it turns out that if I wanted to
instead of saying dot on click equals
count you could have used the same
syntax of ad event listener I could say
add event listener click and then count
to mean when the click event happens go
ahead and run the count function but you
can equivalently shorthand this and just
say dot on click equals count and that
would work just as well
so now what we're saying here is that
wait until the Dom is done loaded wait
until all the content on the page is
loaded and then go ahead and run this
function and what the function is going
to do is it's going to add the event
handler to this button and that'll work
because now we'll be able to find the
button because now all of the content of
the Dom has loaded
so now if I go back
refreshcounter.html you'll notice that
the JavaScript error goes away I don't
seem to have that error anymore
and now if I press count we're able to
see the count increment just as before
as well
and so this then is an improvement upon
what I've had before where now I'm able
to separate out my JavaScript code from
all of the rest of my code as well
but much as in the case of CSS where we
were able to take CSS it was originally
located in the head of our page and move
it into a separate file you can do the
same thing with JavaScript too and this
can be helpful if you have multiple
people working on different files you
want one person working on the HTML and
someone else working on the JavaScript
it can be helpful if you expect that one
of these things is going to change more
frequently than the other so you might
not need to load the other one as often
so there can be value in separating our
HTML code from our JavaScript even more
by moving our JavaScript into a separate
file and so in order to do that
I can create a new file that I'll just
call counter.js which will contain all
of the JavaScript for mycounter.html
file so in order to do that what I can
say is let's go ahead and copy all of
this JavaScript code
go ahead and cut it out of this page and
I'll paste it into counter.js remove
some of that indentation
so now I have a file called counter.js
that just contains all of the JavaScript
I want to run on my counter.html page
and now rather than include actual
JavaScript in between these script tags
what I can say is script SRC SRC for
Source equals
counter.js for example to say go ahead
and reference counter.js and use that
JavaScript
in the head of the page here and that
then is going to work exactly the same
way I still am able to count as high as
I'd like I still get an alert every time
the count reaches a multiple of 10 but
my HTML is now a little bit simpler it's
just the body it's just the H1 and the
button and then all of my JavaScript is
now located in a separate file that
allows me to do that allows me to keep
my HTML code and my JavaScript code
separate from each other and that can be
value for valuable for a couple of
reasons among them if I have common
JavaScript code that's in use by
multiple different HTML Pages multiple
HTML Pages can all include the same
JavaScript Source rather than needing to
repeat myself use the same JavaScript
across multiple different pages I can
just use the same JavaScript across all
of them and that'll be helpful too as we
begin to take a look later at some
JavaScript libraries which are
JavaScript written by other people we
can just include other people's
JavaScript in our own web pages just by
adding a script tag at the top of our
page that specifies a particular Source
you may have already interacted with
bootstrap that has its own JavaScript
code and you can include bootstraps
JavaScript just by including a script
tag at the top of our HTML page in order
to say go ahead and include all of that
JavaScript
in our page as well
so what else can we do now now that we
have the ability to like get at elements
of the Dom and actually manipulate their
contents well one thing we can do is
begin to make our Pages a little bit
more interactive actually respond to
what users are doing on the page whether
the user is typing something in or maybe
filling out a form for example so let's
go ahead and try an example of that
where the user might be filling out a
form and we would like for our code to
somehow respond to what it is that they
type I'll go ahead and go back into
hello.html
and now inside of the body of the page
I've said hello at the top I'm here
instead of a button I'm going to have a
form
this HTML form will look like the HTML
forms we've seen before I have an input
field that'll add the autofocus
attribute to to mean like automatically
Focus this input field when I open the
page because I might want the user to
start typing right away
I'm going to give this input field an ID
of name for example
and then a placeholder
of name capital N whose type is text
so what have I done here I've created an
input field where the user can type in
some text the placeholder the thing the
user sees filled into that input field
originally will just be capital N name
telling them they should type their name
in here
and I've given this input field
an ID some unique identifier such that I
later on can reference and find this
particular input field
and then I have input type equals submit
some way for me to now submit this form
as well
and so if I load this page load
hello.html
here's what I see Hello a field where I
can type in my name the placeholder name
shows up there for me and then a button
where I can submit this form
and now what I'd like to do inside of my
JavaScript is instead of this hello
function what I'm going to do is I'm
going to first run some JavaScript when
the Dom is done loading and so I'll use
that same line from before you're going
to see it quite a bit where we're going
to say document.ad eventlistener Dom
content loaded and then this function to
mean go ahead and run this code when the
Dom is done loaded and the code I'd like
to run is to say when I submit the form
I want something to happen when I submit
the form maybe I want to display an
alert that if I typed in Brian it'll say
hello Brian or if I typed in David it'll
say hello David for example so how might
I do that
well how do I get the form that's the
first question anytime you want to get
at an element one particular element on
an HTML page usually what we're going to
do is document.queryselector
to say get me the element
that is a form and there's only one form
on the page so I don't have to worry
about ambiguity I'm just saying get me
that form
and then I can say dot on submit when
you submit the form
what code should run and if I had a name
of a function like a function f i could
just say like run function f when the
form is submitted
but alternatively just as before instead
of providing the name of a function I
can also just provide the function
itself I can say function
and then in between these curly braces I
can specify exactly what code should run
when the form is submitted by providing
this Anonymous function instead using
this Anonymous function as the value of
the on submit property of this form
and so now what I'd like to do is
somehow get access to whatever the user
typed into the input field whatever the
user's name happens to be and so I could
get the input field via
document.queryselector input and that
would work this time but we'll want to
start to be a little bit careful because
on this page there are multiple
different input elements there's an
input element here for typing in the
name and a second input element here for
telling me you're giving me a button
where I can submit this particular HTML
form and so what I probably want to do
is be a little bit more specific
and it turns out that inside of query
selector I can use all of the standard
ways in CSS that we could select for a
particular element so in CSS if you'll
recall we had the ability to run CSS and
just say style all the H1s or we could
say style all the things with this
particular ID or with this particular
class and document.queryselector works
the same way that I can say
document.queryselector and pass in a tag
to say like get me the H1 element or get
me the button or get me the form but if
there are multiple H1 elements or
multiple buttons or multiple forms I can
be more specific than that if for
example an element has an ID in which
case I can say document.queryselector
and then in quotation marks the hash
mark and then the name of the ID to say
get me the element with that particular
ID again using the exact same syntax
that CSS uses if I want to apply a
particular set of styles to only one
element that only has one ID
likewise too I can say
document.queryselector and then use dot
followed by the name of a class if
there's a particular particular class of
elements and I want to just get one of
those to say get me an element that has
this particular class in order to
manipulate it as well so the same types
of syntax that we could use in CSS for
trying to reference and get at a
particular HTML element we can do the
same thing here with
document.queryselector to go ahead and
try and get a particular element based
on its tag name based on its ID or based
on its class and it was for that reason
that inside of the HTML page
for my input I gave the input an ID of
name I wanted some way to be able to
uniquely reference it and I can uniquely
reference it not by input but by pound
name or I can say get me the element
that has an ID of name and that is the
element that I would like to extract
inside of my JavaScript code
once I have that HTML element what I
want is like what the user actually
typed into that input field and it turns
out that if you have an input field in
HTML I can get access to what the user
typed in by accessing its value property
value is a property that for that refers
to what it is the user actually typed in
so I can say dot value
and I'm going to go ahead and save that
inside of a variable so I could say
something like let name equal whatever
the user typed in but if I'm not going
to reassign name to something else
inside of this function inside of this
function I'm really going to get the
name once and I'm not going to change it
inside of the function so I can use a
const variable instead and that would be
better designed so I have a constant
variable called name which is equal to
document.queryselector get me the
element whose idea's name and get access
to its value
and now I can display an alert I can
alert something like in backticks hello
comma and then using the dollar sign
curly brace syntax I can say plug in the
name there followed by an exclamation
point
so I've extracted the name from the form
get me the input field where they typed
the name get access to its value and
then I'm displaying an alert that is
going to say hello to that person for
example
and so now
if I refresh the page I type in my name
I press submit I get an alert that says
hello Brian I press OK I can try it
again I can type in something like David
press submit and now the page says hello
David
so here again we've been able to combine
event listeners and functions and query
selector to be able to both read
information from the page in order to
say get me this particular HTML element
find me an HTML element and access like
what the user typed into it the dot
value property that gets me what the
user typed into an input field and we've
been able to combine that with event
listeners and alerts that are able to
actually respond dynamically to when a
user submits the form or when the entire
content of the page is done loading in
order to produce some interesting
effects as well
but it turns out we can do more than
just change like the HTML that is
contained within an element we can also
change CSS as well change the style
properties of a particular element as
well so let's go ahead and see an
example of that I'll go ahead and create
a new file
that I'll call colors.html and inside of
colors I'll include the same
standard HTML boilerplate code that we
often start with a head section with a
title and a body section and inside of
the body of this page I'm going to
display a heading
that just says hello for example and
maybe I'll give it an ID just so I can
reference it by name maybe it has an ID
of hello
and then I'll have three buttons I'll
have a button called red
a button called blue and then a button
called Green for example
where now if I open up colors.html
here's what I see I see a big heading
that says hello and then I see three
buttons red blue and green but of course
right now these buttons don't actually
do anything
how do I get the buttons to do something
well that's where javascript's going to
come in I'll add a script tagged at the
top of my page and I only want to run
this JavaScript when the Dom is done
loading so again we'll use the same
syntax as before document dot add event
listener
Dom content loaded and then run this
function to say everything in between
these curly braces this is all the code
that should run once the page is done
loading and what I'd really like to do
is get at these three buttons and say
when you click on each one of them do
something different like change the
color of a particular HTML element and
in order to do that I need some way of
uniquely referencing these buttons so to
do that I'm going to give them all IDs
this button will have an ID of red this
button will have an ID of blue this
button will have an ID of green just
unique names I can give to the buttons
in HTML such that in JavaScript I'm
later able to reference them
so what I what do I include now here
inside of my JavaScript code
well let me say document.queryselector
hash red to say get me the element whose
ID is read
and when you're clicked on on click go
ahead and run this function what should
the function do well I want to take this
H1 element and change its color to Red I
want to change the font color to red and
I'll leave a comment to myself in
JavaScript the way you can leave a
comment just to document what you're
doing is using these two slashes the two
slashes indicate everything after that
on the page is going to be a comment
browser will ignore it but it can be
useful to you the programmer into
someone who's reading your code to be
able to see what it is that you're
describing here on the page
and now what I'd like to do is
document.queryselector hello get me the
HTML element whose ID is hello
and go ahead and modify its style
property
and now inside of this style object I
can modify any of the CSS style
properties one of them for example is
something like color so I can update the
color property and set it equal to red
so here now I'm saying when you click on
the red button
go ahead and run this function and what
the function should do is find the hello
element
update its style what part of the style
update its color what should we update
it to we should update it to red
and I'm going to do the same thing for
the other two buttons as well and it's
pretty similar code so I'm just going to
copy paste copy paste here I'm going to
have one for changing the color to Blue
when I click the blue button you should
change the color to blue and then we'll
do it one more time change the font
color to Green when you click on the
green button you should change the color
to Green
so now when I refresh the colors.html
right now hello by default is just in
Black standard font color for HTML I
click red Hello changes to Red I click
blue it changes to Blue I click green it
changes to Green so depending on what
button I click that triggers some event
listener that's going to then say when
the button is clicked run this function
and what the function does is it grabs
this H1 element the element whose ID is
hello modifies its style updates its
color property to be something like red
or blue or green
and that's showing that we can modify
style in addition to just modifying the
content of the page itself
but it turns out that as you looked at
me writing that code something should
have struck you is probably not optimal
design that in general anytime you find
yourself writing the same code again and
again and again especially if you're
copy pasting that that is a generally a
bad sign usually a sign that there is
some better way of trying to modify of
trying to implement the behavior that
I'm trying to create and it turns out
that there is and there are a number of
ways that you could do this one way here
is that I might like to consolidate
these three event listeners into just
like a single function that is going to
handle changing the color to whatever
the button says the color should be
changed to but one problem here is that
if I just attach the same event listener
to all three of the buttons it's not
going to be clear to me when I click on
the button how does the button know what
color we should change the text to
and so to that effect we can add some
additional special attributes to a
particular HTML element that are called
Data attributes
or a data attribute is my way of saying
that I would like to associate some data
with this particular H2O HTML element
where here I can say data Dash color
equals Red Data Dash color equals blue
data Dash color equals green data
attributes always start with data
followed by a dash and then I can
specify really any name that I want for
some information that I would like to
store about the HTML element and here
the information I want to store is I
want to store data about what color you
should change the text to when the
button is clicked on and so what we're
going to have the ability to do now is
the ability to say that if I have access
to this element this button I can access
its data color property to know whether
we should change the text to red or blue
or green by adding these data attributes
to these HTML elements
and so now what I want is some way of
getting all of these buttons now
document.queryselector as you recall
just gets one element it's just going to
get for me a single element and it's
going to get the first one that it finds
if I want to get multiple elements what
I can do instead is something like
document dot query selector all
query selector all is going to return
the same thing the query selector does
but instead of query selector returning
a single element that matches what it
looks for query selector all is going to
return to mean an array of all of the
elements that match my particular query
so if I want to select not just the
first button I find but all of the
buttons I find I can here say query
selector all for button and that will
give me back a JavaScript array the
equivalent of a list that represents all
of those buttons
and we can actually test what this looks
like by looking at things inside of the
JavaScript console that if I go ahead
and refresh this page colors I can open
up the inspector go into the JavaScript
console and just as you could see error
messages here you can also actually
write JavaScript code here as well so I
can say something like
document.queryselector
button say all right what's going to
happen when I try and select for a
button on this particular page
and what I get is all right I get just
this very first button button whose data
Dash color is equal to Red that's what I
would expect query selector just finds
me one element and it's going to find me
the very first element
and likewise I can say all right instead
of query selector let's do query
selector all
and what I get back is a node list which
you can think of as kind of like an
array or a list in Python that's got
three buttons in it button zero one and
two and just as with a list in python as
you can index into things arrays in
Python arrays in JavaScript can be
indexed into as well that if I have
something like const names equals Harry
Ron and Hermione
like a array of three names I can say
name square bracket zero to get the
first name name square bracket one to
get the second one name score bracket
two to get the third one for example and
that gives me each of the individual
elements in the array if I want to get
the whole length of the array I can do
names dot length to get all right the
length of the names array happens to be
three so just some additional features
that we have access to If you happen to
have an array of things turns out query
selector all returns to me a node list
which is kind of like an array
and that's going to be useful because
when I say document.queryselector all
button I am saying get me all of the
buttons on the page
and now what I would like to do is
effectively Loop over all of those
buttons and say for each of the buttons
inside of this list that comes back to
me I would like to add an event handler
for when that button is clicked on to
say for each of the buttons that comes
back go ahead and say when you're
clicked on change the color of the H1
element
and so there are a number of ways again
that you could do this
but one way is to use a particular
property called for each and for each is
a function that accepts as an argument
another function where the idea is going
to be I would like to run a function for
each of the elements inside of an array
or inside of a node list for example
so here I can say
for each button go ahead and run this
function
this is going to be a function now that
takes something as input it's going to
take one of the elements in the list as
input something like a button
and now for each button what would I
like to do for that button
well when the button is clicked on
button Dot unclick
then go ahead and run a function
that is going to
document.queryselector
get me the element whose ID is hello
change its style within the style change
its color and what do I want to change
this color to will I have access to this
button this argument to the function is
whichever button I'm currently trying to
add an event listener for
and in order to access its data
properties I can access a special
property of an HTML element called its
data set property
and then I can say something like
button.dataset dot color to get at the
data Dash color attribute
so a lot of stuff going on here let's go
ahead and try and read through this
entire thing and just get a feel for
what's happening because we have
functions nested within other functions
nested within other functions up at the
very top I've said add an event listener
to the document when the documents Dom
content is loaded meaning all the
content of the page is downloading go
ahead and run this function this is the
body of the function
so what do I want to do when the page is
done loading I'm going to
document.queryselector all looking for
all of the buttons and if I wanted to if
there could be more buttons I could have
added a class to these buttons and just
look for things with a particular class
query selector all just returns all of
the elements that match a particular
query
and then I'm saying for each of those
buttons for each of the buttons that
came back I would like to run a function
on each of those buttons I'm basically
saying if I have three buttons that came
back let me run a function on the first
button then the same function on the
second button then the same function on
the third button and what is that
function
well it's this function here a function
that takes as input the button it's
first going to pass in as input the
first button then the second button then
the Third
and what this function does is it adds
an on click Handler to the button it
says when the button is clicked on go
ahead and run this other function and
this function now is the function that
will run when the button is clicked on
to say when the button is clicked on get
me the hello element change its color to
button.dataset.color and
button.dataset.color takes a button
takes an HTML element like this one here
and accesses its data set all of its
data properties and specifically
accesses the color data property which
in this case is equal to red and that is
what we would like to set color equal to
it's a little bit more complex than
we've seen before but now we've been
able to reduce what was three different
event handlers into just a single one
and now this is going to work the same
way change it to red blue and green all
by just using those data properties that
we have access to
and so when in doubt about how these
things are working about what query
selector is returning the JavaScript
console can be a very powerful tool for
this so you can go into the JavaScript
console and actually manipulate things
you can run and run queries you can run
functions you can even modify the values
of variables like if I go back for
instance to counter.html or had this
counter that's counting zero one two
three four if I wanted to I could say
something like counter equals 27 just
like change the value of the counter
nothing appears to have changed on the
page I didn't say update anything on the
page but now next time I run count it's
going to update the value of the count
to 28 because I had updated the value
inside of the JavaScript console it's
going to increment that value display
that value inside of the H1 element so
you can modify variables you can run
functions you can run
document.queryselector to figure out
what particular elements are going to
come back all through the use of the
JavaScript console which can be a very
very powerful tool especially as you
begin working on trying to debug these
programs and trying to figure out what
might be wrong with them it turns out
too that there are other changes that we
can make in order to optimize our code a
little bit more in order to make it a
little bit more succinct and one way is
that in more recent versions of
JavaScript they've introduced a
particular notation for functions called
the arrow notation for functions and
I'll just show it to you because it'll
come up but oftentimes instead of using
the keyword function before introducing
a function you'll just have something
like button
and then Arrow the curly braces and
strictly speaking you'd only even need
the parentheses around the input where
button arrow and then in these curly
braces some code just means here is
going to be a function that takes us
input a variable called button and then
runs this particular block of code when
that function is run
and likewise if a function takes no
input like this function up here you
could express it using arrow notation
with just parentheses Arrow block and so
this is often a notation that you'll see
in JavaScript so if you ever see it know
that that's really just shorthand for
creating a function whatever it is to
the left of the arrow sign is the input
to the function and whatever is to the
right of the arrow is what code should
actually run when the function body gets
executed when the function is called
upon
so what other changes might we want to
make to colors.html well if we look back
at colors.html here's what it looks like
now we've got a heading that says hello
and then buttons to change the color to
red or blue or green for example we
might instead if we want the user to
choose from one from a number of options
decide upon the user interface choice of
using a drop down instead of a bunch of
buttons for example and JavaScript
supports that as well and we'll use this
as an opportunity to explore some of the
other event handlers that exist within
JavaScript so for example
instead of having these all inside of
buttons I can make my life a little bit
easier by making this a select drop down
where the select is going to have an
option whose value is let's say black is
the default option we'll just say black
and then we'll add another option whose
value is red and then we say red and the
value is what we'll get in JavaScript
when we try and extract the value of a
particular select drop down well it's in
between the option tags themselves is
what the user is going to see on the
page when they actually view it so I'm
capitalizing it just for them
option value equals blue it'll be blue
and then option value equals green and
that'll be green
so now what the user sees is they say
hello and then a drop down menu where
they can choose from a list of colors
rather than click buttons in order to do
so and now of course this select drop
down doesn't do anything at the moment
but I can modify it so that it does
so now instead of selecting for all of
the buttons and doing something with all
the buttons we don't have any buttons
anymore what I do have is I have
a select drop down
and now just as we've seen like on click
to say when you click on something as
we've seen Dom content loaded as an
event there's another event called on
change which applies to things like
select drop-downs where when something
changes in the select drop down when a
user chooses something different I can
run some code for example so I can run a
function
that in this case is going to take
document.queryselector
hello meaning get me the hello HTML
element
change its style what part of the style
change its color
and I want to change it to something I
want to change it to the value of this
select drop down but how do I get access
to this particular select drop down well
in JavaScript we have access to a
special value called this and this has
special meaning in JavaScript and its
meaning varies based on context but in
the context of an event handler a
function that is called when a
particular event happens this is going
to be a special keyword that always
refers to the thing that received the
event so what received the event it was
the select drop down that is what
received the event of being changed and
so this is going to be a special keyword
that always refers to that that always
refers to the drop down menu where I
made a different selection so if I want
to get the value of that drop down menu
what it is the user actually selected I
can just say this dot value to mean get
that drop down menu and get at the value
the thing that the user selected in that
menu and now much more succinctly than
before I've been able to implement the
same kind of idea it says hello right
now in black but if I choose from the
drop down menu to change its color to
something like red for example color
changes to Red if I instead choose blue
it changes to blue green changes to
Green I choose black it changes Back to
Black so now I have this ability to
detect these other types of events and
respond to them as well and there are
many many different events that exist in
JavaScript there's on click which we've
seen already on Mouse over it can detect
like when you Mouse over something when
you're hovering over a particular
element if you've ever seen websites
that somehow respond when your mouse
moves over something that can be how
it's implemented on key down and on key
up can respond to keyboard events
something like when you press a key on
the keyboard when you press down on the
key that's on key down and when you lift
your finger off the key that's on key up
and there are other events as well many
more events that are just listed here
that you can listen for and respond to
so that you can really interact with the
user based on what it is that they're
doing
so now let's take a look at an example
of how we can use some of these events
to now begin to create a little bit of a
more interesting application we'll go
ahead and build a to-do list application
this time using exclusively JavaScript
we've seen to-do lists before that
involve communicating with a server
making requests and responses we'll now
build a to-do list that only uses
JavaScript to do so
I'll create a new file called tasks.html
and we'll use them we'll create a head
section whose title is tasks
and a body section and inside the body
of the page I'll go ahead and have a
heading that says tasks
and underneath that I want an unordered
list of all of my tasks so I have an
unordered list I'll give it an ID of
tasks just for good measure so I can
reference it later but initially
nothing's going to be in here
but what I'll have underneath the
unordered list is a form a form where I
can submit a new task for example so
I'll give myself an input field also
given an ID the ID will be task singular
for the new task that I am typing in
the placeholder will be new task just so
the user knows what to type in and the
type of the input field will be text so
I have an input field where the user can
type in some new task and I'll also add
an input field for good measure whose
type is submit that allows the user to
submit a new task once they've created
it
so if I open up tasks.html
here's then what I see big heading there
is technically an unordered list
underneath it here but there's nothing
in that unordered list yet so it just
shows up as empty then a text field
where I can type in a task and then a
submit button where I can submit my new
task
so now I'd like some JavaScript such
that when I submit this form we actually
do something
so add a script tag I want this
JavaScript to run after
the Dom content is loaded
so we'll go ahead and add the usual Dom
content loaded event listener
and now I want to run code when the form
is submitted so I can say
document.queryselector
form
dot on submit equals and then I want to
run a function and I could use the
keyword function again but I can just
use an arrow function which will be a
little bit faster to type just say all
right here's the function that I want to
run when the form is submitted
and what would I like to do well I'd
first like to figure out all right what
did the user actually type in and what
the user typed in well that'll be
document.queryselector
task
dot value
get me the element with ID task that's
the input field dot value gets the value
of the input field which is what the
user actually typed in and I can save
that as like
const task that is what it is the user
typed in
and if I'm curious as to what the user
typed in I can actually print it out to
the JavaScript console and the way to do
that is using a special function called
console.log and that just logs something
to the console the equivalent of
printing something out in Python where
it just shows up in the python terminal
here this is going to show up in the
JavaScript console
and one other thing I'll add is by
default forms will try and submit when
you press the submit button like take
you to another page we've seen this
before already in the context of Django
that when you submit a form it tries and
submits another web request if I want to
prevent that behavior stop the form from
submitting so stop form from submitting
I can
return false at the end of my form
submission Handler to say don't actually
submit the form we're going to do
everything client-side everything just
inside of the browser so now this won't
quite work yet but it'll be progress I
refresh the page I'm going to open up
the JavaScript console so I can see
what's going on if I add a task
something just like Foo
press submit this now gets logged to the
JavaScript console it's the equivalent
of a way of like providing debugging
information to myself to know all right
I now have access to this value Foo and
it's also telling me what line of code
logged at it with tasks.html line 9 is
the line of code that logged Foo and so
this can be useful when you're debugging
a program when you want to see what the
values of variables are you can just
print them out using console.log to
figure out what's going on in your
program at any particular point in time
but what I want to do is not
console.loget what I want to do is
really create a new element that I'm
going to add into my body of the HTML so
how can I do that well to create a new
element for my document I can run a
function called document dot create
element
followed by what type of element do I
want to create well I have an unordered
list a ul and every item inside of an
unordered list is a list item An Li so
I'll go ahead and create an Li element a
list item
and I'll save that in a variable then
I'll call Li
so I've created a new list item and this
list items inner HTML the HTML content
inside of that list item
well that's just going to be task this
variable from up here which is whatever
the user typed in so I've now created a
new list item and said what HTML should
go inside of the list item it should be
whatever task the user typed in
and now
I'm going to say document dot query
selector tasks get me the element whose
ideas tasks and that's going to be this
unordered list here the unordered list
whose ID is tasks and if I have an HTML
element I can add a new element inside
of it by saying dot append
Li
and what that now is going to do is it's
going to say get me the unordered list
whose ideas tasks get me the element
whose ID is tasks by a query selector
here once I have that element append to
the end of what's inside of that element
this value Li which happens to be this
new element that I've created a new list
item so I've been able to add a new HTML
element and this line of code is going
to say add it to the Dom add it to the
unordered list that I am here now
constructing
so now I rerun this I see tasks I type
in something like Foo I press submit and
all right food now shows up I type in
something like I delete that type in bar
bar now shows up I type in baz bazino
shows up now one minor user interface
annoyance is that it seems that every
time I submit a new task this input
field retains the value of what it used
to be and that's probably not what I
want because I'd rather it just clear
out I've already submitted the task no
need for it to stay there but that's
easy to manipulate in JavaScript if I
want to clear out this input field the
input field whose ID is tasked then all
I need to do is say document dot query
selector
task get me that input field change its
value equal to the empty string equal to
nothing just to say clear out the value
of what happens to be inside of that
input field right now and now if I
refresh the page type in Foo press
submit input field clears out and now I
can type in something like bar and then
something like baz to continue to add
tasks as well
now one thing that might be slightly
annoying is if I'm not careful if I
press submit
well it submits the empty string as a
task and so I just get this empty bullet
point that shows up here when I press
submit and I just get all of these empty
bullet points it might be nice from a
user experience perspective if I were to
not allow the user to do that not allow
them to submit a task if they haven't
actually typed something in to the new
task field and we can do that just by
modifying properties of elements that it
turns out that HTML elements have a
property called disabled that can be
true or false that allows us to disable
something like a button
so if I want to disable the submit
button one thing I might want to do
first is give this submit button an ID
I'll give it an ID of submit so that in
my JavaScript code I can reference the
submit button
and now inside of this JavaScript code
when the Dom content is loaded
by default
the submit button should be disabled
like when I first load the page I don't
want the submit button to be enabled
because I want the user to type in a
task first before I enable the submit
button so how do I do that well I can
document.queryselector get me the
element whose ID is submit get me that
submit button and just set its disabled
property equal to True JavaScript has
Boolean values true and false I set the
disabled value equal to true to disable
the submit button
now if I refresh the page I can type in
a new task but the submit button is
disabled it doesn't do anything now
obviously I don't want to keep it that
way I'd like it such that as I begin to
type things in then the submit button
stops being disabled disabled gets set
from True to false instead
and so what I really want to do is
listen for me like pressing keys on the
keyboard
and so the way I can do that is by
adding yet another event listener
document.queryselector
what do I want to add a query selector
to what do I want to add an event
handler for well I want to add an event
handler for when I type something into
this input field and this input field
has an ID of task
so let me go ahead and get the input
field the element whose ID is task
and add an on key up Handler on key up
again is the event when I lift my finger
off of a key
go ahead and run this function and what
should the function do well it's going
to say document.queryselector submit
set the disabled property equal to false
and so now here's what we're doing we're
saying by default when I first load the
page take the submit button and disable
it set dot disabled equal to true then
anytime I type a key and my finger comes
off the key that means on key up is the
event that gets triggered run this
function and what the function is going
to do is take that same submit button
and set its disabled property equal to
false so now instead of being disabled
it will be enabled
so if I go back to the page go here I
type in right now by default the submit
button is disabled but as soon as I
start typing something now the submit
button is active and I can actually
click on it
and all right this isn't great because I
clicked on it but the submit button is
still enabled so what I might like to do
is all right after I've submitted the
form after I've added a new task let's
go back and disable the submit button so
after I've
submitted the form after we've added the
new task to my list of tasks after we've
cleared out the value from the input
field let me also
get the submit button set its disabled
property equal to true
now even after I submit the form the
submit button is still going to be
disabled such that I type in Foo now
submit is active I press it but the
submit button goes back to being
inactive as well
it turns out that even now there's still
a little bit of a bug if I go back here
and I type in something like bar but
then I backspace back to like nothing
here the submit button is still active
so I can still technically submit a task
that has no content inside of it and so
I might like to have some way of
preventing against that as well and
that's just some additional logic we now
have access to JavaScript that has
conditions that has Loops that has
functions and so if I want to do
something
like conditionally check I can say if
document.query selector task
dot value dot length is greater than
zero meaning like something's actually
typed into the task field we'll then go
ahead and set disable defaults
but otherwise
go ahead and set disabled
equal to true
so now here we're checking if the length
of what the user has typed in is greater
than zero they actually type something
in then yes give them access to the
submit button but otherwise don't give
them access to that button
so now I refresh the page disabled by
default I type something in it's enabled
I delete delete delete and it goes back
to being disabled so JavaScript has
allowed us to really make our Pages much
more interactive and immediately
interactive based on how the user is
interacting with the page as they begin
to type things as they begin to delete
things as they press buttons we're able
to have the page respond either by
adding content to the Dom by literally
adding parts to the HTML Page Changing
the stylus of things changing particular
properties of elements and this is
really where the power of JavaScript
begins to come in it's been allowing
ourselves to do things like that
now so far we've only been able to have
events happen when the user does
something when the user clicks on a
button or when the user presses a key
for example but it turns out JavaScript
has other ways of allowing functions to
run in fact on their own we can set what
are called intervals where a particular
function runs every sum number of
milliseconds for example and so if we go
back to like the counter example from
before
right now for this counter example I
have to be the one to press the count
button that is going to increment the
value of count every single time but I
could put that inside of an interval
instead so let me go back to
counter.html whose JavaScript is inside
of counter.js
and now what I'd like to say
is
I would like when the Dom content is
loaded
let me set an interval
for count
and one thousand
so what is that going to do set interval
is a function built into JavaScript here
where I'm saying that I would like to
create a new interval where every so
often go ahead and run a particular
function and I would like to run the
count function we'll recall that count
function is going to increment the value
of count and I'll get rid of this alert
for now just for Simplicity all I want
the count function to do is update the
H1 with the new value of the counter and
go ahead and run that count function
every 1000 milliseconds otherwise known
as every one second go ahead and run the
count function
so now when I open counter.html
it's 0 but every second now it's going
to change every second updating one by
one by one I don't have to click the
button of course I could in the event
handler would still work but the
interval is saying now every one second
go ahead and run the count function and
that has this particular result so if
you've ever seen a web page that like
displays the current time in seconds it
was like a countdown timer or it's
displaying the current time with seconds
it might be doing something like this
just having some sort of interval that
every second is going to count an
increment in order to say update the
number to the one greater one greater
and one greater than that
of course if I close the page and go
back to it if I close these pages and
then opencounter.html again I've gone
back to zero like JavaScript is not
saving any state about my page it's just
every time we're running the page it's
going to go back to counter.js it's
going to say all right we're defining a
variable called counter we're setting
that variable equal to zero so every
time I load the page it's going to be
set back to zero and that might not be
great depending on the type of page
you're trying to create that maybe you
want a page that is somehow able to
store information such that on
subsequent visits we're able to utilize
the information that was already stored
some way of remembering information for
later use
and later versions of JavaScript and
more modern browsers now allow us to do
something just like that called local
storage and what local storage is is
it's a way for us to be able to store
information inside of the user's web
browser that a page can ask to store
particular values inside the web browser
and later on on subsequent visits to
that page we can go back and say let's
extract those values that were
previously stored inside of local
storage
local storage is going to give us access
to two key functions that we're going to
use to manipulate this local storage the
first is
localstorage.getitem where we would like
to get something out of local storage
based on its key some name that we have
given to that value and we also have
access to localstorage.set item which
goes ahead and adds a new value to local
storage or replaces an existing value in
local storage setting this key equal to
a particular value so we can use local
storage then to allow our web pages
using JavaScript to be able to store
information and retrieve information
from the browser and let's now try to
use that in order to
solve this problem of the counter that
seems to always reset back to zero
so now in counter.js instead of
sentencounter equal to zero the first
thing I want to know is is there already
a value for the counter in local storage
so I can ask a question
like if local storage dot get item
counter meaning go to local storage
try and get the counter
and anything in this if expression will
happen if there is something inside of
local storage for counter but it turns
out that if I want to do the inverse of
that say not I can just use the
exclamation point much like in C in
JavaScript the exclamation point just
means not so meaning if there is not
something in local storage called
counter
well then let's go ahead and just set
the value in local storage local storage
dot set item counter and we'll set it
equal to zero
so what this is doing here is before
anything else happens we are checking
local storage to say is there already a
value for counter and if there is not
already a value for counter we need to
make sure there is something there
inside of local storage for the counter
so we are going to set the value of
counter equal to zero for example
and so now what needs to change I'll go
ahead and get rid of the interval so
that it only happens when I click on it
but what should this count function
actually do
well first let me get the value of the
counter
counter is going to be whatever
localstorage dot get item counter is I'm
going to get the counter out of local
storage I'm going to increment it
counter plus plus
we'll go ahead and set the value of this
H1 elements inner HTML equal to that
counter
but the last step is I'll also do local
storage dot set item
counter is equal to the new value of
counter
so what I've done here is to say that
when I click the button count function
is going to run we're first going to go
into local storage get the value for the
key counter whatever the value of
counter happens to be save it inside of
this variable called counter we'll go
ahead and increment that variable
setting it equal to itself plus one
update the H1s inner HTML same as before
just to update what we actually see on
the page but then go ahead and
localstorage.set item counter gets set
to counter for example
so now
let's go ahead and see what's going to
happen
if I go ahead and open counter.html
we see Zero
we count one two three four five
everything so far so good now watch what
happens if I refresh this page I refresh
the page
and all right that seems a little bit
strange it's zero let me try counting
and see what happens I press count
and all right the count changed to six
so it seems like it did remember that I
counted up to five zero one two three
four five but when I refresh the page it
still showed me zero but then let me
count up to the number six and I can
keep counting seven eight nine ten what
happens if I refresh the page now I can
try it I refresh the page I've gone back
to zero but I count and okay now I'm at
11. so somehow I am still remembering
but the first time it's still giving me
zero every time why might that be
well if you look back at counter.html
you'll notice that the reason is just
inside the body of the page the initial
value of the H1 is just always zero so
if I want to fix that then what I need
to say is when the Dom content is loaded
go ahead and get
document.queryselector H1 go ahead and
update the inner HTML equal to
whatever local storage dot get item
counter happens to be so every time I
open the page even before I click the
button even before the event listener is
triggered I'd like to say go ahead and
replace this heading update its inner
HTML to be the result of getting the
counter out of local storage for example
so now if I refresh the page it's at 11
I can update update update click again
some number of times bring it up to 18
for example refresh the page and it
stays at the number 18 and no matter
what value I get it to it's going to
store that number inside of local
storage such that when I refresh the
page that number is going to stay there
and we can actually see the value inside
of local storage by again going into
Chrome's inspector I go into Chrome if I
go to the application tab
and I go to local storage here on the
left
I can see that I have a value for T
counter whose value in this case happens
to be 28 and you could go into local
storage you can manipulate this value
you could delete it if you want but this
just goes to show you that we have now
stored this value inside of my browser
such that on subsequent visits if this
page gets loaded again we can access
that value from inside of the
application as well
and so now we've been able to see how
our pages are able to store data in
order to just make the user experience a
little bit better if we want the user to
be able to have information remembered
from the last time they visited a
particular page we can sometimes
actually be quite helpful
all right so now we've seen a lot of
features of JavaScript we've seen a
bunch of different ways of representing
data we've stored data in variables and
those variables have had types like
integers those variables of some has
been strings sometimes have been HTML
elements sometimes they've been arrays
or lists of items sometimes they've even
been functions you can set a variable
equal to a function but perhaps one of
the most useful data types inside of
JavaScript is the JavaScript object so
go into the JavaScript console just to
demonstrate this with the JavaScript
object is is it's really the equivalent
of like a python dictionary some
Association of keys to values where you
can look up something by a key or by a
property and see what its value happens
to be
so if I had a variable like person
I could set person equal to a JavaScript
object whose like first name is Harry
and whose last name is Potter
again using syntax very similar to what
the dictionary syntax looks like inside
of python as well and now that I have
this variable person which is first
Harry last Potter I can access a
particular property of the person in a
number of ways I can say something like
person DOT first to say get me the first
name property of this particular object
and I see that it's equal to Harry I
could equivalently use square bracket
notation the way python does square
bracket first and that will also give me
Harry
but this turns out to be quite powerful
to be able to represent data in this
structured way like this where I have an
association of keys otherwise known as
properties with particular values and
then I have the ability given a
JavaScript object to be able to access a
particular value and it turns out that
one of the ways this is most useful is
in the exchange of data moving data
around from one service to another and
so here we're going to introduce what
are known as apis otherwise known as
application programming interfaces which
in the context of the web you can think
of as some well-defined structured way
for services on the internet to
communicate with each other that if you
want your application to be able to talk
to some other servers maybe you want
your application to interact with Google
Maps or to be able to interact with
Amazon or some other Weather Service to
get the day's weather then you might be
able to access some API some mechanism
whereby you can communicate with another
service by sending a request and
receiving back data in some sort of very
well structured format and very often
that well-structured format happens to
be a particular type of data known as
Json which stands for JavaScript object
notation which is a way of transferring
data in the form of JavaScript objects
these sort of objects that happen to
have properties and values associated
with them and so what does JavaScript
object notation look like well if we
think back to the applications that
we've been creating these applications
that are able to represent things like
an airline and movements of planes
between particular destinations a
JavaScript object representing a flight
might look something like this a
JavaScript object that has properties
for origin is something destination is
something duration is something things
we've seen before but you might imagine
that if we wanted our airline to be able
to make its data available to other
services so that other web applications
or other programs could programmatically
access information about flights we
could pass data in this format to those
other applications so that they could
then treat this as a JavaScript object
and get access to the information about
it and the nice thing about this
particular representation is that it is
both human readable and machine readable
that we as people can look at this and
get an intuitive understanding for what
all of this means but also a computer
knows how to access particular
properties that appear before the colon
and get access to what those values are
which appear after that colon as well so
JavaScript object notation otherwise
known as Json offers a very convenient
representation and this isn't exactly
what the JavaScript object syntax is in
JavaScript objects you don't strictly
need the quotation marks around the keys
you could just say origin colon and not
origin and quotation marks so JavaScript
object notation uses slightly different
syntax But ultimately very reminiscent
of what we've seen in JavaScript objects
and JavaScript knows how to take data in
this form and turn it into something
like a JavaScript object and turns out
there are ways of doing this in python
as well in other programming languages
have the ability to interpret Json data
in order to use it in some meaningful
way
and another advantage of the Json
representation is that it's very
conducive to representing structures of
things so these values don't just need
to be strings or numbers they could be
lists or arrays that happen to have a
sequence of possible values or they
could even be other JavaScript objects
that if we wanted to represent not just
a city name but represent the city name
and the airport code for example as we
saw that we wanted to do before I could
instead of having origin be equal to a
string like New York have origin be
equal to yet another JavaScript object
that contains a city property and a code
property where the city is the name of
the city and the code is the name of the
airport code and the important thing is
as long as I and the person I'm
communicating with agree upon this
representation agree upon what the names
of these keys are and what the structure
of this Json payload this Json object
happens to be then the person on the
receiving end can take this data and
write a program that's able to interpret
it and use that data in some meaningful
way
and so we'll see an example of this now
of using JavaScript to be able to
communicate with yet another online
service in particular for accessing
information about currency exchange
rates currency exchange rates are always
changing we want access to the latest
currency exchange rate data and if there
is an online service an API that
provides access to that data in Json
form in a format like this that is
machine readable then we can use that
data to write a stock a currency
exchange application that uses real-time
data in order to make those conversions
what might that data look like well the
data could look something like this that
we make a request for accessing what are
the exchange rates for converting from
US Dollars otherwise known as USD and we
get back a Json object that looks like
this
that has a base key of USD and then it
has a rates key that has a whole bunch
of rates within it so conversion to
euros and Japanese Yen Great British
written pounds as well as Australian
dollars and all of the various different
currency exchange rates for all of these
different currencies for example and
this doesn't have to be the way that
this data is structured but it happens
to be a convenient way and so long as
the person providing this data to me and
I both know what this structure is we
can begin to write programs that are
able to use that data and so we'll now
see our example of an API which is a
exchange rates API dot IO and if we go
to api.exchange rates API dot IO latest
and provide a get parameter of Base
equals US Dollars then what we get back
is data that looks like this
now it's a little bit messy looking not
nearly as clean as we saw before but
it's the same exact thing just without
the white space we have a JavaScript
object that has a rates key that tells
me all right here is the exchange rate
between US Dollars and Canadian dollars
and the pound and the Euro and other
currencies that exist as well and down
below we have the base of what base
currency we're converting from so all of
this data can come back to me if I just
make an HTTP request I make a web
request to this particular URL I then
get access to all of this currency
exchange rate information that I can
then use inside of my application
so how can I do this how can I now begin
to use this information inside of an
application
let's now create a new page
I'm going to call this currency.html
inside of currency.html
I'll add our usual HTML a title of
currency exchange and a body
and inside the body I'm just going to
include nothing for now what I really
care about is the JavaScript that is
going to make a web request in order to
get access to additional data now so far
in JavaScript our JavaScript code has
exclusively been running code that
exists only on our computer it's running
inside the web browser and all happening
inside the web browser we're not
communicating with some external server
what we'll take a look at now is
something known as Ajax which was about
asynchronous JavaScript where the idea
is that even after a page has loaded
using JavaScript we can make additional
web requests to ask for additional
information either from our own web
servers or from some third-party web
servers if we want additional
information on our page and what we want
in this case is for our page to make an
asynchronous request request for
additional data about the current
currency exchange rates for example
so how am I going to do that well I want
to do this after
the Dom content is loaded
so we'll add that usually there
and what we're going to take advantage
of is a function built into more recent
versions of JavaScript and supported by
most major browsers now and it's a
function called Fetch and what fetch is
going to do is it is going to make a web
request it is going to query some
website it could be our own it could be
someone else's and it's going to get
back some HTTP response from that page
and I'm going to fetch and the page I'm
going to fetch is this URL
api.exchange rates api.io latest base
equals USD and the only reason I happen
to know how this API works is because
I've read the api's documentation that
describes how the URL parameters work
and what the structure of the data that
I get back is
and so I'm here going to say go ahead
and fetch from this URL make a HTTP
request asking for additional
information from this URL and get back
what the results are going to be and
what fetch gives back to us is something
in JavaScript known as a promise and A
promise is going to be a way of
representing the idea that something is
going to come back but it may not come
back immediately we're not going to go
into the details of exactly how those
promises work but it turns out there's a
particular Syntax for dealing with them
which is that I can say after I fetch I
can add a line called dot then
that says what should I do when the
promise comes back once I get back
something like a response
and so when I get back the response what
I want to do is convert the response
into Json treat it as Json data Java a
JavaScript object as something that I
can then manipulate and so what I can do
is just use this as a function to say go
ahead and return response
dot Jason
and so what this is saying is go ahead
and get me the latest exchange rates and
then after that's done this is an
asynchronous process it might take some
time but once I get back those results
then run this function take the response
and return the Json version of the
response convert that response into just
the raw Json data such that I can use
that data to then access the currency
exchange rates and it turns out that
with arrow functions if you ever have a
very simple function that all it's doing
is taking something and returning
something else I can simplify this
function even further and just say I can
emit the curly braces I can omit the
return I can just say response arrow
response.json and this is a shorthand
way of saying a function that takes as
input the response and returns as output
response.json
so here I'm saying go ahead and fetch me
the latest exchange rates from this
particular API
then convert the response to Json data
and then once you have the data
here's what I want you to do with that
data
and for now let's just go ahead and
console.log that data just to print it
out to the terminal so we're not doing
anything else just yet all I'm doing is
saying get me the exchange rates convert
the exchange rates data into Json and
then let's go ahead and print out that
data
so I'll open up
currency.html it's a blank page but if I
look in the JavaScript inspector I see
what got logged is a JavaScript object
here indicated by the word object and if
I click the triangle at left I can open
up and see all right inside of this
object is all of this data about
exchange rates
for a whole bunch of different exchange
rates for converting from the US dollar
we're here US dollar one means one US
dollar is one US dollar for example
so now that I've got this data let's
actually try and use this inside of the
program maybe let's say I want to
convert between US Dollars and the euro
to figure out what the conversion rate
is between dollars in euros well if we
recall what the data looks like the data
is a JavaScript object where we have a
key called rate and inside of rates is
this object and inside of that object I
can access the EUR property to get the
exchange rate of one US dollar is equal
to some number of Euros for example so
it's inside of the rates key and then
inside of the EUR key and that's how I
know what to get access to inside of my
data
so
what I really want to do
is accessdata dot rates
dot EUR that says get me all the data
that came back access the rates key
and then access the Euro key
and we'll go ahead and save that in a
variable called rate
and now I'll just document.queryselect
your body
dot innerhtml equals rate just like take
that rate put it inside of the body
so now if I refresh currency.html
what I see is just this value
0.908843 which means that right now one
US dollar happens to be equal to about
0.91 Euros for instance
so that's useful I could make this a
little more human friendly by putting
this inside of a template string I could
say one US dollar is equal to and then
rate
Euros for example
and so now if I refresh the page
I see one US dollar is equal to this
many euros and even this is a little bit
annoying I probably don't care about it
to this many decimal places unless I'm
really in the mood to be very precise
about these exchange rates if I only
care about it to like three decimal
places for example it turns out
JavaScript has functions I can use on
numbers like rate dot two fixed passing
in three as an argument there to mean
I'd like to take this exchange rate and
just round it to three decimal places
for example
so now I refresh the page and I see one
US dollar is equal to 0.909 euros and
the interesting thing about what's
Happening Here is this is happening as a
result of an asynchronous request I am
asking for the latest exchange rates and
when I get back the exchange rates data
JavaScript is plugging that information
into the body of the page I know
communicating with an API getting back
that api's data in Json form and then
using that data to update the contents
of my HTML page
of course in practice if I really want a
currency exchange web page I probably
don't just want to display the exchange
rate between US Dollars and Euros I
probably want to let the user pick what
currencies they would like to exchange
between and so here's how I might go
about doing that
inside of the body of the page now
rather than just have an empty body
let's go ahead and add a form
that forum is going to have an input
whose ID is currency just so I have a
way of referencing it later the
placeholder will just be currency and
the type of it is text
and then I'll have an input whose type
is submit and we'll give it a value of
convert that'll be what the button says
it says convert and then I can convert
to a particular currency
and then I need some place to put my
results so I'll go ahead and add a div
whose ID is result and this is where
after I've done all the currency
conversion this is where I'm going to
put the results of doing that currency
conversion
so now rather than fetch right away
here's what I need to do I need to do
something only when the form is
submitted so I can get the form
by saying document.queryselector form
dot on submit equals this function and
I'm going to go ahead and just in
advance return false at the end of the
function so we don't actually try and
submit the form to another page I just
want to run everything locally on this
same page
but now inside of this form once you
submit it that is when I want to run
this code that is going to fetch new
data so I'm going to fetch data from the
exchange rates API convert that data to
Json same as before then go ahead and
get access to that data but now what I
want to do is I want to figure out what
the user actually typed in to the input
field and that is going to be the
currency that I care about getting
access to so I'll create a variable
called currency
which will be equal to document dot
query selector and to write the input
field if I scroll down it has an ID of
currency so if I want to get that input
field I'm going to say get the element
whose ID is currency
and get its value
so this now is the currency that the
user wanted me to get access to
and I can then say data dot rates
currency instead of
data.rates.eur and importantly I can't
do data.rates dot currency that would
literally try to access a property of
rates that is called currency if I use
square brackets instead that allows me
to use a variable something like the
currency variable which are defined up
here on line 13 as the currency that the
user typed in I would like to access
that particular currency inside of the
rates
and so now I can ask a question there
are two possibilities here either the
currency the user typed in is a valid
currency or it's not and it turns out
that if you try and access a property of
an object that doesn't exist what you
get back is a particular JavaScript
variable called undefined meaning there
is no value there so for example if I
have something like let person equal
first name is Harry and last name is
Potter like we did before I can access
something like person.first and get
Harry I can access person.last and get
Potter but if I access person dot middle
that is going to be a special variable
in JavaScript or Special Value in
JavaScript called undefined meaning
there is no value there
slightly different from null which also
has a similar meaning they're used in
slightly different contexts so here what
I can say is if the rate is not
undefined
well then let's go ahead and update
not the body but the result
to say one US dollar is equal to this
rate not necessarily Euros but whatever
the currency happens to be
and otherwise let's go ahead and
document.queryselector result
dot inner HTML equals invalid currency
just to let the user know that the
currency they tried to provide is not
actually a valid currency and so we're
going to need to try a different
currency in order to get the result to
work
so now here's what we can do
if I open up currency.html again I now
see a form where I can type in a
currency I can type in something like
the Euro for example press convert and I
see all right one US dollar equal to
0.909 euros I type in something like the
pound press convert one US dollar equal
to 0.771 pounds I type in the Japanese
Yen one US dollar is equal to 109.852
Japanese Yen and all of this is
happening where every time I submit the
form it's making yet another request so
if the exchange rates happen to change
in between when I submit the form the
next time I submit the form I will be
getting the latest exchange rates
according to that exchange rates API and
the results are going to come back here
and of course if I type in a currency
that doesn't exist I type in something
like Foo for example and press convert
invalid currency so it's going to report
back to me that it wasn't able to find
that currency and so it tells me that I
need to type in something valid and so I
can type in something valid maybe I
tried just US Dollars itself it tells me
one US dollar is equal to one US dollar
exactly what I would expect it to be
now there are a couple of optimizations
and improvements that we can make here
one is that I can search for euros right
now with EUR press convert but if I
search for euros in lower case for
example it turns out it thinks that's an
invalid currency and the reason why is
because if you look at the data that
comes back to me from the API this is
the data that I get back from the
exchange rates API what you'll notice is
that all of the currencies are all in
capital letters they're all capital
letters all capital letters which means
the only keys that I'm allowed to access
are in fact those that have capital
letters in them because these are the
only keys that this API makes available
to me
so if I want to convert between US
Dollars and Euros lowercase what I might
want to do is first take the currency
the thing the user typed in and first
just call to uppercase on it which is a
JavaScript function that takes a string
and converts it to uppercase I'd like to
take whatever the user typed in and now
just first convert it to uppercase that
way if I go back here I can type in Euro
lowercase press convert and I'm still
able to get the correct conversion rate
the other thing that we won't noticeably
notice the difference with here is that
right now I'm assuming that all of this
is going to go successfully that we're
going to successfully be able to make a
web request we'll successfully convert
the response back to Json but you never
know an API could go down the API could
change and do something unexpected and
so anytime you're dealing with these
types of promises where you fetch
something and say then do this then do
that it can often be a good idea to add
one last case which is a a catch case
that basically says what should you do
if something goes wrong so I can say
catch the error and what I can just do
is say like console.log
error and then log the error there and
all that's really saying is that if
anything above goes wrong with the
fetching and trying to process the
response it's going to catch the error
and then we'll just like print out to
the console that something went wrong
some error message happened and so that
can be helpful nice to have just to make
sure that when things crash they crash
in a predictable way that you're able to
see exactly what the error is
just by looking inside the JavaScript
console and so now we have a fully
working web page that is able to
communicate with an external API that is
able to ask for information from another
service on the internet use those
results and put them back into the page
really just going to show the power now
that we get by taking advantage of the
JavaScript language we have the ability
now to not only use JavaScript to be
able to run code on the client where we
weren't able to before where right
before we only had python code that was
running on a web server but using
JavaScript the really powerful thing is
now the ability to manipulate the Dom
the ability to use JavaScript to take
the page and change the contents of the
Page by updating things by reading what
happens to be on the page whether it's
inside of a particular element or what a
user happened to type in and using that
in conjunction with event handlers ways
that we can listen for when the user
clicks on something or when the user
Scrolls through something or when the
user types a key to be able to respond
and therefore make our web pages all the
more Interactive
next time we'll continue our discussion
of JavaScript looking at how we can
leverage the features of JavaScript to
continue to build even more interesting
and engaging user interfaces so we'll
see you next time
[Music]
welcome back everyone to web programming
with python and JavaScript and last time
we took a look at JavaScript that
language that ran inside of a user's web
browser client-side and allowed us to do
a number of things to make our web pages
more interactive JavaScript enabled us
to display alerts to be able to
manipulate the Dom the structure of the
web page in order to add content or see
what content was already there and it
also let us respond to user events when
a user clicked on a button or submitted
a form or typed something into an input
field we could have JavaScript functions
run that responded to those events in
order to make our web pages more
interactive today we're going to
continue that conversation in particular
taking a look at user interface design
looking at some common paradigms in
terms of user interfaces and how we can
leverage JavaScript to be able to
achieve those goals to create
interactive user interfaces that will be
valuable when users are interacting with
our applications so one of the more
common paradigms especially nowadays in
web programming is the idea of single
page applications thus far if we want to
create a web application that has
multiple different pages we've generally
done that by multiple different routes
in our Django web application for
example where you go to slash something
to get one page and slash something else
in order to get another page
but commonly using JavaScript we have
the ability to create single page
applications where the entire web page
is really just a single page and then we
use JavaScript to manipulate the Dom to
replace portions of the page with things
we want to replace and this has a number
of advantages one of them being that we
only need to make modifications to the
part of the page that is actually
changing if for example you have five
different pages but the general layout
and structure of the page is pretty
similar when you switch between Pages
rather than load an entirely new page
you can just load the part of the page
that is changing and this is especially
helpful for applications that are
changing quite frequently so let's take
a look now at how we could Implement for
example a very simple single page
application so let's imagine for example
that we want a single page application
that just displays three different pages
but all included in the same page I'll
go ahead and create a new file that I'll
call single page.html
inside of which we'll include our usual
HTML tags
and inside the body of this page now I'm
going to include three different
sections of the page to represent the
three different pages I might want to
display to the user so I'll have a div
whose ID is page one that maybe just has
a heading that says this is page one and
you could imagine there's more content
on these Pages as well idea of whose ID
is page two we'll say this is page two
and then one final day of whose ID is
Page Three
it has a heading that says this is Page
Three for example
now right now if I were to open up
single page.html what we'd see is we see
all three pages at the same time and now
that's probably not what we want what we
really want is by default to hide these
Pages until we want to view the pages
one at a time for example so one thing I
could do is use CSS to be able to toggle
whether or not something is visible
adding some style tags to my page to say
that by default
all of my divs should have a display
property set To None meaning they're not
visible they're not displayed on the
screen
now if I refresh the page I don't
actually see any of the three headings
that I had there before
but what I'd really like is for some
buttons now to allow me to toggle
between these three pages so I'll give
myself three buttons one button that
says page one one button that says page
two and one button that says page three
for example
and I need some mechanism for these
buttons to know when you click on this
button what page should be displayed so
I'll go ahead and use data attributes
which we saw last time with JavaScript
to add some additional information to
these particular HTML elements where
I'll give the first button a data Dash
page value of page one the second one a
data Dash page value of page two and the
third one a data Dash page value of Page
Three here again just providing
information so that later when I write
some JavaScript I can have the
JavaScript code look at the data Dash
page attribute to say that when you
click on this button you should let me
see the div whose ID is page one that's
what this is going to allow us to signal
so now let's go ahead and write that
JavaScript
what I want to be able to do is to be
able to say I would like to show page
one and hide the other two or show page
two and hide the other two or show page
three for example and so to do that I'll
first write a function that will let me
do that I'll write a function called
show page that takes us its argument
like what page I want to show
and so what should this function do
what we're going to do is we're going to
say document.queryselector and I want to
get the thing that has a particular ID
the ID of whatever this input happens to
be this page is going to represent the
ID of the div that I want to show so
I'll say get me the thing that has this
ID and then using a template literal
I'll say all right get me the ID of page
whatever element has that particular ID
and then I'd like to change its style
property which part of the style well I
want to change its display property and
instead of none which was the default
here where I said don't don't show it at
all the other option for a div is block
meaning it shows up as just a block that
is on the page that is actually visible
and so now I have this show page
function and I can test it in fact if I
go into my browser refresh the page I
now see three buttons the buttons don't
do anything just yet
but what I can do is in the console if I
actually just try running this I can run
the show page function and say like show
page page one for example press return
and all right page one now appears on my
page and if I rest show page page two
then page two will become visible and
all right that did half of what I wanted
page two is now visible but so is page
one so I probably want it such that if I
ever show a page I hide the other Pages
first like hide all the pages and then
show page two or hide all the pages and
then show page three so how could I go
about doing that
well first I might want to just when I
show a page first hide all of the other
Pages hide all the pages so to get all
the pages I'll do document.queryselector
all
get all of the divs which is what I'm
using to include and close the pages
and now for each one of those again
effectively creating a loop where I'm
looping over each of the divs for each
div let's go ahead and set the div.style
dot display property equal to none
and so what this show page function is
now doing is it is first querying for
all of the divs which are simulating my
pages inside of the single page
application and for each one of the divs
we're going to pass it as input into
this function which is the argument to
for each again using this Arrow function
notation which is just a shorthand way
of expressing a function where I'm here
saying that for each of the divs we'll
go ahead and modify its style property
setting display equal to none meaning
don't show any of the divs and then show
only the div that was requested so now
this should solve the problem of
multiple Pages appearing simultaneously
that if I go back to this page and I
click or write show page page one
then page one appears but if I run show
page of page 2
then page two appears but page one
disappears and likewise when I show page
page three that shows page three but not
the other two so I can manipulate which
page is visible all via the console but
now what I'd like to do is get these
buttons to actually work where if I
click on one of the buttons that has the
effect of actually displaying the
requested page
so in order to do that well I want to
attach some event listeners to these
buttons which means I need to wait until
those buttons have loaded onto the page
so we'll use document dot add event
listener
Dom content loaded again waiting until
all of the content on the page has been
loaded
and then and only then
will I say
let's go ahead and query selector all
for all of the buttons
and for each one of those buttons let's
go ahead and attach an event listener to
each of those buttons so I'm querying
for all of the buttons and saying for
each of the buttons I would like to do
this with each button and what I'd like
to do is say button dot on click when
the button is clicked on
go ahead and run this function I'd like
to show page and which page do I want to
show well I want to show whatever page
is in the page part of the buttons data
set and to get it the current button the
button that has been clicked on recall
that when we're inside of an event
handler we can take advantage of the
JavaScript keyword this which refers to
whatever element has received the event
so whatever button in this case that was
clicked on so I can say this dot dataset
dot page to mean that all right for each
of the buttons when the button is
clicked on we're saying button dot on
click for each of the buttons run this
function when the button is clicked we'd
like to show a page which page do we
want to show we'll take this button the
button that received the event
access its data properties accesses Data
Page attribute which are down here
either page 1 or page two or page three
and go ahead and just call the show page
function that we wrote a moment ago
so now that we've done that we've
attached these event handlers to the
buttons so now if I refresh the page I
can click on these buttons and toggle
between any of the three pages
and now the interesting thing here is
that we now have the ability to just in
a single page allow myself to simulate
the idea of having multiple Pages all
enclosed in a single HTML file but not
needing to consistently make additional
requests to a server in order to get
access to that information
now sometimes though it might be
reasonable to want to reach out to a
server when you need new information for
a page for example you might imagine
that each of these Pages contains a lot
of text it's going to be inefficient if
immediately we're loading all of that
data into HTML and just showing and
hiding them when we need to because
maybe we're loading more information
than the user is ever going to actually
care about if they're never going to
look at page 2 or page 3. so one thing
we might imagine doing is loading this
data dynamically last time when we were
talking about JavaScript we saw how we
could use fetch to say go ahead and
request some additional information from
a web server last time it was currency
exchange rates but then we used that
data that came back in order to fill in
something onto our page and likewise we
could do a similar thing here that if we
have the general structure of a single
page and we want to load new content
rather than load entirely new HTML
content and reload the entire page we
can just ask our own web server for what
part of the page needs to change and
then just replace that part of the page
and so that's what we'll take a look at
now now combining Django for our web
server and JavaScript for writing the
client-side code to be able to generate
a single page application and so for
this we'll go ahead and go into an
example I had in advance called single
page one and inside of single page one
this is just a Django application with a
single app called single page and what
we'll notice is we'll go to the URLs
first
there are two URLs one default URL that
just loads the index function and then a
URL for loading different like sections
of a page that I might want to
dynamically load for example so I have
section slash some particular number
and if we look at the views for what it
is these URLs are actually doing the
index function just returns index.html
and then what the section function does
is it first make sure the number is
between one and three and if so responds
with one of these just strings of text
for example
so how does this actually work if I go
into
a single page one
and run the server
if I go to this URL slash section one
for example what I get is this block of
text and if I go to slash section two I
get that block of text section three a
different block of text altogether so
just different text and I'd like to
incorporate this text into an existing
HTML page for instance
so here I'll go into index.html this
template that gets loaded when I go to
the default route
and inside of index.html
what we'll see
is I have a show section function that
behaves very similar to the show page
function we saw from a moment ago but
instead what show section is going to do
is it's going to fetch what text I
should display on the page from my own
web server I'm fetching from slash
sections slash fill in a number here
number like one or two or three when I
get the response in the past we've seen
how we can convert that response into
Json data if it's some structured data
we can also just convert the response
into plain text then I'll take that text
console.log it just so we can see it in
the log output but then go ahead and
query select for the content of the page
something that has an ID of content
update its inner HTML and set it equal
to that text so what this entire
function is now doing is it is going to
reach out to my server figure out what
text content belongs in the new section
and fill in the part of my page
accordingly with the text that comes
back from that HTTP request
and then down further below inside of
the page we'll see that I have a Hello
heading three buttons that toggle
between the different sections each of
them has a data Dash section attribute
this time for which section should be
loaded and then a div that is initially
blank just for the content of the page
so putting this all together now
if I go to the default route I see Hello
plus three buttons to give me a choice
between three different sections and if
I click section one what's going to
happen is Javascript is going to query
slash section one ask for the text it
gets that text back and it's going to
fill it in into the page section one
section two and section three so very
similar to before but unlike what we had
before where all of the text was being
loaded into the HTML page all at once
now we're using asynchronous JavaScript
to only dynamically load information
when we need it when we click on a
section then it's going to make the
request for what content needs to be
filled in and it's going to fill it in
and everything else these buttons this
heading and you might imagine in a more
complex website you've got a lot more
going on around the edges of this web
page all of that stays the same we don't
need to reload any of that information
we're only reloading the portion of the
page that actually changes as we toggle
between these various different section
headings
now this seems to be an advantage in
some ways that maybe we can be more
efficient about how we run our single
page applications like this one thing we
seem to lose though is the notion of
maintaining State inside of the URL that
generally the URL gives you an
indication for what page you're on
you're on something like slash one if
you're on section one or slash two if
you're on section two slash three for
section three but of course we're
staying on the same page in all of these
examples whenever I click a button
section one or two or three the URL is
never changing the URL stays the same it
turns out there's a way in JavaScript to
manipulate that URL taking advantage of
what's known as the JavaScript history
API where I can push something to the
history meaning update the URL and
actually save that inside the user's
browser history so later on they could
potentially go back to that
and to do that I'll show you yet another
example inside of a single page two
which is very similar except inside of
index.html I've added a couple
additional things
one is that when I click on a button
meaning when I click on Section 1 or
section 2 or Section 3 I've added this
line here
history.push State when history.push
state is going to do is it is going to
basically add a new element to my
browsing history where I first specify
any data associated with the state so in
particular I'm storing a JavaScript
object representing what section number
is being represented here next is a
title parameter that most web browsers
actually ignore so that can generally be
the empty string but the third argument
here is what should go in the URL and
what I want to go in the URL in this
case is something like section followed
by the section number so I can go to
slash section one or slash section two
or slash Section 3 for instance and
those will appear in the URL bar when I
click on a different page
then what I want to be able to support
is the ability to say when I go back
through my history if I click the back
button in my web browser I'd like to go
back from section 3 to section two if
that was the page I visited previously
and then it turns out to be an event
handler for that as well window dot on
pop State meaning when I pop something
off of the history like go back in my
history
we have the ability to take some event
as an argument and if you look at
event.state.section which I've
run console.log on so we can take a look
at it in a moment we'll see what state
was stored associated with that part of
the user's history and I can go ahead
and show that section
so all in all when I run this web
application going into single page two
this time
when I run the server
I see Hello three sections for buttons
when I click on one of those buttons not
only do I see text but I also see in the
URL bar that I'm now on slash section
one that has been pushed onto my history
and I've updated the URL to reflect that
too I click section two that updates the
URL as well Section 3 updates the URL
too and when I've pushed things onto my
history I've Associated some state with
them so that I can go back if I ever
need to and in fact if I open up the
JavaScript console now and I go back for
example back to section two what you'll
see is that what gets logged is the
number two when I print out like what is
the current section that's associated
with this URL it's saving that state
that I should be loading section number
two and so it does load section number
two here
so there's certainly nothing wrong with
the original Paradigm of just loading
different pages dynamically using Django
like make a request and get a response
but oftentimes as you begin to imagine
applications where a lot of things are
changing on the same page simultaneously
you might imagine social networking
websites where a lot of things stay the
same but new posts might be added and
you might be looking at different parts
of the same page being able to
dynamically load information request
additional information and then display
it on the page can actually be quite
powerful a way to make your web pages a
little bit more Interactive so that then
is how we might build single page
applications taking advantage of
JavaScript to asynchronously load new
data and then taking advantage of this
history API that let us add things to
the URL add things to the user's
browsing history such that we could go
back to them later by listening for
window dot on pop State and it turns out
that window object that we get access to
in JavaScript is quite powerful it
represents the physical window on the
computer screen that displays all of
their web content and there are certain
properties of that window we can look at
that allow us to enable some interesting
features so for example your window is
really described by what the user
actually sees inside of their window in
Google Chrome or Safari or whatever web
browser they happen to be using and
there are a couple of properties that
might be of use something like
window.inner width will represent how
wide is the window which might be useful
to know to know like the size of the
user's screen for example to know how
many pixels wide the window happens to
be and just as there's a window.inter
with there's also a window.inner height
that represents
the height of the window as well now
window represents the physical part that
they're actually seeing we've also seen
another variable that JavaScript gives
us access to and that is this document
object so what is the difference between
the window and the document well the
document generally represents the entire
web page but if web pages are long
oftentimes the web page doesn't fit
entirely inside of the window that you
generally have to scroll through an
entire web page and the windows only
showing you one portion of that page in
any given time so you can represent the
document as like this big vertical
section that goes beyond the window
there might be part of the document that
is above the window part of the document
that is below the window as well
so window.scroll Y is another variable
you have access to on the window and
window.scroll Y represents how many
pixels far down have you scrolled so if
you're at the top of the page
window.scroll Y is zero you haven't
scrolled at all but as you begin to
scroll if you want to know how far the
user has scrolled on a page you can look
at window.scroll y to figure out the
number of pixels the user has scrolled
in the y direction the up and down
Direction
and the entire height of the page is
represented in
document.body.offset height that
represents how tall the entire height of
the document is and we talk about all
this in addition to things like
window.inner height and window.inter
with because using all of these values
together you can begin to do some
interesting calculations so one thing
you might want to detect for example is
has the user scrolled down to the bottom
of the page or not that might be
something you care about knowing and it
turns out there isn't an event listener
that does this automatically but we can
calculate it in order to try and figure
this out if inner height is the height
of the window scroll y is how far
vertically the user has scrolled and
document body offset height is the
entire height of the document you can
ask yourself what needs to be true if
the user has scrolled to the bottom of
the page
and well if the user is scrolled to the
bottom of the page well then scroll why
plus the inner height meaning the amount
they've scrolled plus the height of the
window that must be at least or equal to
document body offset height meaning the
amount that they scrolled plus the
window takes you down to the bottom of
the page to the end of the page to
whoever tall the document happens to be
and using that mathematical comparison
we can actually detect when the user has
reached the bottom of the page and we
can actually try and now put that into
practice so I'll go ahead and open up an
example that I have here
called scroll.html and all scroll.html
has right now is 100 paragraphs inside
of the body tag I have a p for paragraph
paragraph one paragraph two so on and so
forth I have 100 paragraphs inside of
the body of this HTML page and that's
all that really is there right now such
that now if I go ahead and open scroll
dot HTML
I see that I have 100 paragraphs that I
can scroll through and what I might like
to do is detect when I've reached the
bottom of the page and maybe do
something when I do so something like
change the color of the page for
instance so how might I go about doing
that well I'm going to need some
JavaScript so I'm going to add some
JavaScript
and I'll add an event listener for
window dot on scroll on scrolling is an
event that listens for when I'm
scrolling through the window
and when I scroll through the window
we'll go ahead and run this function
I'll just use an arrow function as a
shorthand here
what do I want to calculate well I want
to calculate if
window.inner height meaning the height
of the window itself
plus window dot scroll y meaning the
amount that I've scrolled if that is
at least document.body dot offset height
well that means I must have scrolled to
the bottom of the page or maybe even a
little bit further if there's a little
wiggle room to scroll past the end of
the page so if this is true
well then I've reached the end of the
page
and then we'll go ahead and say
document.queryselector body and let's go
ahead and change its style in particular
change its background color
and change the background color to Green
otherwise if we haven't reached the end
of the page then we'll take the body of
the page
and change its background color to white
so what we're now doing here is taking
advantage of the properties we know of
this window object saying when we scroll
the window let's check to see if we add
this up and at least the height of the
entire document we've reached the end of
the page go ahead and change the style
of the background to the body
accordingly otherwise change the
background to white or leave it at White
if it already is
so now if I take a look at this actual
HTML page and reload scroll.html we'll
see that the background is initially
white but as I scroll down once I reach
the bottom
we'll see that the page changes to Green
it's white before I reach the bottom but
as soon as I get to the bottom of the
page it turns to green and the reason
why is because the height of the window
height of the window here plus however
much I've already scrolled from the top
of the page up until now that together
is equal to the entire height of the
document which means we're able to
detect the fact that I reached the end
of the page and as a result we can
change the color of the background to
Green
now this in itself is not a particularly
practical use of detecting when we
scroll to the end of something we
probably don't usually care about
changing the background color when you
reach the end of the page but there
actually are real applications and you
might imagine this in the context of
websites that allow for things like
infinite scroll but if you're on a
social networking site that has a whole
bunch of posts you scroll to the bottom
of the list of posts and then it
generates the new set of posts as well
or you're looking at news articles and
you're scrolling through news articles
and once you reach the bottom it'll load
a whole new set of news articles without
you having to go to another page how is
it doing that well it's a combination of
the same types of ideas that we've been
talking about number one the ability to
detect when you've reached the end of
the page using JavaScript to detect that
you're at the bottom of the page and
number two to be able to asynchronously
load using JavaScript load additional
content fetch some additional page that
has some additional content some
additional news articles some additional
posts and whatnot and then take that
information and manipulate the Dom to
add that information to the existing web
page and that ultimately is what's going
to give us this power
to be able to support something like
infinite scroll
so let's now go ahead and try and see
what it would look like to implement
infinite scroll I've already started to
create a sample application inside of
this application called scroll and I've
got an app called posts inside of it and
what the posts app does is it's got a
couple of URLs it's got a default URL
that just loads an index route and then
a post route that loads this posts view
and so let's look at what these do
index all it does is going to load a
file called index.html this template
and if I make a request to slash posts I
need to provide two arguments
I need to provide a start for what post
I want to start with an N for what post
I want to end with and then it's just
going to generate some sample posts that
just say like Post Number One post
number two so on and so forth in
practice you could actually use social
network posts in place of this but this
is good just for demonstration purposes
so what this is going to do if I go into
scroll and run server
is that if I go to slash post and say
start equals one and end equals 10 for
example
then I get a JavaScript object that
looks like this recall that a JavaScript
object is just a convenient format for
passing information back and forth in
Json format and what we have here is a
Json object with a key called posts that
gives me all of the posts Post Number
One Post Number Two all the way up to
number 10 and it's giving me those posts
because I said start at one end at 10.
but I could have specified other numbers
as well if I had said something like uh
start at 20 and go to 28 then it's going
to give me post number 20 through post
number 28. I can specify the range of
posts that I want so this now is an API
that I have implemented effectively that
allows someone to get access to a
variety of different posts by hitting
this particular URL this endpoint so to
speak and passing in parameters passing
in what posts they want to start with
and what posts they want to end with and
then they get all of this data back
presented to them in Json format that
can then be used
and what's nice about this is that now
when we're loading posts rather than
have to just guess at how many posts we
need to load and then require someone to
go to another page we can just do
something like load the first 20 posts
and now what we'd like to do is if they
reach the end of the page go ahead and
load the next 20 posts by hitting this
API endpoint getting the next 20 posts
and then filling that in into the HTML
page so let's see now how that actually
works in practice by taking a look at
that template in index.html
so go into templates
index.html and there's a fair bit of
JavaScript here but look at the body
first the body just have a has a div for
all the posts that initially is going to
be empty
now here's what the JavaScript is going
to do and we'll walk through it
we start with the first post so counter
is going to keep track of what post we
need to load next by default we're just
going to start by loading Post Number
One
we have a variable called quantity
that's going to tell us how many posts
are we going to load at a time let's
just say load 20 posts at a time so
start with 1 to 20 then 21 to 40 41 to
60 so on and so forth
and when Dom content is loaded go ahead
and just call this function that's
called load and what the load function
does is it figures out what the start
and end should be it fetches all the new
posts and then for each of the posts
that comes back is it figures out what
this so asynchronously asking for new
posts and what the ad post function does
is it creates a new div populates the
post inside of it and adds it to the Dom
so now that we have these parts the
ability to load new posts as by fetching
from some URL all the posts that we care
about and then for each of those posts
that comes back add something new to the
Dom as by creating a new HTML element
and inserting it into the page we have
the ability to dynamically load all of
these posts so if I go not to slash
posts but just to this default route
I'll see that we have something like 20
posts that all show up but just 20 posts
because every time I call the load
function that is going to load the next
set of posts for example and so what I
can do is in the console if I try
running the load function just by
calling it myself press return after a
second or so the next set of posts show
up 21 all the way through 40. I call
load again the next set of posts show up
41 through 60. 20 posts at a time all
using that asynchronous JavaScript
but now what I'd like to happen is for
all this to happen on its own without me
having to intervene and manually write
JavaScript calls I would just like to
say
well the same type of logic as before
window.el and scroll
let's go ahead and say if window.inner
height plus window.scroll y is at least
document.body.offset height meaning if I
have scrolled to the end of the page
well then
just go ahead and call the load function
that's all these lines are doing every
time I scroll we check did we scroll to
the end of the page and if we did scroll
to the end of the page then go ahead and
load the next set of posts
so now
I refresh the page
I see post one all the way up through
post 20. now watch what happens when I
get to post 20 if I scroll to the bottom
after a second the next set of posts
appears I scroll to the bottom again I'm
at 40 and then after a second the next
set appears every time I scroll to the
bottom more posts are going to load
after that allowing you to effectively
implement this idea of infinite
scrolling by taking advantage of some
JavaScript techniques where I can check
for when I've got to the end of the page
and then dynamically do something as a
result of that something like load some
additional Pages onto the screen
and so here too a lot of power to be had
inside of JavaScript and a lot of where
the power of user interface comes from
is from how it is that the user
interface interacts with the user
thinking about what the user is going to
do and how the page should interact as a
result something like user Scrolls to
the end of the page and they see some
new pages show up as well and one
Technique we can use for just making
HTML elements a little more responsive a
little bit more interesting is by adding
some animation to them as well the
ability for things to move around and
change their properties in some way and
it turns out that CSS has support for
animation CSS has already given us
support for things like styling elements
saying we want this element to be of
this color and this size for example but
it also gives us the ability to animate
those properties as well to change the
size of something or change the position
of something over some amount of time
and so let's now take a look at an
example of what that might actually look
like I'll go ahead and create a new file
and I'll call it
animate.html and inside of animate.html
I'll go ahead and start by including
our usual HTML
title is animate
and what I'd like to do is just add a
little bit of Animation using CSS into
this particular page I'm going to start
with just a heading a heading that says
something like
welcome for example it's just going to
display a welcome message such that now
if I open
animate.html
here's what I see just a message that
says welcome
but now let's add some CSS to it
let's go into the style tag
and for H1 for this heading I'd like to
apply a particular animation to it and I
first need to specify what the
animation's name is going to be
and I can pick a name for the animation
I'll say something like grow for example
I'll set the animations duration to be
two seconds
and then the animation fill mode is like
what direction should the animation move
in should it go forwards or should it go
backwards well generally want our
animations to go forward so they're
making some sort of forward progress
According to some rules that we're going
to specify so here I'm saying we're
going to animate all of our headings
using an animation called grow and now I
need to Define what that animation
actually does and to do that up above in
style I'm going to say at keyframes grow
and what this is going to allow me to do
is specify some key frames for this
particular element meaning where should
the element start what should its style
properties be and then at the end what
should the style properties be and CSS
is going to take care of the process of
figuring out what needs to happen in all
those intermediary fractions of seconds
for example
so what I can say is something like go
ahead and grow from meaning what should
its initial properties be and maybe
initially I wanted to have a font size
of 20 pixels and then we'll say 2
font size of 100 pixels for example
so all in all what this is saying is I
would like to apply an animation called
grow to all of my headings this
animation should last two seconds and go
forwards and what is the grow animation
going to do well it's going to mean at
the start anything that obeys the grow
animation we'll start with a font size
of 20 pixels and at the end it will grow
to a font size of 100 pixels and I have
now defined what it is that that
animation means
so now if I go ahead and refresh this
page animate.html
you'll see that welcome changes size
over the course of two seconds it goes
from smaller to larger by obeying those
keyframes I told it to obey this
particular step a set of instructions
where it goes from a particular font
size to another font size and as a
result we see the effect here on the
page and it turns out you can do more
than just manipulate size you can
manipulate just about any CSS property
you want so if I tell the heading that
it should have a relative position
meaning its position should be relative
to other elements or other things and
it's parent I can say you should change
your position from being zero percent
away from the left side of the screen
to being
50 of the way from the left side of the
screen
and at this point grow is probably not
the best name for this animation I'll
call it move instead so animation name
is move and so now what this animation
is going to do is it's going to say when
you run the animation go from being
right next to the left side of the
screen to being about 50 away from the
left side of the screen
so I can go ahead and rerun this
and we see that's the animation that
takes place it goes from the left all
the way back up to about halfway across
the screen refresh the page and it goes
ahead and does the exact same thing and
it turns out we don't just need to
specify a beginning point and an end
point for an animation we can specify
various different keyframes for
different points within the animation
that we would like to capture something
like at the beginning of the animation
have this set of CSS properties maybe
halfway through the animation have a
different set of CSS properties and then
at the very end have yet another set of
CSS properties so I could say something
like if I want the heading not just to
move from left to right but also to move
back again I can say at the beginning at
the zero percent point when you're zero
percent of the way through the animation
you should be zero percent away from the
left hand side
when you're 50 of the way through the
animation you should be 50 away from the
left hand side and then when you're done
with the animation 100 of the way
through let's go back to zero percent
away from the left hand side I now have
three keyframes beginning of the
animation middle of the animation back
to the beginning of the animation again
and the effect of this is if I refresh
the page we go to the right and then we
go back we're able to move One Direction
and then move back
and there are other properties we can
use to manipulate these animations as
well I can set the animation iteration
count for example to two to mean rather
than just do the animation once and then
stop do the animation twice and then
stop so refresh it goes to the right and
then it goes left and then it repeats
that a second time and it turns out if
you really want you can set this to
infinite to mean never stop performing
that animation it's consistently going
to have this heading move to the right
and then move left according to those
keyframes that I've specified and so if
you ever see things moving around on a
page interactive in some way there are a
number of ways to do it you can animate
things using JavaScript for example but
there are many cases where CSS alone is
pretty good at just creating these types
of animations and while this animation
right now is just running forever we
could use JavaScript in order to control
that animation as well so let's see an
example of what that would look like
I'll go back here in the body of the
page in addition to a heading that says
welcome I'll go ahead and add a button
that just says
click here for example
and now what I'll do is add a little bit
of JavaScript
I'm going to add some JavaScript so that
the button can now control the animation
decide when the animation is going to
start and stop
and so what we'll do inside of the
script is to First say document.ad event
listener
Dom content loaded meaning wait until
the Dom is done loading as we've done
before
and let me now get that H1 element
document.queryselector
H1
and initially I'm going to set its style
dot animation playstate equal to
paused
so animation play state is a property of
the style that lets me decide if the
animation is playing or paused and I can
control that using JavaScript rather
than just say run infinitely forever I
can say the animation playstate should
start out as paused by first getting the
H1 element
then modifying the animation play state
property of that particular element
but now what I'd like to happen
is anytime someone clicks on the button
I want to change the animation play
state so I'm going to say
document.queryselector button meaning
get that button
and when someone clicks on the button
let's run this function where if the
current animation play state is paused
well then go ahead and set animation
play State equal to running
and otherwise if it's already running
then let's go ahead and set the
animation play State equal to
paused
so all in all what this function is
going to do is it's going to get me the
heading pause this initially and every
time the button is clicked run this
function where the function says if
we're paused go ahead and start running
the animation otherwise go ahead and
pause the animation by modifying that
animation play state property of the
head
so now if I refresh this page right now
we have welcome plus a button that says
click here and initially everything is
pause there's no animation happening but
I click here and that begins the
animation which would go on indefinitely
until I decide that I want to stop it at
which point I click it again and the
animation pauses and I can control when
to start and when to pause that
animation as well
and so this can be helpful and nice when
you want to create something a little
bit more interactive something animated
on the page but this is especially
helpful because it means that you can
gradually change CSS properties over
time rather than just immediately change
something you have the ability to
animate something to make it work a
little bit better so let's take a look
at an example of how you might put that
idea into practice let's go back to
our posts example where we had this
infinite scrolling let's suppose but
imagine now that we want the ability to
hide posts when we're done with them so
I've prepared an example called hide
which is very similar to what we had
before
but this time I've just added one extra
button and the button says hide on every
single div right now clicking the hide
button does nothing we'll go ahead and
Implement that in just a moment but
first to see how this worked if you go
into hide go into the index.html
template the only change that's been
made here is what happens when I add a
new post recall again that what this
application does is it loads posts from
a server and then when it gets those
posts it Loops over each of the
individual posts which is a string of
text and it adds that string of text
inside of an element onto the page via
this add post function
and what the ad post function is going
to do here is first create a new element
create a div in which to store that post
give it a class name because that's how
we're going to animate it and then set
its inner HTML equal to the contents of
the post something like Post Number One
Post Number Two post number three
and then add a button that just says
hide
and then we're going to go ahead and add
that to the Dom as well
so that's what ad post is now going to
do we're sort of generating some HTML
using this JavaScript code and then
adding that HTML to the page and now
what we're adding is a div that has not
only the contents of the post as text
but it's also going to give us access to
a button that ultimately we hope is
going to let us hide that post as well
so how do we actually get the hiding of
the post to work well what we want to do
is somehow detect when the user clicks
on one of those hide buttons so there's
a number of ways we could do this but
one way is just to listen for any time
anyone clicks
on the document as a whole
anytime anyone clicks on the document I
might like to ask something like what
did they actually click on and it turns
out that with most event listeners the
function the event listener takes in can
take as an optional argument the event
itself which is a JavaScript object that
contains information about the event
that happened like the Click event or
the scroll event or the key down event
or the key up event for example and one
of the properties you get access to is
event dot Target which is like what was
the target of the event in this case
what was the thing that was actually
clicked on and I'll go ahead and save
event.target inside of a variable
called element where the idea now is
that whatever gets clicked on that is
the event's Target we're going to save
that inside of element and what I want
to know is is element is that one of the
Hide buttons I want to know is it a hide
button I could have also attached an
event listener to each of the Hide
buttons this is just an alternative way
of doing it that I'm showing you for
sake of demonstration where we say when
we click anywhere in the document figure
out what was clicked on and save it
inside of this variable and if it's a
hide button then it's going to have a
class of hide right because I gave every
class every hide button a class of hide
and so what I can say is
if element dot class name equals hide
well that means that what was clicked on
is something with a class of hide we can
assume that it is in fact a hide button
and then what I want to do is I can do
something like element dot remove to say
go ahead and get rid of that element
so now what does this do
if I refresh the page let's try it post
number one if I hide it I want to hide
Post Number One
all right that didn't quite work it was
close it got rid of the Hide button but
I didn't want to get rid of the Hide
button I wanted to get rid of the whole
post
so what's going on here is it seems to
be that if the element's class name is
hide meaning I clicked on a hide button
element.remove just removes that element
it removes the hide button but it
doesn't remove the post that contains it
and if you think about this in terms of
the Dom the post is a div and it's child
element is the button this hide button
and so you remove the button but it
doesn't also remove the post as well if
you want to remove the post as well you
need to remove not the element but the
elements parent and in JavaScript it
turns out there's a way to do that too
rather than element dot remove I can say
element dot parentelement dot remove to
say take the element get its parent and
remove that
so now I refresh the page
now I see a post one I want to hide it I
hide post one and all right now I see
post 2 and the post one has gone away if
I want to hide post three I hide post
three now post three is gone now I go
straight from post 2 to post four
so this works but it's also not
immediately obvious what's going on like
because all of the posts are the exact
same height when I get rid of post one
and three it's not immediately obvious
to the eye that they've gone away
because post two and four they look
almost exactly the same you really have
to be paying attention to know the
hiding worked and so this can be a time
where animation can actually be quite
helpful so what I can do is say
something like
let's go ahead and give this post an
animation associated with every post
we'll give it an animation name called
hide an animation duration of two
seconds we'll say it'll take you two
seconds in order to hide and an
animation fill mode forwards I want to
go forwards with the animation and
initially I'll give the post an
animation play state
of paused meaning initially I don't want
the animation to be running because I
don't want to hide all the posts
immediately pause this animation later
we'll go ahead and run the animation in
order to actually hide the post
then I need to Define what does it
actually mean to hide the post
and I'll say well all right at the zero
percent Mark what does it mean let's
give yourselves an opacity of one
opacity is a CSS property that just
controls how opaque or how transparent
an HTML element happens to be
and at the end a hundred percent of the
way done with the animation we'll set
opacity to zero so initially we can
fully see the element at the end the
element is totally transparent and now
what I need to do is actually trigger
this to happen somehow
so this is probably going to happen
inside of my event listener where
instead of removing the element right
away
let me just take the parent element and
set its animation play State equal to
running for example meaning
when I click the hide button go ahead
and run the animation that will change
the opacity from one to zero over the
course of a couple of seconds
and then if I really want to I can add
another event listener to say take the
parent element
add event listener there's an event
called animation end which happens when
the animation is over
and then I can say all right when the
animation is over we'll then go ahead
and remove the element
so all in all rather than just
immediately remove the element when I
click on the button that says hide what
I'd like to do is say if you click on a
button and the button is hide go ahead
and get the parent element not the hide
button but the post itself
set its animation play state to running
meaning run the hide animation
and then add an event listener to the
parent to that post as a whole to say
when the animation is over go ahead and
remove that entire post from the Dom
altogether
so what is the effect of all of this now
of having this animation and running it
well now if I refresh the page I see all
these posts if I try and hide like post
number two for example you'll see that
the opacity changes and then it slowly
disappears and then only after it's
totally transparent the post disappears
entirely so I can say hide Post Number
Four it disappears and then post number
five jumps up to fill its place and I
can do that for any of these posts
triggering the animation when I click on
the hide button and so this is part of
the value of what animation can do is to
be able to make our user interfaces a
little more pleasant from the
perspective of the user by not
immediately getting rid of a post but by
having a nice fade out so it disappears
nicely now even this is not perfect
animation wise like one thing you might
notice is that it jumps up as soon as
the post is gone if I hide post number
three I hide it it disappears and post
five sort of jumps up very abruptly in
order to fill its place what I might
like is to be a little bit cleverer to
somehow shrink the size of the post
after it's gone so that the post doesn't
jump into place but it slides a little
bit more naturally into place and so
there's some additional things I can
play with here maybe I want to say
they're all right let me make this
animation a multiple part animation so
here instead of just from zero to 100
setting the opacity from one to zero
maybe in the first 75 percent of the
animation that will take care of
reducing the opacity going down from one
all the way down to zero but in the last
25 percent of the animation will still
end with an opacity of zero
but anything that creates vertical space
I want to reduce down to zero so the
height should be zero pixels the line
height which is how high the text is
should also be zero pixels and any
padding I want to go away it turns out
I've added some margin to the bottom of
the post I want to make that go away as
well so I want to set all of those to
Zero from whatever their initial values
happen to be that initially the height
is like a hundred percent of what the
height could be likewise for line height
100 of the parent uh initially I have
like 20 pixels of padding and a margin
at the bottom of 10 pixels and I want
all of that to still be true 75 percent
of the way through the animation but
it's only in the last 25 percent of the
animation that I want to set all of
these vertical height properties down to
zero I want to remove all the height
remove the line height remove all the
padding and the effect of this is I'll
have an animation now where for the
first 75 percent of the animation the
only thing that changes is the opacity
the opacity goes from one fully visible
to zero fully transparent and then in
the last 25 percent of the animation the
post is already transparent you can't
see it but it's still taking up physical
space on the page but we're going to now
reduce the height of that post so that
now you won't be able to see it at all
so now if I refresh this page
here we go under all the posts but now
if I click hide on a particular post
we'll see that it first Fades out and
then its height shrinks so that the next
post slides very nicely into place I can
do that again hide the post it's
transparent and then it slides into
place and this again is just an
application of this idea of CSS
animations using properties of Animation
to make our interfaces a little bit
nicer to use a little bit clearer
visually to the user that one post has
gone away and the rest of the posts have
now scrolled up in order to take their
place
so now we've been able to use JavaScript
to create a lot of nice user interfaces
we've been able to create single page
applications to create infinite
scrolling to be able to create some
animations as well and use JavaScript to
be able to control them but one thing
you might be realizing at this point is
that our applications are starting to
get fairly complicated there's a lot of
JavaScript code needed to manipulate a
lot of different parts of our
application at the same time and you can
imagine that as web pages start to get
more complex and as you want to start
making them more interactive and more
Dynamic there's going to be a lot of
JavaScript code required in order to
keep everything in sync in order to make
sure that all of the elements are
updated when they should so on and so
forth and it's for that reason that in
recent years a lot of JavaScript has now
turned to some JavaScript libraries or
Frameworks that allow to more
efficiently and more effectively create
user interfaces that are more
interactive and more reactive and one of
the most popular of these is a framework
known as react react is a JavaScript
library that is going to enable us to be
able to design user interfaces that are
very interactive where the content of
the web page updates automatically based
on some underlying State and what we'll
do now is take a look at a brief Taste
of react to get a sense for how
Frameworks like it can actually work and
can help us in designing some
interactive and useful interfaces for
users to be able to interact with
react is ultimately based on this idea
of declarative programming a particular
style of programming which is different
from the types of programming you might
be familiar with more classical
programming Styles like imperative
programming in imperative programming
you generally give the computer commands
tell the computer what to do for example
if we had that counter program from
before and we wanted to update the
counter from one number to another
number in the view like the HTML that
the user sees we would include something
like a heading that just has the number
zero inside of it and then the logic in
imperative programming would take
something like this form it would be
like all right first
document.queryselector H1 to get that H1
tag get it at the inner HTML parse int
will take the string and convert it into
an integer and we can save that inside
of a variable called num for example and
then after that if I want to increase it
I would take this variable num and just
add one to it num plus equals one add
one to it and then if I want to update
this heading in order to replace the
zero with a one for example well then I
would need to say document.queryselector
H1 set the inner HTML equal to that
number for instance in order to say all
right numbers now one go ahead and
replace that in the view
but this is a fair amount of code to do
something fairly simple just like
increase a number by one and the reason
why is because we've had to be very
explicit about what instructions we're
giving to the web browser we're saying
First grab the H1 figure out what number
is inside of it add one to that number
and then replace it inside of this tag
what declarative programming is going to
allow us to do is it's going to allow us
to just describe what State Should be
displayed on the page in what form in
declarative programming in our view like
the HTML like code that we're going to
be writing we're just going to say
something like H1 and then in curly
braces num to mean like fill in the
number here and this is what the react
syntax is going to look like and then
the logic code if we want to increment
that number by one is we just need to
say num plus equals one add one to the
number and the effect of that is that
since we have declared that inside of
this heading it should be whatever the
value of the number is when we increment
the value of number react is effectively
just going to update the view so that
the number updates as well and so this
will be some of the power that react
gives us react lets us divide our
application into a whole bunch of
different components where a component
is something like this thing here that
is keeping track of some sort of count
along with a button that might
manipulate it and then make that
component based on some underlying State
some underlying variables that represent
the state of the application something
like the current number and then we can
manipulate that state and when we
manipulate the state that will have an
impact on what the user actually sees
and react will handle the process of
updating that user interface for us
there are a number of ways to get react
working on our web page but the simplest
is probably just to include these three
JavaScript packages inside of our web
page so we're first going to include
react itself which is going to be the
library that's going to allow us to
Define these components and how they
behave then is react Dom a special
package that's going to allow us to take
react components and insert them into
the Dom the document object model that
represents the struct structure of the
entire page and then finally Babel is
going to be a package that we're going
to use in order to translate code from
one language to another it turns out
that when we're rating react code we're
not actually going to be writing
JavaScript we're going to be writing in
an extension to JavaScript known as jsx
and jsx is going to be an extension to
JavaScript that looks a lot like
JavaScript but has some additional
features in particular it has the
ability to effectively allow us to
represent HTML inside of our JavaScript
code in a way that's much easier to read
and it's going to be convenient for us
to deal with
browsers on the other hand don't
understand jsx automatically so what
we're going to use is a tool like Babel
to convert that jsx code into plain
JavaScript that our web browsers are
ultimately going to be able to
understand
the best way to get a feel for this kind
of thing is just to see it in action so
I'll go ahead and create a couple of
react applications just to get a sense
for how it is that you can use react in
your own applications as well
so let's start by taking a look at
react.html and what I have here is the
beginning of an HTML page inside the
head section what you'll notice is I've
already included these three script tags
and what these script tags are doing are
just including those three JavaScript
libraries we were talking about a moment
ago I have a title for the page just
called react and now let's start to fill
in the body of this web page I'll begin
by adding a div which I'll give an ID to
I'll call it app but I could call it
anything and this is where our
application is going to go but right now
I'm just going to leave it as empty it's
going to be react's job to fill in this
div with the content of our user
interface
and now beneath that div I'll start to
write some JavaScript but remember I'm
not going to be writing JavaScript per
se but rather jsx that extension to
JavaScript so in this case I'll need to
add an extra attribute type equals Text
slash Babel and all this is doing is
telling my browser that it's going to
need to translate this jsx code into
JavaScript code that the browser is
actually going to be able to understand
before it tries to run this code in
practice if you were developing a real
application what you would want to do is
you would want to do this translation
ahead of time prior to deploying the
application but here we're just going to
translate it on the Fly
and so all of our react applications are
going to be composed of components where
a component is just some part of my web
application's user interface and to
describe a component I can write a
JavaScript function so I'll create a
function called app which is going to
represent this app component
and what's going to go inside of this
app component well it's a function so
it's going to return something and what
it's going to return is what should
appear inside of that component and this
app component could really just be for
example a div that says hello let's say
and this is where the power of jsx
really starts to come in that here I can
write HTML like syntax inside of my
JavaScript code and jsx is going to be
able to understand it so this function
right here is a function called app that
is representing a react component and
when this component is rendered onto my
web page it's going to say hello
so there's one last line I need inside
of my JavaScript now and that is to
actually render this component into the
page to do that I'll say react Dom dot
render
and the first argument to this function
reactdom.render is what component would
I like to render the component is this
app component that I just created and so
I'll say app again using this HTML like
syntax
and then the second argument is where on
the page would I like to render this
component and I want to render this
component right here on line 10 where I
have a div whose ID is app so I'll need
to add some JavaScript code to find that
particular div and to do that I can just
say document dot query selector and then
uh
hash app to say find the element with an
ID of app and that is where I would like
to render this app component
so I first created this empty div then I
defined this function representing a
react component and then after that
we're going to render that component
inside of the HTML page itself
so now if we were to open a browser
and see what this page actually looks
like I'll make the text a little bit
bigger you see that we actually do see
the word hello
and if I make a change to the component
and refresh the page it will change the
page as well so if the component instead
displayed hello world
well then I refresh the page and the
page now also says hello world
and because this is Javascript I can add
JavaScript code to the function just as
I could with any function in JavaScript
imagine for example that I had some
variables like let's create a variable X
which is equal to 1 and a variable Y
which is equal to 2. inside of this div
rather than just render some text I can
use curly braces to say plug in the
value of some JavaScript expression I
could plug in the value of x plus y for
example
and now by including X Plus Y in these
curly braces JavaScript is going to
evaluate what is X Plus Y and display
that inside of the div instead
and so now when I refresh the page you
see that the page just says three for
example
and so that's the basics of react we
create these components and then render
those components all using the power of
JavaScript
but where react starts to get more
powerful is when we can reuse components
the whole idea of a component is it
represents some part of the user
interface and I could reuse that same
component across multiple parts of the
interface as well imagine for example
that inside of my app component I was
going to render a div that had three
headings Each of which said hello
so there's one heading there's another
one and we'll add a third one there as
well
so I have a div with three headings
inside of it and we can see what that
looks like each one of them says hello
but there's some repetition here I'm
having to use this H1 tag three times
all to create exactly the same UI
element on the page this is a case where
I can create a separate component and
then just reuse that component rather
than have to repeat myself multiple
times so how could I do that well
remember that in JavaScript we can write
a function to represent a react
component so I'll add another function
here and I'll call that function hello
because it's going to represent this
hello component and this hello function
is also going to return something
and what it's going to return is a
heading in H1 that just says hello
and so now inside of my app component
rather than render three separate H1s I
can simplify this a little bit to just
say hello here I'm saying go ahead and
render a hello component here we'll
render a second one and a third one
after that
each time I render a hello component
it's going to display as this heading
that just says hello
so I refresh the page and nothing
changes I still see three headings Each
of which says hello because inside of my
app component I'm rendering this hello
component three times and each time it's
going to display this H1
but where components start to get more
powerful is when they're not always
displaying the same information every
time but when we can parameterize those
components with Properties or as react
simplifies them props short for
properties
so what would that mean we see that HTML
elements can take attributes likewise
react components can take properties
where maybe I don't just want to say
hello but I want to say hello to someone
hello to Harry or to Ron or Hermione for
example so I could say hello name equals
Harry using syntax much like an HTML
attribute then here say hello name
equals Ron and then finally hello name
equals Hermione
and so now my hello component is
accepting this prop this property called
name which is different for all three of
these components
and so inside this hello function now I
would like the hello function to take
advantage of these properties of these
props
and so I'm going to add an argument to
the hello function that argument is
conventionally just called props
and now instead of just saying hello I'm
going to say hello comma and then
remember to plug in a JavaScript value I
use curly braces
and inside of those curly braces I can
say props Dot and then whatever the name
of the property is in this case the name
of the property is just name so I can
say props dot name to say whatever the
name prop is go ahead and plug that in
right here inside of the hello component
so the hello component is going to say
hello comma and then someone's name
so I can save that
refresh the page and now I see Hello
Harry hello Ron and hello Hermione three
different components Each of which is
still just this hello component but
we're rendering it with different props
one time with the name of Harry one time
with the name of Ron and one time with
the name Hermione and so this is where
components can start to get a little bit
different by passing in different props
into those components we can decide how
that component is ultimately going to
render
but let's add to this a little bit and
start to add State into our react
components as well and state is going to
mean any kind of data that we want to
store inside of the component itself and
for this let's try to recreate the
counter application that we created when
we first introduced JavaScript where we
were really just creating a button that
allowed you to count and it counted up
from zero one two three four
Etc
so to do this let's create a new file
I'll create a new file and just call it
counter.html
and we can start just by copying the
contents of react.html into our
counter.html file we're still going to
use those same script tags and we can
still have an app component
but what's going to be inside this app
component is going to be a little
different I'll change the title of the
page 2 to the counter instead of react
so what goes inside of the app component
well if we're going to do discounting we
need a div that's going to display the
number that we've currently counted to
something like zero to start with
and we're going to need a button this
button is just going to be count
which will be the label for that button
so a div that just says 0 and a button
that says count
and now if I open up counter.html
make it a little bigger you can see that
I have this number 0 here and a button
that says count of course right now
clicking on the button doesn't do
anything because I haven't written any
JavaScript code to say what should
happen when this button is actually
clicked on
but before we get there let's modify
this program a little bit
right now I've written the number zero
directly into the div itself but it's
not always going to be zero eventually
as I start counting by pressing that
count button that number is going to
change so what I'm going to do now is
Factor this zero out into what's known
as state inside of my react component
and here one way to create state in my
react component is to use a special
function inside of react called use
State this is one example of a react
hook that allows me to add some
additional functionality into my react
component and the argument to react.use
state is going to be the initial value
of that state I'm going to start
counting and I want to start counting
from the number 0 so I'm going to
include the number 0 as the argument to
this use State function
so we're going to start counting at zero
and what this use State function returns
is really an array of two things it's
going to be a variable that I can give a
name to I'll call it count and also a
function that I'm going to call set
count and that function is going to
allow me to set the value for the state
If Ever I need to change the state at
some point in the future
so this use State function except 0 the
initial State as its argument and then I
get two things back I get the state
variable itself called count and I get a
function for changing that state when I
need to
so now instead of rendering a zero
inside of the div just by writing the
number zero I'm going to instead in
curly braces
go ahead and render whatever the value
of count is initially it's going to be
zero but eventually that number might
change and I want my UI to reflect the
changes in the underlying state
so right now if I refresh the page it
still says zero because the initial
state was set to zero but I could change
that if initially that initial state was
some other value I could refresh the
page and see a different value appear
for the count instead whatever the value
of this count variable is in the state
that's going to be what the user is
going to see when they're looking at my
user interface And when they see my
component
so now let's make this button actually
do something because right now the
number is never changing to do that I
can add an on click Handler and notice
one difference between on click and
react and unclicked as we traditionally
used it in JavaScript I'm using this
Capital C and that's just a common react
convention when we're defining event
handlers
and here I'm going to say on click and
then in curly braces the name of a
function a function that I would like to
run when this button is clicked and I
can call that function whatever I'd like
I'll call it update count for example
and now what I need to do is Define a
function called update count
and I'm going to Define that function
inside of this react component inside of
my app function it turns out in
JavaScript you can have functions that
are defined inside of other functions so
I'll Define this function called update
count
and what do I want the update count
function to do well what I'd like to do
is just increase count by one and you
might think that I could do that just by
saying count equals count plus one but
it turns out you can't quite do that in
react in react whenever whenever I'm
using this use state if I want to change
the state I have to use this function
that use state provides to me for
whenever I want to set the new value of
the state so rather than count equals
count plus one I have to use the set
count function and the argument to set
count is going to be count plus one
so set count is this function that is
going to change the underlying State
inside of my component and the argument
is what should the new state be and in
this case it's just going to be count
plus one one more than whatever the
count was before
so I can save that
and I'll go ahead and refresh the pager
it starts out at zero but every time I
click on this count button you'll notice
the count increases by one
and again I have no code that's saying
go into the div and change whatever is
inside of the diva all I have inside of
this div is this reference to this state
variable count and whenever the state
changes JavaScript and in turn react
knows that what react needs to do is to
recreate this component re-render the
component by displaying the new value of
this state variable and then when the
button is clicked on we're able to run
this function to change the value of
that underlying state
so by taking advantage of these react
components with State we can start to
represent information inside of our
components and then Define what our
component is going to display as just by
representing HTML in terms of that
underlying State deciding how we should
use that state in order to render an
interface that the user is ultimately
going to see
so let's now try and put these pieces
together and create a web application
that uses these abilities of react to
Define State and to manipulate that
state and in turn update a user
interface based on changes that are
happening to that underlying State and
we'll create an application that will
just display some simple mathematical
questions to the user and quiz the user
on some basic addition facts for example
so let's create that application I'll
create a new file and call it
addition.html
and inside of addition.html I'll start
again just by copying the contents of
this counter.html file because the
framework the structure of this page
will be similar but I'll go ahead and
clear out what's inside of my app
component at least for now
and so what would I like for my app
component to render
well let's go ahead and render a div
and if I want to create an application
that's going to ask the user some
mathematical questions and then prompt
the user to type in an answer there are
at least two parts of this user
interface that I'm going to need I'm
going to need a place to display the
addition fact answer like what is one
plus two for example and then I'll need
an input field where the user can type
in their response to that question and
then see if they got the question right
or wrong
so inside the div I'll start by creating
a div that displays the question itself
something like one plus two
and then beneath that I'll just add an
input field eventually we'll add more to
this user interface but for now all we
really need is a div that displays the
mathematical question and an input for
the user to type in their response so
now if I go ahead and go to
addition.html here's what I see I'll
make it a little bit bigger I see one
plus two and then an input field where
the user could start to type in their
response but just as we did before I
don't want to literally write the
numbers 1 and 2 into what I'm returning
instead I want these one and two to be
based on some underlying State inside of
my application the application is going
to maintain State about what two numbers
to add together and then it's going to
display a user interface based on that
state
so what could I do here
well one thing I could do is again use
react.use State start this number off as
1. and maybe call this num1 and then a
function to set number one
and then I could do it again let's
create num2 and set num2 to be react.use
state two and I could have two different
pieces of state num1 and num2 Each of
which has a different function set num1
and set num2 that are each representing
the two different numbers that I would
like to add together
but already this is starting to get
messy and over time as I add more
different pieces of state to the
application as we'll see in just a
moment the state might start to get more
and more complex with more and more
different functions and variables and so
it's often helpful and a common practice
in react to combine multiple pieces of
State just into one JavaScript object
that's maintaining all of the different
pieces of State for this particular
component
and to do that I'll again use react.use
state but instead of setting the state
initially to be a number like one or two
it's instead going to be a JavaScript
object that has keys and values
or I could say let num1 be the number
one and let num2 be the number two much
like a dictionary in Python for example
where I have multiple different values
num1 and num2 all together inside of the
same object and I can call that state
and have a variable and have a function
called set state that is going to update
the value of that state and so rather
than have to have all of these different
variables I can simplify a little bit to
just State and a function to set the
state and the state now has these two
different pieces number one and number
two
and so now instead of rendering
literally the number one using curly
braces I can say State DOT num1
and instead of rendering literally the
number two I can say state DOT num2
drawing upon that state to decide what
it is going to appear inside of the user
interface and so right now the page
appears no different but if I were to
change those initial values of the state
maybe make it two and four for example
and then refresh the page well now it
displays as two plus four
and so that's helpful we now have a user
interface where the numbers are based on
the state but now what I'd like to do is
add the ability to keep track of what
the user typed in so we can tell if the
user correctly typed in the answer to
this mathematical problem and how would
I do that well the state represents any
information that we need to keep track
of inside of this component and so in
addition to storing the two numbers
inside of the state I likely also need
to keep track of a third piece of
information which is the response what
did the user type in
into this text field and so I'll add a
third part of the state called response
that initially will just be the empty
string will just be nothing
and then this input field I'm going to
give it a value and the value is going
to be state DOT response
whatever the user typed in as the
response that's stored inside of the
state and that is going to be the value
of what shows up in the input field
and so that way whatever is in the input
field will have access to it inside of
this state.response variable
but there is a problem and here's the
problem I'll try refreshing the page
I'll go into this text field and let's
say I know the answer I know 2 plus 4 is
equal to 6. I'm now going to press 6 on
my keyboard
but as I press six on the keyboard
nothing's happening no 6 is appearing
inside of the text field even though I
am pressing the key on the keyboard
so why is that why is the text field not
updating
well the reason is the value of the
input field whatever appears in the
input field is this value state DOT
response and state.response is always
this empty string and never changing
what state DOT response is equal to
and so I need to change this a little
bit I need to add as an attribute to
this input field
on change meaning when the input field
changes I need to do something
and I'll call a function that I can call
update response
but again I could call that update
function whatever I'd like it's just the
name for the function that's going to
run whenever something changes in the
input field so let me now Define that
update response function I'll Define a
function called update response and
because it's an event handler it can
accept an argument which is the event
itself the fact that something has
changed inside of the input field
and when I have access to this event it
turns out that if I want to figure out
what it is the user is typed into the
input field I can get at that with event
dot Target dot value and I'd only know
that by looking at it in the
documentation but what I'd like is for
event.target.value to be the new value
for this response
and so what I'd like to do is do
something like this set State and what
should the new value of the state be
well I would like for a response to no
longer be the empty string but to now be
event dot Target dot value and that is
going to be the new value for response
quite done yet
because State doesn't just have response
as one of the parts of the state the
state also has num1 and num2 and those
two pieces aren't really changing so I
could say all right num1 is just going
to be whatever state DOT num1 was that's
not changing and num2 is going to be
whatever state DOT num2 was that's not
changing the only thing that's changing
is the response but this is starting to
get a little bit verbose and especially
if I start adding more and more
different pieces to the state it's going
to become difficult to manage if I
constantly have to repeat myself for all
of the parts of the state that aren't
changing ideally what I'd like to do is
just specify the parts of the state that
will change and ignore everything else
and so one shorthand way to do that in
JavaScript is to use what's known as the
spread operator and it looks like this
dot dot dot and then state and what this
is saying is just use the existing
values of the state for everything else
like num1 and num2 the only thing to
override is the new value for the
response
and so this syntax here is my way of
saying I would like to update the state
everything should stay the same except
for response which is now going to be
event.target.value in other words
whatever it is the user typed in into
that input field
and so I'll go ahead and refresh the
page and now if I type a number like six
you actually see that number appear in
the input field
so that's great we've now displayed a
question where the numbers are stored in
the state and the user can type in a
response where that response is also
stored in the state now what I'd like is
when the user presses the enter key on
their keyboard we check did they get the
answer right or did they get the answer
wrong
and so how would I do that well the
first thing I need to do
is in this input field somehow detect
when a key is pressed
when a key is pressed what I'd like to
do is check to see if it was the enter
key and if it was the enter key then
let's go ahead and check to see what the
actual sum of the two numbers is and see
if the user got that right or wrong
so let's add an event handler on key
press
is going to be equal to something again
I can name this function whatever I'd
like I'll call it input key press but
again I could name that anything
and now let's define that input keypress
function so up above I'm going to Define
this function called input keypress
again it takes that event as its
argument
and this event is going to happen
anytime a key is pressed regardless of
whether it's a letter or a number or the
enter key and so I want to check to make
sure that the key is actually the enter
key that's the only time that I want to
now check to see if they got the
question right or wrong so I'll add here
a condition it's just JavaScript so I
can say if event.key is equal to enter
well then let's go ahead and check and
otherwise we don't have to do anything I
don't need an else case here because
nothing should happen unless it's the
enter key that was actually pressed
and so now how do I check to see if the
user got the answer right or wrong
well inside of state.num1 is the first
number
and inside of state DOT num2 is the
second number so I could have a
condition that check if state.num1 plus
state.num2 is equal to State DOT
response which is what the user typed in
into the input field but that doesn't
quite work because state.response that's
a string the user doesn't necessarily
have to type in numbers it's possible
the user is going to type in some
letters instead for example or other
characters instead and so what I'm going
to do first is convert the response into
an integer if we're able to do so
so I'm going to Define a variable called
answer using the JavaScript function
parseint that takes a string and tries
to convert it into an integer so we're
going to parse the end state DOT
response
and now we can check if number one plus
number two is equal to the answer
well then this means the user got the
question right
and else if the sum is not equal to the
answer that means the user
got the question wrong
and so now what I could do is handle
those two different scenarios in one
case the user got the question right and
we should do something and in another
case the user got the question wrong and
we should do something else and we're
making that decision by looking at the
state of the application by looking at
what two numbers we're supposed to be
adding and looking at what the user
typed in as their response
so what should we do when the user gets
a question right or gets a question
wrong well maybe this game is going to
keep score by maintaining a number for
how many questions the user has gotten
right and every time the user gets a
question right we could increase that
score by one and anytime the user gets a
question wrong we could decrease that
score by one for example so how would we
do that well the score is some piece of
State inside of the application and so
we're going to need to add to the state
right now in the state we're storing a
number one a number two and a response
I'll add to that a score
where the score is going to start out as
just zero
and we can render that score on the page
if I scroll down to where we're
returning the div to render
let's add
another day of it that says the score is
and then using curly braces plug in
whatever the value of a state DOT score
is whatever the score is let's figure
that out from the state and let's
display that in the user interface
so now this user interface shows not
only a question and an input field but
also a score and the score starts out as
just the number zero
so let's now go back to this function
when a key is pressed if it's the enter
key let's check to see if they got the
answer right or wrong we check did the
user actually get the question right if
so what should we do well we should
increase the score and how do we do that
we do that by calling the set State
function
all of the state is going to be the same
so using that dot dot dot State spread
operator the only thing that's different
is the score is going to be state DOT
score plus one
so we're updating the state to increase
the score by one
and if the user gets the question wrong
let's set the state to be dot dot State
and then the score is going to be state
DOT score
minus 1.
so if the user gets the question right
we increase the score by one otherwise
we decrease the score by one and let's
test that to see what it actually looks
like when we try this in the user
interface
I'll refresh the page two plus four if I
type in the correct answer six press
return the score increases by one
if I typed in the wrong answer let's say
eight press return the score decreases
by one
so this appears to work depending on
whether I get the question right or
wrong the score is able to update
increasing or decreasing based on the
result of that condition now this game
is pretty easy to get a high score on
right now because I can just keep
pressing return over and over and over
and the question is never changing my
response is already there and so the
score keeps going up and up and up so
let's make the game a little bit more
interesting every time the user gets a
question right let's display a new
question for them to answer and how
would we do that well the question
that's displayed to the user is based on
two underlying pieces of the state of
the component it's based on state.num1
and it's based on state.num2
so if I want to change the question all
I have to do is when the user gets the
question right and I'm updating the
state instead of only updating the score
let's also update num1 and num2
and I could set these to be specific
values maybe like 5 and 10 for example
but let's make it more interesting and
display a random number every time we'll
generate a random number and so the user
will be adding two random numbers
together every time they get a new
question right how do we generate a
random number well math.random is a
JavaScript function that generates a
random number between 0 and 1. we can
multiply it by 10 so now we're getting a
number between 0 and 10 but we don't
want any decimals to appear in the
number so I'll go ahead and take the
ceiling of the number math.seal to say
if the number was like 5.8 we'll just go
ahead and round that up to six for
example
and we'll do the same thing for number
two we'll take the ceiling of
math.random times 10. so every time the
user gets a question right we'll update
num1 and num2 to be new random numbers
generated just like this
and so let's go back and try it again we
see two plus four I type in the correct
answer 6 and the question changes eight
plus five I type in the correct answer
press return my score increases and the
question changes again this time if I
get the answer wrong I type in 10 for
example watch my score decrease it went
from 2 down to one but the question
didn't change now I get another
opportunity to try to answer this
question and when I answer it correctly
the score increases again from one to
two
so this game is starting to come along
now it's keeping track of my score it's
displaying different questions there is
at least one user interface Quirk right
now and that is the fact that at the
moment when I get a question right and
press return I type in six and press
return the six still stays there ideally
I get a new question I'd like to clear
out the response so the user can just
type in whatever the new answer is
rather than have to delete whatever they
typed in before and then type in a new
number so how could we do that reset
whatever is inside of the input field
well what's typed into the input field
is stored inside of the state of my
component it's stored inside of state
DOT response
and so if I wanted to change that
all I would have to do is say let's
change the response to be
the empty string
when the user gets a question right
we're going to update these two numbers
increase the score and also clear out
the response so that it's just the empty
string and I can do the same thing if
the user gets a question wrong decrease
the score by one but also clear out that
response back to the empty string so
that there's nothing there
and so now
we get a question I type in an answer
press return and the input field clears
out I get a new question and the score
increases by one four separate pieces of
State all changing at the same time and
that gets reflected in the user
interface that I'm now able to see so I
type in another value and the score
increases and everything updates again
all right so that's definitely progress
one other user interface Quirk that I
noticed here is that the input field by
default isn't automatically selected
where I would have to go in and click on
the input field in order to highlight it
so that I can start typing in my
response I can fix that pretty easily if
I scroll down to where the input field
is we'll add in auto focus attribute
and just set that to be true so that the
input field automatically focuses when I
load the page for the first time
so now I refresh the page the input
field is already highlighted and
immediately I can start to try to play
this game
so now that we have the basic
functionality of this app working let's
try and improve the CSS so that the game
looks a little bit nicer I'll scroll up
to the top of the page and add a style
tag to the Head section of my HTML page
and I'd like for this entire app to be
centered so I'll say text align is going
to be Center
and I'm going to set the font family to
be Sans serif because I prefer that font
for this particular game
so I refresh the page and now everything
is centered and the font is different
than what the default was
and what else would I like to have
changed
well this problem two plus four maybe
I'd like for that to be bigger I'd like
the problem to be big and the score
beneath that that can stay the same size
that it is right now
so how would I do that well if I go back
to the HTML here I'll go ahead and give
this div where I'm displaying the
problem number one plus number two I'll
give it an ID of problem
and then if I scroll back up I'll say
for the element with an ID of problem
let's go ahead and set the font size to
be
72 pixels for example
just to make it bigger and so now I see
a big math equation two plus four for
example the input field and then the
smaller score beneath it so that's a
nice UI enhancement a little bit and now
I can play the game get a question right
uh and the score increases and I get a
question wrong and I get to try again
but maybe I'd like to offer more of a
visual indication that the user got a
question wrong maybe any time the user
gets a question wrong I'd like to change
the color of this text instead of being
black instead it should be red when the
user gets a question wrong and how could
I go about doing that well we can change
the color of something just by using CSS
if we had like a class called incorrect
for example if I scroll down here
and give this div a class name which is
how you add a class in react of
incorrect
then I could use this class name to
style it as red or not red so I could
say
anything that has a class of incorrect
let's go ahead and give that a color of
red
and so now because I gave this problem a
class of Incorrect and I said turn all
incorrect text to be read we now see
this text appear as red but this again
is not quite what I want I don't want it
to be read all of the time I only want
it to be read when the user has just
gotten the question wrong when they were
just incorrect In answering a
mathematical question and so how could I
represent that information inside of my
application well I'm going to need some
additional state state again is any
information that I need to keep track of
inside of my component and now it seems
that in addition to the response and the
score and the numbers I also want to
keep track of did the user just answer a
question incorrectly or not
so I'll add another piece to the state
I'll call it Incorrect and initially it
will be false they didn't just get
something incorrect
and now here
if I scroll down to this class name
rather than have it be incorrect all the
time
let me add in curly braces in expression
I'll say if state DOT incorrect is true
using the ternary operator with a
question mark then the class should be
incorrect but otherwise it shouldn't
have a class of incorrect it'll just be
the empty string and so this expression
here allows me to change the class of an
HTML element based on the underlying
state if State DOT incorrect is true
then this div will have a class of
Incorrect and otherwise it won't
and so now when I load the page for the
first time
the text appears as black
and what I need to do is when the user
gets a question wrong I need to change
the state to indicate that they just got
a question wrong
how do I do that
well here is the set State call when the
user gets a question wrong
and in that case I'll go ahead and set
incorrect equal to true
and when the user gets a question right
we'll go ahead and set incorrect equal
to false we're modifying this one
additional piece of State based on
whether the user got the question right
or wrong
so now if I load the page answer a
question correctly the score increases
and I get a new question but if I answer
a question incorrectly and press return
you'll notice the score decreases the
input field clears out and the text
changes color because I change the value
of that incorrect part of the underlying
State and based on that we were able to
see the text color change as well if I
now get a question correct press return
the text color changes Back to Black and
the score increases
and let's now add one final piece of
state or one final change to the UI for
this application let's give me a way to
win this game maybe once I get to a
score of 10 by answering 10 questions
correctly then we're going to win the
game and how could I do that well
remember that each react component can
just be a JavaScript function and this
function is just immediately returning
this div but it's a function so I can
add additional logic to it I can say if
state DOT score is equal to 10 for
example then rather than render the old
div let's run return a new div
this div is just going to display
something like U1
and so that I can style it I'll give it
an ID
the ID will be winner
and if the ID is winner
let's go ahead and make the font size 72
pixels and let's make the color green if
I win
so I added some CSS just to style it but
really the only New Logic is further
down below where I'm here saying check
the state if the score is 10 well that
means we win so instead of returning the
new problem just return a div that says
you won the game
so let's try that now
I get these questions every time I
answer a question you're noticing that
the score is going to increase by one
and every time we're generating new
random numbers to display as the uh as
what's going to appear in the user
interface and once I get to question
number 10 if I answer it correctly press
return the entire UI changes instead of
the problem in an input field and the
score I just see in green large text
that I want and again I was able to do
that by looking here at this condition
where we're looking at the value of the
state and if the state is 10 we're
deciding what's a retina and this again
is one of the great powers of react this
ability to use this underlying State and
based on the value of the underlying
State decide what it is the user should
see in their user interface
and react is just one of many libraries
that do this type of thing other popular
ones include angular and view where all
of these are just these web Frameworks
that make it easy to be able to create
applications that are able to respond to
some underlying state so that you the
programmer don't have to worry about
constantly having to manipulate various
different parts of the page which
especially as you imagine websites like
Facebook or Twitter where there are many
things happening on the page at the same
time every time a new tweet comes in you
might get a notification and see a new
Post in your main area of your news feed
so these are the types of things that
you might want the application to be
able to more easily handle for you where
you describe what the state is you
describe what the page should look like
based on that underlying State and let
the library whether it's react or
something else begin to handle the
process of doing that for you and the
world of user interfaces is changing
pretty quickly that a lot changes in
user interfaces in terms of the
Technologies and the tools that are
quite popular but they're really based
on the same set of underlying ideas the
idea that we can use JavaScript in order
to manipulate what it is the user sees
on their page in order to detect what's
happening based on particular events
like scrolling to the bottom of the page
or typing something into an input field
and then responding to those particular
events by providing some sort of
function that gets called anytime a
particular event happens by mixing that
in with other features like the ability
to asynchronously request information
from an external server or the ability
to do computations based on the values
of the state like we saw within react we
have the ability to create very
interesting engaging Dynamic user
interfaces very very quickly all just
using the power of combining Python and
JavaScript that was web programming with
python and JavaScript for today we'll
see you next time
[Music]
thank you
okay welcome back everyone to web
programming with python and JavaScript
and now at this point we've seen a
number of different techniques and tools
that we can use in order to design web
applications HTML and CSS to describe
how it is that our Pages look a
programming language like python using a
framework like Django in order to listen
for requests process them and provide
some sort of response and then more
recently we took a look at JavaScript
another programming language that we can
use in particular on the client side
running inside of the user's web browser
in order to make our web pages even more
interactive and user friendly now what
we'll transition to today is taking a
look at some of software's best
practices some tools and techniques that
developers actually use when they're
working on web applications especially
as those web applications start to grow
larger in particular we'll start by
discussing testing this idea of
verifying that our code is correct and
then transition to CI CD short for
continuous integration and continuous
delivery some other best practices that
are used in making sure that the work
that software developers are working on
can be tested and deployed readily and
very quickly
so we'll begin the conversation with
testing and testing is really about this
idea of verifying and making sure that
the code that software developers are
writing are in fact correct to make sure
that the functions work the way they're
supposed to that the web pages behave
the way that they are supposed to and
ideally we'd like some way to be able to
efficiently and effectively test our
code over time and as our programs grow
more complicated to allow our tests to
make sure that our program is behaving
the way that we want it to so we'll go
ahead and start simple and consider the
basic way that we might take a function
for example written in Python and test
and verify to make sure that it works
the way we would expect it to and to do
so we can start with a command in Python
known as assert and what assert does in
Python is it asserts or just states that
something should be true and if that
something is not true then the assert is
going to throw an exception some sort of
error so that whoever is running the
program or running the command knows
that something went wrong and this can
be a very basic way that we can leverage
Python's abilities to test a function
and verify that that function behaves
the way we would want it to so let's go
ahead and try a simple example of
writing a python function and then
trying to test to make sure that that
function works the way we would want it
to
so we'll go ahead and create a new file
I'll call it a search.pi
and let me Define a new python function
for example that is going to take an
integer and square it just want to take
a number and return it Square so I'm
going to define a function called Square
that takes us input a number like X and
I want to return x times x so fairly
straightforward function but I would
like to now verify that the function
works the way I would expect it to now
there are a number of ways that you
could do this one would be just like
let's print out what the square of 10 is
for example and just see what that's
equal to and then you could run a
program something like Python assert.pi
and just say all right the answer is 100
and I could say to myself okay that's
what I would expect it to be but I now
have to do the mental math of squaring
the number 10 making sure that the
answer comes out to be the value that I
expect it would be nice if I could
automate this process
well one thing I could do is print out
does the square of 10 equal 100 I know
that I want square of 10 to equal 100 so
I could just print out that value print
out does square of 10 equal the number
100 I'll go ahead and run the program
again and this time what I get is true
for example because those two things are
equal to each other and if on the other
hand I had tried to check for something
that wasn't true like does square of 10
equal 101 you run the program and okay
now it's going to be false
so this is nothing new nothing we
haven't seen before but now what I can
do is instead of this I can just say let
me assert that square of 10 is equal to
100. here I'm just asserting that this
expression that the square of 10 is
equal to 100 is going to be true
and now I can run the program and what
you'll notice is nothing happens no
output nothing at all because when an
assert statement it runs and the
expression that it's checking turns out
to be true that the square of 10 does
equal 100 it effectively ignores that
statement altogether just continues on
to the next thing no output no side
effect of any sort and this is helpful
because it just means that if I want to
assert that something is true I can
assert it and then just continue writing
my code and it's as if I hadn't written
that a certain statement at all so long
is the thing that I'm asserting is
actually true but if there were a bug in
my code for example some sort of mistake
where instead of returning x times x
imagine that I accidentally said return
X Plus X to calculate the square instead
something that would be a bug in this
case
well then when I try to run python
assert.pi what I'm going to get is an
exception and the type of exception that
I get is something known as an assertion
error and I can see that here there's an
assertion error and then I see the
reason why the assertion error happened
in the assertion error happened on line
four which is this line here where I
said I would like to assert that the
square of 10 is equal to 100. so one way
we could imagine testing our code is
just by including a number of these
different assert statements if I want to
verify that my code is correct I can
write various different assert
statements and for a function that's
fairly simple like the square function
probably not too many tests that I would
need to write but you can imagine for
more complex functions that have
multiple different conditional branches
being able to assert that no matter
which conditional Branch the program
chooses to follow that the code will
actually be correct can be a valuable
thing to be able to say
and this can be helpful too when in
working on a larger project you want to
deal with the problem of like bugs that
might appear inside of a project and
this gets at the idea of test driven
development developing while keeping
this notion of testing in mind and one
of the best practices would be if ever
you're working on a program of your own
and you encounter some bug in the
program you'll first want to fix the bug
but then you'll want to write a test
that verifies that the new behavior is
working as expected and once you've
written these tests these tests can
start to grow over time and as you
continue working on your project you can
always run those existing set of tests
to make sure that you nothing no new
changes that you make to the program
down the line no future features that
you add or changes you might make are
going to break anything that was there
before and this is especially valuable
as programs start to get more complex
and testing everything by hand would
start to become a very tedious process
to be able to just automate the process
of just run a whole bunch of tests on
all the things that I know that I would
like the program to do and making sure
they work as expected that can be quite
helpful
so assert then is one basic way of just
saying that I would like for this
statement to be true and if it's not
true go ahead and throw an exception and
using python we know we also have the
ability to catch those exceptions in
order to make sure that we're able to
handle those appropriately so we can
display a nice error message for example
if we wanted to do so
but now let's go ahead and try and write
a more complex function something more
complex than just taking a number and
squaring it somewhere where there's more
room for various different cases that I
might want to test and more room where I
the programmer might make a mistake for
example so let's imagine
writing a new file then I'm going to
call prime.pi where here I'll go ahead
and say that I would like Prime dot pi
to implement a function called is prime
and what the is prime function should do
is check to see if a number is prime or
not the prime number only has factors of
one and itself and I would like to write
a function that verifies that fact
and so how might I go about doing that
well if n is less than two
then it is definitely not prime because
we say 0 and 1 are not going to be Prime
and we'll only deal with numbers that
are zero or greater and we'll deal with
that for now but let's start then with
other numbers numbers that are two or
greater
well what do I want to do I really want
to check each of the possible factors
like if I want to check whether or not
100 is prime or not then I want to Loop
over all the possible numbers that could
be factors of 100 like 2 3 4 5 6 and
when I get to a number like 2 or a
number like 5 that do go into 100
cleanly well then I'll know that the
number is not prime so I could say for I
in range from 2 all the way up through n
for example
let me go ahead and say if n mod I
equals 0 then return false so what am I
saying here I'm saying go ahead and
start at 2 go up through but not
including n so for if I'm checking to
see if 10 is prime for example I'm going
to check for I is 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and
for each of those numbers check if n my
input to this function mod I the factor
that I would like to check is equal to
zero this mod operator this percent if
you don't recall gives us the remainder
when you divide one number by another
and so if n mod I equals 0 that means
the remainder when you divide n by I
equals 0 meaning I goes into end cleanly
with no remainder and that means that
it's not prime because it does have a
factor whatever I is is going to be that
factor
and if I get to the end of this for Loop
then I can go ahead and just say return
true if we weren't able to find a factor
for the number other than one and the
number itself well then we can go ahead
and say that true this number is going
to be Prime
and so this for example could be a
function that checks to see if a number
is prime but if I'm trying to optimize
I'm trying to make my function more
efficient I might realize that you
really don't need to check every number
from 2 all the way up to the number n
itself I could really just check up to
like the square root of that number for
example that for a number like 25 I want
to check like 2 3 4 5 because 5 squared
is going to be 25 but after 5 I don't
need to check any more numbers beyond
that that after you get to a number
after a number the square root of that
number is multiplied by itself there's
never going to be a case where a number
bigger than that could be a factor that
I won't have already known about so just
thinking about things a little bit
mathematically we might be able to make
some sort of optimizations where instead
of going from 2 all the way up through N
I might go up to the square root of n
and I'll go ahead and import math to be
able to use math.s square root and I'll
convert that number to an integer just
in case the square root doesn't already
happen to be an integer so I think this
works I've at least talked myself into
thinking that this is a function that
might be able to check if a number is
prime so what could I do if I wanted to
verify this well I could write some
assert statements another thing I could
do is just use the python interpreter I
could say all right let me go ahead and
type python
and now I'm in the python interpreter
and I can say from Prime go ahead and
import is prime prime is the name of
that file is prime is the function in
that file that I would like to test and
let's just try alright like is prime of
5. that's a prime number hopefully it'll
say true that it's Prime all right it
does let's try is prime 10 see if that
works all right is prime 10 is false
because 10 is not prime that's good that
seems to be working as well let's try
like is prime uh 99 that's not prime
because like 3 is a multiple of that for
example all right false so that's good
this seems to be working and I could in
The Interpreter test this function to
make sure that it works the way that I
would want it to work but let's now see
some other ways that I might go about
testing it well one way
is that I could write a file like uh
test0 dot pi and when test 0.pi is going
to do instead of using assert I'm just
going to do our Boolean checks like we
were doing before I'm going to import
the is prime function and I've defined a
new function called test Prime which is
going to serve the role of testing to
make sure that when you square some
number or when you check to see if some
number n is prime that you get some
expected value where that expected value
is either true for it is prime or false
for it's not Prime what then is this
function doing well the function is
checking we're calling the is prime
function on this number n and seeing
whether or not it is equal to the
expected value that we get where we
expect it to be either true or false and
if we run is Prime on n and it is not
equal to what we expect well then we
print out okay there's an error we
expected some value true or false but it
turned out not to be the case
and so now that I have this test Prime
function well I can say all right let me
go back into the python interpreter from
test zero import test Prime and now I
can say all right let me test Prime make
sure that 5
is prime so I'm passing in my first
input the number n the number I would
like to check I want to check if 5 is
Prime and the second input I provide is
what I expect it to be either true or
false and here nothing happens which is
a good thing if there were an error it
would have printed something out and the
fact that I see nothing printed out
means that everything was okay if I test
Prime now and say something like all
right make sure 10 is not prime make
sure the 10 when you pass it into is
prime is going to give us false again
nothing happens seems to be working just
fine
let me now try I can try more examples
maybe I try test Prime 25 I want to make
sure the 25 is not prime because 25 is
not a prime number
all right we got some sort of error
there's an error on is prime 25 where I
expected the output to be false but for
some reason it looks like is prime
returns something other than false it
probably return true and some might
indicate some sort of bug in my program
that somehow I don't think that 25
should be a prime number but my program
thinks that 25 is a prime number and
that error can be a clue to me as to how
to do this but ultimately especially as
programs start to grow longer especially
as I start to add more and more
functions testing each of those
functions by hand is going to start to
get tedious so one thing I could do is
like write a script to be able to run
all these tests for me automatically and
so here what I have a test zero dot sh
dot sh being like a shell script some
script that I can just run inside my
terminal and what this is doing is it's
running python3 for python version 3
Dash C which means I'm just going to
give it a command and it is going to run
that command and so I can just run these
and each of these lines does what from
test 0 it Imports my test Prime function
that function that is going to test to
make sure that the prime function
produces the output that I would expect
it to and each time I'm testing a
different number making sure that one is
not prime making sure that 2 is prime 8
is not prime so on and so forth and I
can just write a whole bunch of these
tests and then rather than have to run
each test one at a time what I can do is
I can just run test zero dot sh I can
just say
that I would like to run dot slash
test0.sh
and all right I see that I get two
errors I get an error on is prime 8
where I expected it to not be prime but
for some reason it seems to be Prime and
then again here exception on is prime 25
or I expected it to not be prime but for
some reason my program thinks that it is
prime so very helpful way for me to know
immediately that there's some sort of
error that is going on here
But ultimately rather than have me have
to write all this framework for how to
go about testing my code on my own there
exists libraries that can help us with
this and one of the most popular in
Python is a library known as unit test
and what unit test is a library designed
to do is it is going to allow us to very
quickly write tests that are able to
check whether something is equal to
something else and then unit test is
built in with an automated test Runner
that will run all of the tests for me
and verify the output and unit test gets
built in to a lot of other libraries
within python we'll see how we'll soon
be able to apply this sort of idea to
our Django applications as well but
let's now translate these tests that we
have written ourselves just by writing a
function that like tests whether the
prime number is what we expect it to be
and now translate it to using this
python unit test Library instead
and so just to get a sense for what this
looks like I'll now go ahead and open up
tests one dot Pi where here first thing
I'm doing is I'm importing unit test
which we get for free with python I'm
also importing the function that I would
like to test and now I'm defining a
class which will contain all of my tests
this is a class that inherits from or
derives from unit test.test case which
means that this is going to be a class
that is going to define a whole bunch of
functions Each of which is something
that I would like to test and so for
example in this very first test this is
a test that checks to make sure that one
is not Prime
and so the way I do that is by calling
self this testing object itself it
happens to have a method or function
built into it called assert false
there's an equivalent assert true but I
would like to assert false and what
would I like to assert that is false is
prime one
so whatever is prime one is that should
be false and I would like to just assert
that it is false
likewise for the number two now I want
to check that the number two is Prime
and the way I do that is by calling self
dot assert true I would like to assert
that when I run the is prime function on
the number two the output that I get is
going to be a true value self not a
third true
and I can translate each of the rest of
my tests into one of these self.assert
truths or self dot assert false and then
I say that if you go ahead and run the
program go ahead and call unittest.main
which will run all of these unit tests
so now when I run python test1 dot pi
here's what I get I get some nice output
we're up at the top I see dots every
time a test succeeded and on letter f
for a test that happened to fail it says
that it ran six tests and down at the
bottom I see that there were two
failures so it's immediately going to
tell me exactly what failed and it'll
give me some rationale some reason for
why it is that those tests failed as
well so we can see all right here is one
test here's another test this test that
failed is the test that checked that 25
is not Prime and this sentence here is
what I supplied inside of what was known
as that python doc string inside of
those triple quotation marks underneath
the Declaration of the function those
triple quotation marks otherwise known
as a doc string serve a number of
purposes they can serve as just a
comment for describing what it is the
function does but there are special
comment in so far as someone who's
looking at the function can access that
doc string that's usually used for
documentation for what it is that the
function is doing and they can use it
inside of other places as well and so
what unit test is doing is for every
function it uses that Doctrine as a
description of what the test is testing
for so that if a test fails then I can
see exactly what the name is of the test
that failed and what it was tested where
the description describes what was
happening now in this case where it's
just one function I'm testing a whole
bunch of different numbers it doesn't
seem all that useful but again if you
imagine projects that start to get more
complex being able to know immediately
when you run your tests which parts of
the program or which parts of your web
application aren't working the way they
are expected to can actually be quite
helpful
so test 25 that was the function that
triggered an assertion failure in this
case and the line that caused it was
self.assert false is prime 25 and the
reason that it failed is because true
which apparently was the output of this
function is not false and I expected it
to be false instead
and so multiple different ways of trying
to run our tests this happens to be one
quite popular one but this now tells me
that I should go back and try and fix my
is prime function I can go back
into Prime dot pi and say all right I
would like to figure out why this went
wrong and if you look at this enough and
maybe give it a little bit of testing
you might see that I have a slight off
by one error that I probably need to
check one additional number than I
actually am because in checking whether
or not 25 is prime or not for example I
might need to go up 2 and including the
number five to know that 5 is a factor
of 25 but before I was going up to the
number five but I wasn't including the
number five so I also need to just check
one more number and now to verify that
this is right I could just manually test
the function myself or I could just run
these tests again run Python test1.pi
and this time all these dots mean all
these tests succeeded we ran six tests
and everything was okay no failures and
so
this can be a helpful way for me to know
immediately that thing seems to be
working okay
so the takeaways from here are that
these tests can definitely help as you
begin to write new changes to your
program especially as you begin to
optimize functions you might make a
function more efficient but then run
your tests to make sure that in making
these improvements you haven't broken
anything you haven't changed any
behavior that the way the program was
supposed to behave and now it doesn't
behave that way you're able to verify
with much more confidence that that is
true but of course that only works if
your tests have good coverage of all the
things that you would want the function
to do and you've covered appropriately
all the various different cases for how
the function should behave because only
if the tests are comprehensive will they
actually be useful to you in indicating
that the change that you made isn't
going to break anything and only then
can you actually feel confident in those
changes themselves
so now let's take this idea of using
unit tests to be able to write these
tests that verify that a function works
and apply it to something like a web
application like a web application
written in Django that we would like to
now use in order to be able to test to
make sure that various different
functions inside of our Django web
application work as well
so what I'm going to do is actually take
a look at the airline program that we
wrote back when we were first talking
about Django and first talking about
storing data inside of databases and I'm
going to open up models.pi
where you see that I've made one
addition to our definition of a flight
and recall from before when we first
introduced this idea of defining a model
inside of our application for a flight
inside of an airline we gave that model
three properties it had an origin and a
destination where both origin and
destination referenced an airport object
where an airport object with an object
we defined separately but a flight has
an origin airport and a destination
airport and in addition to that every
flight has a duration some number of
minutes long that that flight is going
to last
now I might like to have some way to
validate to verify that a flight is a
valid flight there isn't some error
somewhere in how the data was entered
into the database I would like to just
generally make sure that given a flight
I can check to make sure it's a valid
flight and what does it mean for a
flight to be valid well in general given
these particular Fields I'll say there
are two things that need to be true for
a flight to be valid uh the origin and
the destination need to be different
that's condition number one it wouldn't
make sense to have a flight whose origin
and destination are the same airport and
condition number two the duration of the
flight needs to be greater than zero
minutes if ever the duration is zero or
the duration is negative that probably
indicates to me that there was some sort
of mistake in data entry or some problem
that happened with how it is that these
flights were configured so I want to
make sure that the duration is greater
than zero and those then are my two
conditions for what makes a valid flight
and I've in fact written a function here
called is valid flight that just works
on the slight class that simply checks
given a flight make sure that is in fact
valid and the way it's doing that is by
checking for these two conditions that
I've just described it's checking to
make sure that the origin is not equal
to the destination it's checking to make
sure that the duration of the flight is
greater than or equal to zero and maybe
I should change that to greater than to
make sure it's entirely positive but
this then is my definition for what it
means for something to be a valid flight
and what I'd like to do now is test
these various different parts of my
application I have this is valid flight
function inside of flight that I might
like to test as well but we also have
all of these other properties that I
would like to test these relationships
that a flight has an origin and a
destination we have passengers that can
be associated with flights so there's
lots of relationships between my data
that I would like to test and verify to
make sure they work the way we would
expect it to
so to do that whenever we create an
application in Django like this flights
application here we were also given this
test.pi file and we haven't yet used the
test.pi FI file for anything but what
it's supposed to be used for is for
writing these sorts of tests testing
that verifies that our application
behaves the way that we want it to
behave
so let's go ahead now and open up
test.pi and see what happens to be in
here what we can do is we can define a
subclass of test case which behaves very
similar to unit test and it's based on
that same idea I'll Define a new class
called flight test case that will just
Define all of the tests that I would
like to run on my flights application
and so things to know about this is that
first I might need to do some initial
setup in order to make sure that there's
some data that I can actually work with
and test with and what Django will do
when I go ahead and run these unit tests
is that it will create an entirely
separate database for me just for
testing purposes that we have one
database that contains all the
information that actually pertains to
the flights that are actually there on
my web server but we might also like to
just test things with some dummy flights
and some dummy airports just to make
sure that things are working and then
once we're confident things are working
then we can deploy our web application
to let actual users begin to use
whatever new features we've added to the
web application for example so inside of
this database I might need to do some
initial setup and I can do so by
defining a setup function inside of my
test case class this is a special
function and Django knows that when it's
running these tests it should first do
any of the setup steps that we need to
do
and so how are we doing this well what
we're doing is inside of the setup we're
going to just add some sample data into
the test database again this won't touch
the database that users actually see and
actually interact with this is just our
test one for testing purposes and we'll
start by going ahead and creating some
airports so airport Dot objects.create
and then specifying what the values for
these fields should be
we'll just have an airport whose code is
AAA for City a and an airport whose code
is BBB
for City B just dummy airport names
they're not real airports but just use
for testing purposes and I'll save those
airport objects inside of these values
A1 and A2
and beneath that what I'm going to do
next is go ahead and create some flights
where I create using
flight.objects.create three different
flights one that goes from A1 to A2 with
the duration of 100 minutes one from A1
to A1 with a duration of 200 minutes one
from A1 to A2 with a duration of
negative 100 minutes so I have a whole
bunch of these flights now that I would
like to test that I would like to make
sure work in some predetermined or
expected way
and so now if I scroll down we can see
that I have a whole bunch of these
various different tests here is one test
that just tests the departures count so
every airport has access to a field
called departures which ideally should
be like how many flights are departing
from that airport and I'd like to make
sure that departures count works the way
I expect it to so here
I go ahead and get the airport whose
code is AAA
and now using unit tests like syntax I'd
like to say self dot assert equal so
assert true verifies that something is
true assert false verifies that
something is false assert equal verifies
that two numbers are equal to each other
and here I'd like to verify that
a.departures.count if I take airport a
and count how many flights are departing
from that airport that that should be
three so just verifying that that works
and then after that if this test passes
then I can be confident that elsewhere
in my program if I take an airport and
call that
airport.departures.count I can feel
pretty confident that that is going to
work the way I would expect it to
I can do the same thing for arrivals get
the airport and assert that
a.arrivals.count that that is going to
be equal to the number one if there's
only one flight that arrives at airport
A1 for example
so that tests these relationships and I
can also now test the is valid flight
function as well that here I get my two
airports A1 and A2 this is the one who
was code AS AAA this is the one whose
code is BBB I'll go ahead and get the
flight whose origin is A1 whose
destination is A2 whose duration is 100
and let me just assert true that this
flight is going to be a valid flight
because this flight is valid the origin
is different from the destination it's
duration is some positive number of
minutes and so I should feel pretty
confident that this is going to be a
valid flight that I can verify by
calling self not a third true
I can do the same thing for testing for
an invalid flight testing for an invalid
flight because the destination is bad I
can get the flight airport A1 and get
the flight whose origin and destination
are both A1 and now let me self dot
assert false say that this should not be
a valid flight because the origin in the
destination are the same
what's the other way a flight can be
invalid well flight can be invalid
because of its duration so I could say
something like go ahead and get airports
A1 and A2
and get me the flight whose origin is A1
destination is A2 but the duration is
negative 100 minutes that was one of the
flights as well and while that should
not be a valid flight so I'll say self
dot assert false is valid flight because
when a call is valid flight on that
flight it shouldn't be valid because the
duration makes it an invalid flight
so here now I've defined a whole bunch
of tests and there are more down below
that we'll take a look at in a moment as
well but I've defined a whole bunch of
these slides now or a bunch of these
tests and now I'd like to run them and
the way that I can run tests in Django
is via a manage.pi command manage.pi has
a whole bunch of different commands that
we can run we've seen like make
migrations and migrate and run server
but one of them as well is if I go into
Airline zero I can say python
manage.pi test that's just going to run
all of my tests
and all right it seems that we ran 10
tests but two of them failed so let's go
ahead and see why did those two tests
fail well the way to read this is that
we get this heading anytime a test
failed and so we failed the test invalid
flight destination function and we
failed the test invalid flight duration
function and Doc strings could have
helped me to know what it is that these
tests are exactly doing but it seems
that true is not false I wanted to
assert that this should not be a valid
flight that it should be false but for
some reason these appear to be valid
flight so something seems wrong with is
valid flight where it's returning true
when it should be returning false and so
this then gives me a place to start
looking I can say all right let me go to
is valid flight and make sure that
function is correct so I'll go back into
models.pi I'll take another look at is
valid flight maybe I'll Think Through
the logic again all right I wanted to
check that self.origin is not
self.destination I wanted to check that
the duration is greater than or equal to
zero I could change this to greater than
but I don't think that's the issue
because my duration was negative and so
that already should have been invalid
but the other thing I might realize
looking at this now is that okay The
Logical connective that I have used uh
was not the right one I want to check
that for it to be a valid flight it
needs to satisfy both of the conditions
the origin and the destination need to
be different and the duration of the
flight needs to be greater than zero for
example and here I've used or instead of
and so I can just change it all right
and hopefully that will fix things and
to verify as much I can rerun
pythonmanage.pi test go ahead and press
return
it's going to check things ran 10 tests
everything is okay and all right it
seems that now I have passed all of
these tests
and notice here at the top it created a
test database so it just created a test
database for me in order to do all this
testing work and then it destroyed that
test database at the end as well so none
of my tests if I'm adding data removing
data it's not going to touch any of the
actual data inside of my database for
the web application Django will take
care of the process of keeping all of
that separate for me by first calling
that setup function to make sure that my
new test database has everything that it
needs to
so all right we now have the ability by
using unit test to be able to test
various different functions inside of
our web application we first saw that we
could test a function like the is prime
function just the python function that
we wrote but we can also test things
like functions on our models like
checking to make sure that a flight is
valid checking to make sure that we can
take a flight and access all of the or
take an airport and access all of its
arrivals and all of its departures but
I'd like to do more than that especially
for a web application I'd like to check
that like particular web pages work the
way that I want them to work and so to
do that Django lets us simulate trying
to make requests and risket responses to
a web application
and so let's go ahead and look at some
of these other tests as well here what
we have is a function called test index
and what test index is going to do is
it's just going to test my default
flights page to make sure that it works
correctly so we start by creating a
client some client that's going to be
interacting request and response Style
then I'm going to call
client.getflights that is the route that
gets me the index page for all the
flights
and I'm saving that inside of a variable
called response whatever response I get
back from trying to get that page I
would like to save inside of this
variable called response and now I can
have multiple assert statements inside
of the same test if I would like to
sometimes you might want to separate
them but here I want to check that the
index page works and what that means is
a couple of things it means that
response.statuscode well that should be
equal to 200 200 again meaning okay I
want to make sure that whatever response
I get back that that is going to be a
200. and if there was some sort of error
like a 404 because the page wasn't found
or a 500 because of some internal server
error I would like to know about that so
let me first just assert that the status
code should be equal to 200.
but then Django also lets me access the
context for a response and what is the
context well recall again in Django when
we rendered a template for example we
called like return render then provided
the request and what page we were going
to render but we could also provide some
context some python dictionary
describing all of the values that we
wanted to pass in to that template and
Django's testing framework gives us
access to that context so that we can
test to make sure that it contains what
we would expect it to contain and on the
index page for all my flights I would
expect that to contain a listing of all
of the flights and we created three
sample flights inside of this test
database so I should be able to assert
that these two things are equal
response.contacts flights that gets me
whatever was passed in as flight in the
context
dot count
well that better be three because I want
to make sure that there are exactly
three results that come back when I look
at the context and access whatever
happens to be inside of that flight's
key
there are other tests I can run as well
so in this case I've gone ahead and
gotten a particular flight the flight
who in this case had an origin of A1 and
a destination of A1 now that was not a
valid flight but we'll go ahead and get
it anyway because it exists in the
database and now I can get slash flights
slash that flights ID
right because on my flights page I would
like to be able to go to slash flights
one to get AT flight number one and go
to slash Flight 2 to get AT flight
number two so if I take some valid ID
some ID of an actual flight F and go to
slash flights slash that ID well that
should work it should have a status code
of 200.
meanwhile though
if I test an invalid flight page this is
a Django command that will get me the
maximum value for the ID this ID
underscore underscore Max gets me the
biggest possible ID out of all of the
flights that happen to exist inside of
my database if I go ahead and try and
get slash flights slash Max ID plus one
so a number that is one greater than any
of the flights that were already inside
of my database well that shouldn't work
there shouldn't be a page for a flight
that doesn't exist so here then I can
assert equal that the status code of
what comes back that that is equal to
404 because I would expect that page to
return a 404.
and finally I can also check various
different contexts for things about the
passenger page so in this case I've
added some sample passengers to the
database so inside of my test I can
manipulate the database as well adding
data into the database and checking to
make sure that when you count up the
number of passengers on a flight page
that that is going to be like the number
one for example
so a number of different tests that we
can then write in order to verify
various different parts of our web
application I would like to verify not
only that our database works the way we
would expect the database to work in
terms of how functions on our models
work in terms of relationships between
those models like the relationship
between a flight and an airport but we
can also simulate a get request
simulating a request to a page and
verify that the status code that comes
back is what we would expect it to be
verified that the contents of the page
contain the right contents verify that
the context that was passed into that
template is correct as well and then all
of that can then be verified
by saying something like python
manage.pi test
then go ahead and running that
and we see that in this case all of the
tests happen to pass which means that
everything seems to be okay at least for
now
so this then again very helpful as our
web programs start to get more complex
as we have multiple different models
multiple different routes the ability to
test to make sure that if we change
things in one part of the program that
it doesn't break things in another part
that can be quite helpful too what we
haven't yet been able to test though is
any interaction that's happening
exclusively in the browser that I've
been able to test a lot of things that
are happening server side and recall
that Django is all about working on
writing this web server a python
application that acts as a web server
that listens for requests that come in
from users processes those using these
various different views and models and
then provides some sort of response back
and we can test the contents of that
response things like does the status
code match what we would expect it to
does the context match what we would
expect it to but there are some times
where we would like to really simulate
like a user clicking on buttons and
trying things on a page and making sure
that page behaves we would like it how
we would like it to as well even if
we're not using Django or even if we're
just dealing with the front end
so let's create like a sample JavaScript
webpage that we might like to test now
by using these sorts of ideas the
ability to automate the process of
testing various different parts of our
application to verify that they do in
fact work correctly what I'm going to do
now
is we'll get out of the airline
directory and I'm going to create a new
file that I'll call counter.html
and recall before we created a counter
application using just JavaScript or
what the counter application did is it
let me click a button like an increase
or Account button that just incremented
a number it went from zero to one to two
to three to four and so forth I'm going
to do the same thing here we'll add a
little more complexity though and give
myself both an increase button to add a
number and a decrease button to decrease
the number by one as well so I'll go
ahead and start
with our usual doctype HTML
and our HTML tag I'll give this page a
title of counter
and now inside of the body of this page
I will go ahead and start with a big
heading that just says zero
and then beneath that I'll create two
buttons I'll have one button which will
be the plus symbol and one button which
will be the minus symbol
so now no JavaScript yet this won't
actually work but I can go ahead and go
into opencounter.html
and I can see that I now have 0 and I
have a plus and a minus button although
those plus and minus buttons don't
actually do anything right now so let's
go ahead and make them do something
let's give this button an ID called
increase
so that I can reference it later and
give this button an ID called decrease
again so that I can reference it inside
of my JavaScript
and now in the head section of my web
page I'll add a script tag where I want
to start running some JavaScript once
the page is done loading and to do that
you'll recall I can say document dot add
event listener
Dom content loaded to say go ahead and
run this function
once the Dom is loaded once all the
contents of this page have loaded the
way I would expect it to
and what am I going to do well I first
need a variable something like let
counter equals zero
and then I can say all right
document.queryselector increase get me
the element whose ID is increase that's
that plus button and when you are
clicked let's go ahead and add an event
handler in the form of this callback
function this function that will be
called when the increase button is
clicked
and what would I like to do well I'd
like to increase the counter go ahead
and say counter plus plus
and then I'm going to update this H1
that currently contains 0.
document.queryselector H1 that gets me
the H1 element
I'll go ahead and update its inner HTML
and go ahead and set that to whatever
the value of counter happens to be
and then I'll do the same thing for the
decrease button
document.queryselector get me the
element whose ID is decreased that's the
button that will be the minus button and
when you are clicked go ahead and run
this callback function which will do the
same thing except we'll first do counter
minus minus decrease the value of the
counter by one and then
get me the H1 element
set it to Inner HTML equal to the
counter
I think this should work and I could
verify that by opening up counter.html
I'll refresh the page
and I can test these buttons test the
plus button
all right that seems to work increases
the value by one I can test the minus
button make sure that that decreases the
value by one that all seems to work just
fine but of course this requires me
having to interact with this page I have
to open up the page I have to click on
these buttons and it's not the type of
thing where I'm simulating like a get
request or a post request there's no
server that I'm sending a request to and
getting back a response of one two three
four from this is all happening in the
browser and so what I might like to have
the ability to do is some sort of
browser testing and there are a number
of different Frameworks for doing this
one of the most popular is selenium
and what this is going to allow me to do
is I can define a test file that using
unit tests or a similar Library can
effectively simulate a web browser can
simulate a web browser and simulate a
user interacting with that web browser
using something that we call a web
driver that's going to allow me to use
in code control what it is that the
browser is doing and how it is that the
user is interacting with this program
so how is this going to work well I'm
going to go ahead and just as a test let
me open up the python interpreter and
let me import from tests import Star
and that's going to give me access to a
couple of different things but the first
thing you'll notice that it's doing is
because I'm using this Webdriver it's
going to give me a web browser and here
I'm using Chrome but you could use
another browser but notice that here
Chrome is telling me Chrome is being
controlled by automated test software
that Chrome has the ability to allow me
using automated test software using like
python code control what it is the web
browser is doing
and so what I can do here is the first
thing I need to do is like tell Chrome
to open up my web page and it turns out
that in order to do so I need to get
that Page's URI or uniform resource
identifier just some string that will
identify that page and I've defined a
function called a file URI that gets me
the URI of a particular file in this
directory so I'm going to say I want to
open up counter.html and I need to get
its URI
but now what I can say is driver dot get
URI meaning like tell this Webdriver
this python part of the part of the
Python program that is controlling the
web browser that I would like to get
this web page as if the user had gone to
the web page and like pressed return
after typing in the URL so I say
driver.geturi
I go ahead and press that
and what you'll notice on the right hand
side here is that Chrome has loaded this
page I am effectively controlling this
web browser window using my Python
program I said driver.geturi meaning go
ahead and open up thecounter.html page
and then inside of this test window
Chrome has opened that up and inside my
Python program Now using this Webdriver
I have the ability to like see the same
things that the user sees when they open
the page so what does the user see when
they open the page well they see for
example the title of the page so I could
say like driver dot title
and see that all right the title of this
page is counter that was in fact the
title of the page but I could verify
that inside my Python program that by
checking that driver.title by taking my
web driver getting the title of the
current page that it's looking at making
sure that that is counter
and likewise if I looked at driver.page
source press return When I see there in
string format so it's a little bit messy
is the contents the HTML content of this
page and you'll notice things like you
know Dom content loaded here my on click
handlers here's my H1 that says zero
it's very messy because it's being
represented as a python string and these
backslash ends refer to like new lines
where there's a line break but this is
the content and this is really all the
browser gets the browser takes this
information and just knows how to render
it in some nice more graphical
representation that's easier for a user
to look at and therefore be able to
understand but this is fundamentally all
that my web browser is actually getting
back when it tries to load a web page
so what can I do from here well I would
like to simulate a user's behavior on
this page that sure I can get a page and
see the title but I want to simulate
like clicking on the plus button for
example so in order to do that first
thing I need to do is like actually get
the plus button
and to do that I could say something
like driver dot uh get or find element
by ID there are a number of ways that I
could try and find an HTML element but I
would like to find an HTML element by
its ID and I know that the plus button
the increase button has an ID of
increase for example
and so if I find element by ID let me
find the element whose ID is increase
and all right it seems here
that I've gotten some web element object
back from my Webdriver
and I'll go ahead and save that inside
of a variable called increase
so what I now have is a variable called
increase that represents the increase
button that my web driver has found on
the web page it's the effect of the
effectively the same thing as you the
human going through the page looking for
the increase button the web driver is
doing the same thing except instead of
looking for the button based on what it
looks like it looks for the button based
on its ID and so this again another
reason why it's helpful to give your
HTML elements IDs in case you ever need
to be able to find that element it's
very useful to be able to reference that
element by its name
but now that I have a button I can
simulate user interaction with that
button I can say something like increase
dot click to say I would like to take
the increase button and simulate a user
clicking on that button in order to see
whatever it is that the user would get
back when they click on that button so
increase.click I press return and what
you'll notice happens is that the number
increases increases from zero to one
it's as if I the user had actually
clicked on the plus button except all I
did was say like increase.click to say
go ahead and increase the increase
button and let the browser do what it
would normally do in response and what
it would do in response is get that
JavaScript event handler that on click
Handler and run that callback function
that increases the value of counter and
updates the H1 so I can say increase dot
click to simulate increasing the value
of that variable
but this is just a function call which
means I can include it in any other
python constructs that I want that if I
want to repeat something like 25 times
for example and press the button 25
times I can say like for I in range 25
go ahead and like click the increase
button and now very quickly 25 times
it's going to click the increase button
and I'm going to see the result of all
of that interaction so I can simulate
user interaction just by using the
python interpreter
likewise If instead of increasing I
wanted to decrease well then I'm going
to do the same thing I'm going to say
decrease equals driver dot find element
by ID let me get the decrease element
the element whose ID is decrease and now
say decrease dot click
and that will simulate me pressing the
decrease button press it again and the
more I press it every time it's just
going to decrease by one
and if I want to decrease it all the way
back to zero well then I'll just do it
20 times for I in range 20 go ahead and
decrease dot click and that's going to
go ahead and reduce the count all the
way back to zero by simulating the user
pressing a button 20 times and what
you'll notice is that it happened
remarkably fast like I can simulate 100
presses of the increase button by saying
for I in range 100
increase dot click and very quickly
you'll see that number 100 times go
ahead and go up to 100 faster than a
human could ever have clicked that plus
button over and over again and so these
tests can not only be automated but they
can be much faster than any human could
ever be in order to test this Behavior
so how then can we incorporate this idea
into actual tests that we write into
like a unit testing framework that
allows me to Define all these various
different functions that test different
parts of my web applications Behavior
well to do that
let's go ahead and take another look at
tests.pi
inside of test.pi here again is that
file URI function where that function
has the sole purpose of like taking a
file and getting its URI and we need the
URI to be able to open it up
then we go ahead and get the Chrome web
driver which is going to be what's going
to allow us to run the in simulate
interaction with chrome and in order to
get Chrome's Webdriver you do have to
get Chrome driver separately it is
separate from Google Chrome itself but
Google does make it available and other
web browsers make equivalent web drivers
available as well if you'd like to test
how things would work in other browsers
because different browsers might behave
differently and it might be useful to be
able to test to make sure that not only
does everything work in Google Chrome
but it's also going to work in other
browsers that you might expect users to
be working with as well
here then I've defined a class that
again inherits from unit test.test case
that is going to Define all of the tests
that I would like to run on this web
page that here I have a function called
test title that's going to go ahead and
first get counter.html it's going to
open up that page and then just assert
equal let's make sure the title of the
page is actually counter that's what I
would expect it to be so I can write a
test in order to test for that case as
well
here I test the increase button by
finding the element whose ID is increase
and clicking on that button to simulate
a user pressing the plus button in order
to increase the value of the counter and
then what do I want to check well I want
to check that when you find element by
tag name H1 and so find element by tag
name similar to find element by ID
except instead of finding something by
its ID it's going to look at what's the
tag and it only is one element that is
an H1 and so here I'm saying go ahead
and get me the H1 element and access its
text property meaning whatever it is
that is contained inside of those two H1
tags I would expect that to be the
number one and so I would assert that
this is equal to 1. and likewise I can
do the same thing for the decrease
button finding the element whose ID is
decrease clicking on that button and
then asserting equal find me the H1
element and make sure that the contents
of it are equal to the number negative
one for instance and this final test
just test things multiple times that
three times and then press the increase
button and make sure that after I press
the increase button three times when I
check the H1 check what's inside of its
text that the answer should in fact be
three
so now I should be able to go ahead and
test this code by running
pythontests.pi and what that is going to
do is it's going to open up a web
browser and what you're going to see it
very quickly flashed across my screen
were all of those tests we test the
increase by one we test decrease by one
and then we test like increase three
times after we check to make sure the
title was correct and then we can see
here is the output we ran four tests in
this amount of time and everything
turned out to be okay none of the tests
failed but if one of the tests had
failed well then
we would see a different output so let's
imagine for example that I had had a bug
in my decrease function for example
where the decrease function wasn't
actually working what would that bug
look like maybe I forgot to say counter
minus minus or maybe perhaps more likely
what might have happened is I wanted to
I already had written the increase
function and I decided to very quickly
add the decrease function and I thought
I'd just you know what copy paste like
copy the increase event handler the
decrease event handler is basically the
same thing except I need to query for
decrease instead and maybe I just did
that and forgot to change a plus plus to
minus minus a bug that might happen if
you're not too careful about how you
copy and paste code from one place to
another
now when I run these tests pythontest.pi
we'll see the simulation
a whole bunch gets simulated and when I
go back and check the output of my test
see what actually happened I see that we
do seem to have an assertion error here
the assertion fail was on the test
decrease function and it happened when I
tried to assert that was inside of the
H1 element was negative one because one
is not equal to negative one so this is
the value of this assertion error as
well and this is helpful an advantage
over just assert assert just tells you
you know there's an assertion error but
here in unit test we actually get to see
if I asserted that two things are equal
it tells me what both of those things
are it tells me the actual output of
h1's text it was one
but what I expected it to be was
negative one so it tells me exactly what
the discrepancy is I know that for some
reason it was one instead of negative
one and that can be a clue to me a hint
to me as to how I can go about trying to
solve this problem
and I can solve the problem by going
into my decrease event handler seeing
that all right this was increasing the
counter instead of decreasing it change
plus plus to minus minus and now rerun
my tests and see
all the test simulated inside of my
Chrome driver
and we ran four tests and this time
everything was okay so all of my tests
appear to have passed this time
so those then are some possibilities for
being able to test our code especially
taking advantage of unit tests this
library that we can use in Python in
order to make various types of
assertions about what we would like to
be true or false about our code and unit
test contains a number of helpful
methods for being able to perform these
sorts of assertions some of them are
here so we can say things like I would
like to assert the two things are equal
to each other which we've seen there's a
counterpart to that a certain not equal
for making sure the two things are not
equal to one another assert true and
false we've seen this well there are
others as well though things like assert
in or assert not in if I would like to
assert for example that some element is
in some list for example or that some
element is not in some list
there are other assert methods as well
that we can use in order to verify that
a part of our program or a part of our
web application does in fact behave the
way we would want to behave and we can
integrate this type of idea into a
number of different types of testing we
thought integrating it into Django
itself using Django's unit testing in
order to verify that our database works
the way we expected it to and that our
views works the way that we expected
them to and provided the right context
back to the user after the user makes a
request to our web application and there
are also applications of unit testing
whether using the framework or not to
browser-based testing when I want to
test like inside of the user's web
browser does it actually work when a
user clicks on this button that the
JavaScript behaves the way that we
expect it to and I don't need to
especially use JavaScript in order to do
those tests I can write those tests
using python using unit test to be able
to say click on the button that has this
ID and verify that the result that we
get back is what we would expect it to
be
so that then was testing and now we'll
go ahead and take a look at CI CD
continuous integration and continuous
delivery which refer to two best
practices in the software development
world that have to do with how it is
that code is written especially by
groups or teams of people how it all
works together and how that code is
eventually delivered and deployed to
users who are using those applications
so CI which refers to continuous
integration involves frequent merges to
a main branch of some repository like a
git repository and then automatically
running unit tests when that code is
pushed
so what does that generally mean well in
the past you might imagine that if
multiple people are working on some
project at the same time and multiple
people are each working on different
features or different parts of that
project then after everyone's done
working on those features and we're
ready to like ship some new version of a
web application or ship some new version
of a software product well then
everyone's going to have to take all
these various different features and
combine them all together at the end and
figure out how to then try and deliver
that program to users and this has a
tendency to cause problems especially if
people have been working on different
big changes all simultaneously they
might not all be compatible with one
another there might be conflicts between
the various different changes that have
been made SO waiting until everyone's
done working on a feature to merge them
all back together and then deliver it is
not necessarily the best practice which
is why increasingly many more teams are
beginning to adopt a system of
continuous integration that there's one
repository somewhere online that's
keeping the official version of the code
everyone works on their own version of
the code maybe on their own Branch for
example
but very frequently all of these changes
are merged back together into the same
Branch to make sure that these
incremental changes can be happening
such that it's less likely that there's
two really Divergent paths that the
program has gone under and as a result
it's much more difficult to merge those
two paths back together
in addition to frequently merging to a
thumb main branch another key idea of
continuous integration is this idea of
automated unit testing where unit
testing again refers to this idea of on
our program we run a big series of tests
that verify each little part of our
program to make sure that the web
application behaves the way it is
supposed to and unit tests generally
refer to testing particular small
components of our program making sure
that each component works as expected
there are also bigger scale tests tests
like integration tests that make sure
that the entire pathway from like user
request to response that everything
along a certain pipeline works as well
but there are various different types of
testing and the important thing is
making sure that anytime some new change
is merged into the main branch or
someone wants to merge their changes
into the main branch that these tests
are run to make sure that nobody ever
makes a change to one part of a program
that breaks some other part of the
program and in a large enough code base
it's going to be impossible for any one
person to know exactly what the effect
of one particular change is going to be
on every other part of the program
they're going to be unforeseen
consequences that the one programmer may
or may not know about and so the
advantage of unit testing assuming
they're comprehensive and cover all of
these various different components of
the program is that anytime someone
makes a change and attempts to merge
that change into the main branch
according to the practice of continuous
integration the fact that it doesn't
pass a test will know about that
immediately and as a result that
programmer can go back and try to fix it
as opposed to waiting until everything
is done merging everything together and
then running the tests realizing
something doesn't work and then being
unsure of where to begin we don't know
where the bug is which change happened
to cause the bug if everything is merged
more incrementally it's easier to spot
those bugs assuming there's good
coverage of tests to make sure that
we're accounting for these various
different possibilities
so continuous integration refers to that
idea frequently and more incrementally
updating the main branch and making sure
that the tests are in fact passing and
it's closely tied to a related idea of
continuous delivery which is about the
process of how it is that the software
is actually released to users how the
web application actually gets deployed
and there are a couple of models you
might go about thinking with regards to
how it is that some program or web
application gets deployed you might
imagine the release cycle might be quite
long the people spend months working on
various different features on some
software development team and after
they're happy with all the new changes
they've released some new version of the
web application but especially with web
applications that are undergoing
constant change that have lots of users
that are moving very quickly one thing
that's quite popular is this notion of
continuous delivery which refers to
having shorter release schedules instead
of immediately releasing something at
the end of some long cycle you can in
shorter Cycles make releases every day
every week or so in order to say that
let's just go ahead and incrementally
make those changes whatever new changes
happen to have merged to the main branch
let's go ahead and release those as
opposed to waiting much longer in order
to perform those releases
and that again lends itself to certain
benefits the benefit of being able to
just incrementally make changes such as
something goes wrong you know more
immediately what went wrong as opposed
to making a lot of changes at once where
if something goes wrong it's not
necessarily clear what went wrong and it
also allows new features to get out to
users much more quickly so especially in
a competitive market where many
different web applications are competing
with one another being able to take a
new feature and release it very quickly
can be quite helpful so continuous
delivery is all about that idea of short
release Cycles rather than wait a long
time for a new version to be released
release versions incrementally as new
features begin to come in it's closely
related to the idea of continuous
deployment which CD will sometimes also
represent continuous deployment is
similar in spirit to continuous delivery
but the deployments happen automatically
that rather than a human having to say
all right we've made a couple of changes
let's go ahead and deploy those changes
in continuous deployment anytime these
changes are made the pipeline of
deploying the application to users will
automatically take place as well just
removing one thing for humans to have to
think about and allowing for these
deployments to happen even more quickly
as well
so the question then is what tools can
allow us to make continuous integration
and continuous delivery a little bit
easier what techniques can we use in
order to do so and there are a number of
different continuous integration tools
but one of them produced by GitHub more
recently is known as GitHub actions and
what GitHub actions allows us to do is
to create these workflows where we can
say that anytime for example someone
pushes to a git repository I would like
for certain steps to take place certain
steps that might be like checking to
make sure the code is styled well that
if a company has some style guide that
it expects all of its programmers to
adhere to when working on a particular
product you could have a GitHub action
such that anytime someone pushes to a
repository you have an action that
automatically checks that code against
the style guide to make sure that it is
well styled well common to documented
and so forth you might also for instance
have a GitHub action that tests our code
to make sure that anytime anyone pushes
code to a GitHub repository we
automatically run whatever tests we
would like to run on that particular
code base and GitHub actions can allow
us to do that as well by defining some
workflow to be able to do so and so
that's what we'll take a look at in just
a moment using GitHub actions to
automate the process of running tests so
that the human though it would be a good
thing for the programmer when they're
done writing their code to test their
code and make sure it works we can
enforce that by making sure that every
time anyone pushes to a GitHub
repository will automatically run some
GitHub action that is going to take care
of the process of running tests on that
program and we'll know immediately as
via an email that GitHub might send to
you to say that this particular test
failed and you'll know every time you
push to that Repository
so how do these workflows get structured
what is the syntax of them will they use
a particular type of syntax known as
yamo which is some language a
configuration language that can be used
in order to describe often described for
configuration of various different tools
and software GitHub actions happens to
use it other Technologies use it as well
and yaml is a file format that
structures its data sort of like this in
terms of key value pairs much in the
same way that a Json object or a python
dictionary might where we'll have the
name of a key followed by a colon
followed by its value name of a key
followed by colon followed by a value
and the value doesn't necessarily need
to be just a single value it could be a
sequence of values like a list of values
for example and those are denoted this
way by like a hyphen indicating a list
item one item two item three and in
addition to just having single values
and lists of items these ideas these
lists these sequences these values can
be nested within one another that you
might have one key that leads to another
set of keys that are associated with
values that leads to other sets of keys
associated with values as well much in
the same way that a Json object like a
representation of keys and values can
also have nested Json objects within a
Json object likewise too we can have
nested key value pairs as the value for
a particular key too so we'll take a
look at an example of what that actually
looks like in the context of creating
some GitHub workflow that will run some
GitHub actions
so what will that look like let's go
back into Airline zero where here I've
defined inside of a DOT GitHub directory
a directory called workflows inside of
which I have a ci.yml file it can be any
name.yaml.yml or dot yaml or the
conventional file extensions for a yaml
file
and here I'll open up ci.yml and this
now is the configuration for how this
workflow
ought to behave I give the workflow a
name it's called testing because what I
want the workflow to do is like test my
Airline application
then I specify an on key to mean when
should this workflow run
and here I've said on push meaning
anytime someone pushes their code to
GitHub we would like to run this
workflow
every workflow consists of some jobs and
so what are the jobs what tasks should
happen anytime that I try and push to
this repository well I've defined a job
called test project and this is a name
that I chose for myself you can choose
any name for a job that you would like
and now I need to specify two things for
what happens on a job one thing I need
to specify is what sort of machine is it
going to run on that GitHub has its own
virtual machines otherwise known as VMS
and I would like to run this job on one
of those virtual machines and they're
virtual machines for various different
operating systems here I'm just saying
go ahead and run on the latest version
of Ubuntu which is a related version of
Linux that I would like for this test to
run on and then for the job I specify
what steps should happen where I can now
specify like what actions should happen
when someone tries to test the project
when I try and run this job and here I'm
using a particular GitHub action and
this is a GitHub action written by
GitHub called actions slash checkout and
what this is going to do is it's going
to check out my code in the git
repository and allow me to like run
programs that operate on that code and
you can write your own GitHub actions if
you would like but here all we really
need to do is go ahead and check out the
code AS by looking at what's on the
branch that I just pushed to and then
I'm going to run Django unit tests this
is just a description for me to know
what's going on in this particular step
and here is what I would like to run I'm
going to first go ahead and install
Django because I'm going to need to
install Django to be able to run all
these tests but after and if there are
other requirements I might need to
install those requirements as well but
the airline program is fairly simple all
we really need in order to run the tests
is just Django so I'll go ahead and
install Django
and then
I'll run python3 manage.pi test I would
like to test run all of the tests and
the way I can do that is just by
providing this manage.pi command to say
that I would like to run all of the
tests on this particular application
so this configuration file all together
now is going to specify a particular
workflow the workflow that says that
every time I push to the GitHub
repository what I would like to happen
is I would like to check out my code
inside of the git repository so on some
Ubuntu VM GitHub is going to check out
my code and it's going to run these
commands it's going to install Django
and then it's going to test my code and
it will then give back to me what the
response is after I do that
so let's go ahead and test this and in
particular let's run it on a program
where the tests are going to fail so I
might say for example let's go into
flights and models.pi
and let's go to my is valid flight
function from before and change it back
to that version that didn't work but
before it was something and something
I'll change it to something or something
that as long as the origin is not the
destination or the duration is greater
than zero we'll count that as valid but
we know that that's wrong that should
not work
so here's what I'll do I'll go ahead and
first say git status see all right
what's changed and it seems that all
right I've changed I've modified
models.pi
which makes sense I'll go ahead and get
add I'll add dot we'll just add all the
files that I might have modified I'll
commit my changes so go ahead and use a
wrong valid flight function
that's what I'm going to do and now I'm
going to push my code to GitHub
I added it I committed it I pushed it
that now then pushes my code to GitHub
into a repository called airline that I
already have and now if I go ahead and
go to GitHub and I go to my Airline
Repository
what you'll notice is that we've mostly
been dealing with this code tab but
GitHub gives us other tabs as well that
are quite useful as you begin to think
about working on a project in larger
teams so in addition to looking at the
code we have issues issues are ways for
people to just report that something is
not quite right or there's a feature
request that we have for this particular
code base so the issues might maintain a
list of all the pending action items for
a particular repository things that we
still need to deal with and once those
issues are dealt with the issues can be
closed so I have no issues here as well
pull requests are people that are trying
to merge some part of the code from one
branch into another Branch so you might
imagine on a larger project you don't
want everyone merging things into master
all at the same time you might have
people working on their own separate
branches and then when they feel
confident and happy with their code then
they can propose a pull request to merge
their code into the master branch and
that allows for various other features
like the ability for someone to offer a
code review to be able to review the
code write comments and propose
suggestions for what changes should be
made to a particular part of the code
before it gets merged into the master
branch and that's another common
practice with regards to
working on a GitHub repository or any
other larger project that you're
controlling using Source control is this
idea of code reviews that oftentimes you
don't want just one person making the
changes without anyone's eyes on that
code but you'll want a second pair of
eyes to be able to look things over make
sure the code is correct make sure it's
efficient make sure it's in line with
the practices that the application is
using and so pull requests can be quite
helpful for that and then this fourth
tab over here represents GitHub actions
these are the various different actions
or workflows that I might want to run on
this particular repository and what
we'll see here is that if I go to the
actions tab now
what I'll see is here is my most recent
testing action so anytime I push I get a
new testing action this one was from 29
seconds ago
I'll go ahead and click on it and see
what's within it all right here was the
job that I ran test project I see that
on the left hand side you'll notice this
big red X on the left hand side of this
workflow means something went wrong so
I'd like to know what it is that went
wrong I'll go ahead and click on test
project
and here within it these are all of the
steps the things that happened when we
actually ran this particular job first
the job sets up then the checkout action
goes ahead and checks out my code
because we need access to my code to be
able to run it
here with the step I defined run Django
unit tests which was going to install
Django and run those tests
it has an X next to it indicating
something went wrong and I see down
below annotations one failure so all
over the place GitHub is trying to tell
me that something went wrong it failed
two minutes ago here
I'll go ahead and open this up
and what I'll see is the first thing
that happened is we install Django and
that seems to have worked okay
but down below what you'll see is the
output of running these unit tests that
we see failed failures too and now I can
see here are the unit tests that failed
we failed the invalid flight destination
test we failed the invalid flight
duration test and as before I can see in
github's user interface what those
assertion errors are I can see it true
is not false true is not false those
were the problems that happened when I
tried to run this particular test Suite
and now others who are also working on
this repository can see as well what the
results of these tests are and can offer
suggestions can offer ways that I might
be able to fix the code in order to deal
with that problem but now I know that
this particular test failed
and if I go back to the main code page
for this GitHub repository
I'll see
that next to this commit there's a
little X symbol and that little X symbol
next to the commit just tells me that
the most recent time I tried to commit
something went wrong they ran the
workflow in there was an error and so
I'll immediately see for this commit and
I can go back and look at the history of
commits and see which ones were okay and
which ones had a tendency to cause some
sort of problem
so this one it appears caused a problem
and we know why it caused a problem
because of this condition something or
something else so I can fix it I'll
change the or to an end
I'll go ahead and get add dot get commit
say I will fix
a valid flight check
if I do get status just to check out
like what's going on right now I'm ahead
of the master Branch by one commit
that's exactly what I would expect and
now I'll go ahead and push my code to
GitHub by running git push
saying all right let's push this update
and now hopefully we're going to pass
the workflow now now I go back to the
repository I refresh the page
here's my latest commit fix valid flight
check you'll notice here there's an
orange dot instead of the Red X as
before this dot just means the tests are
currently pending the workflow is in
progress because it takes some time for
GitHub to be able to start up the VM to
be able to initialize the job to check
out my code to run all those tests so it
does take some time but if I go back to
the actions tab I'll see that all right
this time for testing we get a green
check mark everything seems to be okay I
go to test project just to see it and
now I notice the green check mark next
to run Django unit tests means that the
unit tests have passed as well
if I open those up now I see at the
bottom the same output that I saw before
when I was running those unit tests on
my own machine we ran 10 tests and
everything was okay and that tells me
that these tests have passed so GitHub
actions have the ability to allow for
certain jobs to happen certain work to
happen anytime you push code anytime you
submit a pull request or on various
different actions that might happen on a
GitHub repository and they're very
helpful for being able to implement this
idea of continuous integration because
it means you can make sure that when
you're merging code from some developers
Branch into the main branch that
everyone's merging their code into you
can verify that those tests can pass and
you can add rules to say that you don't
want to allow anyone to merge code into
the branch if the tests don't pass to
guarantee that any code that does get
merged is going to pass all of those
tests as well
and so that can definitely help the
development cycle make it easier to
ensure the changes can be made quickly
but as we make those changes quickly
we're not going to lose accuracy and
validity within our code that we can
make sure that our code still passes
those tests by automating the process of
running those tests altogether
so other than continuous integration
then we now talk about this idea of
continuous delivery these short
application Cycles where we would like
to very quickly be able to deploy our
application onto some sort of web server
and when we're deploying applications to
a web server there are things that we
need to think about we need to think
about getting our program that was
running fine on our computer working on
a web server as well and this can just
be fraught with headaches and all sorts
of configuration problems because you
might imagine that the computer that you
are using is not necessarily going to be
the same as the computer that on the
cloud the computer and the server where
your web application is actually running
it might be running a different
operating system it might have a
different version of python installed if
you have certain packages working on
your own computer those same packages
might not be installed on the server so
we've run into all sorts of various
different configuration problems where
you can be developing deploy your code
and realize that it doesn't work on the
server because of some sort of
difference between what's happening on
your computer and what's happening on
the server and this becomes even more
problematic if you're working on a
larger team you and multiple other
people working on a software project but
you each have different versions of
various different packages or libraries
installed and those different versions
have different features and might not
all work and cooperate with one another
and so we need some way in order to be
able to deploy applications efficiently
and effectively to be able to
standardize on just you know one version
of the environment one version of all
these packages to make sure that every
developer is working on the project in
the same environment and once we deploy
the application it's going to be working
in the same environment as well and the
solution to this comes in a number of
possible options but one option is to
take advantage of a tool like Docker
which is some sort of containerization
software and by containerization
software what we're talking about is the
idea that when we're running an
application instead of just running it
on your computer we're going to run it
inside of a container on your computer
and each container is going to contain
its own configuration it's going to have
certain package is installed it's going
to have certain versions of certain
pieces of software it's going to be
configured in exactly the same way
and by leveraging a tool like Docker you
can make sure that so long as you
provide the right instructions for how
to start up and set up these containers
then if you are working on the
application and someone you're working
with some colleague is also working on
the same project so long as you're using
the same instructions for how to set up
a Docker container you're going to be
working in the identical environments
that if a package is installed on your
computer in your container it's going to
be installed in your colleagues
container as well and the advantage of
this too works with this idea of
continuous delivery when you want to
deliver and deploy your application to
the internet you can run your
application inside of that exact same
container set up using the exact same
set of instructions so that you don't
have to worry about the nightmare
headaches of trying to make sure that
all the right packages and all the right
versions are in fact installed on the
server
Docker might remind you of the idea of a
virtual machine or a VM if you're
familiar with that concept GitHub uses
VMS for instance when running into
GitHub actions they are in fact
different a VM is effectively running an
entire virtual computer with its own
virtual operating system and libraries
and application running on top of that
all inside of your own computer so a
virtual machine ends up taking up a lot
of memory taking up a lot of Space
Docker containers meanwhile are a bit
lighter weight they don't have their own
operating system they're all running
still on top of the host operating
system but there's this Docker layer in
between that keeps track of all these
various different containers and keeps
track of for each container such that
every container can have its own
separate set of libraries a percent of
binaries and an application running on
top of that
so the advantage then of
containerization is that these
containers are lighter weight than
having an entire virtual machine but
they can still keep their own
environment consistent such that you can
feel confident that if the application
is working in a Docker container you can
have that Docker container running on
your computer on someone else's computer
on the server to guarantee that the
application is going to work the way
that you would actually expect it to and
so how exactly do we configure these
various different Docker containers well
in order to do so
we're going to write what's called a
Docker file so to do this I'll go ahead
and go into Airline one
and I'll open up this Docker file
and the docker file describes the
instructions for creating a Docker image
where the docker image represents all of
the libraries and other installed items
we might want to have inside of the
container inside and then based on that
image we're able to create a whole bunch
of different containers that are all
based on that same image where each
container has its own files and can run
the web application inside of it so this
Docker file for example describes how I
might create a container that is going
to run my Django web application
so first essay from python colon 3 this
happens to be another Docker image on
which I'm going to base these
instructions that this is going to be a
Docker image that already contains
instructions for installing python3
installing other related packages that
might be helpful oftentimes when you're
writing a Docker file you'll base it on
some existing Docker file that already
exists so here I'm saying go ahead and
use python3
and now what do I want to do in order to
set up this container well I want to
copy anything in dot in my current
directory into the container and I have
to decide where in the container am I
going to store it well there I could
choose to store it anywhere but I'll
just store it in slash user Source app
just some you are some particular path
that will take me to a directory where I
am going to store the application but
you could choose something else entirely
so I copy all of the current files in my
current directory so that'll include
things like my requirements file my
manage.pi file my applications files all
my settings files everything inside of
the directory I would like to copy into
the container
then I'm saying workder meaning change
my working directory effectively the
same thing as something like CD on your
terminal to move into some directory I
would like to set my working directory
equal to that same application directory
the application directory inside of the
container that now contains all of the
files for my application because I
copied all of those files into the
container
now once I'm inside of this directory I
need to install all of my requirements
so assuming I've put all my requirements
like Django and any other packages that
I needed inside of a file called
requirements.txt I can just run the
command
pip install requirements.txt
and then finally inside the docker file
I specify a command and this is the
command that should run when I start up
the container everything else is going
to happen initially when we're just
setting up this Docker image but when I
start up the container and actually want
to run my web application here is the
command that should run and I provide it
effectively as like a python list where
each word in the command is separated by
a comma where here I'm saying the
command that I would like to run when
you start up this container is python
manage.pi run server and here I'm just
specifying on what address and what port
I would like it to run and running it on
Port 8000 for example but I could choose
another Port that I would like to run
instead
so what's going to happen then is that
when I start up this Docker container
it's going to if it needs to go through
these instructions and make sure that it
sets up the container according to these
instructions make sure that we've
installed all the necessary requirements
make sure that we're using python3 and
anyone using the same Docker file can
generate a container that has all the
same configuration on it so we don't
have to worry about configuration
differences between me and someone else
who might not have the exact same
computer setup that I do and the nice
thing about this is that it can run on
Mac and windows and Linux so even people
running on different operating systems
can still have containers that all have
the same configuration that all work in
the same way just to speed up that
process
now so far when we've been building
Django applications we've been using a
sqlite database sqlite database just
being a file that is stored inside of
our application and this file based
database allows us to create tables
insert rows into it delete rows from it
in most production environments and most
real web applications that are working
with many many users sqlite is not
actually the database that is used it
doesn't scale nearly as well when there
are many users all trying to access it
concurrently oftentimes in those sorts
of situations you want your database
hosted Elsewhere on some separate server
to be able to handle its own incoming
requests and connections and we talked
about a couple of possible databases we
could use instead of sqlite things like
my secret MySQL things like postgres or
various different SQL based databases
so imagine now I want to deploy my
application but instead of using SQL
Lite I would like to use postgres for
example as the database server that I
would like to run well that would seem
to be pretty complicated for me to test
on my own because now in addition to
running my web application in one server
effectively I also need like another
server that's running postgres for
example such that I can communicate with
that postgres database instead and
that's going to be even harder for like
other people to be able to work on as
well potentially it might be difficult
to get the server to work in that way
too but the nice thing about Docker is
that I can run each of these processes
in a different container effectively I
can have one container that's running my
web application using this Docker file
right here and I can have another
container that's just going to run
postgres and as long as other people
also have access to that same container
for running postgres they can be working
in an identical environment to the one
that I am working in as well
and so there's also a feature of Docker
known as Docker compose and what Docker
compose lets us do is allow us to
compose multiple different Services
together that I would like to run my web
application in one container and I would
like to run a postgres database in
another container but I would like for
those containers to be able to talk to
each other to be able to work together
whenever I start up the application
so if I'd like to do that in order to
run this application on my computer and
have both the web application and
postgres installed I can create a Docker
compose file which looks like this here
I'm specifying using version 3 of Docker
compose
here I specify again using a yaml file
much as in my GitHub workflows we're
formatted in yaml just as a
configuration file Docker compose.yml is
a yaml file that describes all of the
various different services that I want
to be part of my application where each
service is going to be its own container
that could be based on a different
Docker image
here I'm saying that I have two Services
one called DB for database one called
web for my web application the database
is going to be based on the postgres
docker image image the postgres wrote
that I don't have to worry about someone
else has written the docker file for how
to start up a postgres container
here though for the web application
that's going to be built based on the
docker file in my current directory the
docker file that I have written
and then down below I've just specified
that my current directory should
correspond to the app directory and then
I've specified when I'm running this on
my own computer I would like Port 8000
on the container to correspond to Port
8000 on my own computer just so that I
can access port 8000 in my browser and
access port 8000 inside the container it
just lets my computer actually talk to
The Container so I can open up the web
application in my web browser for
example and actually see the results of
all of this
so here then I've created two Services a
database and web so now let's actually
try starting up these containers I'm
going to first go into my Airline One
Directory and I'm going to say Docker
compose up to mean go ahead and start up
these Services I'll press return and
what you'll see is we're going ahead and
starting up two Services I'm starting up
the database service and I'm starting up
the web service
and now as a result of all of this
I've started up the application and I
started it on Port 8000 so if I go to
0.0.0.0 8000 or colon 8000 slash flights
that's going to take me to the flights
page and now this is running not just on
my own computer but inside of a Docker
container now of course right now there
are no flights inside of this page
because I haven't actually added
anything to the database yet so I could
do that if I wanted to but how do I do
that well I needed to like go into slash
admin to say like let me log in and go
ahead and create some sample flights but
I don't have a login yet because I need
to like create a super user account and
I can't just like inside of my Airline
One Directory say python manage.pi
create super user the way that I used to
because this is running in my terminal
on my computer whereas what I really
want to do is go into the docker
container and run this command there
inside of the container so how can I do
that well there are various different
Docker commands that I can use Docker PS
will show me all of the docker
containers that are currently running so
go ahead and Shrink this down a little
bit I see two rows one for each
container one for my postgres container
that's running the database one for just
my web application that's running as
well
each one has a container ID
so I want to go into my web application
container in order to run some commands
inside of that container so I'm going to
copy its container ID and say Docker
exec meaning go ahead and execute a
command on the container Dash it will
make this interactive here is the
container ID that I would like to
execute a command on and the command I
want to execute is dash pass in the dash
L flag but bash to say I want to run a
bash prompt I want to be able to
interact with a shell so that I can run
commands inside of this container
so I press return
and now what you'll notice is that I am
inside of my container in the user
Source app directory that directory that
contained all the information about this
web application I type LS and what I'll
see is here all the files inside of this
container now and now I can say
something like python manage.pi create
super user
and now it's going to let me create a
super user so I'll create a user inside
of my web application called Brian I'll
give it my email address I'll type in a
password
and now we've created a super user
and you can run other commands here if
you wanted to migrate all of your
migrations I could say python manage.pi
migrate it turns out I've already done
that so I didn't actually have to do it
again but you can run any commands that
you could run on your computer but now
you can run them inside of the docker
container instead I'm going to press
Ctrl D just to log out get out of the
container and get back to my computer
but now I've created a super user so I
could go ahead and sign in to Django's
admin and now I can begin to manipulate
this database which is a postgres
database running in a separate container
but the nice thing about it is that I
can start them both up together just by
running something like Docker compose up
for example
so Docker can be quite a powerful tool
for allowing us to very quickly ensure
that an application is running in the
environment that we expect it to be
running to make sure that all the right
libraries are installed make sure that
all the right packages are installed as
well that the configuration between my
development environment and the
environment that's running on the server
are the same as well
so those then were just some of the best
practices for how you can go about
developing a program now that we have
the tools to do so we have a lot of
tools for being able to develop these
web applications but as our programs
start to get more complex it'll be
increasingly important to test them make
sure that each various different
component of our web application behaves
the way that it is expected to behave
and then taking advantage especially in
bigger teams of CI CD continuous
integration continuous delivery to make
incremental changes and make sure each
of those incremental changes in fact
works on the web application and then
cud continuous delivery to say that
rather than wait and then deploy
everything all at once let's deploy
things incrementally as well let users
more quickly get access to the latest
features and more quickly find out if
something went wrong we can better
identify what it is that went wrong if
we've deployed things incrementally
rather than waiting a long time in order
to do so as well so these are some of
the best practices in modern software
application development not only for web
applications but for software more
generally next time we'll consider other
challenges that might arise as we go
about trying to make web applications
that are used by more and more users in
particular taking a look at challenges
that will arise in terms of scalability
as our programs get bigger and also
security of what security
vulnerabilities open themselves up as we
begin to design our web applications
using Python and JavaScript so more on
that next time and we'll see you then
[Music]
thank you
all right welcome back everyone to web
programming with python and JavaScript
and for our final topic we're going to
explore scalability and security so so
far in the class we've been building web
applications and we've been building web
applications that work on our own
computer but if we want to take those
web applications and deploy them to the
world so people all across the internet
can begin to use them then we're going
to need to host our web application on
some sort of web server some dedicated
piece of Hardware that is listening for
web requests and responding to them with
the response that we would like for our
web application to deliver and when we
do so this introduces a whole bunch of
interesting issues surrounding
scalability and security so we'll take a
look at these issues today beginning
with problems concerning scalability
what those problems are and how we might
go about addressing them so when we
deploy our web applications we deploy
them by putting them onto a web server
that I'm here just representing with
this rectangle but all the server is is
some dedicated computer some piece of
Hardware that is listening for incoming
requests so we'll draw this line to
represent an incoming web request from a
user the server takes that request and
responds to it but ultimately our web
application isn't just going to be
servicing one user if it becomes popular
it might have many users that are all
trying to connect to that server at the
same time and as multiple people start
to connect to that server at the same
time here's where we start to deal with
issues of scalability a single computer
a single server can only service so many
users at any given time and so therefore
we need to think in advance about how
we're going to deal with those issues of
scale but the first question before we
even get there is where these servers
actually exist and nowadays there are
two main options for where these servers
can exist these server series can be on
the cloud or they can be on premise an
on-premise servers you might imagine and
as if a company is running their own web
application on-premise servers or
servers that are inside of the company's
walls the company owns the physical
servers maybe on some server racks
inside of a room and therefore they have
very direct control over all of the
servers exactly what kind of servers
they are exactly what software is
running on them they can go and
physically look at the servers and debug
them if need be in order to make sure
that any issues are dealt with but
increasingly we're starting to move into
a world where cloud computing is
becoming increasingly popular we're in
cloud computing rather than have
dedicated servers that are on premise we
have servers that are somewhere in the
cloud where cloud computing companies
like Amazon or Google or Microsoft are
able to run their own servers and we
simply use those servers that are
provided by those third parties whether
it's Amazon or Google or Microsoft or
someone else and there are trade-offs
here with cloud computing we no longer
have as direct control over the machines
themselves because they're not on
premise we can't physically manipulate
those computers but we have the
advantage of not having to worry about
dealing with physical objects that are
inside of the premise of the company
whose servers we'd like to run code for
that when it's on the cloud everything
is managed externally by some other
company and we can simply use the
servers that we need to and we'll see
that This lends itself to other benefits
as well as we might need more servers as
we start to get more sophisticated web
applications that need more users these
cloud computing companies can allow us
to create web app locations that are
able to scale across multiple different
servers as we start to get more and more
users but we'll discuss those issues of
scale as we get to them the question we
need to ask after we have these servers
whether they're servers that are on
premise or servers that are operating
somewhere in the cloud is how many can
those users can the server actually
service at any given time and that's
going to vary it's going to vary based
on the size of the server the computing
power of the server and it's going to be
dependent upon how diff how long it
takes to process any particular user's
request if user requests are quite
expensive it might mean that there are
fewer users that can be serviced at any
given time and it's for that reason that
a helpful tool is to do some kind of
benchmarking some process of trying to
do some analysis on how many users a
server can actually be handling at any
particular time and there are numerous
different tools that allow us to do this
kind of benchmarking Apache bench or
otherwise known as a b is a popular tool
for doing this kind of thing but
benchmarking is going to be useful so
that we know how many users one
particular server can handle maybe it
can handle 50 users maybe it can handle
100 users maybe it can handle more at
any given time but ultimately it's going
to be some finite limit every computer
just has some finite amount of resources
and servers are no exception there's
going to be some number of users after
which the server is not going to be able
to handle it so what do we do in that
situation what do we do if our server
can only handle 100 users at any given
time but 101 users are trying to use our
web application at the same time
something needs to change we need to
deal with some sort of scaling to make
sure that our web application can scale
and there are a couple of different
types of scaling that we can try one
approach is to do what's called vertical
scaling which might be the simplest way
you could imagine scaling if this server
is not good enough for handling the
number of users that we needed to handle
we'll then just get a bigger server in
vertical scaling we just take the server
and get a bigger server a more powerful
server a server that can handle more
users at any given time it's going to
cost more but if we need it to handle
more users we can just get a bigger
server to be able to deal with that
problem this approach is fairly simple
it just involves swapping out one server
for another one that can handle more
users concurrently but it also has
drawbacks right there's some limit to
how big the server can be to how many
users any physical one server is going
to be able to handle because there's a
physical limitation on what is the
biggest fastest most powerful server we
could possibly get
so when vertical scaling ends up not
being enough an alternative as you might
imagine is what's known as horizontal
scaling and the idea behind horizontal
scaling is that when one server isn't
enough to be able to service all of the
users that might be trying to use a web
application at the same time well then
we can take the approach of saying well
rather than just using one server let's
go ahead and split it up into two
different servers we now have two
servers that are both running the web
application and now effectively we've
been able to double the number of users
that this web application can handle
rather than just a single server that
can serve as 100 users if we have two of
them now we can Service 200 users at any
given time if you imagine 100 of them
using server a over here and 100 of them
using server B over there
but this then lends itself to some other
questions that we have to answer which
is how do these servers get their users
in the first place like when a user
requests a web page how does that user
get directed either to server a or to
server B it seems that they need some
way to make that decision in order to
decide whether to go One Direction or
another
and it's for that reason that we might
introduce another piece of Hardware into
this picture and that additional piece
of Hardware is what we might call a load
balancer and a load balancer is just
another piece of Hardware that is going
to sit in front of these servers so to
speak in other words when a user makes a
request to a web page rather than
immediately getting that request to one
of these web servers the request is
first going to go through this load
balancer where the request first comes
into the load balancer and the load
balancer then decides whether to send
that request to server a or to send that
request to server B
and this process is likely less
expensive than actually dealing with and
processing that request so the load
balancer is effectively just acting as a
dispatcher it waits for those requests
to come in and when the requests do come
in the load balancer directs those
requests either to go to one server or
to another and you might imagine a story
where we have more than just two servers
maybe we have many servers and the load
balancer is just going to balance
between all of those different servers
and this process of deciding which
server to send a request to is known as
load balancing which is what the load
balancer is ultimately doing and there
are various different methods that you
might use in order to perform this load
balancing so you might imagine thinking
about this intuitively how would the
load balancer decide given some request
should we send the request to this
router to this server or should we send
the request to some other server instead
and there are many different approaches
that our load balancer might take and
here are just a couple random Choice
might be the simplest of options given a
user that shows up and tries to make a
request to our web server the load
balancer first takes a look at the user
and just randomly assigns them to one of
the various different servers that might
be processing that request if there are
10 different servers it randomly chooses
among those 10 servers to decide which
of them is going to be servicing that
request this has the advantage of being
very simple it's just a quick
calculation the computers can pretty
readily Generate random numbers and
based on that random number the computer
can dispatch the user to one server or
to another server but it might not be
the best option because if we happen to
get unlucky we might end up with many
more users on one server than another or
in such we might end up with servers
that are entirely unused if it just so
happens that we don't end up randomly
selecting that server now in practice
with many users that are all using this
load balance they're all being
dispatched odds are high that eventually
all of them will be used but it might
not be a totally even distribution and
so for that reason another approach you
might take is a round-robin approach
where the approach is instead for the
very first user go ahead and assign that
user to server number one for the next
user assign them to server number two
and maybe if there are five servers you
say the third user goes to server three
user four goes to server four user 5
goes to server five and then user six
goes back to server number one you
basically rotate going one through five
and then once you've assigned someone to
each of the servers you go back to the
beginning
this is also a relatively easy thing to
implement because you can simply just
keep count somewhere in the load
balancer saying what was the most recent
server that I assigned a user to and the
next time a request comes in go ahead
and assign it to the next server and the
next server after that effectively is
doing a round robin style approach where
you go through all the servers once
before going through the servers again
now this might seem better than random
choice in the sense that it's going to
more equitably decide whether to assign
any particular uh request to any
particular server but it also suffers
from certain problems that round robin
might be great but if some requests take
longer than other requests we might also
get unlucky and the requests that are
taking longer might end up all going to
one of the servers as opposed to another
server so there are other approaches
that we might want to go to as well for
example something like fewest
connections where the approach there is
to say go ahead and when a user makes a
request
the load balancer should pick which of
the servers currently has the fewest
connections the fewest active
connections from other users and other
requests that are currently connected to
those servers instead and by choosing
the server that happens to have the
fewest connections you're probably going
to do a better job of trying to balance
out between all the various different
requests that might be happening inside
of your web application
and while this might do a better job
there are trade-offs here as well that
it might be more expensive for example
to compute which of the servers happens
to have the fewest number of connections
whereas it's much easier just to say
choose a server at random or to do the
round robin style approach of just one
two three four five one two three four
five again and again and again
but all of these approaches naively have
yet another problem which has to do with
sessions and you recall that sessions we
used whenever we wanted to store
information about the user's current
interaction with the web application
when you log into a website like you log
into your email or you log into Amazon
for example and then you come back to
that website or visit another page on
that website making another request for
example it's not the case that you have
to sign in yet again that the web
browser has totally forgotten who you
are when I go back to my mail account or
when I go back to Amazon for a second
time my mail account or Amazon remembers
me from the last time that I visited I
have some sort of session where it's
keeping track of who is logged in maybe
information about what I've been doing
on the page and allows me to continue
interacting with the web application
even if I'm making multiple requests
and this you might imagine could be a
problem for this type of load balancing
but if I have multiple different servers
imagine if I try to log into a website
and the first time I make a request I'm
directed to server number one and I'm
now logged in on server number one but
then I make another request I'm directed
back to the load balancer and maybe the
load balancer this time decides to send
me to server number two but if the
session is stored in server number one
somewhere server number one remembers
who I am and what I'm doing then server
number two is not going to know who I am
and therefore it's not going to remember
that I've already logged into this web
application and as a result I might be
prompted to log in again and if I would
go make another request and I end up on
yet another server I might be logged out
again and have to log in for a third
time so the problem comes about when our
load balancing happens but we're not
doing so in a session aware way that our
load balancer isn't caring about when a
user visits the page and then visits
another page on the same web application
again because we want to remember
information from the previous time that
the user was here
so how can we solve this problem how can
we make sure that when we do this load
balancing across multiple different
servers that we do so in a session aware
way well there are multiple different
approaches to session aware load
balancing one approach is this general
idea known as sticky sessions where the
idea is that when I come back to the
load balancer the load balancer will
remember what server I was sent to last
time and send me there yet again
so for example if I log into a website
once and I'm directed to server number
two for example then the next time I
visit this web application even if I
should be directed to server 3 or 4
according to random choice or according
to fewest connections or any of these
other load balancing methods the load
balancer should remember that last time
I came to this site I got directed to
server number two and so this time the
load balancer is going to direct me to
server number two yet again that way
server number two which contains
information about my session is going to
see me again and remember who it is that
I am and it's not going to make me log
in again into the exact same website for
a second time for example and so sticky
sessions are one way of dealing with
this problem but again with all of these
approaches and this will be a recurring
theme as we talk about scalability and
security there are trade-offs here that
are trade-off to the sticky sessions is
that it's possible that one of these
servers is going to end up getting far
more load than another if one server
happens to have a lot of users that keep
coming back to the website and keep
requesting additional pages but other
Pages other servers might have had users
that decided not to come back for
example and so there's a difference in
utilization where some of our servers
might be more heavily utilized than
other servers and we're not doing a very
good job of balancing between them
and so one approach is to store sessions
inside of the database rather than store
information about sessions inside of the
server themselves so that if I get
directed to another server that other
Server doesn't remember who I am doesn't
remember information about my
interaction with this website if we
instead choose to store sessions inside
of a database and in particular inside
of a database that all of the servers
have the ability to access well then it
doesn't matter which of the servers I
get directed to and which server the
load balancer decides to send me to
because regardless of which server I end
up getting sent to the session
information is in the database and each
of the servers can connect to the
database to find out who I am to find
out whether I've logged into the site
already and therefore is able to
recognize me
and so that might be one approach as
well another approach to store sessions
on the client side we've talked a little
bit about this idea of cookies which can
be stored where the web browser can set
a cookie so that your web browser is
able to present that cookie the next
time it makes a request to the same web
application and inside this cookie you
can store a whole bunch of information
including information about the session
you might inside of a cookie store
information about what user is currently
logged in for example or other session
related information but here too there
are drawbacks if you're not careful
someone could manipulate that cookie and
maybe pretend to be something else and
so for that reason you might want to do
some encryption or some kind of signing
to make sure that you can't fake a
cookie and pretend to be someone that
you're not but another concern is that
as you start to store more and more
information inside of these cookies
these cookies keep get sitting back and
forth between the server and the client
every time a request is made that can
start to get expensive too more and more
information passing back and forth
between the client and between the
server
so lots of possible approaches no one
approach that is necessarily the right
approach or the best approach to use in
any cases but things to be aware of
things to think about as we begin to
deal with these issues of scale of
making sure we have multiple servers
that are available for usage in case we
do need it but also making sure that
when we do so we don't break the user
experience we don't result in a
situation where a user is logged in but
then suddenly isn't logged in at all
and so horizontal scaling gives us this
kind of capacity the ability to have
multiple different servers all of which
can be dealing with user requests and
responding to those user requests as
well
but a reasonable question asked is how
many of those servers do we need
now we can use benchmarking to try to
estimate this if we have an estimate of
how many users are going to be on our
website at any given time we can
Benchmark and see how many users there
can be handled by a single server and
extrapolate based on that information to
infer how many servers we might need in
our web application to be able to
service all of these different users but
it might be the case that our web
application doesn't always have the same
number of users maybe sometimes they're
going to be far more users than another
time you might imagine for example that
in a news organization's website like
the web application for a newspaper
when there's breaking news some big
story there's going to be a lot more
people that are all trying to access the
website at the same time than at other
times so one approach might be like
consider the maximum what is the most
number of users that ever might be
trying to use our web application at any
given time and choose a number of
servers based on that maximum so that no
matter how high the number of users get
we will have enough servers to be able
to service all of those users but that's
probably not a great economical choice
if in the vast majority of cases there
will be far fewer users in that case
you're going to have a lot of servers
that are underutilized where you don't
need that many servers but you're still
paying for the electricity for keeping
all of them running which might not be
an ideal choice either
so one solution to this quite popular
especially in this world of cloud
computing is the idea of Auto scaling
where you can have an auto scaler to say
that you know what let's start with for
example two servers
but if there's enough traffic to the
website if enough people are making
requests to the website maybe it's a
peak time where people are using the
website go ahead and scale up go ahead
and add a third server where now our
load balancer can balance between all
three of those servers and if even more
traffic ends up coming to the website
more users are trying to use this
application all at the same time well
then we can go ahead and add a fourth
server as well and we can continue to do
that most Auto scalers will let you
configure for example a minimum number
of servers and a maximum number of
servers and dependent on how many users
happen to be using your web application
at any given time
the auto scaler can scale up or scale
down adding new servers with more users
come to the website removing servers as
fewer users are using the website as
well
and so this can be a nice solution to
this problem of scale where you don't
have to worry about how many servers
there are it just Auto scales entirely
on its own now there are trade-offs here
too that this Auto scaling process might
take time and if a lot of users all come
into your website all at the exact same
time well it's going to take some time
to be able to add all these additional
servers to start them up and so there
might be some trade-offs there too
where you might not be able to service
all of those users immediately
and another problem we're thinking about
is as you add more and more of these
servers you introduce opportunities for
failure now it's better than having a
single server where if that single
server fails now suddenly the entire web
application doesn't work at all that's
what we generally call a single point of
failure a single place where if it fails
the entire system is going to be broken
one advantage of having multiple servers
is that we no longer have a single
server that acts as a point of failure
if one of the servers goes down then
ideally our load balancer should be able
to know based on that information
to no longer send a requests to that
particular server to instead balance the
load across the remaining three servers
instead
now there's an interesting question
there as well which is how does the load
balancer know that this server is no
longer responding for some reason and
have some sort of error that it's not
able to process requests appropriately
well there are multiple ways you can do
this but one of the most common is
what's simply known as a heartbeat where
effectively every so often every sum
number of seconds the load balancer
pings all the servers just sends a quick
request to all the servers and all of
the servers are supposed to respond back
and using that information
the load balancer knows a little bit
about the latency of each of the servers
how long it took for the server to
respond to the request but also it can
get information about whether or not the
server is functioning properly that if
one of the servers doesn't respond to
the Ping well then the load balancer
knows that there's probably something
wrong with the server that we probably
shouldn't be directing more users to
that server at all
and so this can solve for the problem of
a single point of failure by allowing
ourselves multiple servers where if any
one of the servers fails the load
balancer learns about that via heartbeat
and then based on that information can
begin to redirect traffic to the other
servers instead
now one thing you might notice is that
even in this picture now the load
balancer appears to be like a single
point of failure where if the load
balancer happens to fail well now
nothing is going to work because the
load balancer is the one responsible for
directing traffic to all of these
various different servers and so even
there there's no single server that has
a point of failure this load balancer
also appears to be a single point of
failure and that's definitely true and
you might imagine instead having
multiple load balancers where if one
load balancer goes down another load
balancer can swoop in acting as a hot
spare where it picks up all the traffic
that was originally going to the first
load balancer and if it ever goes down a
second one is ready to take its place
and it might also be doing this kind of
heartbeat process checking up on the
first load balancer and if all is well
the second load balancer doesn't have to
do anything but if the first load
balancer ever were to fail well then the
second load balancer can step in and
begin servicing those requests directing
them to all of these individual servers
as well and so there too another
opportunity to think about where the
single points of failure are and
thinking about how we might address
those single points of failure in order
to make sure that our web applications
are scalable so that then deals with
issues about how we might go about
scaling up these servers But ultimately
the servers are not the entirety of the
story that inside of our applications
we've mostly been writing web
applications that interact and deal with
data in some way and there are multiple
different databases that we've talked
about SQL Lite has been the default one
that Django provides to us which just
stores data inside of a file but as we
begin to grow our applications we want
to begin to scale them it's quite
popular and quite common to put
databases entirely somewhere separate to
have a separate database server running
somewhere else where the servers are all
communicating with that database whether
it's running MySQL or postgres or some
other database system instead and all of
the servers then have access to that
database and so there too are are
considerations that we need to take into
account issues of how it is that we go
about scaling up these databases
that in this picture for example you
might imagine a load balancer that is
communicating with two servers but both
of those servers for example need to be
communicating with this database and
much like any server can only handle
some number of requests some number of
users at any given time databases 2 can
only handle some number of requests some
concurrent number of connections at any
given time and so we need to begin to
think about issues of how it is and that
we scale these databases as well in
order to be able to handle more and more
users
now one approach the first thing we
might try to do is something called
database partitioning effectively
splitting up what is a big data set into
multiple different parts to that data
set and we've already seen some examples
of database partitioning we've seen one
example where for example when we talked
about SQL we looked at a table of
flights where each flight Had An Origin
City the origin cities airport code the
destination city the destination cities
airport code and some number of minutes
the duration for that particular flight
and we decided that storing all of this
data in a single table probably wasn't
the best idea and instead we wanted to
split that data up in a type of
partitioning where instead we said all
right let's just have one table that
will have all of the airports and so
each airport gets its own row inside of
this Airport's table and we also had
another table which was just the flights
table which rather than storing all of
those columns just mapped to airports to
each other that with any given flight it
has an origin ID meaning Which object
which Row in the origin of airports
table is represented by the flight and
then which Row in the airports table is
going to represent the destination for
that flight
so we took one table and effectively
split it up into multiple tables Each of
which ultimately had fewer columns and
this might be something we call the
vertical partitioning of a database
where instead of just having single big
long tables we split them up into
multiple tables Each of which have fewer
columns that are able to represent data
in a more relational way and that's
something we've seen before too but in
addition to Vertical partitioning we can
also do horizontal partitioning where
the idea there is that we take a table
and just split it up into multiple
tables that are all storing effectively
the same data but split up into
different data sets so the same type of
data but just in different tables where
we might have originally had a flights
table and instead we split it up into a
domestic flights table and an
international flights table each of
these tables still has the exact same
columns they still have a destination
column they still have an origin column
they still have a duration column for
example but we've just now taken the
data that used to be in one table and
split up that data into two or more
multiple different tables instead one
for all the domestic flights one for all
the international flights and the
advantage there is that we no longer
need to search through the entirety of
the data set if we're just looking for
one domestic flight for example if you
know the flight you're looking for is a
domestic flight well then it can be more
efficient to just search the flight's
domestic table and not bother searching
through the flight's International table
and so for intelligent about how we
choose to take a table and split it up
into multiple different tables the
effect of that is that we can often
improve the efficiency of our searches
the efficiency of our operations because
we're dealing with multiple smaller
tables where these operations can come
faster
one drawback though is that as we begin
to split data across multiple different
tables it becomes more expensive if ever
we need to join this data back together
and connect all the domestic and
international flights running separate
queries on each and so in that case
we'll want to think about trying to
separate our data in such a way that
generally we're only going to need to
deal with one table or the other at any
given time and so domestic and
international might be a reasonable way
to split up our flights table because
maybe most of the time our airport just
cares about searching domestic flights
if we know we're looking for one kind of
flight or just cares about searching for
international flights if they're
different people or different computers
that are going to handle each of those
different types of systems
and so partitioning our database can
sometimes help with issues of scale by
making it faster to search through large
amounts of data and being able to
represent data a little bit more cleanly
but it still seems to represent a single
point of failure that we have multiple
servers now that are all connected to
the same database and there again is a
single point of failure if the database
fails for some reason well now suddenly
none of our web application is going to
work because all of those servers are
all connected to that exact same
database and so it's for that reason
that we might just as we tried to add
more servers in order to solve the
problem of a single point of failure
with our servers we might also try
database replication that rather than
just have a single database in our web
application in order to guard against
potential failure we might replicate our
database have multiple different
databases and therefore reduce the
likelihood that our application entirely
fails and there are a couple of
approaches that we can use for database
replication two of the most common are
what are known as single primary
replication and multi-primary
replication and in single primary
database replication we have multiple
different databases but one of those
databases is considered to be the
primary database and what we mean by a
primary database is a database to which
we can both read data meaning like
select rows from the table but also
write data meaning insert rows or update
rows or delete rows to any of those
tables
so in single primary replication we have
a single database where we can both read
and write and we have some number of
other databases in this case two other
databases from which we can only read
data so we can get data from those
databases but we can't update or insert
or delete from those databases
and now we need some mechanism to make
sure that all of these databases are
kept in sync and ultimately what that
means is that anytime the database
changes all of the databases are
informed now the only database that can
change is our primary one this is the
only one that can be written to the only
one that allows for the data to change
the others are read-only so anytime this
primary database updates or changes in
some way it needs to inform the other
databases of that update and so it
informs the other databases of that
update and now all of the databases are
kept in sync where if you try and run a
query on any of these databases to
select and get some information you'll
get the same results from all of these
various different databases now the
single primary approach has some
drawbacks it has the drawback of only
one of these databases can be written to
so if you have a lot of users that are
all trying to write data to the database
at the exact same time
well there might be some issues here
where this one database is going to be
carrying all of that load for all of the
people that might be trying to update
and change that database and it also has
a slightly smaller version of the same
problem of a single point of failure
there's no longer a single point of
failure for reading from that data that
if you want to read from the data and
one of the databases goes out you can
read data from any of the other
databases and they'll work just fine but
it does have the drawback that if this
database fails if our primary database
fails well then we're no longer able to
write data that if we want to update
data inside of our database this one
database is no longer going to be
operational and none of the other
databases are going to allow us to write
new changes
so there are a couple of approaches we
can use to try to solve this problem one
approach though is instead of having a
single primary database a single
database to which we can read and write
to use a multi-primary approach and in
the multi-primary approach we have
multiple databases all of which we can
read and write to we can select rows
from all the databases and we can insert
and update and delete rows to all of
these databases as well but now the
synchronization process becomes a little
bit trickier and here now is the
trade-off and now we've replicated the
number of reads and writes we can do by
having many databases to which we can
read data and write data but anytime any
of these databases changes every
database needs to inform all of the
other databases of those updates
and that's certainly going to take some
amount of time it introduces some
complexity into our system as well and
it also introduces the possibility for
conflicts that you might imagine
situations where if two people are
editing similar data at the same time
that you might run into a number of
different types of conflicts so one type
of conflict for example would be an
update conflict if I try to edit one row
in one database and someone else tries
to edit the same Row in another database
when they sync up with each other via
this update process our database system
needs some way to decide how it's going
to resolve those various different
updates
another conflict might be a uniqueness
conflict we've seen in the case of
databases in SQL that when we're
designing our tables I can specify that
this particular field should be a unique
field common one being the ID field for
example where every single row is going
to have its own unique ID well what
happens if two people try to insert data
at the same time into two different
databases they're each given a unique ID
but it's the same ID on both of the
databases because neither database knows
that the other databases added a new row
yet so when they sync back up we might
run into uniqueness conflict where two
different databases have assigned the
same exact ID to multiple different
entries and so we need some way to be
able to resolve those conflicts as well
and there are many other conflicts that
you might imagine trying to deal with
one example being for instance delete
conflicts where one person tries to
delete a row and another person tries to
update that row well which should take
precedence should we update the row
should we delete the row we need some
way
to be able to make those decisions
because there is some latency between
When A change is made to a database and
when that database is able to
communicate with another database so
these issues have scale these issues of
synchronization are always going to come
up as we start to deal with programs
that are interacting with more and more
of this kind of data and as a result we
need to design more and more
sophisticated systems that are able to
deal with those issues of scale
now ultimately we'd ideally like to
reduce the number of different of these
database servers that we have that every
additional database server is going to
cost time it's going to cost resources
to cost money in terms of keeping all of
these servers running and so ideally
we'd like not to have to talk to this
database if we don't need to so you
might imagine for example a news
organization's website something like
the front page of the New York Times if
you go to the homepage of the New York
Times website it displays all of the
day's headlines with images and with
information about what each of the
stories are about for example and you
might imagine that the way they're doing
something like this
is that they have some kind of database
that's storing all of these news
articles and when you visit the front
page of the New York Times it's going to
do some kind of database query selecting
all of the recent top headlines for
example and rendering all of that
information in an HTML page that you can
see
and that would certainly work but if a
lot of people are all requesting the
front page at the same time
well it probably doesn't make all that
much sense if the web application every
time is making a database query getting
the latest articles
and then displaying that information to
all the users because the Articles might
not be changing all that frequently if
one person makes a request one second
and another person makes the same
request half a second later it probably
is not going to be useful to re-request
all the information from the database
regenerate that template yet again
because it's an expensive process of
requesting data from the database of
generating that template we'd ideally
like some way of dealing with that
problem and the way we can deal with
that problem is some form of caching and
caching refers to a whole bunch of
different types of of ideas and tools
that we can use at various different
places inside of our system but in
general when we're talking about caching
we're talking about storing a saved
version of some information in a way
that we can access it more quickly so
that we don't need to continue making
requests to a database for example and
so there are a number of ways we can do
caching one way we can do caching is on
the client side via client-side caching
where the idea is that your browser
whether it's Safari or Chrome or
something else is able to cache data
store information so that the browser
doesn't need to re-request the same
information the next time it visits the
page for example if you request a page
and it loads an image on the page for
example and you reload the page well
your web browser might try and make a
request again for the exact same image
and then display it to you but an
alternative might be
but your web browser could just save a
copy of the image inside of a cache to
locally store a version of the image so
that the next time that the user makes a
request to the website the user doesn't
need to reload that entire image and
that might be true of entire web pages
and web resources that if there's some
page that doesn't change very often then
if the web browser just stores a cache a
saved version of that page then the next
time the user goes to their web browser
tries to access that page
rather than re-request to the server and
make a new request that the server needs
to respond to if the browser has that
page to cached the browser can just
display the cached saved version of the
page saving the need to talk to the
server at all so this can certainly help
to reduce the load on any given server
that if users are caching information
inside of the web browser it makes the
experience faster for the user because
they can see the information immediately
rather than need to make a request and
wait for a response to come back and
it's good for the server because the
server doesn't need to be dealing with
as many requests if some of those
requests are getting cached
and so one approach to trying to do this
is by adding this inside of the headers
of an HTTP response that when your web
server responds to some request the web
server can include a line like this
inside of the response something like
cache control max age 86 400 in effect
specifying the number of seconds that
you should cache this resource for that
if I try to access this page 10 seconds
later well that's less than 86 400 so
rather than reload and re-request the
entire page
we're just going to use the version of
the page that happens to be cached
inside of the web browser and so this
has several advantages that we've talked
about in terms of reducing the amount of
time it takes to see the content of a
page because it's already saved and
reducing the load on any particular
server but it also has drawbacks that if
for example the resource changes within
this amount of time that maybe in 60
seconds the page has changed if I try
and load the page again well then if
it's loading the cached version of the
page I might be seeing an outdated
version of a web page I'm seeing an
older version of the web page because my
web browser just so happens to have that
particular resource cached and this
might be true of a web page it's
especially true of other like static
resources things like CSS files or
JavaScript files that the CSS of a web
page probably doesn't change all that
often and so as a result it's pretty
natural that your web browser rather
than request the exact same CSS files
again and again and again might just
save a copy of that those CSS files
cache them such that it's able to just
reuse the cached version but if the
website were to update their CSS you
might not see the latest changes and you
might have experienced this yourself if
you're working on your own web
applications when you change your CSS
and refresh the page you might not
always see those changes reflected if
your web browser is caching those
results and so in most web browsers you
can do a hard refresh to say ignore
whatever's in the cache and actually go
out and make a new request and get some
new data but ultimately
if you don't do that you're subject to
this cache control where the web browser
is going to say unless this number of
seconds has elapsed we're going to reuse
the existing version of the page and so
an alternative to this approach and this
approach certainly works and is quite
popular we can add to this approach by
adding what's known as an e-tag and the
e-tag for a resource like a CSS file or
an image or a Javascript file is just
some unique sequence of characters that
identifies a particular version of a
resource that identifies a particular
version of a CSS file or a Javascript
file for example
and what this allows a program to do
like a web browser is that when a web
browser requests a resource like makes a
request for a CSS file or a Javascript
file they get it back and they get its
Associated e-tag value so I know that
this is the value that is associated
with this version of the CSS file and if
the web browser if the web server were
ever to change that CSS file replace it
with a new updated CSS file the
corresponding e-tag will also change
so why is this helpful
well it means that if I am trying to
decide should I load a new version of
the resource or not should I try and
make another request to get the latest
version of the CSS what I can do first
is just ask for what is the e-tag value
this short sequence that can be answered
very quickly that very quickly we can
just respond and say you know what if
the etag value is the same as what I
remembered from last time well then I
don't need to get a whole new version of
that resource and so this is quite
common too that a web browser will say
hey let me request this resource but I
already have a version of the resource
with this particular e-tag so if that
e-tag is still the re-tag for the most
recent version of a particular resource
like a CSS or JavaScript file then no
need for the web server to send a new
version of that file
just go ahead and respond and say the
version you have that one works totally
fine but if there is a new version well
then the web server can respond with the
new asset the new CSS file for example
but also the new etag value so these two
approaches can work in concert with each
other that you can say go ahead and
cache this for some number of seconds so
that for some number of seconds you're
not going to ever request a new version
of that resource but even if you do ask
for a new version of the resource after
this number of seconds has elapsed if
the etag value hasn't updated then no
need to re-download a whole new version
of a particular file you can just reuse
the version
that happens to be cached already in the
browser so caching in the browser can be
an incredibly powerful tool for trying
to speed up these requests for trying to
reduce the load on any particular server
but the client side is not the only
place where we can begin to do this kind
of caching we also have the ability to
do server side caching and in
server-side caching we're going to
introduce to our picture the notion of a
cache
that we have these multiple servers that
are all communicating with the database
but these servers can also communicate
with a cache someplace where we've
stored information that we might want to
reuse later rather than have to do all
of that recalculation
and Django in turns out has an entire
cash framework a whole host of features
that Django offers that allow us to
leverage this ability to use the cache
to be able to speed up requests so there
are per view caches where you can
specify a cache on a particular view to
say that rather than run through all
this python code every time someone
makes a request to this particular view
instead
and just cache The View so that for the
next 30 seconds or 30 minutes the next
time someone tries to visit the same
view go ahead and just reuse the results
of the last time that that view was
loaded and this can work not just for a
single view it can work for fragments
inside of a template that your template
might have multiple different parts that
on your web page you might render the
navigation bar in the sidebar and the
footer maybe based on information about
today that might change the next day
but if you expect that the sidebar of
your page is not going to change very
often within the same minute or within
the same hour well then you might
imagine caching that part of the
template so the next time that Django
tries to load that entire template it
doesn't need to recalculate how to
generate the sidebar for your website it
just knows that we can use the save
version of the sidebar from the last
time that we loaded this website instead
and Django also gives you access to a
lower level cache API where for any
information that you might want to cache
and store for use later you can save
that information inside of the API you
make an expensive database query that
takes a couple of milliseconds or a
couple of seconds to process you can
save those results inside of a cache to
make it easier to access that same data
if ever you tried to get access to that
again
so caching allows us to be able to deal
with these issues of scale by reducing
load on our servers but also on our
databases that rather than need to talk
to the database every single time we
make a new request for a particular web
application
we can just reuse information that
happens to be in the cache to allow our
web applications to become even more
scalable
so that then was a look at some issues
concerning scalability and we'll next
turn our attention to security trying to
make sure that as we build our web
applications as we deploy our web
applications and more users start to use
them we want to make sure that they're
secure and there are a whole bunch of
security considerations to take into
account across all of the topics that
we've looked at in the course we've
looked at a number of different topics
and with each of them there are security
vulnerabilities there are ideas to be
mindful of when it comes towards making
sure that our applications are secure
and we can begin our story in fact by
talking about git and Version Control
git is all about trying to make sure
we're able to keep track of different
versions of our code and one thing that
goes hand in hand with Git is this idea
of Open Source software but on websites
like GitHub and other services that host
git repositories increasingly a lot of
software is becoming open source where
anyone can see and contribute to the
source code of an application and this
is great in the sense that it allows for
many people to be able to collaborate
work together in order to try to find
bugs that might exist inside of a web
application but it also comes with
drawbacks drawbacks where if there is a
bug in the application now someone who's
looking through the source code of our
program might be able to spot that bug
or you might imagine
now because git keeps track of different
versions of our code every time we make
a commit to our repository you have to
be very careful when it comes towards
credentials or things that might leak
inside of the source code you generally
never want to put passwords or any
secure information inside of the git
repository because the git repository
could be shared with other people it
might be open to anyone to look at and
so there's a security considerations to
be mindful there as well that if you
make a commit and accidentally make a
commit to your code where you expose
those credentials you might remove those
credentials and commit again to the
latest version of your program doesn't
have those credentials in it but someone
who has access to the git repository has
access not just to the latest version of
your code but to every version of your
code and that person
could theoretically go back through the
history of the repository and find the
commit where the credentials were
exposed and see those credentials as
well so while git is a very powerful
tool it's also one to be mindful of that
any change you make could potentially
get saved inside of a commit could
potentially therefore be accessed later
on and so if ever credentials are
exposed inside of the repository you
want to make sure to wipe out all of
those previous commits and not just make
some new commit in order to try and hide
the previous credentials that can be
exposed because they can still be
retrieved if someone goes back through
the history of any particular Repository
and so that then was a look at some
issues that might concern git we also
talked at the beginning of the course
about HTML and about what it is that we
can use with HTML and how we can use
this language in order to design the
structure of a web page in order to
decide where all of the paragraphs are
going to be what tables are going to be
on the page we talked about links and
how we can use anchor tags to link one
page to another page now one concern and
is this type of attack known as a
phishing attack with HTML and a phishing
attack really just comes down to a
little bit of HTML that looks like this
very easy to write where I have an
anchor tag that is going to direct the
user to URL one but it looks like it
directs the user to url2
so what made an example of this be all
right so we'll take a look I'll go ahead
and open up link.html
and in link.html I have a website that
I've written that appears to have a link
to Google but if I click on that link
I'm suddenly directed to this course's
website for example so how did that
happen why did that happen it seems like
it's linking to Google well if you look
at the code if I go ahead and open up
link.html we'll see that here I have an
anchor tag that actually links to the
course website but appears to be linking
the text that the user sees appears that
it is linking instead to Google and so
this is a very common attack Vector
especially in emails for example that
you might see an email that tells you to
click on a particular link but that link
takes you to somewhere else entirely
instead and as a result someone might
inadvertently share their bank account
credentials or other sensitive
information and so here too something to
be mindful of if you interact with the
web maybe not necessarily on your own
website but in other websites that you
might interact with just to be mindful
about where links are actually taking
you and most web browsers if you hover
over a link will show you where that
link might actually be directing you to
because it might be different than what
the text of that particular anchor tag
might appear to link you to instead
and so HTML has all these various
different vulnerabilities where because
you can just decide what you want the
structure of the page to be it leaves
open the possibility that someone might
try to trick you into thinking that
you're going to a page that you're not
actually on and this problem is more
widespread because anyone can look at
the HTML for any page HTML comes back
from the server and therefore the web
browser has access to all of that HTML
and can use that HTML in order to render
a page for example and this leaves open
other vulnerabilities too so for example
let me go ahead and go to
bankofamerica.com just Bank of America's
website go to any other website instead
if I wanted to create a fake version of
Bank of America's website for example to
trick people into thinking they're going
to Bank of America's website when really
they're going to my website well then
what I can do is just go ahead and view
the source of this page I'll go ahead
and view page source
and here is all of the HTML for Bank of
America's website and nothing then stops
me from copying all this content
going into an HTML file and creating a
new file then I'll just call like
bank.html
and I'll go ahead and paste in the
contents of that HTML file
so here then is all of Bank of America's
HTML
and now if I open up bank.html that HTML
file that I have now written but really
just copied from Bank of America
I open it up
and now here on my page is a web page
that appears to look like Bank of
America it's using all of Bank of
America's HTML but instead it is my HTML
page and not actually Bank of America
and so you might imagine combining these
to create an even more concerning attack
Vector where instead of linking to
google.com let me try and link to Bank
of america.com
but where I'm actually going to link to
is
bank.html my version of Bank of
America's website where now if I open up
link.html
here appears to be a link that links me
to bankofamerica.com if I click on that
link I get to a page that looks like
Bank of America's website but it's not
Bank of America's website it's my
bank.html file that I have written that
Joseph happens to look like Bank of
America's website because I copied all
of that underlying HTML so HTML has the
ability to describe the structure of our
web page but anytime you're writing this
HTML it's good to be mindful of the fact
that anyone can copy your HTML could
theoretically pretend to be you and
these are security vulnerabilities that
are worth bearing in mind as we start to
develop web applications and interacting
with web applications as well
so ultimately we used HTML in the
context of Designing web applications
using Django a framework and how exactly
then did these web Frameworks work in
terms of creating these web servers that
are listening for requests and that are
responding to those requests well
ultimately much of the internet is based
around this idea of a client
communicating with a server or more
generally any one computer communicating
with another computer using HTTP and in
particular https a more secure version
of the HTTP protocol and so you might
imagine that what these Protocols are
really about is how information gets
from one person to another and what
we're storing with that information that
we have one computer trying to
communicate with some other computer and
in order to do so information is
generally going to flow through these
routers that you might imagine
information going back and forth between
one computer and another computer going
through these intermediate routers along
the way
and as a result one thing to be cautious
about is how do you know that this
information that's getting passed back
and forth is getting passed back and
forth securely then ideally when I send
a message to another computer I'm
sending an email to someone else and
sending a message or making a request to
a website that might contain sensitive
information like my bank account for
example I don't want it so that any
intercepting router that is taking my
request and passing it along I don't
want those routers to be able to look at
that request and see the contents of my
email or the contents of what password I
happen to be sending across the web or
not ideally I'd like for this
information to be encrypted and so here
we'll talk a little bit about
cryptography this process of trying to
make sure that I am able to communicate
with some other person without some
eavesdropper in the middle being able to
intercept that message
obviously if I just take a plain text
version of the message I'm trying to
send I just literally take the text of
the message I'm trying to send and
effectively pass it along across the
internet well then anyone who's able to
see that message is going to know what
the text of that message is and so I
want to do some kind of encryption some
way of encrypting that message so that
someone along the way won't be able to
do that decryption if a router in the
middle or someone in the middle is able
to intercept that message and so the
first approach we'll look at is what's
known as secret key cryptography in
secret key cryptography I have not just
the plain text but some key some secret
piece of information that can be used in
order to encrypt or decrypt information
and so
I'll use both the key and the plain text
to generate what's known as the
ciphertext the encrypted version of the
message I'm trying to send and then
instead of instead of sending the plain
text across the internet to the other
person I might instead want to just send
the cipher text across the internet to
the other person so that I'm not sending
the plain version of the message across
the internet so the ciphertext goes
across and the other person will also
need the key and now if the other person
has both the ciphertext and the key well
then using that information the other
person can use the key to decrypt the
ciphertext and obtain the original plain
text
this key is what we might call a
symmetric key encryption and decryption
key you use the key in order to encrypt
messages and you use the same key in
order to do the decryption process and
as long as both I and the person I'm
communicating with both have access to
that key well then we'll be able to
encrypt messages and decrypt messages
and someone who just has the ciphertext
but not the key likely won't be able to
figure out what that original message
was
but there's a problem here especially in
the context of the internet and that is
that both I and the other person need to
have access to this key the key is what
I use to do the encryption and the
decryption and I can't just send the key
across the internet to the other person
because if I do that well then someone
in the middle who's intercepting all of
my requests could intercept both the
ciphertext and the key and therefore
they would be able to decrypt the
message because they have both the
ciphertext and the key now if I were
able to go to another person in person
and exchange the secret key in secret
well then this scheme might work because
we both have the key and I didn't share
the key publicly with anyone who might
intercept the message only I and the
other person have the key but in general
when communicating on the internet
you're not communicating with servers
you've necessarily communicated with
before I might be trying to make a
request to a new website and we somehow
still need to agree on a system where I
can encrypt messages but only the other
person on the other side is able to
decrypt those messages instead
so this kind of cryptography probably
not great for trying to initially try
and create a secure connection on the
internet and for that reason a major
advancement in cryptography that allows
for the internet to work is this notion
of public key cryptography in secret key
cryptography it's important the key is
secret because if the key were known by
everyone well then anyone would be able
to decrypt messages in public key
cryptography we're able to create a
secure encryption system where the key
is allowed to be public or one of the
keys as we'll soon see and the idea here
is that we're using two keys instead of
just one that we have both a public key
and what's known as a private key the
private key your private key is
something you should not share with
other people to keep the encryption
scheme secure but the public key is one
that is okay to share with other people
and the distinction between the two
is that the public key will be used in
order to encrypt information and the
private key will be used to decrypt
information that was encrypted by the
public key and the public key and the
private key are mathematically related
and there are a couple of ways that we
might imagine doing that but the idea
now is that if I want to communicate
with another person that person sends me
their public key and it's okay for the
public key to travel across the internet
anyone is allowed to see the public key
because the public key is only used for
encrypting that data so I can then take
the plain text and the public key and
use that to generate the ciphertext the
encrypted version of the message that I
am trying to send across the internet
and then I send the ciphertext to the
other person with whom I'm trying to
communicate and the other person now
using the ciphertext then uses the
private key the private key that they
did not share and then private key that
has the ability to decrypt information
that was encrypted using the public key
so using a combination of the ciphertext
and the private key the person I'm
communicating with can decrypt that
information and get back whatever the
original plain text of that information
happened to be and so this then is how
we can do a lot of this communication on
the Internet by using this public
private key pair we can say use the
public key to do the encrypting use the
private key to do the decrypting and now
two computers that have never interacted
with each other before without having
the opportunity to meet to exchange some
secret information can use a technique
like this in order to securely
communicate with each other to send a
message back and forth without anyone in
the middle being able to intercept the
message and identify what the message is
about
and once you have this ability the
ability to communicate with another
secretly well then you could imagine
agreeing on some secret key and then
using secret key encryption to be able
to encrypt and decrypt messages as well
and so that's an approach that you can
also take when trying to communicate
with other people across the internet
but this idea of encryption is what
allows for https a secure version of the
HTTP protocol to actually work to make
sure that when you are communicating
with your bank's website for example
someone along the way won't be able to
intercept that information and identify
what it is that you're communicating
about and instead only has the encrypted
version of the information and a plan
and a public key with which they can
encrypt information but not a private
key that can ultimately be used in order
to decrypt information as well
and so that then is how we might allow
for this kind of secure communication on
the internet and allow our web
applications to be secure but in
addition to our web applications just
listening for requests and then
providing some sort of response our web
applications were also dealing with data
we introduced the idea of SQL data
tables where we had tables of data with
rows and columns that are representing
information and we've also created web
applications in this course where we've
had applications that have users users
sign in with a username and a password
for example and so how might we
represent that information about users
and their passwords well one way
would be just a stored inside of a table
like this here's a table of users every
user has an ID they have a username and
they have a password
but this turns out to be an incredibly
insecure way to store passwords to be
storing passwords in what might be
called plain text just to literally
store the passwords inside of a database
and we should never do this in practice
because of the security vulnerabilities
associated with it if ever someone were
to unauthorize get access to this
database they would be able to see all
of the passwords for all of the users so
if this database ever leaked for
whatever reason suddenly all of these
passwords are now known and this kind of
thing does happen that if companies are
not careful about how they represent
usernames and passwords inside of their
databases and however there's sort of
some sort of database leak
suddenly a whole bunch of passwords
could potentially be compromised and
it's for that reason that the
recommended approach rather than store
an actual password is to store a hashed
version of the same password using a
hash function or a hash function in this
context is some function that takes a
password of input and outputs some
hash some sequence of characters and
numbers in this case that represents
that particular password a hashed
version of the password but the
important thing about this hash function
is that it's a one-way hash function
from the password you can get to the
sequence of letters and numbers but it
is very very difficult to go the other
way around to use this information
to figure out what the original password
actually was and so what this means is
that the companies won't actually know
what any particular user's password is
when a user tries to log in what we'll
do is take their password that they're
trying to log in with will hash it and
compare that hash against the hash that
we've stored in the database
if the hashes match up that means the
user probably typed in their password
correctly and therefore we can sign the
user in and otherwise that's a sign that
the user did not type their password in
correctly so this then is the reason why
companies if they're obeying these best
practices usually can't tell you what
your password actually is if you forget
your password if you forget your
password the company will let you reset
your password they can update the data
inside of the table but the company
won't be able to tell you what your
password actually is because the company
doesn't know your password the company
only knows some hashed version of the
password some result of passing that
password through a hash function and as
a result
they're able to know whether you logged
in successfully or not with the correct
credentials without actually knowing
what your password actually is and so
this is another area where you might
imagine that if you're not careful about
how you're storing this data it could be
a security vulnerability inside of your
program wherever that data is leaked
passwords suddenly become known and
there are other more subtle ways that
web applications could potentially leak
information that you as the web
developer need to decide if you're okay
with or not imagine a website for
example where you do have a place where
you can say if you forgot your password
you can be sent a place where you can
reset your password for example
you might imagine that if you type in
your email address click reset password
you might get a message like all right
password reset email has been sent but
you might imagine typing in an email
address and getting something like error
there is no user with that email address
and here again is a potential security
vulnerability in terms of leaked
information this page that just seems to
send you an email if you forgot your
password is now leaking information
about which users happen to have
accounts on your website and which users
do not because all someone needs to do
is type in an email address and find out
whether it results in an error or not in
order to know whether a user happens to
have an account on the website or not
and maybe that's not a big deal if
that's not something that you care about
securing but if it's a website where you
do care
about making sure that if someone has an
account or doesn't have an account that
information is kept private and secure
only to the user unless they want to
share it well then this type of page
this type of interface with the database
could potentially be leaking that kind
of information and information can be
leaked in all sorts of different ways
you can even leak information just based
on the time it takes for the database to
be able to respond to a particular
request that you might imagine if you
make a request about a user and it takes
longer to respond that might tell you
something about the number of database
queries it needs to run or the amount of
information that's stored about that
user as opposed to if a request takes
less time so even something like how
many milliseconds it takes for a web
server to respond to a request can
reveal or leak information about the
data that is stored inside of the
database and there have been examples of
researchers who actually tried and see
what information they can get just from
looking at these kinds of information
that it doesn't seem like would leak
information but might actually reveal
information as well
now another concern when dealing with
SQL and databases we've talked about is
the context of SQL injection this threat
where if you're not careful about how it
is that you run your SQL code you could
inadvertently end up executing code that
you don't mean to be executing
situations like here when a username and
password field we've seen this example
before where if a user tries to log in
you might imagine a query like this is
run selecting from the users table where
username equals whatever was typed in as
the username and password equals
whatever was typed in as the password
and we saw how for a normal user someone
who types in like Harry and one two
three four five as they're username and
password
now this type of query works just fine
but if a hacker tries to log into a
website and maybe includes a double
quotation mark and two hyphens for
example where two hyphens mean a comment
in SQL and we were to literally
substitute these values into our SQL
queries well then you might end up
substituting hacker hyphen hyphen hyphen
hyphen creating a comment that ignores
the rest of this query effectively
ignoring any kind of password checking
that we might want our web application
to be doing so this to another
vulnerability that comes about whenever
we're dealing when executing SQL code
inside of a database and in order to
deal with this we want to make sure that
we're escaping any of these potentially
dangerous characters that might show up
inside of our SQL queries and Django's
models do this for us so when we do
these kinds of queries using Django
saying like dot objects.filter to be
able to filter out for only certain
versions of a particular model it is
going to take care of the process of
making sure that it's not subject to
these kinds of SQL injection attacks but
if ever you're writing a web application
that is directly executing SQL code
which you might imagine doing you do
want to be careful about making sure
that you're not exposing the application
to be vulnerable to these kinds of
threats as well
so that then are potential threats to
come about when we're just talking about
what's happening on the server but we
also can think about what might happen
when we're interacting with other
servers when we're interacting with apis
for example and so we talked about
JavaScript and using JavaScript to be
able to make additional requests to apis
or to other services that are able to
return back with certain types of
information and with apis there are a
number of techniques that we can use in
apis to allow them to be more scalable
to allow them to be more secure
one is this notion of rate limiting
where we might want to make sure that no
user is able to make more than a certain
number of requests to an API in any
particular amount of time this is in
response to a security threat that has
to do with the scalability of a system
which is known as a Dos or denial of
service attack where effectively if you
just make a whole bunch of requests to a
single server over and over and over
again you could potentially shut down
that system because you're making so
many requests that it's not able to
handle that many requests all at the
same time and for that reason because
it's so easy to make an API request you
can do so using just a single line of
like python or JavaScript for example
apis will often Institute some kind of
rate limiting to limit the number of
requests you can make so that you're not
going to overwhelm the server or
overwhelm the database that needs to be
queried in order to respond to those
requests into this kind of limiting
might work as well
apis might also want to add some kind of
Route authentication you might not want
everybody to access the same data via an
API maybe there's some sort of
permission model where only certain
users are able to access certain pieces
of data from the API so you might
imagine that a user needs to have an API
key for example some effectively like a
password that they need to pass around
anytime they're making an API request to
your API and that allows you to then be
able to look at that key and verify that
they are who they say they are
now with those API Keys comes other
potential security vulnerabilities to be
mindful of one is that just as you
should never be putting like passwords
inside of your source code inside of
your git repository for example you
likewise generally shouldn't be putting
your API keys inside of your web
applications as well inside of the
source code of those web applications
because then anyone who has access to
the source code for the web application
can see what your API key is could then
use the API key to pretend to be you and
therefore get access to potential API
routes that they should not be able to
access one common solution to this is to
use what are known as environment
variables where effectively
you and your program say that your API
key is not going to be some
predetermined string that is in the text
of your program but instead is going to
be drawn from the environment in which
the program is being run and then on the
server
when you're running the web application
you'll first make sure the server has
all of those environment variables set
correctly
so that rather than have the API key
actually in the source code of the
program the API key is simply in the
environment on the server where the web
application is running and the server
can just draw that information from the
environment so that it knows what the
API key should be without the API key
actually having to be inside of the web
application source code itself and so as
we begin to deal with apis you might
notice that many apis will require you
to have an API key and often it's for
these sorts of reasons to make sure that
we're able to authenticate users
effectively and also to make sure that
we're able to limit users to make sure
that they're not making too many
requests to the server or to the
database at any particular time
but this then starts to get us into
other potential vulnerabilities in
particular vulnerability is concerning
JavaScript JavaScript again is a
programming language that we use in
order to write code that runs inside of
our web browser a browser like Chrome or
Safari or something like that and as a
result
JavaScript has a lot of power to
manipulate things on the page it can
simulate the clicking of buttons it can
change the content of what happens to be
on any particular page and as a result
there are many many vulnerabilities that
come about when it comes to thinking
about JavaScript
and one such vulnerability is this
notion of cross-site scripting that in
general when on your web application you
only want JavaScript to run if you
yourself have written it cross-site
scripting is a Potential Threat where
someone else might be able to get
JavaScript code to run on your website
when it's JavaScript code that someone
else wrote instead of you yourself and
this is a potential vulnerability
because someone else can write the
JavaScript code they can manipulate the
contents of what happens to be on your
website they can potentially manipulate
the user experience to get a result that
is not actually desired so let's go
ahead and take a look at one example of
cross-site scripting all right so I've
prepared a web application in advance
it's called security inside of which is
a single Django app called xsx xss for
cross-site scripting
and inside of here we'll first take a
look at the URLs so there's a single URL
that just allows us to provide any path
and then it's going to load the index
View
and on the index View
we're going to display an HTTP response
that says here was the path that just
happened to be requested so you might
imagine this is a simplified version of
what you might see on other websites for
example where websites might show you on
any particular page what path you're on
in order to get to that page some sort
of indication of where you are inside of
this web application
so I'll go ahead and CD into security
and run the server pythonmanage.pi run
server
so I am now running the server and I'll
now go ahead and go into
my web application slash hello for
example and so what I see here is
requested path hello which is what I
would expect it to be I can change it to
something else like hi so here's
requested path Hi here's hi slash two
for example whatever page I visit it
gives me a page that says requested path
and then whatever path I happen to be
visiting
but watch what happens if I try and
visit this URL instead I'm going to
visit URL slash script alert hi
and then end script
so I run it and suddenly an alert shows
up on my page that says hi
and then press OK and it says all right
requested path that alert was a
JavaScript alert it was JavaScript code
running on my web application but it was
not code that was JavaScript code inside
of my web application it was someone
else who wrote based on the URL to run
particular JavaScript on my particular
page and so if someone linked to my web
application and passed in this script
tag as part of the URL someone who
clicked on that link might have been
taken to my web application but
ultimately had JavaScript run that was
created by someone else
and that ultimately is potentially
dangerous it leaves open the possibility
that someone else could run JavaScript
code on my page and it might not just be
something like a script you might
imagine someone not just displaying an
alert but modifying something inside of
the Dom changing the contents of the web
page making API requests doing other
types of tasks that you can do using
JavaScript inside of a web browser that
ultimately leave my page open to
potential security vulnerabilities and
so these are cases where it's important
to be mindful of when you're designing
these Pages if ever there's a
possibility that someone could inject
their own JavaScript into your page
somehow you'll want to either detect
that or Escape it in some way or take
other precautions to make sure that this
kind of cross-site scripting isn't going
to be possible you might imagine that in
a messaging application for example if
you're messaging back and forth you
don't want it to be the case that if you
message someone else some JavaScript
code that when they receive it that code
actually ends up running as some
JavaScript that runs on that particular
page you want to be sure to escape that
information so that they just see the
text of the JavaScript code but the code
isn't actually executed and this is a
similar threat to that threat of SQL
injection it all comes back to the idea
of not wanting to allow someone else to
be able to inject their own code into
your program you don't want someone else
to be able to inject SQL code into the
queries you run on your database and you
don't want someone to be able to inject
JavaScript code into your web page
because that leaves open potential
security vulnerabilities as well
one type of security vulnerability the
Django is quite good at defending
against is one that we've seen before
but we'll explore in more detail how it
might work and it's this idea of
cross-site request forgery where you
fake a request to a website when you
didn't intend to actually make a request
to that website so you might imagine
that if your bank for example had a URL
that allowed you to transfer money from
one person to another person we've
talked about this idea a little bit but
imagine now how you could implement this
if it really was just a URL that you
could go to like slash transfer and say
as get parameters who am I transferring
money to and what is the amount that I'm
transferring then someone else on some
other website could in the body of their
page just have a link
where that link says click here and it
links to your bank.com or whatever your
bank is transferring money like to me in
this amount and if some user unknowingly
just clicked on that link not knowing
where it would take them this website
might be able to forge a request to the
bank make it seem like the user had gone
to the bank and tried to initiate some
kind of transfer and ultimately try to
transfer money and it doesn't even
necessarily need to be in a link how
else might you get some new request to
happen inside of the web browser you
might imagine though it might seem a bit
strange to put this inside of an image
image source the source of the image is
this particular URL the bank's transfer
page now that doesn't really make any
sense the transfer page is not an image
but it doesn't matter
all an image tag is going to do is try
to make a request to this Source URL to
get that image and then try to display
it in the user's web browser but the
first part is what's important the fact
that this Source ends up being requested
by the web browser without the user
having to click on or do anything they
might try and request from your bank.com
transfer this particular request which
might initiate some sort of bank
transfer without the user even realizing
it and it's for that reason that we
generally suggest that anytime you're
creating a website
but it's going to allow for the
manipulation of some kind of state that
allows for some change to happen
something like transferring money you
don't want that to be via a get request
something you could just load in an
image or a load by clicking on a link
that takes you to another page you don't
want that to happen because then it
makes it very easy for someone else to
fake a request to your page by just
creating an image or a linking to
somehow a website like transferring
funds from one user to another
so a solution to this as we've talked
about is that generally we only want
post requests to be able to manipulate
something inside of the database to be
able to actually initiate a transfer
from one user to another user but even
then this is not perfectly secure that
you could still be tricked into
submitting a post request imagine an
adversarial website that had a form like
this a form whose action was
yourbank.com transfer and whose method
was post and now here to input Fields
whose type is hidden meaning you won't
actually be able to see those input
Fields when the user is looking at the
page they'd only know about it if they
inspected the source code of this
particular HTML page
here there's the hidden input whose name
is two meaning the person I'd like to
transfer money to here's the amount the
value that I would like to transfer and
all the user is going to see is a button
that says click here they're not going
to see either of the input Fields
because they're hidden but if they do
click the click here button well then
suddenly they're going to be submitting
a post request to the bank and
initiating some transfer when they
didn't intend to now maybe this seems
like oh it's not a big deal because the
user still needs to click a button and
the user shouldn't be clicking on a
button if they don't know what the
button is going to do well for one
it's probably reasonable to imagine that
an adversary might embed this button
inside of a page where it looks totally
safe to be able to click on a button but
moreover the user doesn't even need to
click on it in order to submit the form
we can just add a little bit of
JavaScript you might imagine that an
adversary could do something like this
add an on load attribute to the body
that says when the body of the page is
done loading go to document.forms
meaning all of the forms for this
webpage get the first one and submit it
submit the form
and what that's going to do is even
without the user doing anything even
without the user clicking on the click
here Button as soon as this page is
loaded this form is going to submit
submitting a post request to the bank
and attempting to transfer funds from
one user to another user and so this is
what we might call a cross-site request
forgery where some adversario website
has forged a request to our website and
ideally we wouldn't like for that to be
able to happen so how did we guard
against this
well what Django allows us to do and a
very common approach is to add a csrf
token a cross-site request forgery token
that is going to be regenerated for
every session
such that only if that token is present
will the transfer be able to go through
so on our website
we can include the csrf token inside of
this HTML form and as a result make sure
that we're able to transfer money only
when the csrf token is present but if
some other website tries to forge a
request they won't know what the csrf
token should be because it changes for
every session and therefore they won't
be able to actually Forge a request from
one user to another
so all across the various different
tools and Technologies we've been using
python HTTP Django HTML in terms of
creating these web applications using
JavaScript and the apis we might be
interacting with there are security
considerations all throughout we've only
touched on a couple of them here but
just goes to show how it's important to
be mindful if you think about the
practice of web programming thinking
about what you're going to add to your
web applications and what features your
web application supports to think about
what the potential vulnerability is
there are as well how someone might
exploit your web application in order to
do something with it that they probably
shouldn't and as you take your web
applications from applications that are
just running on your own local computer
to applications that are running in some
web server that many people are starting
to use these are the types of questions
to start to be asking how can you make
sure that your web application is
scalable how can you make sure that your
web application is secure
so now that we've explored that a lot of
web programming what comes next in this
course we've explored a number of
different tools and Technologies and
languages but there are many other web
Frameworks and ways you can build web
applications as well we spent most of
our time looking at the Django web
framework written in Python but you can
use other programming languages to build
web applications as well express.js for
example is a very popular JavaScript
framework for building web applications
Ruby on Rails is a popular server-side
web framework but built using Ruby and
there are many others as well and there
are also client-side Frameworks used
primarily with JavaScript to be able to
build user interfaces we've seen a
little bit of react to build Dynamic and
interactive user interfaces other
popular client-side Frameworks include
angularjs and view JS and a number of
others as well and then once you've
built these web applications using any
of these server-side Frameworks and
client-side Frameworks then you might
imagine wanting to take these
applications and deploy them to the web
and to do that there are a number of
ways we can do this as well a number of
different services including Amazon web
services AWS Google cloud and Microsoft
Azure they can be used in order to
deploy these web applications
Heroku is a service that uses AWS and
tries to simplify the process of making
it easier to deploy your web
applications and if your web application
is really just static it's just HTML and
CSS and JavaScript well then you can use
something like GitHub pages to be able
to host a web application for free on
github's own servers instead and there
are many other ways you can imagine
deploying web applications as well
different services that you can use in
order to take the web applications that
you have been building or web
applications you might build in the
future and make them available on the
internet for others to be able to use as
well so as we look back on the various
topics within web programming we've
explored we've seen a lot of tools and
Technologies we can use that we can
leverage in order to build interesting
web applications we started by taking a
closer look at HTML and CSS diving into
how we can use that to describe the
structure of our page and then taking
advantage of tools like SAS that allow
us to generate CSS that allows for much
more complex styling for our website
that would have been much more difficult
to do with just CSS alone as we started
to build larger web applications we took
a look at Git Version Control tools that
we can use in order to make sure that we
keep track of versions and changes we
make to our code allowing multiple
people to collaborate on a project
simultaneously we then took a look at
python looking at various different
features that the language offered
functions and conditions and Loops as
we've seen in many other programming
languages but also object oriented
programming the ability to represent
objects and methods and functions that
operate on those particular objects
which prove especially powerful in the
context of dealing with data inside of
our web applications
Django was the example of a web
framework written in Python that we use
to very quickly be able to start up a
web application that's able to listen
for requests and make responses Django
has a whole lot of features built in
that really make it easy to get started
with building a web application and in
particular it makes it easy for writing
web applications that deal with data so
Django allows us the ability to build
models that interact with SQL without us
having to actually write any SQL code
Django can generate the SQL for us just
using these models and migrations then
allow us to continually apply changes
that we make to our database that as we
add new tables add and modify existing
fields on those tables Django can take
care of all of that
after that is the only recall we took
our attention towards the second of the
main programming languages in the course
JavaScript which was has a lot of uses
and is very very popular but we
primarily used on the client side to be
able to build interesting user
interfaces using JavaScript to
manipulate the Dom the structure of the
page to change what it is to use our
theism and also to add event handling so
that when the user clicks on a button
when the user hovers over something when
the user interacts with the page in some
sort of way our code is able to respond
to it and we saw react a web framework
that our client-side framework that uses
JavaScript in order to allow us to
create really interesting and
interactive user interfaces with not all
that much code at all and then finally
in these last couple of lectures we've
been looking at some best practices how
we can design tests tests that test the
server but also the client to make sure
that our code is working appropriately
and also some industry practices like
continuous integration and continuous
delivery that just help to make sure
that as we make changes to our code
we're able to deploy and deliver them
rapidly and effectively and make sure
that we're able to make incremental
changes to our code base rather than
need to wait on longer release Cycles
and then finally today we've been
talking about issues about scalability
and security especially important as we
begin to take our application and move
them to the web we want to make sure
that these applications are scalable
that they're able to handle multiple
different users and also to make sure
that they're secure that we're not
exposing ourselves to potential
vulnerabilities like someone who might
inject SQL or inject JavaScript code
into our Pages or who might try to
access some data that they're not
supposed to access we want to make sure
that when we go about designing these
web applications we're able to do so in
a scalable and ultimately in a secure
way
so hopefully you enjoyed this
exploration into the world of web
programming with python and JavaScript
best of luck with the web programs that
you yourself might build with the tools
we've seen here today and also other
tools that are inspired by or use
similar tools and techniques and ideas
as the things that we've ultimately
talked about here a big thanks to the
courses teaching staff and the
production team for making this entire
class possible I look forward to seeing
the web applications that you might go
on to create this was web programming
with python and JavaScript
this course from Harvard University
picks up where cs50x leaves off diving
more deeply into the design and
implementation of web apps with python
JavaScript and SQL using Frameworks like
Django react and bootstrap
Brian you will teach you topics such as
database design scalability security and
user experience you learn to write and
use apis create interactive uis and
Leverage
and leverage cloud services like GitHub
and Heroku